curran is an expert when it comes to
data visualizations this is an edited
collection of live streams where current
teaches data visualization using d3
so hi everyone i'm curran welcome to
this stream get it right in black and
white i am super super excited about
this
this new series
which i'm calling get it right in black
and white
is going to be a long running live
stream series and course on data
visualization with svg and d3
and maybe other technologies we will
weave in
in time
but that's the theme
a little bit about what this course is
i'm very excited to
begin again
from the beginning
i have
learned a lot from teaching this course
in 2018 and 2020
this is the 2018 version of the course
which was quite popular
and its
visualization was d3
this is the 2020 version of the course
called dataviz 2020. it was recently
published by free codecamp as a giant
compilation
but having taught this entire course
twice now actually three times the first
time it wasn't public
i've learned quite a lot
and
one of the main pieces of feedback that
i've got from dataviz2020
is that you know that's cool and all but
how can i do all that stuff without
react
so one of the key differences from the
last year's version of this is that it's
going to be oriented around pure d3
meaning
figuring out all these visualization
problems purely with d3
but coding it in such a way that if you
wanted to you could integrate with
different frameworks
another
key difference is that this is going to
be live it's going to be like a tv show
about data visualization
so you can tune in live to the event
i'm gonna have you know youtube chat
open and i'll be responsive to that
during the event
and i'm also inviting a small group of
friends and special guests
to participate um
with me live on the stream with their
audio so we can have direct discussions
during
this event
the reason why i'm doing this is because
in previous courses
i was sitting there all alone making
these videos and
if i forgot to say something or cover
something
it would come up only you know a week
later that's why i want to have this
live
element to it
this is a great opportunity to explain
everything step by step so i'm there's
lots of time here i think this series my
intention at the moment is to have this
series go for about a year
so this will be a recurring event every
single saturday for a year at this time
i mean i might change the time but
there's lots of time so there's no need
to rush through anything there's no need
to skip anything so i want to build up
the viewers understanding step by step
every step of the way
so that's the
overall
summary of this course
so
introductions there are a couple here a
couple folks here present
in audio only
via google meet
um
this is my sort of little uh you know
community of collaborators slash
learners
um
you know the idea is that these folks
can step in we can have discussions on
the fly
i can be interrupted and be asked
questions to go into more detail about
whatever thing is happening
so
why don't you all just introduce
yourselves i think i'll i'll call on you
one by one
um
ideally you want to go first
uh sure thank you karum um hello
everyone i am adil and i'm very excited
to be here i'm based in the uk and i
work in the
informatics department of a
hospital
and
my work is a bit sequel heavy but i
became enamored with d3 a while back and
i'm really excited to be learning it uh
deeply and yeah i'm really really happy
to be here
nice welcome a deal
um
sri ram sharma is also here you want to
go sriram
sure hi um
my name is sriram
i used to be a journalist
now i'm learning to become a front-end
web developer
i have been following d3 through current
tutorials and uh
been a big fan of his database 2020 uh
database
2020 and even the 2018 uh series
so i'm really looking forward to this
uh
series as well and just kind of
uh learning more from
current on d3 as much as possible
nice
yep welcome shiram and also nita is here
you want to go
hello everyone my name is nita
i'm also
very much interested into data
visualization
and i see this
live stream has an opportunity to learn
directly from kara
and his time is really valuable
but
he managed to do this trimming so i'm
planning on getting benefited from it as
much as i can
and i hope you also you all also get
benefited from it it's really good
series is doing
all right
welcome neeta
all right here we go this is episode one
of get it right in black and white
svg
fundamentals
what we'll cover
today is what is html css and svg
adding an svg element to an html page
creating circles rectangles and lines
adding text
in svg
and customizing the font
with css
all right so html hypertext markup
language this is the standard
that defines the language of
web pages that you see on the web every
single web page is an html
page
there's some source code
that somebody wrote or that gets
generated on the fly that has markup
with those brackets and everything and
your browser loads that in and it parses
that html page
and then displays it
in your browser
so when you go to a url in your browser
that makes an http request
to some server http means hypertext
transfer protocol that's the you know
the protocol the networking protocol
that web browsers use
so the browser makes an http request to
some server that server
comes back with an http response that
has a bunch of text which is html source
code and then when that source code gets
loaded into your browser
your browser parses it meaning it
interprets it and then it does a whole
bunch of stuff to
make the web page appear
within the html standard there are
apis application programming
interfaces that are sort of partitioned
off
one of them is svg
scalable vector graphics
another is css cascading style sheets
and another is
javascript which is often abbreviated
js
i'll go into detail
on each of these a little bit
these wikipedia pages are great i would
recommend to read them if these are new
concepts for you
html hypertext markup language
it was invented in 1993 28 years ago
that's very old
by tim berners-lee
and it went through many many revisions
and each revision introduced a lot of
new features right now we're at html5
and this standard is maintained by this
group called
w3c world wide web consortium
so it's an open standard and all these
various browsers implement it
and this is what a very basic
html page
looks like
and i'll go into more detail later
on the specifics
css stands for
cascading style sheets
it is a style sheet language so it's it
is its own
different language that gets embedded
within html
and um
it it looks um
see if i can find an example
it looks something like this where
inside of a style
tag
these things are called tags by the way
there's an opening tag and a closing tag
you can select elements on the page like
an h1 element which is a heading one
element and you can
set a bunch of properties on it like the
color and
there's many many many properties that
you can use this is very useful for
styling
things on the page and when i say
styling i mean changing the color the
font the size
all sorts of different
presentation kind of
attributes
svg stands for scalable vector graphics
so scalable vector graphics
it's a way of
representing computer graphics that is
based on the geometries and the shapes
so for example
if you have the letter s
and you zoom it in with
svg
because it's vector graphics you don't
lose any crispness because the graphics
are defined in terms of the
geometries themselves
points
and you know lines that connect the
as opposed to
raster
images like
pngs bitmaps jpegs
these are images defined in terms of
pixels
and a pixel is one of these little
squares
on your screen
um so if you zoom it
the pixels
will get uh
blown up or blurry
often when you scale a raster it ends up
getting blurry
because the rendering engine tries to
compensate
so that's what happens with
raster images when you scale them
they get pixelated or blurry
that's because they're defined in terms
of pixels not the geometries
and this is um
one of the many reasons why svg is
really good for data visualization
because
if you define a visualization with svg
shapes
you can for example output that to a pdf
and print it out and it's very crisp
when you print it
in a web browser you can use the browser
zoom and scale it and it doesn't lose
any clarity
that's one huge advantage of svg
and also it's generally
easy to work with programmatically
because it's got this um
dom
structure
which i'll get into but you can you can
define um
tags essentially in html for these
different svg shapes
so that's what html is
in a nutshell
any questions so far
sure i was um wondering um
svg
um
elements are they
designed to
create things that html can't do
normally is that why svg exists
so the question is um
can h can svg elements do things that
you can't do in
html without svg
yes that's right
yes that's right um
i believe in the early days of html svg
was not a part of html and you were
limited to
things like divs
to make shapes
and that was it's very limiting to just
use divs and css
to make graphics on the screen
so there are many many many things that
you can do in svg
that you can't do in html without svg
there's a it's
it's a massive library essentially of
graphics capabilities
paths lines areas
different ways of blending the colors
together
all sorts of text utilities um
yeah a great many things and and it's
svg has a history as an image format
as well
so um tools like adobe illustrator
can be used to create svg
image files
which
if you open up an svg image file you see
the text it looks a lot like html it's
actually
i guess a subset of xml
so yeah it does introduce a lot of
capabilities to html that that html does
not have
without svg
thank you thanks karen
and and we'll get into those the
specifics and see what they are
so in wikipedia it says svg is an
extensible markup language
yeah
so i'm confused is it's a language
itself or it's just a tag in html
oh well actually if you read this text
carefully it says
scalable vector graphics is
an
xml based
vector image format
so
it's confusing how wikipedia does this
but the way to parse it it says
it's
it's extensible markup language
based meaning it's based on xml
and xml
is is a good thing to know about for
context because
it defines
the structure of
svg
and html
in a sense html
it used to be at least a strict subset
of xml i think now there's some more
language features of html than xml but
xml i think came first
so the comments
that you see in html are derived or
inherited from xml
the notion of tags with openings and
closing is from xml
and so
what it says in the wikipedia article is
that
svg is based on xml
so you don't have any good example
documents there but
just the fact that
svg is defined in terms of tags that can
be nested
that's that's all that it means that
it's based on xml
so htm html is derived from xml yes
correct but yeah great question great
question
i think i'll move on
i think sriram has questions oh did you
three of them
which chat no i just had an observation
uh one is that like fonts which we use
typically on the browser uh they are
vector based
um that was kind of like a thing i
realized because you can scale up the
fonts without losing any quality so
that's like a realization that that's a
vector-based format
whatever type we import into our files
when creating an html file
another observation was that
in the document formats that use the xml
for syntax
this includes like rss atom yes
so
people might have used maybe rss speed
readers most likely soap protocols is
used more by developers i think were
making
uh web uh api things like that so that's
unlikely but essentially it's just
following that same format even html is
i think similar to the
xml format in a sense yes
yep it's very very similar
and another thing was that xml was
considered to be the way that
everything was
supposed to be written but then json
came in and json has become now the
defacto way for applications to talk to
each other that's right what has
happened is there's been a reversal of
fortune because xml is actually two
verbose and there's a lot of craft
in
an xml document which is kind of removed
in something like json json is more
readable which is why it's become more
popular
yeah that's true yeah there and i'll get
into this when we start getting into
like fetching data but there is a a long
history
to to the idea of
um fetching data
it used to be that the only like
the only way to fetch data into the
browser was to use xml files and so that
xml
text would contain data and nowadays
people have migrated to use json instead
javascript object notation
but yeah long story short nowadays
people use json and xml is sort of a
thing in the of the past
uh
except for those little you know legacy
systems that still use it like soap is
using xml i bet there's still a ton of
software that that uses xml as data
interchange but for new projects yeah
the preference is to use json
all right awesome thanks for the
questions everyone
now let's actually use these things to
create some basic shapes with
svg
now i'd like to get into
this segment on
creating
stuff
by writing code
and to do this i'm going to use vishub
which is this thing that i built over
the past couple years
essentially to help me
teach my courses
and i'm trying to evolve it into a
business
and there it's quite an active community
there's you know
5 000 or so
unique users
over the course of its history and
there's a ton of content in here and
people are using it
every day
so this is what i'm going to use
for this entire series
and you too
can use vishub so if you're following
along
with the live stream
or watching this as a video i encourage
you to follow the steps that i'm about
to do
so in vishub
to start really using it you have to
sign in via github
so i'm going to sign into github
so now i'm signed in
and i can see
my
profile or create viz
so if you click on create vis
there are a lot of these
templates here
the most popular template is just a
starter html page
which is where we're going to start from
today
so
what i'm going to do next is fork this
meaning to make a copy of it that i can
modify and you can do the same once
you're logged in if you click on this
little fork icon
you get this little uh pop-up that says
you know choose a name
for this vis
and i'm gonna say
svg
fundamentals
that's my name
so now i've got a copy of this
and i can click open editor right here
to see
this
little browser-based
ide
essentially
ide by the way stands for integrated
development environment
it's not an advanced ide here
by any stretch but it lets you edit code
right here in the browser so if you
click a file
it pops open and you can see
some details
i'm gonna just remove
stuff
that we don't need
um
because i really want to
sort of start from the beginning
here
and vishub has all these options to you
know reclaim screen real estate a lot of
the stuff i built specifically for
teaching
so
here we have
a very very bare bones html page
now i'm going to get into the details of
what is a bare-bones html page
first of all
we've got the doctype
this
is a thing that tells the browser okay
this document uses html version five
and uh
yeah it's not strictly required like i
think it would work without it but
it's good practice from what i hear to
include it
so once you've told the browser that
we're using html5
then you can open up
into this block of
html
and so i just want to point out that the
structure of html is
in general you've got an opening
tag
and a closing
and a tag is defined by these um greater
than less than
things here
and a closing tag
has this slash after the
uh this less than symbol right here
and once you've got this opening and
closing tag pair you can put a bunch of
stuff
inside it essentially developing a tree
data structure and that's what xml is
it's really a tree
data structure meaning there's nodes and
and each node has children so when you
define a pair of opening and closing
tags that's a
that's defining
a node a dom node dom means dom
document object model
so when this html page gets loaded and
parsed and it runs in the browser the
browser
in parsing this and running it creates
this thing called the dom the document
object model
and so this is the document the source
code and the document object model
is this data structure that gets created
from this stuff and so this is the root
node of
the dom which is a tree data structure
and then this root node has two children
the head
and the body
so you can see very clearly here there's
the head
and the body
of an html page
it defines
stuff that
sort of uh is not directly visible
on the page but may have some
side effects
uh for example
the title tag
is a tag that goes into the head and
it's
i believe it's actually required
to to have a valid html document
so if you were to
have a text file on your machine called
index.html
and double click it
and open it in the browser
that the tab
would say svg fundamentals
and
to that point
i want to stress the fact that
you can do all this stuff without using
vishub
so let me just
show you what i mean
i won't spend too much time on this but
i want to stress that
this is all using standard technologies
and there's nothing really viz hub
specific about any of this
so if i make a new directory called test
i'm using linux here
and i create a file called index.html
and i save this file
and then i open up this
folder you can see okay there is a file
called index.html
and if i double click that it opens
in the browser
and check it out it says svg
fundamentals in the tab
so that's the role of the title tag
see all these different pages they have
different text in the tab
all of those are derived from the title
tag
inside of those
html pages
and then
if you right click in the browser
you can say view page source
you can do this on any web page
and it shows you the source code of that
page which was just loaded in from this
text file on my machine
so this little diversion is just to say
that
you don't have to use vishub per se
this is one of the complaints that i've
gotten my previous courses like he
doesn't tell us how to not use vishub
vishub is a tool that makes it easier to
get started writing code right away
without having to set up a local
development environment
but for this svg stuff you don't need
any development environment you can just
double click the file
and it should all work
in vishub
the title
tag
it feeds into the title of the viz
which you see here
on the page
also invis hub there's a file called
readme.md
and i'm just going to delete all that
stuff this is just where you can add the
description
of this page
i'll type something here like
a demonstration
of svg
shapes
so the idea is you can use this
readme.md
to add a text description to your viz
and then
um
you can close out the editor and then
share a link
like this just how viz works you can
share links to these things with other
people and then
this page will load up without the
editor open
all right
so now that we've got
this basic page here
how do we create
svg shapes
well
it turns out you can put svg elements
into the body
the body
is the part of the html document that
contains things that end up visible
on the actual page
so just to give a little preview if we
say hello world
right here
then hello world pops up in really tiny
text
on the running page
and for this sort of thing i like to use
the mini mode of vishub which will show
the running page right there
and i can edit the text
over here
so to create something with svg
we can create an svg element right here
in the body
so we can have an opening svg tag and
then a closing
svg tag
and this opens up
a world of possibilities
because within
this
pair of opening and closing svg tags
we can put
tags that are not valid outside of svg
for example circle
we can put a circle right here and again
it's all tagged so you have to have
opening and closing
so we've got circle
um not circle i like to phrase a lot of
people phrase the closing tag as not
so you could say body not body svg not
svg
circle and then not circle
but
the circle doesn't actually show
because there's no um
there's no attributes of it defined and
in html
attributes are specified like this
cx equals
cx is the attribute that defines the
center x coordinate of the circle in
pixels
so if we set cx to be 50 and cy to be 50
we still don't have anything showing up
because there's no radius
defined the radius of the circle you can
define with r
so if i say r is 50
now we get a circle
current
yeah can i ask questions
um just to recap
the
an element whether it's a html element
or a svg element
that
is a group of tags is that is that right
it's it is the the difference between
element and a tag is it is that quite um
important to know
yeah that's actually a really great
point it's it's real oh thank you so
much this is what this is so good
the distinction between element and tag
is
is very confusing
i feel like a lot of people even folks
who have that have been doing this stuff
for a long time
don't really grok
what the difference is so my
understanding
of what the difference is between an
element and a tag
is that a tag
strictly refers to the text in the
source code
of the html
so this you know when i select this text
on my screen
that's an svg tag
and that's a closing svg tag
and then
when the page
runs
in the browser
that tag which is part of the source
code it's part of the text of the source
code
all of these tags get parsed by the
browser
into this tree data structure called the
document object model
and then in that document object model
the instantiation of that object
is called the element
so
this set of tags
in the source code
when parsed
leads to the creation of an svg element
and a circle element inside of that svg
element
and
you can see
these elements using the chrome dev
tools
which is a really essential thing
so if i right click here
on that circle
in chrome
and click on inspect
it opens up
what's called the chrome dev tools
and you can arrange these or if you like
i prefer them at the bottom i'll make it
bigger with
control plus
so you can see here that
this
is the svg element that's actually
instantiated on the page and see when
you hover over the svg element
that little box appears
and that box by the way is the default
dimensions of svg
when you don't specify width and height
you'll also notice that that box
is not flush with the edge
of
of the page so all of these things we
will be addressing
but yeah to your point
the element
is what's instantiated in the browser
after the page runs the tag
is just the text in the source code
yeah i think that makes sense say so
tags are used to describe what
gets created at runtime exactly yes
yes that's exactly right
thank you thanks correct
yep
um and and by the way i want to
highlight that these chrome dev tools
are are so amazing because you can
actually edit
the dom
so if i change cx to say 100 in the
chrome devtools the circle moved over
and if i change the radius to 500
here it gets bigger it well it fills the
entire
space of the
svg
because svg this svg element has the
default width and height so we can set
the width
to be
um 960 and the height
to be 500
these are the default dimensions
inherited from blocks.org
which vishub also uses
so what we're doing here is
i would call it
manual
dom manipulation so manually
manipulating the document object model
using the chrome dev tools
and
when you hear the term dom manipulation
that's usually when a javascript
program
reaches into the dom and changes it
around at runtime and that's what d3
does that's what react does that's what
vue does felt all these things
uh jquery the original
they all do dom manipulation and so
that's another key distinguishing factor
between tags and elements i mean a tag
is just
it's
static
it just gets loaded once from the source
code but an element the instantiation of
the tag is dynamic meaning it can change
at run time so
it's i'm changing it manually
by
you know changing this text in the
chrome dev tools but you can also make
these
same
kind of dynamic changes
using javascript
and we'll do that
in future episodes
but now if this program reruns again if
i trigger a rerun by editing it all of
those changes are lost
so um
at this point i noticed
some folks
poking their head into this file i saw
anita and sriram
in there
in terms of their presence cursors
and
i want to take this opportunity to open
up
this
viz to be edited
in real time
by you all
so i'm going to go to the collaborators
and add both of you
and all that ideal too just in case
so this is a feature of viz hub where
you can give people permission to edit
the document in real time
and i see some edits are already being
made
um whoever's editing you want to
describe what's going on
yeah i'm editing it it's just so much
fun right
wow this is amazing so
okay a copy of the circle was made
and the fill was set to be red
this is perfect
fill
is an attribute of
svg elements
that defines the color of the inside of
the shape
and notice that the formatting is a
little different um there's single
quotes in use here
uh and there's spaces around the equal
sign
uh but i've used single double quotes i
just want to say it it doesn't really
matter in terms of how the program runs
but stylistically
you can unify
all of this stuff with a utility called
prettier
prettier is an amazing
utility that automatically formats code
and it's built into vishub oh i see you
just use prettier nice
if you click this little colorful p
it auto formats
the code
invis hub to be consistently formatted
wow this is really cool
really cool
so
cx is 150 on the red circle meaning it's
moved over to the right
i want to clarify that that
the coordinate space of svg
it has um the origin in the upper left
so the upper left is actually the
coordinate 0 0.
and then as x increases the shape moves
over
with my screen the shape moves
to the right
and as y increases the shape moves down
and the y direction is inverted relative
to what you see in like math textbooks
with graphs and stuff
or in data visualizations
y typically goes up so that's that's
going to be it's a source of confusion
um often times when developing
visualizations why it's flipped
so just to be aware that's the
coordinate space
of
svg so i see some edits are being made
where there's a rectangle at x equals
but
that's not going to show up because the
svg currently still has its default
width and height
so i'm going to just change that by
saying width
is
and height
is 500.
now the svg should
fill up
the page
and it does
this is quite the little party going on
here we've got a green circle we got a
red circle we got a rectangle
this is great so let me just use
prettier
on this
so we can see clearly this rectangle
rectangles are another you know
fundamental svg shape
it's you can create a rectangle with the
rect element
x and y
are the coordinates of the upper left
corner of that rectangle
rectangles can have width and height
these are all in pixels
and yeah fill
set to none
means that the shape is transparent that
there's no fill inside of it
and stroke
stroke is an attribute of svg elements
that you could apply you can apply to
circles rectangles a lot of different
shapes and that's the outline and so
stroke equals blue means that this thing
here has
a blue outline now
and stroke width
is what you can use to control the
thickness of that outline
so if i set the stroke width to be like
we can see that that rectangle is
actually the outer rectangle
and and check that out that outer
rectangle is actually above the circles
that's another thing about svg is that
um
in
in svg you can't control the z index by
setting the z index css property which
you can with other html elements the z
index means which which thing comes on
top of which other things
the z ordering
uh is purely dependent on
the ordering of the stuff in the
document itself
so that's why this rectangle is
on top of
those circles
but check this out if i move the black
circle
to be to be after that rectangle see how
it appears on top now
so that's why um that's what i mean when
i say the z ordering
is determined by the ordering in the svg
document and that becomes super super
important when you're in the weeds of
making a visualization it's like a
fundamental thing
that you really need to understand
so how about this let's collectively
clean this up a little bit um these
rectangles
let's have like one rectangle one circle
or no we it's multiple circles or it's
nice
in a way
i also wanted to introduce
the svg element of a line
so you can have a line
element
begin line end line
and that line has
x one
so if i put x one at zero
y one at
zero
x
at
maybe 100
and
y2
at 100
should create a line
um it does not
and i believe that's because we have not
set the stroke
on the line i think lines might be
invisible until you set a stroke on them
there we go
now you can see that little line
i'm currently i noticed something
earlier uh when the height of the svg
was uh i think maybe halfway down and
the nice big yellow rectangle was only
only half of it was showing
and i was wondering whether that meant
you could create
uh shapes and elements
outside of that
uh out of outside of the width and
height does that mean
uh
when
one sets a width and a height on the svg
element in the sv svg tag sorry
that only shows a partial view of what's
what's
being created or is like a sort of a
window if that makes sense yeah that's
correct see if we if we were to change
the width for example to be
or let's say 500
it clips
everything
that falls outside of that
so if you inspect the the svg element
you can see that it's bounded
at this square which is 500 and 500.
the outer svg element clips
the things that are inside of it
because the the browser gives the svg
only the screen real estate of its width
and height
and the things inside of it
may well be outside of those that width
and height i mean if we set x to 600
that rectangle is going to be totally
off to the side and it's going to get
clipped out and you won't be able to see
it
so yeah i mean you can you can totally
put stuff in an svg that's outside the
bounds of the width and height
and you just won't be able to see it
yeah and there's a similar construct
called an svg clip path that i think
we'll get into a lot later on but that
with an svg clip path you can you can
use these shapes
to clip
other shapes
inside of it like say if you had a
texture you could clip the texture by a
circle
things like that
i'll get into all that
quite a bit later on
oh i see there's a path
who made that path i think it was sriram
do you want to talk about that
sorry kurt um i was just actually
playing around with an svg that i
downloaded from icon monster
nice
so i thought i'll just try and paste
some elements out of it to see what
exactly it's doing
it's very cool like it's actually an
element from um
this thing that just creates an x button
um
like a menu x button
nice so like we have these burger icons
right like which are pretty much now
the edm for
menu
yeah so i was just going through that
it was a nice
and did it work did it show up there
yeah actually it did i saw a small like
line
cutting across the black circle
so that line
i believe was the one that i had added
see if i set the stroke width on that
line you can see it
should get bigger there
i don't know if that path is visible
so let me let me do this i'll inspect
the element
and the path
somehow the path is not showing up there
in the svg
is it valid oh it's got a self-closing
tag
i i don't believe that's uh that's not
valid um
html it may be valid jsx but in html you
have you have to explicitly close
the tag like this not path now it should
show up
yeah that's what i was wondering like
[Music]
it doesn't have a rosy tank
there it is
yeah yeah you in in in straight html a
closing tag is strictly required except
for certain elements like maybe an image
element
don't know but but yeah there's that
path it is there
it's a nice little rounded uh
a rounded
line
there is there um is there a difference
between line and path or is is one based
on the other um because that that um
i suppose you one could use
either
either thing to create a straight line
like like the
line shown in path
yes there's a huge difference line is
just
it's just a straight line from point a
to point b
point a being
um
x1 y1 point b being x2 y2 but path
is a much much more generic thing that
you can use to construct
all sorts of shapes
really
um
it's got this domain specific language
as part of it
so let me let me edit this path because
this string
this string looks very cryptic
and uh when you when you have icons and
and stuff that are defined in svg you do
have these cryptic strings that you can
copy paste over but these cryptic
strings actually use a language
they use their own language
so i'm going to actually edit this
particular string
i'm going to make
some edits right in here to clarify how
this little domain specific language
works
let me preserve that one just so we have
it as a reference
i'll make a new i'll make a new path
so d equals
this domain specific string that's
specifically for svg paths
m
is the move to
command
so m
if we want to move
to
let's say
400 400
move to the x coordinate 400 and the
y-coordinate 400 it's like that
and then there's another command that
you can issue which is the l
command which is line two
and and this is how it works like this
is one command in this little domain
specific language it means move to this
these coordinates it's like putting a
pen down it's like move your pen to this
place and then l means line two
means draw a line from that place to the
other place so if i say l
500 comma 500
it should draw a little line
and i believe i have to say
i need to i need to specify a stroke so
this i'll say the stroke is black
and see there
there it is there's that little line
there
which is which is our path
and
you may be thinking well that's the kind
of stuff you can do with an svg line
but check this out
um
you can you can add another line to
command attached to that one so let's
say if we go l
500 600
what does that do oh it's actually off
the screen let me just
bring everything down so move to 200 200
line to
300 300 and then another line to
let's say 300 400
you can see that it has created this
filled in
shape there
and it's filled in
because
fill is automatically set to black so if
i say fill
equals
none
now it's just this
this path here
and and let me increase the stroke width
too so you can see it
so here's an example of a path that's
actually comprised of two line segments
this is the first line segment
and this is the second line segment
and so this one here is actually that
path element
and the path element is what is used
to construct line charts for example
that are data driven instead of having a
bunch of separate lines that are
separate elements you can just have one
path element that is comprised of many
lines
and same thing for area charts
if you just use the fill
it becomes this filled in area so you
can use
you can use paths for areas and area
charts paths are also also used for
geometries in maps
like you know the shape of a country or
what have you
so i think that's
all i really want to cover today
but i feel like that's a lot oh and by
the way this is how you can make
comments
in html
begin it with this
exclamation mark in two dashes and then
end it with
two dashes and a
in a um
a less than a greater than symbol or
less than symbol
yeah those are html comments
so i see there's some activity in the
youtube chat let me address
those
there's a question can you make layers
like circle on top of another circle i
see when i was talking someone made that
edit
and in fact yes
you can see that there's there's the
circle
below and the circle above
and yeah the layering is just purely
based on the ordering of the document
so if i were to take this smaller circle
and put it before
then it would be essentially invisible
because it's actually behind the red
circle which we can see if we if we move
it around a little bit
but yeah that's how you would create
layers
is by
just making sure one comes after the
other in the document and the one on top
is smaller so you can see that what's
behind it
yeah great question
adele you had a question
uh yeah i'm just just curious uh about
the
path elements uh specifically the d
attributes and um
i would just uh is there a difference
between
the letters if they're uppercase or
lowercase and um
uh
is is that is that something that um
you
you you've
had to do before to uh because
i'm not sure exactly what the difference
is um
and uh it'd be
i'll just wondering a few
sure
yeah um let's find out if i make it a
lowercase m
it seems to still work and the lowercase
l
oh uh
looks like that did something different
actually
so um it appears it is case sensitive
uh to learn more about this
i would suggest the md
n article about
svg paths because it's an entire
language
it says the d attribute
is a value of string it is animatable
yes
um
and somewhere in here yeah here it is
these are all the path commands
so there are a ton of these
path commands
uh but
more often than not you don't need to
construct these commands yourself
because there's some utility that
generates it
often you encounter these like if you
want to put icons
into your svg you can you can copy paste
these paths from an icon svg file
with data visualization there's a
package called d3 shape that will use
later
that actually generates these
strings for you
so usually you can treat this d
attribute as a black box
that you don't really need to know about
like you don't really need to understand
it
um
but i wanted to go into a little detail
now because
it's good to just know
um
the structure of it
and i see in this example there are
spaces
like i think it could have
spaces in it
and it would be fine
it works just the same
and i feel like i've seen space
delimited coordinates yeah that works
too you don't even need the commas
so there there is some flexibility there
in terms of the structure but it looks
like it is case sensitive maybe
uppercase l and lowercase l
um honestly i don't know they might be
different
commands or something
yeah i think it's uh it says
versus relative coordinates
it could be
just yeah in the note just below your
where you're highlighting ah
yes
oh look at that uppercase
is absolute and lowercase is relative
based on the differences oh that's quite
interesting
so let's let me just see if i really
understand that
in our path
we've got a move to command
and let's let's see this second line to
command
it uses the absolute coordinates 300 400
but in if we were to rephrase that in
terms of relative coordinates with the
lowercase l
the change in x would be zero and the
change in y would be 100
and we get the same result yes
that's what it is nice
nice i'm actually learning that
just now
so
thanks for that
oh there's a question in the youtube
channel
did you say there was a get it right in
black and white channel in the u in the
d3 slack
yeah you know
um
i was going back and forth
mentally about how i wanted to deal with
the
um asynchronous communication for this
and what i've decided is
for now at least
i want to try to use the vishub forum
for these
communications not the d3 slack
mainly because the d3 slack is very
um
transient
but if you feel strongly
let me know i mean i i i may end up
creating a d3 slack channel for for this
series i'm not sure
but i used i used slack in the past
for for the date of his 2020 series and
there was so much really great activity
in the d3 slack
that is currently gone forever lost
to the sands of time
uh because slack doesn't preserve its
history with the d3 slack which is on
their free plan of slack
so that's why um i want to
use this vishub forum
thing instead
so
um
in the youtube stream there's a link to
the blog post about it and in the blog
post there's a link to the forum index
and the forum index looks like this
this is a page that i plan to maintain
that will have an index of all the
resources for all of the episodes and
right now there's just episode one which
doesn't really have anything in here yet
but
this is one i want to leave you with
as we close out today i want to leave
you all who are watching
with an exercise
this is another differentiator
between this series and last series i
want to give exercises at the end of
each and every episode
so that you all can engage with this
stuff and try your hand at it and share
your work and hopefully we'll build up a
community of people who are following
this series
and participating
and so here's what i want you to do make
something creative with basic svg shapes
and do that by
you know fork fork
the hello html example or
you can
fork
the example that we made today
and i'm just going to
remove
collaborators right now so we can like
freeze it
the way that it is
as a record of today
and so you can fork
this viz
to do your
exercise
and by the way
in this vis hub forum software which is
an instance of discourse
what you can do
is
put a vishub link on its own line and it
will unfurl to include a thumbnail so
when you share your work that's what you
can do
let me just sign in so i can edit
so you can fork
this example and what i'm going to do is
drop that viz hub link
and on its own line
and you see what happens here
it unfurls
so yeah that's what i'll leave you with
today uh if you followed along enjoyed
this please go ahead uh fork this thing
modify it
and share your work here
um and feel free to ask questions also
in this
in this forum thread
i'm hoping that this forum
works out well
as a platform for discussions and stuff
um
if there if it doesn't i might introduce
a slack channel
or a slack channel might be good to have
anyway i'm not sure
we'll see uh stay tuned
for that
so welcome everyone to episode two of
get it right in black and white
i'm just so pumped to do this so we've
got adil here we've got anita here some
others may join
but in the meantime
we can start
episode 2 is going to be about pseudo
visualizations what that means is we're
going to use basic svg shapes to
approximate
visualizations and this will make sure
that you know we really grok the
fundamental shapes that go into making
visualizations
what we'll cover today
and this is aspirational i may not get
to all of these but
i am going to review the exercise
submissions from last week
we got some really good ones
removing the default margins and scroll
bars that appear on an html page
i would like to revisit the topic of
text versus elements because there was
some confusion around that
and then we'll go ahead and develop a
pseudo scatter plot a pseudo bar chart a
pseudo line chart and a pseudo area
chart
and i would like to discuss
svg interoperability with figma
and other tools
and if we get to it we'll add svg text
and customize the font
before we get into all of that i just
want to
reflect on what we've gotten into so far
it's been html which is
comprised of svg css and javascript
and we have delved into svg
a little bit more so within that svg
concept we're looking at circles
lines and paths
and i think i'll be evolving this
diagram
as we go to add in all the various
concepts that we learn about
let's review the submissions
from last week the exercise was make
something creative with basic svg shapes
and this is
what happens
here's one submission
i'll click through it and see what it is
this is just gorgeous
beautiful beautiful stuff
you know it's very artistic and this is
what got me thinking of
of highlighting some of the
integrations with design tools
and i want to point out if you put the
link on its own line it will unfurl like
this get a little preview in here
so here's another submission
the vision
beautiful beautiful stuff
and it's all just svg right there in the
page
oh here anita did one with um
transitions
actually now that i'm here um anita
would you mind just describing
the transitions that are happening here
should i talk about it yeah yeah can you
just talk about it for a few minutes and
i'll highlight the the code as you as
you talk about it
okay
so
we made a basic uh
rectangle using svg
so rectangle is graphics here
and
the properties of these rectangles are
width height
fill
x and y position
and we can change all of that using css
language which is here on the top
style and
in the style
so
using
red
i'm accessing this
left element index vg directly
and what is
what is our aim is to do the transition
on it
when i'm hovering on a triangle
so what i want to change the feel of it
fill and stroke with so when i hover on
it
the transition is happening at three
thousand millisecond
means three seconds here
and
in the beginning
the fill of the rectangle is red and
stroke is black
and on however
rect and hover
is changing
fill to grain and stroke weight to 100
pixel
so the first one it just
it
shows the css properties for rectangle
and the next rect semicolon hover
is another state
on the
first state so it changes
and that's where the transition come
transition is actually between two
states
first is when the field is read and the
second state is going to feel is the
green forward angle and that's where
transition property comes
and we can define that using css
language
nice
thank you that's awesome
oh thank you so much for
for describing that that's that's really
great to see
thank you
so yeah just to recap a little bit
i think this is the first time we're
actually using css so when you when you
introduce these style tags it opens up
into a block of css
and then these are the css selectors so
this selects the body element this
selects all rectangles
and this one colon hover
it says okay apply these styles when the
thing is hovered over
and so that is cool by itself and then
you know when you add this transition
you know this is one way to to animate
things
with svg and css
so yeah great one by nita
this one
is really incredible
i was just blown away by this i mean
look at this this is just so beautiful
so beautiful
and i want to highlight that
when this
submission originally came in
it looked like this
and i immediately noticed that there's
the default margin that appears with
html
see on the upper left corner there's a
default margin of some i don't know some
on pixels and then there are scroll bars
here
and so
these are both undesirable things
in the forum i just said oh add the css
and i want to just discuss this css a
little bit because it's very useful for
pretty much anything that you do where
there's a full screen svg
this css
applies to
the body
element that has a default margin
in html
and so
to get rid of that default margin we can
set the margin
css property to zero
that will get rid of the margin
but then
there do appear these scroll bars
which are kind of a bummer and i don't
really understand why they appear but
anyway to get rid of those
scroll bars you can add overflow hidden
to the body as well and this gives you a
really nice
blank canvas
where the svg does
fill up the screen
all right really good stuff
yeah here's here's my comment you know
that's how you can remove the scroll
bars
a couple more
here's one with
some circles it almost looks like a
record
very cool
um oh yeah and you can set the height
of things in viz hub
so i noticed with this one
it's actually larger than the page
there's this scroll bar so you could get
rid of the scroll bar
or
another thing that you could do
is
change the height there's an option here
to set the height i just wanted to make
sure everybody's aware of this
so yeah you can use that to change the
aspect ratio
of the viz
and this one also blew my mind
look at that
took my avatar with and uh
you know exported the paths
to svg pretty wild
and this one also uses
the hover css selector so when you hover
it changes the transform which is a css
property that you can use
to to scale and rotate and translate
things
so i thought this was very nice work
very nice work
here's a flag
of
seychelles
very beautiful
this one uses the polygon construct
within html it also uses an h1
element which is this text here h1 in
html means heading one
so the text is kind of big and bold
and here's what seams work
very nice
kind of like abstract art
and you can see that it's
a bunch of path elements
where the only difference is where it
moves to initially
and since these are lowercase
commands these are relative so all you
need to do is change that one thing and
it moves the whole thing down
and check this out there's a class
on
the path element
and a class can be selected with css
meaning you can use css to select all
elements that have a specific class
using the dot
prefix on the css
selector so this one here
this little block of css
selects this inner path this one here
and sets the fill to black just on that
one
whereas on all the other ones the fill
is none
so that's a nice
you know first sighting of css
classes
can i ask questions yeah
so what is difference between id and
class
oh id and class
yeah
this could be a basic question
let me just uh fork this so i can modify
it and show you to give a sense
so the question is about um
id versus class
class
is something that many things can have
so there could be many classes that have
the same sorry
there could be many path elements that
have the same class in which case this
selector would apply to all of them
there's also a construct called id
and
if you use id
see how now it's broken it didn't it
didn't select
if you use id then the prefix on the css
selector is a hash
symbol
so now
that should work
oops i i misspelled id as i n
so id is inner path and it works
the main difference
between id
and class
is that the intention
behind id
is that there's only one thing that has
a given id
that's why it's called the id means the
identifier for that one particular thing
so
id
is for
just one element
meaning
no two elements should have the same id
ideally but class
is is it defines a class of
elements meaning a grouping of multiple
elements so there could be many elements
that share the same class
so that's the main difference between id
and class
so going through the
submissions
and questions here neeta asked a
question
about svg it says svg is an xml-based
markup language for describing
two-dimensional vector graphics
as such it is text base
and so on
and so the question is
is svg
a graphics language similar to html and
xml
yes
yes it is svg in fact
stands on its own
as an image format
and so in a sense it's not strictly
within html
svg exists
as a standard for defining images
outside of xml outside of html
but it is based on xml so xml is the
language used with the tags and
everything that's the language used
inside of svg images
so i hope that i hope that answers the
question is that clear enough
yes yes intense nice
and is everything inside svg tags
text data
um
well
this comes to the point of the
distinction between the document
and the dom
this came up last time too i think it
was ideal that asks what is the
difference between a tag and an element
and
i gave an answer that i don't think was
100 accurate
uh anita did some researching and
reading about this
um
and i wanted to just clarify this point
that in a document meaning
in the text
that defines
an html document the source code you
know in the dot html file
there are elements there
in the sense that
the syntax in there defines
the element
and that
element in the document is comprised of
the start tag the ending tag and
everything
in between
tags on the other hand are constructs
that only exist in the document the tags
for like every element
in its definition in the in the document
has two tags an opening tag and a
closing tag and those tags are purely
syntax
for defining
the elements
but when the document gets loaded and
parsed into the browser
it becomes the dom the document object
model
and in the dom
it's a tree data structure where there
are elements
so
if you if you google html element and
read about it people discuss it
in
in different ways
and they use the same term
element
to define
things that are in the source code
meaning you know the start tag the end
tag all the attributes and everything in
between
that's often referred to as an element
when you're discussing
the source code the document
but there is a distinction between an
element in the source code and an
element in the living breathing dom
and so
the living breathing dom is a dynamic
thing where the elements can change over
time but the element in the document is
a one-time
thing like it's it's fixed when you load
the page so i just wanted to
discuss about this a little bit
i hope it clears up any confusion around
this any any remaining questions about
this
we'll be talking about dom in the future
because we did not talk about it yet
oh yeah i mean we'll be using the dom
quite a bit
quite a bit and i think we did
talk about it a little bit
yeah so if we look at anything in vishub
i just want to clarify this with some
some grounding
um
here's the begin tag
here's the end tag
and taken together
it defines
the element in the source code
similarly here's this svg
all this stuff that i've selected
defines this svg element and there are
elements nested within this
but this is the source code you know
this is the document but when it runs in
the browser
you can right click it and say inspect
and that gives you this
chrome dev tools
which is a is a window into the dom
not
the document
not the source code
and so
um
in this sense we have touched the dom
by using the chrome dev tools
and like i said last time you can
manipulate these things these attributes
in here
and it will update and see look at that
it actually it it actually transitions
so if i set the width to be 400
it transitions because there's a css
transition applied to it
but what i'm doing here is manipulating
the dom
by using the chrome dev tools
and in the future we're going to use
javascript to manipulate the dom
yeah but we're not quite there yet
so going through the submissions i want
to uh highlight this one by ideal this
is so good
yeah check this out it's this really
beautiful animation with
the sun setting and the colors changing
so this is just gorgeous gorgeous work
and
ideal is live with us now
and i was hoping we could um dive into
this a little bit because there are a
couple of new constructs used
in here like gradients
and animate
tags
so ideal
would you like to sort of narrate what's
going on here and also describe you know
how you came to create this
sure uh this was uh a really fun
exercise um
uh
it i thought
of the uh yeah there was a the idea of
the sun rising and setting and uh
automatically um
thinking well i think how would that
affect the surroundings as well
so we have a um
to begin with i created the sky element
as a rectangle
and
gave it a
fill
um and
which would be determined by
the
something called yeah the sky gradient
and
so this is a linear gradient
that sits in a special tag called defs
where it gets
defined
and
sorry this was a radial gradient not a
not a linear one and uh
the uh it takes an id so we can refer to
the definition
and
it's uh there is also it takes a
cx and cy
property which is uh familiar i think
when when we use the circle
tag
and what the these do is uh similarly
they define the
the
circle for that gradient
and that
the perimeter of that circle
can be
have a gradient um or a color attached
to it
um
and um so yeah this was this was really
uh
this was the first time i'd really come
across the
animate and gradient
apis of svg
um so i just want to make sure i
understand and just to explain
everything uh if you change cx to zero
see how the the gradient is sort of
emanating from
this side
and 50
puts it in the middle and likewise with
cy if you put it to zero
it's emanating from the top
very very nice and you know i didn't
actually know that
um
percentages
are the unit here that so i'm learning
things as we go
so yeah i just wanted to tweak those um
but yeah continue please
yes the uh yeah it takes uh percentage
units uh which was uh interesting and uh
i may be wrong but i wonder whether it
uh
it uh it just corresponds to
the position across the screen in terms
of how far in terms of as a percentage
it goes across this screen um
uh so i think this would be
50 50
for each of cx and cy
would be
right in the middle of the
screen
um
of the svg
and
there is a it takes a radius um
uh which also
i i think
uh tries to yeah uh describe the
again in a percentage
um
uh but also tries to uh describe the
width
of the
overall
where the position of the perimeter
would end up
and so that was this was quite new um
and
uh so i think yeah in so i think we
after experimenting just like that uh
with the various numbers uh i settled on
75 um and then uh but yeah i was
experimenting exactly in that way just
to get an idea of what what that radius
really meant
um
and uh
yeah there's a
inside of that radial gradient there are
a
there is a stop tag
um
a couple of stop tags um
one that uh hasn't uh each of the these
have have an offset property
of z um and one is zero
and the other is a hundred
and um
i think this really describes the offset
property describes where that gradient
stop is
located and
so i think for a radial gradient um
it will be
the distance from the center
to the
uh edges of the circle um
so um
yes again i was experimenting exactly
like that just to see
what the how the numbers would translate
into
into different uh
yeah colors across the screen
um
so that was uh yeah just um
and then there was uh
a little uh yeah so there was a radial
gradient used for
the sky backdrop and then two linear
gradients used for the two
landscapes in the foreground
and um
actually before we go on what is this q
is this what makes it curvy
uh yes so i think uh this is a
cubic
curve if if i i looked up the
mdn documentation um
[Music]
from uh uh last week and i think this is
um
it might be sorry not cubic but
quadratic
um
some quadratic
bezier curve
and so um that will allow
uh
from the current position which is
defined by um
the first two sorry the last the second
two which is um
um
the okay see if i just get this right so
it takes a current position
uh which is
uh defined
by what comes after m
um where we as you described last week
that's where when we put the ink to
paper we put the pen to paper
and then the
what comes after q are four numbers
the first two of those numbers are
control points and the second two are
where you would
uh where the final point ends up
[Music]
so that's
960 is right on the other end of the
screen
and yeah again experimenting this is
this is how i
became a little bit more comfortable uh
with understanding what it does
and the two
um the control points uh straight up to
cue
i think these help this uh help um
these are points located somewhere which
help
describe the
um the curve and the way that
it gets pulled towards those control
points
um
yeah again a lot lots of experimentation
was involved just to
just to see how um this
this could this could work um
very nice
yeah
it was it was fun um yeah similarly
um
we had uh yeah
that was yeah again yeah i think that
about sums it up there's linear
gradients that use a similar format to
the radial gradient
and stops within those and i'm curious
about this animate tag how did you
figure this out
yeah so this was uh
so the problem i was trying to solve
here was
how could we animate the
gradients so to speak how could as as
the
sun is rising and setting how can the
colors change
so um in this case uh this is the um
this this particular uh landscaping i
think in the foreground
this would go from um alice blue to
steel blue back to alice blue
and it would do it across a number of
seconds
and
so
yeah
the animate tag was very interesting
you can
try and descr by using something called
the attribute name
um which is uh the stop color
and you can change the values of the
stop color from and this blue to still
blue and alice blue
so that's a list of values that you
would like it to go through
nice
um again so much experimentation
yes really to help understand what was
really uh
what was going on
this is really great adil thank you so
much
it was fun thank you
you know this might be a good um
transition with the discussion on
control points
to using um
figma
figma is this really amazing design tool
that i've actually been learning myself
for the first time recently and i've
used it to create
all of the various
uh
you know
pieces of graphics
for this series so far
uh you may be interested to know that
the mask
that is applied to my video
is actually
drawn driven by this graphic right here
so that's being masked
onto my video
and that's actually how it's working
but anyway
figma
and a lot of different design tools like
figma including sketch
or adobe xd
or uh even like straight vector graphics
tools like adobe illustrator or inkscape
which is open source or i believe
has limited svg capabilities
but it it lets you design
svg graphics
and there's this whole interface around
it
and because the idea of control points
came up
i want to just create a little sample
to illustrate
control points
so i've got this sort of template here
i'm going to delete this stuff
and there's this thing called the pen
tool
you can use it to define
svg
paths
and so there's a path i can set the
stroke and interactively control all
this stuff so instead of having to
tweak it little by little you know in
the html
you could use a tool like this to very
rapidly
iterate
on stuff like this
and because the control point concept is
so abstract i wanted to illustrate it
in a concrete way
and i believe
if you drag
in here you can define a control point
and so this dragging
defines the control points along this
bezier
curve i think it's a bezier curve i may
be mistaken
but that that is the effect
of the control points
so if i grab that and change it around
see that is
that
right there
is the control point
it sort of pulls the line
in a certain direction
yeah so that's the essence of
control points
one thing i wanted to do today was
pseudo visualizations and what i mean by
that is
approximating visualizations
and i want to take a moment to just
discuss that
sketching
and doing mock-ups
in a design tool
are actually very important pieces of
data visualization work
i mean when i get involved in a client
project for example
we have a meeting
and then the first thing i do you know
if they send me the data i'm lucky if
they don't i have to imagine
the data
but often based on a discussion i often
sketch out something and this is a
popular technique from nadi bremer and
shirley wu they have data sketches that
whole thing highly recommend it
uh but to give a sense you know what i
do
is sketch
on a notebook
so i've got all these ideas
that i've sketched out this is for like
what i wanted to talk about today and
the next episode
and so
sketching is the first step and then
once you have a sketch
that you like and sketches by the way
you can communicate sketches to clients
it's a very effective tool because then
they realize that it's sketchy it's not
final in any way but then once you get a
sketch you like
the next step often is to
mock it up in a design tool
i mean sometimes you do go straight to
implementing with
d3 or whatever but
mocking up something in a design tool is
a big part of the process and i think it
would be good for us to do now to cement
our understanding of the basic svg
shapes
that go into
visualizations
so here i am in
figma which is
the tool that i've come to
really like for this sort of stuff
and i think
you know you can sign up for a free
figma account and use it
for free i think they charge you when
you want to add
real time collaborators
so i'm going to start by making what
they call a frame
in figma
this
is going to be the sort of container
for our svg
and i'm going to set the width
to be
960 and the height to be 500
because that's what the default width
and height are in vishub and in
blocks.org
and let's start by creating a pseudo bar
chart um
p s e u d o pseudo something means a
fake version of the thing
uh if anybody hasn't heard of that term
pseudo
so um
yeah i wanted to make a pseudo uh
scatter plot a pseudo bar chart pseudo
line chart so why don't we start with
the pseudo
scatter plot
a scatter plot
visualization
is
comprised of
circles
and so if you drop in a circle there i
can set the fill here to be black
because we're going to get it right in
black and white
and then
i'm just going to make a bunch of copies
of that circle
and position them
around
the screen like this
so this is a
pseudo scatter plot
really
um
so i'll just you know spread them out a
little more make it sort of
aesthetically pleasing
and
at this point i want to highlight the
interoperability of svg
between tools like this and html so in
figma you can select this frame and
click on export
and then select
svg from this drop down menu here and
then say export like that
and then you get a dot svg
file that you can open up in chrome
and then
you can say view page source and here
you have the
svg text
which you can then copy
into vishub
so here i've got the svg fundamentals
from last week i'm going to fork this
and call it sudo
scatterplot
so i'll clear out the
the readme i'll actually say
an approximation
of a scatter plot
and then in index.html
i'm going to get rid of that svg that we
had before and paste
that text
in there and use prettier to autoformat
that
and there we go we've got a pseudo
scatter plot
uh current yeah
does the xmlns
attribute is that important
is that necessary
that's a great question um
i believe it
might
be necessary for svg files as in image
files that are outside of html inside of
html you really don't need it
it'll work without it
and
it gives you actually a lot of stuff
that you don't need
you'll see this a lot with
programmatically generated svg there's a
bunch of stuff that's not really
necessary so we could clean up this svg
like the view box
um
is something that
you can use to control the relationship
between
the actual pixels and like the the
pixels that you use the coordinate space
that you use to define the shapes
it helps with controlling the aspect
ratio there's some tricks you can do
with the view box but
i'm going to delete it because it's not
strictly required
and also fill of none on the svg that's
not required either
and also fill equals black
i'm going to use vim mode here to delete
all of these at once you don't need the
fill equals black because the fill is
black by default
on
all svg shapes
and this one is suffering from the
default margins and the scroll bars
issue so i'm going to just add that
style
back in
to remove the
margin i'm going to select the body
element
and say margin
is zero
see that moved it
up just a little bit
and then
overflow
is hidden
okay that looks decent
so there we go
a pseudo
scatter plot
uh let's do also a pseudo
bar chart
i'm going to go back to figma here
i'm going to make a copy
of this frame
i'll delete
everything in it
by selecting it hitting delete
we can create rectangles
can you give me access to the file oh
sure
yeah figma has real-time collaborations
so i can add
you
can edit it's an invite
you should be able to see it now
right so making this pseudo bar chart we
can just change the fill of this
rectangle
to be black
and then
i will copy this rectangle
move it over
and make it a
little smaller
and then do the same thing again
and figma has this really nice thing
where it will
sort of snap
to
proportions that make sense so like
the spacing is now the same 39 pixels
between all of these
and i think i'll make one more
make it a little smaller
and then i could select all of these and
then
drag them in
uh yeah figma has these really cool
features where you can
uh move things around all at once like
this
see this this here is a bar chart with
with no
padding
it's the term is padding
between the bars
and when you move them
to be spaced out like this that's
introducing some padding between the
bars
but anyway now we have our pseudo bar
chart i'm going to export this as svg
open it up
view the source
and i'm just going to copy the inside of
the svg because we already have an svg
sort of container
in vishub
then i'll go back to vishub here
and i'll fork this
and i'll call it
pseudo bar chart
and i'll change the description to say
an approximation of a
bar
chart
and then in the source
i'm going to just
delete the stuff in the svg and paste
whatever came out of figma and there we
have it
there we have a pseudo bar chart
and again there's some unnecessary stuff
um
there's a white
background rectangle that we don't need
because the background is already white
we don't need to fill all of these with
black because black is the default fill
and if i run prettier again it nicely
formats itself
so there we have a pseudo bar chart the
essence of a bar chart right here
and i want to point out one thing here
um
because this point trips up people later
on when you end up coding with d3
you might think that you can just change
the height of the bars
and it'll lay out like this but that's
actually not the case look at the y
coordinates
i mean if the y coordinate is the same
and we just vary the height
you end up with this
inverted
bar chart
and this is because in svg the
coordinate space of the y
the y coordinate
it goes from top to bottom meaning a y
of zero is at the top which is again a
confusing point and so what you have to
do
you do have to change the height of the
bars but you also need to change the
y-coordinates
of the bars
to be
the y-coordinate of the bottom
minus
the change in height
relative to the biggest bar
and so we'll express all that in code
later but i just want to sort of
foreshadow
that element you know that aspect of bar
charts
so let's let's do some more
um
a bar chart
can also go the other way
meaning instead of being
the bars going
from left to right and vertical like
this
you could have a bar
like this
and then have several bars that are
you know going down the page
like this
this format
often makes more sense
mainly because
you can position labels
to the left of it
and the text of the labels is not
it's not sideways
and that's a great lead into text
we can say like okay this is
this is bar a
and i can change the size of it
yeah so there's like
bar a
and this would be like
bar b and these would be replaced with
you know actual labels
in real database but these are pseudo
visualization so it's just abcd for now
and the font here i've selected as share
tech this is sort of the
font that i'll be using throughout the
series in figma you can quickly preview
different fonts
and i think most of these are available
with google fonts
but anyway
share tech is what it'll be
and then i'll just uh
you know adjust this
to be
pleasing to the eye
and let's export this one as well
export frame eight
i'll ins i'll view the source
copy this stuff um
oh that's that's odd
the path has ended up as
text
rather the text has ended up as paths i
guess that makes sense
so that you can preserve the font
but this is a great opportunity actually
to
to introduce fonts
in code
so what i'll do is i'll fork this one
horizontal bar chart
and then i'll paste
that svg right in here
and it worked
there it is
but
if you want to
programmatically set the text
it'll have to be
a little different from this i mean if
you wanted to change what the text says
you would have to like regenerate this
path which is
it's not something you want to get into
doing so
instead
what we can do is define the text as
text elements
on the svg so i'm going to delete all
those paths
that gets rid of those letters
and then we can add a text element
so begin text end text
and this is going to say a
and
i want to put it right next to this
particular rectangle so i'm going to
inspect it to see what the x and y
coordinates are
so x is
and and with text elements you can have
x
and y so i'll say x is
just as a starting point and y equals
and we can't quite see it
what if i say
x is a hundred
i'm not seeing it do you have a question
um
there it is so it is there
it's just not getting shown maybe i need
to say explicitly phil is black
there it is
so we've got a little a
okay we've got a little a here now we
want to make it so that it's aligned to
this bar
and it is big and it has a specific font
to do that
well to do a couple of those things we
can use
css
so we've got this style tag here we can
say
select all text
elements within the svg
and say font size
is
i don't know 36
pixels
you just have to sort of tweak it
okay maybe 120.
or actually what was it in figma
i'm going to use the same thing
okay now what we want to do is
center it
so to do that i can just
tweak the x and the y so let's say x is
or 70.
and y should be a little bigger maybe uh
how about 80.
getting there
90.
it looks about right
and to move it over to the left i'll
make it maybe x is 60
how about 50.
there we go that's approximately the
right place
and now i want to introduce the font
the font and so
google fonts
is the way to go when you want to add
custom fonts nowadays there's a long
history of fonts on the web
but
you know this day and age
i would recommend google fonts
you are dependent on the google servers
but
i believe all of these fonts are openly
licensed so if you wanted to migrate
away from google fonts you could but you
would have to host these font files
yourself which is sort of a pain
but to use any of these fonts now you
can just use google fonts and i'll show
you how to do that
so i want to use this font called share
tech
so you could download it
and then
to use it
we can click on select this style
and it gives you this little snippet of
css that you can just copy
so it says here use on the web just copy
this css or no this is html rather
that includes a link
so in vishab i can just paste
that
right there
oh there's some problem
uh looks like i've got a syntax error
somewhere
does it require a closing tag
for the link
for the link time
you know i think link is one of those
things that does not actually require a
closing tag and see if i get rid of it
the syntax error is still there
unexpected character in line 55
oh i didn't
see there it is i didn't add this little
character to close out the text
silly me
okay now we're unblocked and i can paste
that stuff up here
and uh yeah the the link tag
is one of those special tags that does
not require
a closing tag
and i think image
is also one of these so this is a
slightly different syntax this is called
a self-closing tag
where it gets closed with the
the slash right before this character
here
but anyway
now that we've got those
these link tags actually pull in the
fonts
and then
we can set the font family like this by
copying this little snippet
so all the text gets this share tech
font family
and boom
there we have it
all right
so we've got a pseudo bar chart here
we can fill in these labels
just by
copying this text
i'll make a couple copies of that
and move on
yeah sure
is is the css
accessing the dom or just the document
oh
yeah that's a great question
is the css accessing the dom
well
it's
it's like um
the browser is this engine
you could think of it as an engine
that takes all of these things
as input
and
works with
everything
and so
so yeah it's a great question does css
manipulate the dom
not really it's almost like a layer on
top of
the dom
um but it depends on the dom for sure um
so it's not it's not like it's not
strictly
modifying the dom it's like the dom is
there as one thing and then the css is
sort of a layer on top of it that
describes to the browser how to present
that dom
and so
the dependencies are like the css
depends on the structure of the dom to
function but the dom does not depend on
the css
so it's really a layer on top of the dom
so once the dom is there
the browser says okay i've got this dom
i have to present it
how do i present it oh i have to check
all the css that's there to just see if
there's any properties that apply to
these elements before i
display them on the screen and so the
browser engine internally says okay here
i've got this text element i want to i
want to display it
what do i do
which font do i use let me go and
consult the css
uh is there any css selector that
matches this if so does it have a font
family associated with it oh here it is
yes it does therefore you know i need to
use that font family to present
that
that dom element
so that's generally how it works like
that's generally the relationship
between
css
and the dom does that make sense
yeah so
it is always css which makes the final
decision or it is a dom like if we have
fill color in dom
and same fill in the style for same
element then which one will work first
which one is oh
which one is dominant yeah that's a
really good question
that's a really good and this this trips
people up sometimes so let me uh give a
little demonstration
so i'll say the class here for this
rectangle is first
bar
and let me set the fill to be red
in the in the html
and then in the css
we can select that by saying first bar
gets a fill
of green
and look at that
the css
actually takes precedence the css
overrides
what's there
in the dom
in terms of
the fill so this is one of those tricky
rules and you know
sometimes i have run into this
particular problem
when you're coding with d3 and
everything
and you use some code that sets the fill
of a particular element to be some color
and it's not working you know i've often
sat there tearing my hair out being like
what the what is even happening the
twilight zone moment
and
[Music]
so the first thing to do if your
if your
uh fill or any of these attributes in
the dom
if they're not working
check if there's any css that might be
overriding it
see no matter what we set here if we set
this to blue it's not going to work
because there's css that is conflicting
and the css actually takes priority
which is counter-intuitive i mean i
thought
i thought it would make more sense that
the attribute in the dom would take
precedence because it's more localized
but turns out
it's not the case
so yeah for this first bar
we can set the fill to be let's say
white
and the stroke
to be black
and the stroke width
to be
like 20 pixels
goes to show you that yeah css
overrides
what's in the dom
um current i have a question um relating
to this about um
the fill attribute
is that
um
because we are applying it to an svg
element
uh it works but uh i don't know if i've
seen a fill
uh attribute
would that apply to html as well because
i think i've seen other things like
background color or color or
i don't think i've come across a color a
fill attribute
for
yeah that's a great question i believe
it is localized only to svg
it only makes sense to use it with
respect to svg elements
um and and to to clarify this
like if i were to
have this question this is where i would
go the mdn documentation page for phil
and
i think there's this notion of a
presentation attribute
and and that's what
the presentation attribute is
in
in the dom if you set the fill attribute
on an element
and i recall somewhere in here
there was a list of things that could be
used as attributes
and also
as css properties because there are a
couple of these
but i don't know off hand
what they are
but definitely fill and definitely
stroke
and stroke width
but yeah to answer your question
phil is only applicable to svg elements
it's not it doesn't make sense outside
of svg but there are a lot of properties
that do apply outside of svg
like transform i think is so is very
generic it applies to all html elements
not just svg elements but yeah fill and
stroke they could be used as attributes
or they could be used as css properties
and if they are used as css properties
then they dominate
the value
from the attribute
yeah
that's great thank you
awesome so before we close out today
i do want
to also just do one last
pseudo visualization
which is a pseudo line chart
oh wait i've already done that look at
that
so this is a pseudo line chart right
here it's pretty much an svg path
and on this point
um
there are
aspects of svg paths that become
important like
the line join
you could have different values for line
join to make it either jagged cut off
like this or rounded and then there's
also the cap
the cap can be set to round for example
to make the caps
round
so as a last pseudo visualization i'll
just make this bigger
export this
as svg
view the page source
copy that
into vishub
this is going to be a pseudo line chart
and then i'll paste that here
yeah so that completes our series on
pseudo visualizations
yeah i was looking at the youtube chat
uh the only thing i see is from wasim
isn't the logic with svg phil different
from regular html
in which inline styling dominates over
the style tag
that's a great question um
i don't know if
i mean
we've just looked at how it is with svg
with svg
whatever's in the css dominates but with
other
types of tags
like straight html i'm actually not sure
how it is
um i can do
a little experimentation
yeah let's find out
so here's this thing that nita made
that is sort of an exploration of basic
html elements
there's the h1 element that ends up as
this text
there's the p element which is a
paragraph
h2
which is this
smaller text here
and
i'm going to fork this
and call it investigation
of css precedence
and in here
oh this is kind of interesting uh
there's some missing
tags which is another point we should
discuss but to answer the immediate
question i'm going to introduce a style
tag
and i'm going to say
h for h1 elements
let's make them red
oh phil
sorry not phil
but rather color
color is the generic html
css property okay so now that's red
um how would we make that red otherwise
i don't
i'm sort of grasping at straws here you
have to do can i tell you yeah tell me
you write style as a property in h1
equals to
and everything else goes in the
ports here
right yeah this is called inline styles
which you can do with svg too by the way
um
yeah i believe in straight html like
this the color is not
something it's not there is no attribute
for color
and so you would do inline styles like
this
and so in this case um
yeah i see in the youtube chat milo is
saying yeah both things are style
instructions
that's right that's right yeah it is css
so this is called inline css
and
the inline css does take precedence
over
the
other css the sort of external
non-inline css see if i get rid of that
it becomes
green
but if we put the inline style there it
does take precedence
over the other style
and i believe it might be the same
with
svg
let me just
uh double check that
so we've got this pseudo horizontal bar
chart
and
instead of saying fill equals blue
if we say style
equals
fill
is blue does that take precedence
it does
it does look at that
okay cool so we have learned a couple
things um inline styles
like this inline css
always takes precedence over
css defined
elsewhere
however
with the attributes
if i say fill equals blue
the css takes priority over the
attributes so that's how that's how it
all works
with the priorities here
that is so deep
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah this is so great i love this
question format because um we can stop
and really investigate
and get to the bottom of things
uh that people watching are wondering so
yeah this is so uh
so good
before we go i want to leave you all
with this exercise in the forum entry
for episode 2
here's the exercise
recreate a pseudo visualization
from one of these visualization
taxonomies
and so i invite you to go through
i invite you to go through these links
under data visualization taxonomies
and
look through all of these
and then pick one to reproduce as a
pseudo visualization
there's the visual vocabulary
deviation correlation see there's
already sort of pseudo-visualizations in
here these are great taxonomies of
visualization types
that you can use as a reference
uh to know how to
encode certain types of data
and we'll get into all of the logic
behind this
later on but for now you can just see
you know there are a bunch of pseudo
visualizations here
in these various
taxonomies so what i want you to do is
look through these
pick one
and reproduce it with svg
invis hub
you could modify the html directly or
use
some design tool like figma or
others
and here's another one
really amazing work
these are really fascinating
taxonomies
of
visualizations
from data to vis
another one
sort of a decision tree based on what
sort of variables you use which chart
types to pick
so yeah go through these links
and recreate a pseudo visualization from
there and post your visa link
in this thread
alright really looking forward to see
what you come up with
and thanks for tuning in
i'll uh see you again next week take
care
bye
welcome everyone to episode three of get
it right in black and white
um i've been really looking forward to
this one because it's where we're going
to dive
into dom manipulation with javascript
all right so here's what we're going to
talk about this time
soul li wit
reproductions
in vanilla javascript
and this this thing right here
on the screen is
a soul lit
piece
what we'll cover today first i would
like to review um the exercise
submissions from last week got some
really good ones and then i'll talk
about sol lewitt this artist who's done
a lot of really amazing pieces that we
can reproduce with javascript and svg
then i'll talk about javascript basics
like javascript language features
and then i'll talk about the dom api
so we're not going to use any libraries
no d3 it's just going to be vanilla
javascript dom manipulation and to
implement some of these solar with
pieces we're going to need to use svg
masks
and perhaps svg clip path
all right so let's let's uh review these
exercises
so here's the forum post from last
week's assignment which was recreate a
pseudo-visualization from a
visualization taxonomy
i'm just going to step through these
these works here's one from nita
a pseudo
venn diagram
very nice
um
oh anita's here do you want to talk
about this at all
yeah i can talk about it um
i made this one
using figma
just basic three circles
and
from the link that current shared last
time
basic vein diagram it was
took like
not that long to make it and just
exported it using svg
so each shape here is a svg
and
yeah
that's it
thank you
very nice very nice
here's a pseudogantt chart
from
male uh forgive me if i'm not saying
that correctly but this is very nice
very beautiful i mean this is getting
into some serious uh
data vis
type stuff with the numbers and the
labels and the grid and there's a dashed
line
this is fairly impressive you know this
is amazing and and
to be able to implement this later with
d3 would be a great
uh direction for a project
wasim
made a
pseudo slope graph
very nice very nice i appreciate the
styling with the font and everything
it's very much
in the theme of get it right in black
and white and this is one of those
visualization types that we can
definitely implement
in the future
with real data with d3
andre made a pseudo spider chart
this is pretty neat
also sometimes called radar chart
where yeah i could visualize different
dimensions of the data along this
circular
grid shape here
very nice
and here's a pseudo icon array
this is pretty cool
pretty cool indeed you know and i love
the
the creative font
and and the trees here they're sort of
filled in at different levels
very nice work
by
senna
and ideal
check out this one by a deal oh my gosh
this one when i saw it i
i was so happy
this is just so gorgeous
so gorgeous
um ideally you wanna talk about this one
a little bit
uh yeah this was a really nice exercise
it's um
circle packing is
plays on these tree structure and each
circle represents
a level and also a branch so
in the case of um subcircles
will also represent uh sub-branches
and um
and it just i think it
brings out the
hierarchy uh at different levels of the
tree quite nicely and i think maybe
one improvement i could
have maybe do in the future is to
probably apply different shadings to the
different levels
uh circles just to bring that maybe uh
bring the emphasis of the uh hierarchy
out a little bit more
but yeah this was
a really nice fun exercise
and built in
the shapes were built in figma and the
text was added later inside visha
oh very nice that's a great approach
and i have to say i love how
the consecutive levels
are inverted
that's a really nice touch
really nice and i love how it's just
totally black and white
but yes if you were to add color you
could do a lot of different things with
this type of viz and this is another one
that we will definitely implement later
with d3 based on data
so i love where where this is going
uh there was some discussion about how
is this animation done it was using 3js
which is this really crazy uh
three-dimensional
library that we might touch later on
but
yeah the point here is that if you
inspect the dom
you can do some sleuthing and figure out
how these various things that you find
on the web
we're done
alenka did this really nice
pseudo joy plot
very cool very cool
and uh here's here's another one from
kirsten
this
faux data vis it's it's a
approximation of a stream graph
very nice
very nice indeed
yeah this is another one that we can
implement in the future with real data
so
great work from everyone
on these
all right now i'd like to talk about
sol lewitt uh the whole context for this
is that
um i went to this exhibition of solowit
art years and years ago and i was very
inspired
by the the art and and years later i was
thinking oh my gosh this is perfect
stuff to recreate with code because it
highlights some of the
uh the sort of foundational things that
you can do with code
this is solowit he was an american
artist
and he's done all sorts of
interesting
art pieces he had a very
sort of storied career in art
and he does these large-scale
um exhibitions in in large spaces
here's a piece by sol lewitt where it's
this giant set of shapes installed on a
wall
and as you can see it's like bands of
black and white
vertical and horizontal
with different masking patterns applied
so this is one of the pieces
that i think is really nice and this is
the one that i would like to try to
reproduce today
by writing code
and i i really look forward to it it's
going to be a lot of fun
it may be too ambitious to have the
multiple shapes done today but i was
thinking just the first one the leftmost
one here with the circle
masking pattern
i think that's what we can target
for today
before we dive in though i would just
like to take a look at a couple other
solo wit pieces here's another variation
on that theme
of different textures going in different
directions
here's another variation of the same
theme with sort of larger scale
textures
and adding color
to some of them
here's another piece that explores
colors with patterns
i don't know how to describe it really
but some of the same themes
are present in this one
here's another piece by sol lewitt
where it's interconnected lines between
randomly placed points
and by the way the the general theme
with sol lewitt is he would not
do the art himself i don't believe
um or this probably changed in different
places in his career but
the main thing with solowit is he would
give instructions
almost like algorithmic instructions to
a crew of people that would implement
his artwork based on those instructions
so it's very algorithmic to begin with
and it's it's ripe for implementing with
computer code
here's another solar with piece
that is just a grid that's expanding
very
fundamental i love it
let's dive in to trying to reproduce
this this solar with piece with code
i'm going to start
by
creating a viz
i'm going to fork from this svg
fundamentals viz
that we did
earlier i'll fork this
and call it
soul lit
reproduction
all right we've got this sort of blank
canvas here
i'm going to just adjust the readme and
say
a reproduction of a solar with art piece
and i would like to link into it
and this is a good opportunity actually
to talk about how to make links in
markdown
a very small
sidetrack thing here this is how you
make links in markdown
it's very useful so whenever you add a
description to things in your visits
it's always good idea to link to
whatever resources you're drawing from
and the way to do that is with square
brackets for the text see that becomes a
link there
and then in parentheses you put the url
where the link is going to go
and here is the actual article that i
got that image from
so i'm going to paste that url right
there
that's how you can add links in markdown
and then in index.html
i'm going to
clear out all of this stuff
in the svg
okay from here what i would like to do
is start using
javascript
and the way that we can start using
javascript is by introducing a script
tag
inside the html page
so script
not script
like that
and what this does here is it opens up a
whole world of
javascript you can put stuff in the
script tag
that is you know statements in the
javascript language
and so the most basic javascript program
uh
is called hello world and it looks like
this
console.log
hello world in quotes
and then
if you open up the chrome dev tools
by clicking on this little icon here
and then going into more tools
developer tools
by the way this is this is like
something that
you have to use pretty much all the time
when you're developing javascript so i
would recommend learning this keyboard
shortcut ctrl shift i
so inside the developer tools
we've got different tabs we've seen the
elements tab when we inspect elements
but then there's the console meaning the
javascript
console
and by the way with chrome dev
you can use this little
widget here
to move the dev tools around i believe
by default they may be on the right
so
but i personally prefer
to put them on the bottom
and within here you can change the font
size
with control plus and control minus
but anyway
when this program runs
it outputs hello world
right here
there are a bunch of things going on
here
console
is
a variable that's just uh there
in the browser
and when you say console.log you're
accessing a property in that object
called log
and it happens to be a function and that
function gets invoked with these
parentheses
and then the argument that is passed
into that function
is this string it's called a string when
you put something in quotes
that is
hello world
at this point i want to just stop and
take a brief tour of the javascript
language it's not going to be in depth
but it's just um
for for folks who've never seen
javascript before
and i
this course is for such people you don't
have to know javascript already and i
want to introduce everything that you
need along the way
so that's why i'm going to just touch
upon some javascript basics
so inside of console.log
you could put
any javascript expression for example
numbers if i hit console.log five
it prints out five
and in javascript you can comment things
out with uh two two slashes
in the beginning of the line i'm going
to
comment out
everything that we cover so that this
thing is here as a as a record of what
we've done
console.log 5 works
it just outputs a number
this highlights that you can pass
different types of things into
console.log it accepts strings it
accepts numbers
with numbers in javascript you can use
arithmetic like 5 plus 5 is 10.
that works
and there are
you know various operators 5 times 5
works as well that gives us 25.
parentheses work the way that you would
expect them to
um with math so if it's like 2 plus
3 times
that's one thing but then if you put
parentheses around
a group
that's another thing
so these are basic arithmetic operations
in javascript
there's also a fundamental concept of a
variable
in javascript
and for that um in modern times at least
we use let or const
so i'm going to say const
num equals 5
that that creates a variable that's
called number
and it sets the value of that variable
to five
and then we can say console.log num
and that references that variable and it
outputs five here
the thing with const though is that you
you're not allowed to reassign to it so
if i say num equals 10 like this
it says oh
that's not allowed
and that's why it's called const because
it's a constant it's not allowed to
change
over time
this breaks
in order for that not to break we can
use let
if we say let num equals five
we console.log num we get five
but then we can say num
equals this is called reassignment of a
variable it's changing
the value that it has over time
so if we say num equals 10
it changes the value of num and that
works because we're using let not const
and we get num
and in some older code that you may see
you might see var
and var works just the same as let
for the most part but there's some
differences about
scoping
which we can maybe get into
at another time
it's not really so critical
older format
behaves like let
and what else in javascript we have
objects objects are critical
so if we want to create an example
object we could say const obj
or
i'll call it object
and the way that you create an object is
with a pair of curly braces
and then objects can have properties
inside of them
like num for example and then the way
you set the value of properties is with
a colon
like this
and now we can say
console.log object dot
num
the dot is how you access properties
within objects so it prints out five
and that works
and while we're here i want to show you
a a thing that is a little
conceptually tricky to grok
and that is
you can assign
properties of objects even if
the object itself is stored in a const
for example
object.num we can assign that to a new
value
and it works
see it says 10 here
when we access it
and that's because we are mutating the
object we're not reassigning the
variable object
that's called object here
we are just
changing its value its internals this is
called mutating something
so that's the essence of of objects
another piece that we'll need is um
iterating over loops
because when we do this texture thing
we're going to have to make
a shape many many times
and to do that we can use what's called
a for loop
and i'm going to type this up in a
comment
so that it doesn't break because if you
run a for loop before you stop typing it
sometimes it gets into this infinite
loop situation
and so this looks like this four we put
some stuff in parenthesis and then we
put some stuff in
curly braces in the parentheses
we can set a variable
let's say i
to 0 initially
and then say
as long as i is less than
some number like five
we increment i
i plus plus
um
by the way
let me just introduce the plus plus
operator on its own
so if we say let num is five console.log
num we get five we can say num plus plus
that increments the number by one so now
we get six
it's the same as
num equals num plus one
and so now it's incremented twice so now
let's get seven
so that's the plus plus operator
increment operator
and also there's another construct this
less than
there are comparators so if we say like
4 is less than 5 that outputs true and
true and false that's another primitive
type
you can say
true
console.log false
these are booleans
so if you say console.log four is less
than 5
that says true yes it is
but then if you console.log 4 is
greater than 5
that output's false
so those are these
comparisons between numbers
that you can do in javascript
and these are
to be clear
these are expressions in the javascript
language that return a value that is a
boolean
and these can be nested with you know
parentheses and whatnot
that's the beauty of
programming languages
but anyway
now that we've got this for loop here
i'm going to uncomment it and then
inside of these curly braces
i can say
console.log i
and it outputs
these numbers
one two three zero one two three four
see it starts at zero
and that's the usefulness of a for loop
you can have one line that just does one
thing but the for loop says okay do that
one thing you know x number of times
and it gets repeated
i'm seeing there's a question in the
youtube chat
can you assign without const for example
just
stating object.num equals 10 without
first assigning the property
with const
i can maybe clarify that
so it's about this example here
maybe the question is can you just say
object.num equals 10 without defining
object first no you can't you have to
have object it has to be something
it has to exist
first
however
it does not need to have the property
inside of it
so i'm going to comment that out make
another copy
it does not need to have num defined
first
so it could just be an empty object
and then you can
you can
create a property on that object
that didn't exist before just like this
and it works yes so i i hope that
answers
your question
i hope that answers your question you
don't need to have the property
declared like when you create this
object it can be added after the fact
but the object itself needs to exist
if the object doesn't exist
you get this what's called a reference
error says like object is not defined
because it's not there's nothing called
object
so there you have it
as we talked about objects can we talk
about
other basics of javascript like
functions
yes while we're here let's do it i want
to cover each and every fundamental
concept
not in a deep level but
i do want to cover it
so
let's say we want to add two numbers
five and five
we can introduce a function
to add two numbers i think this is a
good first example of a function
so i could say const add
equals
a function
that returns a value and this is es6
es6 syntax for defining functions it can
take as input two numbers i'll call them
a and b
and it can return a plus b
so now
we can say console.log
add
five and five
and it says ten and so if we say add
five and ten
we also we get fifteen
now
this is how you would do it
with
es6 javascript syntax i want to talk
about the different um
variants that you might see
of this
so this is one way of defining add
another way of defining add you could
say function
add
and then put the parentheses right here
and then open it up into curly braces
and then say return
a this is the sort of old school way
of defining functions it's valid
javascript still today
but
as you can see this arrow
syntax is much more concise
another way of defining add
is like this you could say const add
equals function that takes as input a
and b and then open up into curly braces
see when you open up into curly braces
you can put many many different lines of
code in there and those lines of code
will run
when that function gets invoked
however you need to explicitly return
the thing
like this return
a plus b see now it says 15.
and that's
a little confusing thing about this
syntax up here
is that it uses what's called an
implicit
return
it implicitly adds this return statement
if you don't
open up the function body
with curly braces
yeah i was just curious um
what if we happen to be returning an
object
um oh that works yeah
the curly braces if we had multiple
statements and then on the last line we
are returning an object
would that be
um
oh i see yeah i think so yeah the curly
braces for the first
function would be
just just be the function body and
returning an object would
um
still be okay yeah that's fine i think
yeah i get i i understand what you're
getting at and i i would like to walk
through that so let's say for example
i'll start with the old school syntax
let's say we have a function that's
going to return a person object with a
first name and last name
if we were to construct that object
let's say i'll call it person example
this is going to be like the output that
we would like
first name is uh jane
last name
is do
that's a generic name
this is the kind of object that we would
want to
create from a function
and so then we could say person example
dot
first name
and it'll output jane
and then console.log person
example.lastname
it should output jane and do
and by the way you can console.log and
object
which we do it often
and and then you get this little
inspector for that object in the
devtools which is super duper nice
okay this is setting the stage for for
writing a function that generates
such objects
so i'll call it create person and it can
take as input first name
and last name
or for the sake of
brevity
i'll just call it person
first and last
and what we can do in here is say return
an object
and that object can have first
first being the property of the object
we can assign the property of the object
called first to the value of the
variable
that's inside this function body called
first
this is called a closure
by the way the arguments become visible
just like variables inside of this
closure that's demarcated by curly
braces so we can return an object where
first is first
last
is last
and now we can say
console.log person
and then we can pass in jane
and
do
and then we should get
this object back this is first
jane last
do
so to get at your question how does it
play out with the um
the es6 arrow syntax
it is a sort of tricky business
and let me show you what that looks like
we can refactor
or rearrange
this code to use es6 arrow functions
um
so const person equals
function that takes as input first and
last
arrow
to curly braces
and then the inside of it can remain
just the same like it was
this is one valid way to do it
and yeah no issues no confusion here
the place where it gets confusing is
when you start to leverage the implicit
return
on those
that arrow function syntax
so the way that looks is if you want to
return an object
you can't just
do it like this
as in
first name
last name
like this
because uh it gets sort of confused
about um
you know is this an object or is this a
opening up of a function body
so if you if you put a begin curly brace
directly after the arrow it's always
interpreted as
okay we're opening up the function body
now
uh so this this is not velicode it says
unexpected token
what you can do though
is use parentheses
to say okay
i am going to return the thing that is
inside these parentheses
so this version of the code works
and i think this is uh what you were
getting at
yes absolutely yes it was the uh um
thinking about how es6 syntax would uh
accommodate returning an object yeah yep
nice and this is this is it this is how
it works
as the last thing in this segment with
this function i want to highlight that
in es6
the most recent version of javascript
there is a
simplification that you can do in the
case that the property name matches the
variable name and that is you can just
get rid of
this stuff here
and it automatically
assigns
the value of the property called first
to the variable that's in scope here
called first so it's a shorthand
for defining object properties where
the property name happens to match the
variable name
so this is sort of the most concise way
of implementing this person function and
maybe it could all fit on one line
yeah it can all fit on one line
and that's like a very concise
way of doing it
all right that concludes our
um
foray into javascript
i did not touch arrays yet um i think
i'll do that later once we start using
them but this is a first
first pass at
some stuff in javascript
okay since that's what this really is
i'm going to
rename this to be
javascript basics
and then i'll fork this one
into solarwind
reproduction
okay now we can start having some fun
i'm going to delete all this stuff
i would like to
build up
the dom
for this textured background that we see
in the solar wet piece
within this piece
i'm going to first target the background
of
one of these squares
so it's going to be the background of
the leftmost
square
where we're just going to have vertical
lines going across the screen that's the
first target
now to do that i think it makes a lot of
sense to use javascript so that we can
automate the creation of those
rectangles otherwise we would be you
know creating a hundred rectangles by
hand which is just not
practical
but to get there
we need to build up this svg using
javascript
as a first thing
i would like to create this particular
svg element
using javascript
now how do we do that
well it turns out there's this thing
called document
if we say console.log document
we can see what this is
it says document
it turns out
it is the
html
document
it's it's a dom node
that you can um unpack see it has the
head it has the body
all of this stuff is available to you in
javascript
so what we can do is say
document.body
that actually gives us the body element
and on the body element is where we can
append things
using javascript
so as a first goal of something to
create using javascript let's create
this svg element
itself
the way we can create
a dom element a dom node part of the
document object model
i'm going to make a variable i'll call
it
svg
and we can use document
dot
create element
and we can give it svg which is the
tag name
for this element
and now if we say console.log svg
we see that it is in fact an empty
node
that is svg
right now though this
dom node is sort of hanging in space
it's not it's not actually attached to
the dom it's just
in memory in a variable
to put it on the page
we can use
on the body we can use a method called
append child svg
that will append this dom node to the
body
and if we inspect the elements on our
page here
now we should be able to see
that in fact there are two svg elements
now see there's the one that we created
in our
html
syntax
and there's the new one that we created
with javascript
my aim is to replace this first one with
the second one so that we can add more
stuff into it
it's going to need to have
width and height
so how do you do that
well
we can call svg.set attribute
and the first argument is the name of
the attribute
namely width
and i'll set that to
960.
and from the javascript perspective uh
you can pass in numbers and it will be
coerced to a string
so that's what i'll do because it's
conceptually a number
and then svg.set attribute
width
sorry height
svg.set attribute height
to be
500.
now if we inspect
the dom
we can see that there are two identical
svgs
look at that
so now i can delete this one that's
defined in html
and just have the one that's defined in
javascript
there it is
so this is our starting point for
javascript driven
svg
without any libraries without using d3
d3 when we do start using it is going to
do all this stuff it's d3 uses all of
these apis internally it just gives a
nice
way of interacting with these apis
all right now that we've got this svg
element
let's create
a rectangle
that goes inside
this svg element
i'm going to do that by copying this
block because it's structurally very
similar to what we want to do we want to
create a new element
let's say a rectangle
we can say document.createelement
rect
to create a rectangle rectangles also
have width and height
so i'll just set it to 100 and 100 just
so we can see something
and then
instead of appending a child to the body
we can append it to the svg
this is how you can programmatically
build up a tree
data structure
which the dom is it's a tree data
structure so svg.pencil direct should
add that rectangle
to our svg
and i noticed i'm just i have
inconsistent formatting i'm going to use
prettier
to just make everything consistent
we should be seeing a rectangle
but we're not let's see let's see if the
dom is correct
oh it's not there's the width and height
is 100 on the svg somehow
you have to change
attribute
yeah i just forgot to update it here
so rect.set attribute
should be the one
okay now if we inspect it
we can see that
it is there
all right it is there as vichy has width
and height
direct is there
but it's not showing up
the reason why it's not showing up is
because we're using create element
create element does not work
with svg you need to use create element
ns
so here's why
svg and html is a fantastic addition to
the web platform but
since svg is an xml based language see
it comes back to that concept of it is
based on xml
there is some nuance in how it can be
used
when parsing html meaning if we write
svg
and those attributes in html
svg elements are automatically created
correctly
so long as they're inside an svg block
but svg elements cannot be dynamically
created with create element in the same
way as html elements
it's
in order to dynamically create svg
elements you must explicitly tell the
browser that you want to use the svg
name space
so this is something that's particular
with xml
i must admit i don't fully understand it
but what i do understand is this is how
you need to do it
in order for it to work
so let's try this in our code
i'm just going to paste that block here
for reference it's dot create element ns
passing this namespace string
that def i think what it's doing is
saying okay this is an xml document that
uses the svg namespace meaning it's an
svg
xml document
so instead of
document.createelement we can say
document.createelementns
pass that thing and say okay this is an
svg
container element
and similarly with
the rectangle
we can use the same thing
okay
now it shows up
all right
so this is how we can create svg
elements that work
using
the dom api
now
let's get into
um
creating a bunch of rectangles to
approximate that solar width piece
this rectangle is
100 by 100 but
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a bunch of vertical
lines
with rectangles
so the the width of them could be small
let's say 10
just 10 pixels but the height of them
should be the same as the height of the
whole thing
meaning 500.
see now now it's going to go all the way
down the screen
and we can move this rectangle around by
setting
x
if i set x here to be 10
see it moves over
a little bit
if i set x to be 100 it moves
over 100
pixels now at this point i see some
duplication duplicated logic in the code
it's a very uh simple form of duplicated
logic but
instinctually i think to myself oh there
should not be duplication like that and
that is the 500
and 500.
now that we're out of html and in
javascript we can start using variables
and later functions
to eliminate duplicated logic to me
meaning uh if you have to define
something multiple times in different
places
it's preferable to just define it in one
place so that you can you know if you
need to change it you could just change
it in one place
so to do that i'm going to say
const width
equals
960 and height
is 500
and then
wherever there's 960 in use i'm going to
use width
and wherever there's 500 in use i'm
going to use height so setting the
the height of the svg and the height of
the all of these rectangles
so it's just a simple
refactoring
and at this juncture
i want to point out that
instead of hard coding these we can
actually read them from the parent page
which i always love to do because then
when somebody loads the page and it's
resized differently it'll use whatever
width and height the page actually is at
the time
and the way to do that
is
i believe
window
dot inner
width
and window
dot inner height
yeah
so window is another thing kind of like
document that's available in the browser
that you can call upon and
using inner width and inner height gets
you the
the actual
dimensions of the page when it's loaded
okay this feels right to me there's no
numbers that are hard coded i find this
beautiful
oh except for 110
but i feel like maybe those are fine for
now
all right now that we've got one
rectangle let's make
many rectangles
and
conceptually what we want to do is you
know have this code run but just change
x
every time
but rather than copy paste it a bunch of
times i'm going to put it inside of a
for loop
and i'm going to type this in comments
so that we don't run into an infinite
loop
situation
4 let i
equals zero
i is less than
n i like to use n
so that we can change it later if we
want to um initially i'll just i'll set
it to 100. let's make 100 of these
i plus plus
and by the way
in vishub if you ever do
run into an infinite loop
you can just type hash recover
at the end of the url
and
this is how you enter recovery mode
in recovery mode you can edit the code
and it's not going to automatically run
and then when you're done
fixing the code that created the
infinite loop you can just hit exit
recovery mode
but anyway hopefully that'll never
happen
so now
inside of this
for loop this is where i'm going to move
this code i'm going to cut this code
with control x and then paste it into
this block
with ctrl v and then use prettier to
update the formatting so that it's all
indented properly
and now
we can use i
to to move things around
see i starts at zero
and then
uh the second time around i is one and
then the next time around i is two and
so on and so on until it gets to be
in which case
oh this still runs for the 99th time but
when i gets to be 100 this check fails
because 100 is not less than 100 and
then the for loop exits
so our values of i are going to be from
0 to 99.
so
the thing that we want to vary is x
if we just set x to be i
it's going to
go across the screen but it's only going
to move one pixel at a time
right so
if we wanted to move let's say 20 pixels
at a time i can multiply i times 20
and we get it there it is
there it is
i see there's a question in the youtube
chat
um for properties on the window object
you actually don't have to write
window.inner width just inner width
should be enough for the browser to get
it
yes
yes that's true that is true window is
an alias for the global object
so you can actually say
inner height and inner width just like
that
and it works just the same
it's true yeah thanks for that thanks
for that however
if you use a bundler or a build tool
something like that
it will complain and say inner width is
not defined
so that's why i just sort of
by default i do like to explicitly say
window
because those tools
well we're not using them now so it
doesn't matter but if you are using a
tool that sort of checks or eslint for
example that checks the validity of the
code it often would complain that okay
these variables are not defined anywhere
so that's an error
but it those tools do understand that
document and window
are
things that are provided by the browser
and are expected to be in the global
namespace so
yeah that's why you may need to use
window
and i see there's another comment you do
need window prefix for esm
esm
oh modules ecmascript modules
so i don't know i'll just um
i think i'll keep it here for now but
i'll just add a little comment that says
windows optional sometimes
but yeah it's a great little sign
discussion thanks for that
any other questions in the meantime
yes i think uh i have one question um
i'm curious about the const
inside of the loop um it looks like it's
being reassigned but it's
it's not um
and i'm curious as to
how that works
yeah that is a great great question
it looks as though const is reassigned
here
but
in in fact it's not
that's because
const and let are block
scoped
not closure scoped the way that var is
so what that means is
the block
that gets opened up with these curly
braces and this for loop
defines the scope of that wrecked
variable
let me give a concrete example here if i
say
console.log rect
out here
it says reference error
rect is not defined
and that's because we use const
and it's block scoped that means that
that variable does not exist
outside of that for loop
and so essentially every time that for
loop runs with an another version of i
that const
is
re-created in a brand new
block scope
and so that's what makes it so that cons
like this rec it's never actually
reassigned
the whole variable is recreated again
and again
each time
the for loop runs through one of its
loops
however
if we were to use var
here
check this out
then
this console.log rect actually succeeds
it actually prints out this dom element
here
why is that
well it's because when you use var
it's actually scoped relative to the
closure that you're in so right now
we're in the global
closure because we're not inside of any
function definition but if we were
inside of a function definition the
curly braces of that function would
define the closure meaning the scope of
that variable
and this is actually the core difference
between var
and the new constructs of let and const
let is also block scoped
so this is actually the
the difference
the fundamental difference between var
and let var is closure scoped but let
see if i use let here
it's block scoped meaning it's scoped
within the for loop that's why we get
this reference error
when we try to access it here
so yeah that's that's a rundown of
scoping with var versus let and const
i'll switch it back to const because um
it's it's generally i i think
and this is a personal preference thing
it's generally good practice to use
const to default to using const un until
you have the need to reassign it and
then you can use let it just makes it
easier to read the code later on for
your future self or for anybody else
reading the code
someone says
let would still be nicer there
but i respectfully disagree i mean you
could use let i see actually a lot of
developers use let by default
but um
i would argue
strongly
that
it's best practice to use
const
because
when the reader of the code in the
future sees that it's it's clear okay
this is not going to be reassigned it
makes it easier to reason about the code
when i see let when i read somebody
else's code i immediately look for where
it's going to be reassigned like oh
that's like something confusing i have
to think about it could be reassigned to
value where is that reassignment that's
where i immediately would go
so that's why i would strongly argue
that um
just use cost by default and if it turns
out that you need to reassign it then
yeah change it to let change it to let
but only if you need it that's just my
my personal take on all this
all right so i would like to actually
reproduce that solarwind piece
we've got this as one of the directions
of the solar with piece
now i would like to change it around so
that the texture goes the other way that
way we have our two ingredients that we
will eventually put together with this
clipping path thing
to do that i'm going to fork this vis
and i'm going to call it solo it
reproduction
vertical
it's just going to be a vertical variant
and how do we make it a vertical variant
um it's just changing around this stuff
here this logic here
instead of x varying with
i
we can very um y
with i so y
now can be i times 20
and instead of width being 10 height can
be 10
and width can be the value of the width
variable
okay
that's it
now we've got our vertical and our
horizontal
and now what we can do
is we can use an svg mask
the idea with an svg mask
is it defines an alpha mask for
compositing
things
so what we can do is say mask
give it an id
and this mask is going to be
the circle in the solar whip piece
see how this circle in the middle masks
the textures
that's exactly what we're going to do
here so we're going to have
a black background and a white circle
for one of the textures and then a white
background and a black circle for the
other of the textures to invert the mask
and this is how we can implement this
piece
so it looks generally something like
this we create a mask element inside the
svg and give it an id let's do that
and since we're in this world of
uh javascript generated stuff
we need to
use this api which gets cumbersome
pretty fast
so what i'm going to do is copy that
block of the rect and i'm going to
change this to mask
document.createelement and s mask i'm
going to set the id
attribute to
something arbitrary i'll just call it my
or i'll call it um
circle mask
circle dash mask
we don't need anything else
and then we say svg.append
child
mask
and that has to set the attribute on the
mask and we append the mask as a child
okay now that we've got that mask we can
we can create a circle within that mask
so i'm going to copy this block again
and i'm going to say
circle
is document.createelementns
and then on that circle we can set the
attribute of cx and cy to be the middle
so cx would be width divided by 2
to put it in the middle
cy
would be similarly
height divided by two
and then we want to append the circle
to the mask
it has to be a child of the mask
now
that we have this
we can set the mask
of
these rectangles
to be that circle mask
and let me just consult the
documentation again
so on any shape you can say mask equals
url parentheses hash
the id of the mask and it's kind of a
quirky way of
doing it but you know
that's just what it takes
to make it work
so i'm going to copy i'm going to paste
that reference
and then on these rectangles
we can implement that by saying rect.set
attribute
mask
and the value of that attribute is going
to be
url
hash
and then the id of our mask which is
circle dash mask
and i think that should work
it did not work oh because
we need to set the fill of the circle i
believe
so let's set the fill
attribute of the circle to be white
i think this is how these masks work
no
uh black
we don't have vertical
rectangles at all
yeah i know we're not seeing them
because i'm sending the mask
if i remove the mask then we do see them
the question is why is the mask not
working oh
oh i believe
i didn't set the radius of the circle
silly me
so r of the circle can be
say 200
and we may need that fill
after all
okay so we need cx cy and r
i'll just try a value of 200 for r
and let me try setting the fill to be
white
ah there it is
there it is
got there
so now the next challenge uh would be to
invert
this mask
for the other texture
the way that we can invert the mask
is by setting the fill
of the circle
to be black
and then we put a white
background rectangle within the same
mask because the way the masks work is
black becomes
you can't see it and white becomes you
can see it
i'll follow the same pattern as we have
for the circle but with the rect
i'll call it mask
rect
so that it doesn't conflict with the
other rect
not maybe it wouldn't anyway
but
anyway i'll call it mass correct
and the tag name will be wrecked
and on the mask rect we can set
width and height
just to be width and height because i
wanted to fill up the background that's
the point of this is to just fill up the
background
and then mask dot append child mask
erect
and i would have thought
that would work um oh i have to set the
fill
to be white
boom all right see that
we've got the
inverse
and now that we have all of the pieces
let's put them together
to create our
solar with
reproduction
what we need to do
is have the rectangles that go in both
directions present at the same time
right and so i can use
vishhub to look back at
what i've just created
so we've got these horizontal lines oh
and let me consult the direction so the
background
should be vertical
and the foreground should be horizontal
so um in this one we have the vertical
lines
we we should really invert this
mask
because yeah the foreground should be
the vertical ones according to the
actual piece
and then let's bring back the um
let's bring back these lines that go in
this direction
i'm just going to copy this block from
here
into here
as another
for loop that runs
n should be really only defined once
and check that out
that's kind of a cool
intermediate state by itself
i think i'll fork from that
and at this point
what we need to do
is create another mask
that is the inverse
of the mask that we already have
so i'm going to just take all this stuff
that defines the mask
and i'm going to paste it
and rename this to be mask 2
and i'll call it circle mask
not very creative
i'll just put 2 at the end of all these
variables
all right so now we we have that mask 2
with direct and the circle
we can invert these colors of the mask
so i'll change black to white
change white to black
and
for
these
um
vertical rectangles
we can use the mask
of the circle mask
2. so instead of circle mask it should
be circle mask dash two
and boom we have done it
there we have our solar with
reproduction
awesome awesome
yeah this is so satisfying
i'd like to leave you all with an
exercise to do
between uh now and next week
reproduce any solute piece
ideally using the javascript dom
manipulation that we've done today
and these are actually three different
options for an exercise i want it to be
open-ended
so instead of reproducing a particular
solar with piece you can create art you
know just create generative algorithmic
art
in the spirit of soul the wit
very open-ended you know you can be very
creative
creative or
add animation to what we created today
like i was thinking maybe the textures
could be rotating or or the circle could
change size
or something like that
so these are your three options
in terms of the exercise for this week
i have updated the forum index to create
uh to have an episode three link
so when you uh submit your piece please
just submit it
as a response to this thread
and i'll go over it uh i'll review it
next next time
all right questions anyone
i have a question sure sure
what is functional programming and
objective programming
functional programming
versus um
perhaps what you're thinking of is
object oriented programming
that's a great question uh it's it's
very like abstract and philosophical
in a sense
um
but i'll give you a brief take you know
my brief
take on that
functional programming
generally makes heavy use of functions
and in particular passing functions to
other functions
javascript is actually
a functional language it's been called
lisp in see's clothing and i love that i
think that was who said that
i don't remember his name
but yeah javascript is lisp
a famous functional language nc's
clothing and c is a procedural language
and c plus plus and java
are object oriented
languages meaning
the central construct in those languages
is
a class
and then you can have instances of the
class that are called objects
um and so in in the language java for
example an object is an instance of a
class
it's fundamentally different than in
javascript an object in javascript is is
a set of key value pairs
that's often called a
you know hash table
in other languages
and then
there's another language called haskell
on the extreme side of functional
programming
in haskell
there is no mutation there is no such
thing as let and there's no such thing
as reassigning
a value to an object so you have to
create new objects all the time in
haskell it's what's called a pure
functional language so if you want to
learn really really learn about
functional programming
i would suggest to learn about haskell
it's fantastic
but yeah practically speaking we are in
the world of
um
functional programming with
javascript
although it is a mix i mean in es6 there
is there is a class construct and you
can do
object-oriented programming in
javascript
i personally have sort of moved away
from that i don't use classes very much
i just use you know objects that have
key value pairs that are expected to be
a certain thing
um
and then
there's the idea of typescript and type
safety
which you don't have in vanilla
javascript but typescript is great if
you want to be sure that there's no um
bugs
regarding you know objects not having
the things you expect them to
so that's my brief take on functional
versus object-oriented programming i see
there are some
yeah go ahead
what we see here
in this one
exercise we did just now it's functional
programming
mostly
right
i mean is it functional programming is
it object oriented programming
it's um
it's almost like at a at too high of a
level of genericness to even say to even
make a call
i mean the dom api is object oriented
in a sense that you know you're you're
invoking these functions to create
objects that are instances of a class
namely the class called dom node
i believe it is uh
yeah so in this api that we're using
it's an interface
it's an abstract
base class
and all of this terminology reeks of
object-oriented programming it's like
yeah this is definitely object-oriented
programming they're having a base class
and in object-oriented programming you
have classes that inherit from other
classes
and you have this whole hierarchy of
stuff
so we are using
an object oriented api to the dom
so in that sense it is very much object
oriented
however we're not
you know we didn't create any classes of
our own
so in that sense
it's not
object-oriented um and we're also not
using
any functions except for the methods
on these
instances of the classes
so when you when a function is
positioned
as a property of an object
it's often called a method
so these are methods on these objects
which is also from the object-oriented
realm
you know instances of classes have
methods that's just how object-oriented
programming works so if you were to you
know broadly say is this code that we
wrote today object oriented or
functional it's more object oriented
honestly we're not using any functions
really
and even this this way of doing
iteration is very procedural
if we wanted to do it in in a functional
programming kind of way
we would use some other constructs and
we'll do that later
by the way i'm thinking next week we we
refactor this whole thing to use d3 and
functional programming
and abstract away duplicated logic with
functions
just to see how
things get really
tight and concise when you do really
embrace functional programming
and thanks somebody in the youtube chat
said um
lisp and sees clothing is from douglas
crockford yeah yeah yeah
douglas crockford he's he's got some
really good stuff
really good
really good written pieces about
javascript
oh someone asked
could i do this using visual studio code
yes yes of course i mean it's just a
text file here
so invis hub by the way
you can export the thing
and you get a zip file
you can extract this somewhere and then
just open up index.html
in visual studio code
and
you know everything will just work
the same way that it's working here
except that you'll have to open up
the file in a browser and
every time you make a change you can
have to save the file and then go and
refresh the browser
unless you get deeper into the tooling
of having something that automatically
refreshes like a webpack development
environment yeah all this stuff i'm i'm
doing here is just purely uh html
standard
standard html and javascript and svg and
it's it's not in any way dependent on
the fact that i'm in vishub this hub is
i'm just using as a teaching tool so
that i can give you references to these
code files
but yeah you could totally do all this
with visual studio code
and as we get deeper into javascript
i think i'll get deeper into um showing
how to work outside of his hub
using different build tools
yeah great question
oh yeah there's a discussion in the
youtube chat about um
classes in javascript is actually
syntactic sugar for appending stuff to
the prototype
it's very true it's very true but that's
like that's a whole other rabbit hole
there's like uh
when you create objects
in javascript you can actually create
them to inherit from a prototype
which is it's just a whole can of worms
that i just would rather not get into
because we're not going to need those
constructs
another comment in the chat is
you could have wrapped all this stuff in
view.js
yeah it's true it's true i mean this is
a very crude
way of doing dom manipulation but i
wanted to explicitly use the dom apis
just so you see what it is in its bare
form you could wrap all this stuff in d3
do it in react do it in angular do it in
view
anything but the resulting dom is going
to be the same and that's really what
matters in terms of what you get
uh what you see on the screen
all right i think i'll wrap for today
this has been a really good session and
um yeah i'm really super excited to see
what you all come up with
feel free to fork this or start from
scratch um
you know be creative add gradients or
whatever
add animations and
all right really looking forward to next
week
thanks everyone for joining
see you in a week
bye
all right welcome to episode 4 of get it
right in black and white today what
we're going to do
is
use d3
to reproduce this solar with piece
in its
fullness
with different shapes what we'll cover
includes uh
a review of exercise submissions from
last week
and then we're gonna start using d3
selections and data joins we're gonna
take what we did last week and refactor
it you know move the code around change
it so that it does the same thing but
uses d3
and then we'll look at d3 symbols d3
actually provides these nice shapes
that we can use
uh and
along the way to reproducing that solar
whit piece we're going to talk about svg
group elements
translating group elements meaning
moving them around
and we'll touch upon d3
point scales and potentially band scales
depending on how far we get
all right so this is the solar with
piece
that we're aiming to reproduce
and today what i'm hoping to do
is get to the point where we have
multiple different shapes
in this mask
and
if we get to that point and still have
time i want to tackle the problem of the
background being different for each of
these
um i think the first pass would be you
know the background is all
uh vertical lines and this the filled in
shapes are all horizontal lines that
would be the first phase that we're
going to shoot for so phase two
um would be to make it so that each
square here has
has the um
the horizontal lines in the background
and the vertical lines in the foreground
alternating with the vertical lines in
the background and the horizontal lines
in the foreground
so
i don't know i hope it's not too
ambitious um
let's give it a shot
all right here's the forum post from
last week
let's see what we've got um
felipe mayo he's been following and i'm
very impressed by this work um this is
actually a game
check this out
uh he is my face
with
you know
this solo wit-esque
kind of a thing going on
pretty wild
and it changes over time
i'm just blown away by this very nice
very nice work
yeah and i think he actually made this
into a full-blown
game
although i can't find it right now
and look he made this one earlier oh
this is so good look at that
incredible
really incredible
so here's another one
from
w gloss
this is pretty neat there's some
randomness here
very cool very cool
yeah
vanilla
javascript and dom api
here's one from nita
check this out whoa what
that's
crazy oh my gosh nita you want to talk
about this a little bit
yes i can
can i see the code
so i added
animations
and
fast
that's very cool
but how is how are they all going
could you mute
yourself
now how
how is it that each of these are are not
going all at the same time it seems like
it's
the duration of this animate is
is a random number
that's really cool
really cool so that's how that effect
happens
very nice
and
whoa look at this one
very nice
it almost looks like three-dimensional
uh balls or something
wow
very cool very cool
let's see oh here it is he posted again
this is the game version
so i was i was quite impressed by this
check this out you have to you have to
you have
this is so funny
you have to
click
when it's black and white
so that's i just got one point and if
you click when it's not black and white
okay i clicked on a
black and white again but if you click
when it's color
you lose a life
see that
one less little icon there
so this is just
through the roof
really great job
really creative
very nice work
here's another one from nita
a bunch of circles
wow
beautiful beautiful grid of circles
very nice
do you want to talk about this one at
all
yeah i would like to talk about it
so what i did here uh
we are actually
positioning each circle
in x and y direction
so we are using
i and j
twice
so we can get the kind of matrix values
in the matrix i and j for each
cell there
something like that let's say it is
going in the x direction and y
directions at the same time
beautiful
you are getting the whole grid gets
filled up depending on how many numbers
circle we are using
and you can add animation and
other things on top of it and i did it
in another example i kept forking it
again and again it was just fun
awesome awesome
thank you
yeah this is great so it's a nested for
loop where i goes from zero to count j
goes from zero to count
and for each combination of i and j
the circle is positioned
very nice it's very nice
and it's pretty close to this other
solar with piece
so that could be the next
phase perhaps
all right that's it
that's all the work
very cool
all right here we go here's our piece
that we made last time
i'm going to start by forking this
and i'll call it
solar with reproduction with
d3
all right
open the editor
the first order of business
that i want to do here is
include
d3
into our
app
here
one way to do that would be to add a
script tag
to the head
and put the source equal to
something
usually from a cdn like unpackage a cdn
is a content distribution network that
essentially hosts files
on the web that you can pull in
however
in modern
web development usually you use a
a node js based build system
like using webpack or rollup
or using some starter app
system framework thing
and there's a relatively new feature of
this hub that lets you approximate
package.json
which i'm very excited to start using
so let's let's do that i'm going to make
a new file
called package.json
package.json by the way it's like a
it's a standard in a way
npm and the node
npm stands for node package manager it's
a whole ecosystem
of javascript libraries
and so npm expects this thing called
package.json
and you can put a bunch of stuff in here
like set the license
and
you know add dependencies
dependencies is
what matters for us
so it's you specify this object that has
dependencies and then the library name
and the version
we can use this to pull in d3 to our
program
in package.json
i'm going to make it an object
in in json format javascript object
notation format json
and the key
will be
oh there's some something
strange happening
all right so we can type dependencies
as the key and the object can contain
d3
at some specific version
and um
let me check which version d3 is at
the way i like to check that is to go to
which is a cdn that hosts script files
and just type d3
and it will automatically fill in the
latest version so we're at version
6.6.1
so in here d3 version will be 6.6.1
all right that's like a bare minimum
package.json
and then
what we can do is introduce a
a script
file where our javascript can go and
just by convention i'm going to call it
index.js
and what we can do is take all of this
javascript
that was in this script tag directly on
the page
and move it over to
index.js
and everything still runs
now i can delete that script tag over
here
and we have this sort of new setup
in which we can import
from d3
so here we go let's pull in
something from d3
i'm going to say import selection
from
d3
this is es6
module
syntax
to import from packages and this syntax
you can use again with all the modern um
templates
and whatnot
and so let's see if this worked
console.log selection
i just want to see
did it get defined as anything
in the dev tools we can say that indeed
it's a function
array it's a function from d3
it's got these weird uh characters
because it comes from a minified
file
the the d3 build
but anyway this means that now we can
start using d3
so let me talk about selection
if you google d3 selection and click the
first result
it's the documentation page for this
package called d3-selection
and
d3
by the way is structured as a collection
of many smaller packages
that are all composed into this one
monolithic library called
d3
and so if you see in in
d3 itself it just
it exports things from all of these
d3 packages which you could use on their
own but for convenience sake i'm just
going to pull in the whole d3 build
which contains all of this stuff
but anyway d3 selection is one of these
things
and i'm gonna pull in uh from there
and feel free to stop me at any time
with questions
by the way
yeah i haven't really introduced um
d3 itself let me stop and do that
since this is this first time that we're
pulling in
d3
i thought i would take a moment to
discuss d3 and why we'd want to use it
overall just some broad context for this
d3 stands for data driven documents
it
refers to documents as in
the dot the html document object model
d3 has utilities for dom manipulation
which we did last time with the vanilla
um javascript api for dom manipulation
which was quite verbose
a lot of that stuff can be changed such
that it uses d3 for dom manipulation and
the code will shrink down it'll be a lot
simpler to read and use
in addition to daw manipulation d3 has
all sorts of utilities
for building data visualizations
so
that's why
it has become sort of the de facto
standard for building visualizations on
the web
today
the whole rest of this series is going
to be diving into using d3
to make all these different types of
visualizations but as a starting point
i wanted to introduce d3 in a way that's
disconnected from data and all the
complexities that comes along with data
in this solar with exercise here
d3 selection
is the package within
the set of d3 packages that does dom
manipulation
here are some examples of how to use it
um
and and i'll go you know we'll craft
these ourselves but for reference this
page is the canonical
documentation
for d3 selections
all right now that we've imported
selection from d3
we can start to use it to replace this
code that we had from last time
so here's what i'm going to do i'm going
to comment out
everything
and then re-implement it
with d3
one block at a time
the first block to consider
is the one that
sets up the svg element
i'm going to comment this out as well
and replace it with some d3 based stuff
select
body
is what we need to do to get
a d3 selection of the body element
and now that i think of it um
we really need to import select from d3
not selection
so we've got select from d3 we select
the body
and a d3 selection instance is this sort
of complicated thing that we'll be
learning more about
but it has this
this pattern of using it called method
chaining where
once you invoke something and you get a
d3 selection back
that
thing that gets returned by this
function has a bunch of methods on it
one of which is
append
and you can pass into append
the tag name like svg
and that returns the selection of the
svg element that was appended to the
body
so this this one line here
does the exact same thing as
this line
and
it creates a new svg element and appends
it to the body
to set these attributes on this
well first of all let me save this as a
variable
i'll call it svg
once we've got that we can say svg.attr
which is short for
attribute
internally this actually invokes set
and the signature is compatible
with
the vanilla
dom api method set attribute so i can
just paste this stuff here we set the
attribute of width to be the value of
the variable width
and same thing for height
the height attribute gets the value of
the height variable
now we can inspect the dom to see if it
worked
sure enough there it is there's an svg
element
with width 960 and height 500
any questions at this point
all right so this is one way to set up
the svg element
due to this method chaining thing
you can actually combine these together
into one big statement
so instead of having multiple different
statements
it could be one giant statement where we
chain
these things together so we append this
the svg
and then on the selection of the svg we
set the width and height
all right so we've got our svg setup
the thing that i wanted to do next
was
add the
the rectangles that are in the
background that would be a good next
thing to add
yeah this block here where it's a for
loop that adds a bunch of rectangles
let's do this with d3
so i'll bring that up here
the way we would do this
in d3 is
we need to have an array
to work with
and then once we have an array we can
use the d3 data join
concept
so
here's what we can do i'm going to use
this code as a template to build up an
array of objects where each object
represents
the attributes of a single rectangle
so i'll paste that
uncomment it
and then
i can initialize an array
i'll call it marks
because it represents the visual marks
that are going to appear on the page
i'll initialize it like this to an empty
array
and then
in the body of this for loop
instead of creating dom elements
i'm just going to push
objects onto this array meaning you know
append them to the array add new entries
to this list of things
by using the push method
so we can say marks.push
and pass in an object literal
and on this object literal i can build
up all the things that it needs to know
to render a rectangle
so y for example could be set to
i times 20
width could be set to width
height
could be set to 10.
i'm just copying from what's there
and the mask
can be set to
this string here
that's how we can build up an array of
objects that describe
the rectangles this is not using d3 at
all this is just pure javascript and
just to see that it worked
let me console.log
marks
sure enough we get this array
and we can see
it's got a bunch of objects
where the only thing that really varies
is
y
all right so far so good
you have a question
yes so
we are doing this because dt requires
right
yeah yeah that's right
um
you know your audio is really bad i
don't know what it is but
maybe grab a camera or something
the reason why we're setting up this
array
is because d3 expects an array to work
with to use this data join feature of d3
which we're going to use right now
i'm going to refer to this svg
selection
from earlier to
add rectangles inside of it
and to use this pattern of d3
data joins we can take a d3 selection
and say you know that selection dot
select all
uh rect
this makes a selection of all rectangles
that are on the page already
and
at the point that where this code runs
there are none
but the fact that there are none is
useful information to d3
because it knows that okay the set of
dom elements on the page
it doesn't contain what it needs to
therefore i have to add it
so once we've said select all we can say
dot data
marks
this produces a d3
data join that has a bunch of methods on
it um
one method which was added fairly
recently
uh in d3
is dot join
it's a simplified api to
um the other stuff that was in use
before like uh
and dot enter
uh dot merge
sort of stuff
and we'll you know we'll get deeper
deeper into this but
this is the simplified api that we can
use for our case
so what it's going to do here is create
one rectangle
for each of these marks
and then
on this
selection that contains all these
newly minted rectangles we can set some
attributes
we can set the attribute of
i'm looking at this object here we want
to set all four of these attributes
we can set the y attribute to be
well what we want to set it to is the y
value from the corresponding object that
was constructed over here
to do that we can accept
a function
as input
to the second argument to attr
and that function
can take as input d
which is the datum
uh it's just a convention to use d to
represent the datum like one row of the
data or you know one entry in the data
array
and that can return
d dot
y because we've set it up here
so when we access d dot y it's going to
access the y value
that we set up over there
and we can do a similar thing for
all the other
attributes that we need
width
we can set it to d dot width
height
we can set it to d dot height
and mask
we can set to d dot mask
and that that's not doing anything now
because i commented out the actual masks
and as you can see it worked we've got
our rectangles back
this is how you can use d3
to
create a bunch of rectangles on the
screen
now
this duplication
between here and here
is not ideal but
i kind of like this way of doing things
in a sense because it decouples
the computation of the marks from the
rendering
of the marks
this here it just
creates an array of objects that we can
directly pass in to all this d3 logic
over here
and i like this setup because if in the
future you ever wanted to change what
you were using
for doing the dom manipulation
you could
and this part wouldn't have to change at
all the only thing that would have to
change is this like if you wanted to
render it using
react
or view for example these other dom
manipulation
frameworks
but this is not often what you see
so
often what you see is it's all combined
into one big block
and in a sense that's more efficient
because there's no need actually to
create all these strings if they're all
the same
and then refer to it here you know we
could just pass in
uh the value right here
so what i'll do i just want to show you
how that looks
so i'm going to
comment out this
so it's there as a reference in the
future
and then refactor this to use the more
common pattern that you find with d3
which is
to um
to compute all the values in these
accessor functions
so
instead of doing all this stuff here
i'll do it down here
and if we're doing it like that we don't
actually need all this logic to build up
the array we can use a utility from d3
called range
which creates an array
range of say five it creates an array
that has five integers in it that start
at zero and to use this we need to
import
range
from d3 along with select
now that we've done console.log range of
five you can see that it did output here
that array that just contains some
numbers
so this is the data array that i'm going
to use now as the input
instead of saying data marks i'm going
to say data
range of 5
but we did have this variable called n
which is the number of rectangles so i'm
going to use that
instead
now in here instead of accessing the
properties that were on those objects
we can compute those values
on the fly
um
d is the number
in this case so i'm just going to say d
times 20. it can take the place of i
and for these other ones i'm just going
to return
width
and
10 for height
and then this string of the circle mask
right here
and since these are returning the same
values for each rectangle these don't
actually need to be functions
we could just pass in the value directly
like this
this highlights an important aspect of
this dot attr method
that it accepts either
constant values like this
or
functions and when it when it accepts a
function
it passes in
the
object from the array into that function
and then whatever that function returns
it's going to use as the value for that
attribute
all right so we've got this far let's
keep going
in our refactoring of this code here
what does this block do it creates a
mask and it sets the id to be circle
mask
and it depends it to the svg
we can do the same with d3 by saying svg
dot append
mask
and we want to set the id
attribute
to be
circle mask
all right that should do the same thing
as this block of code over here
i don't know why it's not showing up our
rectangles though
oh oh yes because now that mask exists
but it doesn't contain anything yet
it doesn't contain those the circle or
anything
so that's our next step
the next block of code adds that
background rectangle of the mask
let's do that now with d3
that would look like a mask dot append
although we don't have mask
yet
um
i'll just define that here to be that
d3 selection of that mask element so now
we could say mask dot append
wrecked
this one statement does the same thing
as
this statement here which creates the
rectang element
and also appends it
to the mask
parent
now we can set the attributes
width
height
and
fill
and if i change this to white
it should show up all of our rectangles
and it does
okay but black means hide the rectangles
this next block
does the same thing but for a circle
so i'm going to copy
that logic for the rectangle and change
it to be for a circle
instead where we set the cy
attribute
we set the cx
and we set the radius
attribute
and finally we set the fill
attribute of that circle
all right and the mask is working again
fantastic
now
let's do the same for
mask 2
now remember mask 2
was
all the same stuff as mask one except
just the colors
were inverted
so
we can copy
uh this whole block
of stuff
mask 2
oops
is a new mask that has the id circle
mask dash 2.
and then we append a rectangle
to mask 2
and instead of it being black it should
be white
and then
we append the circle
to mask 2 down here
and the fill of that should be black
instead of white
okay
that seems to be working
although
i forgot to change it to mask 2
so i'll change that now mask 2 dot
append mask 2
dot append
all right and lastly we have our
rectangles
which i'll bring up to the top near the
other rectangles
just so all the rectangle stuff is in
one spot
so i'll paste that here and it's almost
exactly the same as this block of code
that we did
for the first set of rectangles
the only difference
is that
x
gets set to
i times 20 so i'll just change this y
here to x
width
gets 10
height gets the value of the height
variable and the mask
is circle mask dash two
okay
um
see this breakage
this is not what we expect
see that
so does anyone have
any idea what's going on here
see what appears to be happening here
is that
this first chunk of code
that made these rectangles
it set up all of these rectangles uh
properly
but
this line this next block of code that
deals with rectangles
it actually selected all of the
rectangles that were there
from the first block of code
and then it set
um
the x value
of that and it set the height value
um
so it's just sort of a mess
where our two different blocks of code
are you know impacting the same set of
rectangles which we don't want
so how can we how can we make it so that
these two different blocks
um
act on different
rectangles
well there's a couple of approaches one
approach is we could use classes to
differentiate them
and another approach is we could use
group elements
to contain them
let me show you how both of those would
play out
if we want to use classes
we can set the class attribute
to be
something like
maybe horizontal
and then when we say select all we can
say
rect.horizon
to only pick up on those horizontal ones
and it's still broken because we haven't
done
the same treatment for the other set
but we could say class is vertical
over here and then we select on
the vertical rectangles only
this is one way of doing it
i'm going to fork at this point
just to have a reference of that state
of things
okay so this is one way of doing it
using classes
another way
i'm just going to put it back to the way
it was
another way of solving this problem is
to use group elements where you could
say
svg.append
g
first
and that way
it would only be working within this
newly appended group element
and an svg group element is
it's a very um
useful
element it it just groups its children
together
in the dom tree
and let me do the same for the other set
okay now you can see it's it's not
broken anymore
and if we inspect the dom
we can see that
there's one group element that contains
the set of rectangles going from top to
bottom
and then there's an entirely other group
element
that contains the rectangles going from
left to right
yeah and the reason why this works is
because the selection for the rectangles
only acts within each of these different
group elements so that's another way to
to solve that breakage
okay
very good
this feels like a milestone
from here i'm going to fork this and try
to
reproduce
that
the full
the full set with the different shapes
any questions at this point
yeah just a couple uh um
the attributes
uh the attr
um
just so to get it straight in my head
those the second arguments to the attr
methods
those effectively s
take
match a data point
in the um your array and
[Music]
put it on the screen basically that they
they attach some kind of pixel
point
to that data point is is that the right
way of thinking about these
um
these these arguments that are passed to
attr
yes
yes that's correct
that's exactly right so whatever we pass
into dot data
should be an array
and
the dot attr
applies to all of the
dom elements in that selection
and so after we call dot join
um the first time this runs
i mean it's not running multiple times
but when it runs
it's going to create a bunch of
rectangles
and then
for each element of that array it's
going to pass that element as the
argument to this function that we've
passed in
and so the responsibility of this
function
is to map
that entry
in that array whatever it may be
whatever shape it may be
onto
whatever is expected for the x
coordinate in this case or in general
the you know the attribute value of the
dom element
and so yeah it's a mapping function that
essentially transforms the thing
from data space
whatever that may be
into
i like to think of it as screen space
in this case the x-coordinate so literal
position on the screen uh but it could
also be
a color or
you know width and height like these
cases here
but yes yes that's exactly what it's
doing
thank you yeah that makes sense
and the
earlier chunk where
it talks about
yeah append
g
um
and select all and data
are these so just so my mental model is
correct
um or as close to correct as possible
it's
recrea it's creating a brand new
selection
um
at that early stage and
what the attr's are doing are
modifying that selection is is that is
that the way to
think about it
correct
yeah some of these lines
create a new selection
and others of these lines
modify
an existing selection
there was uh in the past i mean it still
is there was a convention around
indentation
relating to this point
and that convention
was
any line that creates a new selection be
indented
one level
and then any line that modifies
the exist the other you know modifies
the selection that was defined on the
line above
uh should be indented by
two spaces
however that's sort of fallen out of
fashion because everybody's using
prettier nowadays but it's a nice touch
and just to to really make it clear let
me walk through each and every line
of this
svg.append g
creates
a new
group element a dom element you know
internally it invokes exactly this code
of um you know document.createelementns
with the svg namespace
and
it takes that that dom node that was
constructed and associates it with this
new newly minted d3 selection that
didn't exist before
and it creates a brand new selection
so the return value from svg.append g
is a selection that just contains that
one group element
when you say
dot select all
rect
this creates yet another d3 selection
that happens to be
empty
um
it's it's an empty selection
that would contain wrecked elements if
there were wrecked elements there but
there's not
um
this information
the fact that it's empty is very useful
to
the internals of the dot data
method
which
associates an array
to that selection
and at a certain point selections were
made immutable
which is a really nice feature of
selection selections are immutable
so the dot data call creates a new
selection where that empty selection of
no rectangles is associated with
this data
all right and then when you say dot join
rect
this is actually a short form
of
another pattern
which i'm not sure i totally want to get
into but uh essentially it's dot enter
dot append
wrecked
and so the enter selection
handles the case where there's no dom
element on the page corresponding to a
given data element
and so for each of those cases it will
append a new rectangle
so that's
this this dot join is a short form for
that in this particular case
and then all of these lines that use dot
attr
they
they don't actually mutate the
the anything in javascript like the so
the d3 selection of these rectangles
is immutable however
what it does when this line runs it goes
through each and every dom element and
it mutates the dom element it sets the y
attribute to be the return value of you
know whatever the value is returned
from this function
and same thing with all these others it
goes through and updates
the dom elements
based on the return values so i hope
that clarifies the
the role of the different pieces
definitely thank you very much my
pleasure
i see there's some questions
in the youtube chat did join us to be
enter rect well no it used to be
dot enter dot append wrecked and join it
actually
does something with merge
but we we'll get to that later
um
another question from the youtube chat
since mask
height and width are the same can you
bind them
to a parent g element
that's interesting
so the mask
width and height are applied to the
the rectangle within the mask not the
mask element itself
therefore
um
no i don't think you can do that i don't
think you can do that
okay here we go
let's
um
let's fork this one
and i'll call it
full
solar with reproduction
with d3
the first thing i'm going to do here is
just delete all this junk that is left
over
from
earlier
deleting all these blocks that are
commented out
all right now we're left with this
program that is
62 lines of code
what we can do next is
change this mask to be a shape
and d3 actually provides a set of
symbols that we can use
there is a package called
d3 shape
and in d3 shape
there is a section on symbols
these symbols here are provided
by d3
and
the way this plays out is that
um you call some d3 functions and it
generates for you the string to use
as the d attribute for a
path to create one of these
symbols on the screen we need to just
make a path element and then set the d
attribute to the the return value from
some invocation let's see what that
invocation would be we have to call
d3.symbol and pass in type
and size
the type
that we pass in
should be one of these
symbol types like d3 dot symbol circle
d3 dot symbol cross d3 dot symbol
diamond
also the set of symbols is exposed as d3
dot symbols this is an array that
contains
all of these individual things
and so since our aim
is to reproduce this piece which has a
bunch of different symbols going across
i'd say we can just use that array of
all the symbols that are available
and you know traverse it use that as our
data
all right so let's import symbols from
d3 in our code
import select range and
symbols from d3
we also need to import symbol
from d3
the way we use this
is we call symbol passing in a type and
a size and that returns a symbol
generator
which we then need to invoke
with
some arguments or no arguments i guess
works
and
that there's some just there's just
something complicated um
that you could do if you pass an
argument but you don't need to pass an
argument
so once you invoke this function it will
return that that string that we can use
as the d attribute of a path
so let's give it a shot
on one of these masks
i'm going to replace this circle with a
path
and instead of cxcy and r
we can set the d attribute
to be
symbol
and i'm going to pass in
the symbol type which i can just access
you know symbols
at index 0 the first entry of the
symbols array
and the second argument here could be
the size
um
i don't really know what the range of
size is let's write 300
and this invocation here returns a
symbol generator which we then need to
invoke
as a function
and once we do it should return
some stuff
all right i don't see anything maybe the
size needs to be increased
there it is i see something start to
appear
yeah
okay there it is
the first symbol happens to be a circle
but to see some other
shape we can access i don't know the
next symbol symbols that index one
for example
notice that the symbol is centered in
the upper left
that's i think the first problem i would
like to address here
um
yeah and the way we need to do this is
uh
well we want to move it around
my first goal here is to move it so that
it's in the center
and
to do that i think the most
straightforward way to would be to use
an svg group element as the parent of
this path
and transform
that group element meaning move that
group element around with everything in
it
let's try that
all right so here we've got mask dot
append
path
but instead what if we did mask
dot append
g
dot append path
this works just the same as it did
because it's just a grouping
with no transform applied to it to apply
the transform to this group element to
move this path around we can say dot
attr
transform
and the value will be translate
of
let's just try some numbers 400 comma
yeah that moved it
the way this works is um it's a string
but it looks like a function invocation
it's it's a domain specific language for
transforms
and what it looks like is the first
argument to this
function s kind of a thing
in a string is the x
coordinate so it's going to move it over
to the right by 400 pixels
and the second argument here is the y
coordinate so it's going to move it down
by 400 pixels
ideally
to put it in the center we could say
width divided by two
and height
divided by two
but since this is a string that's not
going to work
we can take advantage of an es6 language
feature called string
template literals
and the way we can use this is by using
backticks
and then inside of this thing
we can bust out into javascript
using this syntax here a dollar symbol
and then a pair of curly braces
so now whatever is inside this pair of
curly braces will be evaluated
as javascript and inserted
into that location in the string
so now we can actually use
width over two
and height over two
and now it's dead center
look at that
i'll bring the size down a little so it
fits
on the screen
there we go
all right so the problem now is that one
of these masks uses this
symbol and the other mask still uses the
circle
so i mean one thing we could do to
address that is
copy paste
all this code
which is what i'll do
for now
and change white to black
all right now this sort of looks is
starting to resemble that solar wood
piece a little bit more
but i hate this
duplicated logic between these two
blocks these two masks i mean there's a
bunch of
code that looks almost exactly the same
the only difference is
one of these is filled with white
and has an id of circle mask
and the other
is filled with black
and has an id of circle mask 2.
and now that i think of it these names
are a little outdated
um because it's not circles anymore
so i'm going to rename it to
mask 1
and mask 2.
and i have to go and update the
references as well
okay
now
what i would like to do before we go any
further
is refactor this so that there's no
duplicated logic
the reason being
once we start adding more shapes into
here we're going to have to copy paste
larger and larger chunks and if we want
to change it in one place we'd have to
change in two places it would be a total
nightmare
and so this is a point at which
refactoring makes a lot of sense
refactoring is this notion of
reorganizing code so that it's more
maintainable or you can do
more things with it generally
refactoring is triggered when you see
duplicated logic in your code
all right so what i'm going to do here
is define a function
and the idea is
we can invoke this function
and and we can pass in only the things
that vary between the two namely the
mask id which is different
and the fill
which is different
so let's try that const um
what should i call it
render
mask
equals function
and
i'm just going to take all this logic
that appends the rectangle and the path
and put it inside these curly braces and
use prettier to automatically indent
that
now the things that we want to
accept here
are the id
and the fill
uh oh but first of all we should
actually invoke this function
okay now everything is in working order
again and we can take as as one argument
here
the id
of the mask
and we can use it here when we're
setting the id
so i'll say render mask and pass in that
string mask dash 1
here
which surfaces inside of this function
as the local variable
called id
which is used here to set the attribute
id
on the
mask
right so we can actually now call render
mask twice passing in different ids
and
i'll just comment out this other block
because
um
it's going to be
replaced by this function
all right so the the fill
is the other thing that we
we need to have vary between these two
function calls
so i think what i'll do is
instead of white this will be fill which
we can accept as the second argument
and so what we can do here is
pass in white
to the first one and black
to the second one
although
this is not exactly right because
we also need to deal with the the
background rectangle
which needs to be inverted like if it's
black it needs to be white
so you know what instead of using fill
i'm going to accept an argument called
inverted
and this this will be a boolean where if
it's true
the colors should be inverted if it's
false they shouldn't be
and so inverted for the first invocation
should be false
and for the second invocation should be
true
and then
uh we want the rect fill
to be black
if it's not inverted and white if it is
and
to do that
i see there's some youtube chatter let
me finish this thought and i'll answer
some questions there
to do that the tool that i would reach
for is the ternary operator
so we can say
inverted
question mark
if it is inverted this should be white
otherwise it should be black
since this is the first time i'm using
this
um
i want to stop and show you what it
would look like without this syntax
it would look kind of like this
let rect fill equals
black
and then we could say if inverted
wrecked fill equals white
and then we would use rect fill
down there
so what it's doing is
if it's not inverted this code will not
run and wrecked fill will be black but
if inverted is true erect fill will be
white and this will be filled in with
white
however
i think the cleaner syntax would be
to use the ternary operator
and say if it's inverted it should be
see now i'm losing track you know which
what should it be
let's say black
and white
now we can apply
the same logic to the fill of the
path
but it should be inverted from the
background and so
if it's inverted now it should be white
if it is and black
if it isn't
okay
there we go
victory
now we can get rid of this commented out
stuff here and now there's just one
block of code that is responsible
for rendering
this mask
the first time we render it as mask 1
which is not inverted and the second
time we render it as mask 2 which is
inverted
and at this juncture i want to
introduce
the the syntax of calling functions
on d3 selections
what that looks like is
it can take this is just a convention
that i want to introduce now it's a
convention that's used when you start to
use functions to abstract
uh to build abstractions
in this d3 world
so what it looks like is we pass the
selection
as the first argument
and inside of this function we refer to
it generically as
some selection and we would pass it in
as svg here
as the first argument
now it works everything works as
expected
and
the conventional way of doing these
sorts of invocations with d3 would be to
use
selection.call
so we could say svg.call
render mask
and then
pass in these second two arguments here
like this
and we can invoke it again
with these
other arguments
these two are exactly equivalent
in terms of what they do
i just wanted to introduce this
way of invoking
functions on selections
it doesn't have any immediate benefit
right now
um but it can be a very nice elegant way
of doing it one of the things
one of the reasons being that you can
chain it like this
so this is also valid syntax
all right
so i'll fork from here
just to capture the state of things
now the task before us is to render
multiple
symbols
in here
instead of just one
so how can we do that
well we've got symbols at index one
in use here and what we essentially want
to do is iterate through so if i change
it to be symbols at index 2
the shape that you see is a different
shape and symbols that index
is a star
for example
what we want to do
is append multiple paths
where each path
has the this d attribute from a
different symbol
so
how can we do this
instead of just appending a single path
we can use this data join pattern that
we used earlier with our rectangles
what this looks like
um
is
well instead of doing it
on the end of here i'm going to assign a
variable
called g
just to sort of
separate these concerns here
so g is our parent we can say g dot
select all
paths
and initially it's going to be
empty
dot data
and what should the data be here what
i'm thinking is it can just be
the same thing we did with the
rectangles we can use the range
utility
to create an array that contains
integers starting at zero
and how many things should be in here
well it should be the same as the number
of symbols that are available which we
can access from
symbols dot length
all arrays have this dot length property
and
it it returns to you the number of
elements that are on
the array
all right so
we've got this array of integers going
from zero to
uh the number of symbols
so now what we need to do is
use this dot join
method on paths
now it's going to create
a bunch of paths
and on each path
we want to set the d attribute
to be
something like this that we had earlier
but we want it to vary
based on the symbols
and we also want the fill
to be white or black
since we are making multiple paths
we can
use a function here to take as input
d
one of these integers
and we can access symbols at index d
to have it be
different
symbols
and what we get here is like this giant
splotch where all the symbols are
right on top of each other
so the task at hand here now that we've
got this far is to split these apart
in the x
direction so that you know one symbol is
on the left and one symbol is on the
right
since we have d
as an integer
that starts at zero and goes upward we
could potentially
move
each of these
group elements
over if we had them but we don't we're
just creating path elements
and there's a containing parent group
element i think what we really want is
to have it so that
for each symbol there is a separate
group element created
and then within that group element
there should be a path
yeah to clarify what i'm what i'm saying
if we inspect the dom here
we can see that within the mask
there's a group element
that has a transform
and then within that group element there
are a bunch of paths
i think instead
we want to invert this containment
relationship where
for each symbol there should be a parent
group element that gets a different
transform that gets translated
differently in the x direction and then
within each one of those group elements
we can put the path
yeah that's what i'm going to go for
and we could keep this
parent
element
but i don't think it's necessary because
we could just set the
transform on the inner elements
so i'm going to get rid of that
for now and instead of appending our
paths to g i'm going to append them to
mask
now it's working again but it's it's in
the upper
left corner
because um you know they're at the
origin now
the next step here
is to
use group elements instead of paths so
i'm going to say mask dot select all g
dot data
dot dot dot join g
however
this
this convenience method is no longer
enough for this case that we've got
now we need to deal with this concept of
the enter
selection because what we want to do is
tell d3
whenever you create a new group element
you should also append a path element
inside of it
yeah and to do that
we need to use the join method in a
slightly different way
um
what we've seen so far is the shorthand
of join where it accepts a string being
the tag name
but the long form of dot join
is where it accepts
arguments for enter update and exits and
i'll get more into this later
but
the simplest form of this is we pass a
function to dot join and it's
interpreted as
uh the enter
selection
um
actually more precisely we need to pass
a function
that takes as input the enter selection
all right
i realize it is a little confusing
and
in here we can say enter
dot append
g
to create our parent group element but
on this we can say dot append
path
and then on these paths
is where we can set
the d
attribute and the fill
attribute
okay we're back in working order
just to work through to walk through
this one more time
we're passing a function to dot join
that function will be invoked with the
enter selection of this data join
and because there are no group elements
initially
the enter selection will
will have this append method that will
get triggered for each and every entry
in the array
so we append a group element and we
append a path element to each of those
group elements
and we set d and fill on each of those
paths
so now if we inspect the dom and look at
it that way
we can see that there are indeed many
group elements
it's just that what we need to do now is
transform
each of these group elements to
translate them so that they're in the
middle vertically but they're spreading
across the page horizontally
and i see in the youtube chat
vonnie
says
use this code right here okay i'm going
to copy that code and see if it works
thanks for that
i'm just pasting this from the youtube
chat
oh that's that's what i've got already
but yes that's correct that's correct
um
all right what we want to do here
is for these group elements
we want to set
the attribute of transform
to be
we can take this thing that we can had
constructed earlier
translate by width over two height over
two okay now it's in the middle again
but we don't actually want to translate
in the x direction by width over two we
want to translate in the x direction by
a function of d and keep in mind d is an
integer that goes between one and uh
however many symbols there are
let's just say d times 200 to like
spread them out
by
200 oh
but this is not a function
it's just a string literal so let me
make it into a function that accepts d
okay there we go
there we go
all right it's starting to come together
that looks like pretty cool
abstract art right there
oh vani says it's not the same it uses i
let me see that
let me take a look at that
yeah so this is the code that i wrote
this is the code from vani in youtube
it's it is slightly different it accepts
i
yeah this when you pass a function it
does take
um
a second argument which is the index in
the array
so this works as well just the same
however
it just so happens that
the array
is integers that would be the same as i
all the time
so that's why this this variant works
but anyway um we can just tweak these
numbers to make it so that different
shapes
show up at this point so they seem to be
a little too large
what if i say you know
the size is 50 000.
and by the way i think this size is like
the number of fills filled in pixels
i don't know it's it's just they're high
numbers but i don't know this is just
what what it takes
so i'll bring down the size until we can
see multiple shapes there we go starting
to
starting to come together
and i'm just guessing here at the
this constant that
will split them apart
you can make it even smaller
all right this is almost there
look at that
beautiful
any questions at this point
so the
example of the
join in this case
that was
a case of appending
elements
to
multiple elements
which was uh different from before
um
is that right
correct yeah it's it's a slightly
different
pattern
and it's using the
the long form
of dot join so that we can access the
enter selection
yeah so
it passes in the enter selection
and the enter selection
is populated with
um
the case where there is no corresponding
group element
for
a given
data element which is the case for all
of them when this runs
that's why enter dot append g
will append a group element for each and
every
entry in our array here for each and
every symbol
and then
after appending that group element and
setting the transform we append to that
group element
a path
and then dot attr d
um
this whole thing
works
because of some
the way d3 is set up
it actually uses the the data element
that was bound to the parent
so that's why this works the data
element
d which is one of those integers
is associated with the group element and
then if you append to it if it came from
the enter selection
you can you can reference those those
data elements
from the child
so that that's why this this uh works
but i realize it is a lot at once
in for today
um
but that's sort of the intention to just
like show
you know the scope of this d3 data joint
thing
um and it will hopefully become more
clear
over time
but does that answer your question
uh yes thank you yeah that's really
clear thank you nice nice
and by the way this
this dot join method is is new to me
i mean i've i i learned really well the
old syntax with the dot enter and the
dot
merge
um
so for what it's worth i really only
learned this
this pattern recently and i'm still sort
of
you know trying to wrap my head around
it
so yeah feel free to interrupt me as i
go and ask questions like this this is
great this is great
oh my gosh oh look at this what time is
it
oh look at the time i'm overtime i'm so
sorry
all right well we've got pretty far
for today
i just want to wrap this up by tweaking
these numbers a little bit so that
there's some space along the side see
how this circle is right up against the
edge there
um i can just add some constant
to this like a hundred
yeah that looks decent and then i'll
bring this number down so that there's
some space on the right
yeah like 125 or so
and i'll bring the size down
just a bit
to make sure that we can see all the
shapes
and in viz hub you can set the height so
i'm going to make it
maybe 200 pixels
so that it more closely resembles the
original piece
okay there we have it
there we have it
that's all we're going to do for today
i will leave it
as an exercise
to make the back
sort of scratch that
to make the background rectangles match
the original solar with piece so here's
your exercise
and this is this is um kind of a
challenging one
see how in this original piece
each subsequent
square
uh
reorients the lines
however in our example what we've done
is um
they're all the same
so that's one thing you could do
as an exercise
alternatively um i i would encourage you
to use d3 to try to reproduce any other
solute piece because now that we have
this this new tool in our toolbox of the
d3
data join
it'll become a lot easier to reproduce
these solar with pieces
or create art just generative art in the
spirit of solo wit and just as a
reminder here's some
other solo wit pieces
that you could do with the tools that we
have now the svg mask
and the paths
this one for example could be done with
nested for loops and math.random to pre
produce the points
so yeah that's all for today
um thanks everyone for joining
and i'll see you next week
here's what i'm hoping to cover today
javascript arrays
writing the dot range function of d3
using vanilla javascript i think this is
a good example to cement
understanding of arrays and functions
and then we're going to look at the ins
and outs of d3 selections
that's what this diagram is over here
we'll get really deep into that
and then the d3 data join
concepts
and various ways of implementing them
with the d3 apis
all right so from here i'm going to dive
into vishub
and i'll create something new
just to uh to get some variety and how
we include d3 i'm going to start with
this hello d3 version 6
d3 starter i'm going to fork this
and call it um
oh actually
apologies we're just going to do vanilla
javascript first for arrays
i think i'll start with this
html starter just totally vanilla
html here
and i'll call it javascript
arrays
all right i'll open the editor
clear out the readme
and then we've got this index.html
to work inside
and again i'll open up the developer
tools so we have this console to work
with
and it says here hello javascript from
this console.log
hello javascript
all right so we won't really need any
html output so i'm just going to sort of
clobber all this stuff so we can focus
on just the javascript
and even i'll hide the output just so we
have our code and the output
in the console here
all right javascript arrays javascript
arrays are like arrays in many languages
it's a list of things essentially and
the syntax for javascript arrays
is
something like this square brackets
square brackets right here
it just defines an empty
array
and you see here it inherits from the
prototype of array which is a built-in
data type in javascript
and if we want to put things in this
array we could say like
for example now it's an array that
contains 1
or 0 comma one
now it's an array that contains two
things
zero and one
and in the developer tools
if you click this little arrow
it tells you all right at index zero
the entry in the ray is zero and at
index one the entry in the the array is
one
and we could put other types of things
in here like a and b for example
this really demonstrates the index
concept so the index of the array always
starts at zero
and
you can sort of use that to look up
things at different
indices different places
different numbers in the list
so let's assign this to a variable then
we can do more things with it
const array equals this and then we can
say console.log
array
same thing happens
now
we can access things in this array by
using the square bracket notation right
after
the array and we have to pass it the
index like index 0 for example so array
at index 0 gives us a
and array at index 1
gives us b
now arrays have a bunch of methods on
them one of which is push
so we can say array.push
c
for example
and now the array has a b
and c
on it
and i want to point out that unlike
other languages where arrays need to all
contain the same type of thing
javascript is a little more flexible so
you could have a mix of types like a b 1
and c or a b
and an object
and c
it doesn't really matter so it's just a
list of things that could be any type
and at this point i believe we have
everything we need to write the range
function
of d3
um are there any questions at this point
yeah there was an interesting uh
an interesting property called length
um indeed
yeah does that mean an array is an
object
oh is an array an object
well it's a
array is one of those
types that is built into javascript
um is it an object i guess it really
depends on what you mean what you can do
is say
type of
array
and it will actually tell you object
and while we're here i think this is the
first time we're seeing typeof so i can
just explain a little bit about type of
it's useful to figure out what type of
thing
something is in javascript so if you say
type of 0 it says number
if you say type of
the string a
it says string
if you say type of
an empty object it says object
and somewhat surprisingly if you say
type of array
it also says object
so in the javascript language
it is actually an object
but it's a special
kind of object
that's an array
yeah there are there are some mysteries
there to be sure
but uh that's that's my understanding of
it
and yeah because it is an object it can
have various properties and methods
see if we just say console.log array and
we expand it in the devtools here
we say we see that the prototype this
underscore underscore proto
is actually
array and on that array prototype
it's essentially a class
you know from the world of
object-oriented programming so what
we've got is this instance of this array
class so it is an object but it inherits
from this prototype which is this
built-in array
class or interface i don't know really
what the correct term is
but this is where
all of these methods are defined so
you've got array.concat
every
filter find
for
each join
map
push reduce
i'm just calling out the ones that i
actually use on a regular basis
sort
slice these are all extremely useful
things and hey if we're talking about
arrays why not dig into some of these
but yeah does that answer your question
ideal
yes thank you yeah that's that's a lot
more clever nice thank you
whoa
all right so at this point let's dig
into
building that um
range function from d3
so the idea with the range function is
that if you give it a number say 3
that's what the length of the array
should be
and
this function should return an array
that has integers
0 1 and 2.
so to simulate what it would be we can
enter 0 1
and 2
and now we get out this array with 0 1
and 2.
so we can combine all the knowledge from
the the basics that we covered before
with for loops and everything
to define this function range
we can say const range is a function
that takes as input i'm going to call it
n
the number of things
and then in this function body
we can just define
an empty array
and then at the end of this function
we can return
this array
and in the middle
we're going to want to push
some stuff onto this array starting with
zero
and then
to sort of test this out i'm going to
say console.log
range of let's say five
okay this is functioning so far
but it's not
actually giving us an array with the
five things
what we want to do
is push you know 0 1 2 3
like this
this is the correct result
but then if we change the number it's no
longer going to be the correct result
because we're not even using n
inside the function
what we can do now is use the for loop
construct that we looked at earlier
we can say 4
let
i
equals 0
i is less than
n
i plus plus
so just to remind you the structure here
this thing runs once it defines this
variable called i
this thing runs every time you go
through the loop to check if it should
proceed or not
and so as long as i is less than m
we proceed it executes the code in this
body and then this thing executes at the
end of whatever's in the body of this
for loop and this increments i it's
equivalent to saying i equals
i plus one
or
i plus equals one
these are all the same thing as
i plus plus
and i typed it in a comment just to
avoid an infinite loop
if it were to run
while i was typing it
so now that we've got this in place
we can say array.push inside of that
loop
and now see we get an array with four
zeros
and now if we just if we want the
correct values all we need to do is pass
in i to this array.push
and now we've got the correct
implementation for range so if we were
to pass in 10 it would give us this
array with
with 10 integers in it
this is what d3.range does
internally
so yeah i'm happy to get to this point
this is i think a good example to cement
our understanding of
arrays for loops and functions
any questions about this so far
all right and i'll i'll just give a
brief tour of a couple other frequently
used array functions
i'm going to extract this return value
to a variable and then we can say my
range
dot
uh well we could say a lot of things
there's a lot of methods but you know
i'll just talk about the methods that i
use most frequently
for each
is a super nice one
it allows you to pass a function that
takes as input something i'll call it d
just by convention this is a convention
from the d3 community to refer to each
element in an array as d stands for
datum
and then we can say console.log d so now
it's console.logging
each of these things here
and by the way this is equivalent
to
writing a for loop
and then
accessing
my range at index i
like this
it does the same thing
oh i i is less than uh
my range.length
this is what it's equivalent to
so yeah dot for each it's like a
functional shorthand for writing this uh
verbose
for loop
and then we've got
some other things like uh filter super
useful
filter takes as input a function that
takes us input one of the elements of
the array
and we could just say is is it equal to
three
and it will just
pass three
or we could say like is it is it even
and we can check if it's even by saying
d
percent 2
equals 0
so this will give us all the even
numbers
this by the way is the modulo operator
it's like
it's the remainder like if you were to
divide it
by the number it gives you the remainder
sometimes useful
let's just see what are what what are
the other methods
i think i might stop here for now but
if there's anything that i'm a big fan
of sort yeah yeah sort
sword is huge
because then you can because then it
comes back when you're doing dom stuff
because the order of things in svg is
really important for its rendering so i
i use sort a lot to sort of get around
that
for sure
so let me
here i'm going to add you as a
collaborator and in fact let me add
everybody here as a collaborator because
i want this to be a live sort of jam
session kind of a thing
we've got a deal here
and we've got sriram
so i'm going to add all of you
and oh let me drop this link to you
i'll share it in the
slack i suppose
and the meat why not
so yeah feel free to jump into this
as i'm going here
but yes sort
sort is hugely useful
let me give some examples of sort
i guess it's hard because your your data
is already sort of pre-sorted you made
it in an order so
it's already sorted so we can build up
an array that's not sorted like
four three five you know just sort of
random numbers here
and if we console.log that that's what
we get
but then
if we just say dot sort
on that
it's sorted all of a sudden
so a couple subtle things
sword actually mutates the array
and
it also returns the array so that's why
it works here it returns the sorted
array
so let me just demonstrate the fact that
it mutates the array
i'll call it sortable
sortable is this thing
and if we say console.log sortable.sort
it does sort
but check this out
if we just say console.log sortable
it's unsorted
and if we say sortable.sort
as an expression in between it's sorted
in the output that means that it
actually changes around the stuff in the
array it mutates the array
so it's not it's not one of these
immutable
things it does not create a new array it
just sorts the things that are there
and um i'm not sure how deep we want to
get into it but sort accepts a
comparator function
well yeah i was going to say how do you
what if i want to sort it in the other
direction
right well well if you want to do that
then the easiest thing would be to do
reverse
on the sword
so now it's sorted in the other way
i'm curious what would happen if we add
a new number like 20
let's find out
interesting yeah oh this is so good
thank you i do this is amazing so i
think what's happening here is if you
just call dot sort
maybe it treats everything as a string
is that right yeah what is it what is it
what is the default sort sort on i guess
is the real question
yeah i don't know let's see mdn
javascript array sort
the mdn docs are always the best
array.prototype.sort it sorts things in
place
the default sort order is ascending
built up here it is
built upon converting the elements into
strings and then comparing the sequences
of utf-16 code units values
cool makes sense totally
right very logical
so i think we should actually dive into
the comparator idea
um
should be here compare function that's
what they call it here
compare function it specifies a function
that defines the sort order so we can
use this if we wanted to sort it by the
actual numbers
or if we had an array of objects and we
wanted to sort by a specific field
of those objects we could use this as
well
so here's what it does
it accepts two things the first element
and the second element
and it returns
i'm surprised that it doesn't specify
here specifically what this function
should return
but i believe it should return negative
0 or 1.
let's see it's weird that it doesn't say
this has always been a fuzzy area if
like it's always been sort of like an
incantation but the
set of like it's like
if if your first element is less than
your second element
return negative one or zero depending on
how you want it to sort right right yeah
exactly exactly
so here it is if you scroll down a
little it says
if a and b are two elements being
compared then
compare function should return less than
zero
oh it says
it says if compare function
returns less than zero then it leaves
a and b unchanged in the order
if compare functions so that's our
negative one
yeah
that could be negative one yeah yeah if
so if you return negative one it leaves
them unchanged meaning
a is less than b
i'm pretty sure got it
but yeah i think you're right about it
if it returns zero
also leave a and b unchanged
with respect to each other but sorted
with respect to all different elements i
don't know this is kind of confusing
yeah i don't know what that means i
don't know what that means
so but if it returns greater than zero
also known as one yeah also known as one
or any other number greater than zero
but yeah one is is the most common uh
then it then it sorts yeah that's how
i've i've always seen it b before a
so let's give it a shot
that was really confusing right
so i'll just leave a record of this
and i'll say
it outputs this
is the documentation assuming that the
elements are numbers
what's being compared
um
well we can do i think we can do
whatever we want in it and return a
number it is expecting us to return a
number we could have like a random
number generator doing negative one
through one and it would randomly sort
you know what i mean
yeah
so
yeah a and b
are the elements in in the array and
they could be anything
what matters is that this compare
function returns a number
and
it's up to the implementer of the
compare function how you derive that
number
so let's try this again let's say
sortable.sort
and then console.log sortable i'll get
rid of this reverse
and we pass in a comparator function
that takes as input a and b two things
and because these are numbers i believe
we could implement this pretty simply as
like a minus b
and now they're sorted
sorry because you're just telling it to
not treat it as strings basically
yeah yeah exactly and and this little
expression follows all of those rules
for sorting meaning um
if b is
greater than a
a negative number is returned
but if a is greater than b
then a
a positive number is returned
so if you did b minus a it would reverse
it i believe so let's give it a shot
yeah
cool
that's right
and another way to phrase this
would be
um
like is b
less than
a
if so return
minus one
otherwise return
one
that works but i think
if they're oh yeah that makes a ton of
sense
[Laughter]
i mean this works
um
and this is often what you see of like
if
if these are data elements
and you want to compare a field you
could say like b dot
some field
ada some
field but i mean it doesn't make sense
now because we don't actually have that
scenario
but later we will i guarantee it
yeah i'm sorry for sending you down this
sort rabbit hole you were about to move
on no no it's good it's good this is why
i love these interruptions because
because like i want to
empty my head of the stuff that people
are
uncertain about and want to know about i
just don't know what people need to hear
at the moment you know when i'm going
through this stuff
and so yeah that that's why i i think
yeah
go ahead go ahead you go ahead
i don't think i've ever read the docs
for sort like i've just like seen
like this pattern and then sort of like
hacked it to because it is mildly
intuitive a little bit but it's cool to
sort of actually see it
laid out in detail the way that you have
for sure for sure oh thanks and you know
i think um if we really want to be like
pedantically correct about it if if two
numbers are the same this function
should return zero i think ideally
and so to do that we can say okay is b
less than a return negative one
otherwise
is b
greater than a
return one but otherwise they're equal
and returns zero
so i think this is like the ultimately
correct way
but it's like who wants to come across
this and you know yeah you're a madman
what is this yeah what is this
there's like some insane pursuing
scribbling on a wall
so
d3 to the rescue
um
turns out
there is a d3 utility to help you
through this stuff
a and b
we can re return ascending
of a and b
and ascending we can import from d3 um
and this is actually the same as just
passing
ascending
into sort
and d3 also provides a thing called
descending
so this is what
you would typically use
in practice
and these ascending and descending
things from d3 automatic like i think
they implement this logic
internally but they hide it from you
they just make it you know
very intuitive easy to use
and that's the same as like like you
were about to go talk about d3 range
right like that's these are all sort of
very simple wrappers so you don't have
to get into this level i've been spoiled
right i only ever use the d3 wrappers i
never really write any of this stuff
exactly exactly yeah and some of the you
know philosophy of
this course the way i'm progressing
through things is to like
to show
uh
like how it's made like how the sausage
is made sort of thing you know like this
is how d3 works inside it's not like so
crazy mysterious but it's a pain if you
wanted to implement it yourself all the
time
all right i think
i think that's it for arrays
let me see
um
we covered filter for each
push
oh map i gotta talk about map
oh yeah gosh map is
map is huge map is like the most you
know one of the most useful things that
i find myself using all the time all the
time
all right we've got console.log sortable
and we get this stuff
oh actually
let me let me use the other
um
arrays just so all these sections are
like decoupled
we've got my range here
console.log my range gives us these
numbers from 0 to 9.
check it out we can use dot map
map expects a function it's a lot like
for each it goes through each of the
elements of the array
and if we just write a function that
returns
each element
it doesn't do anything essentially
passes things through this function
it generates a new array with all the
return values
so if we say like d times 2 for example
now we get all of the original the
original numbers but multiplied
by two
so this is this is super useful i mean
you could
you could do all sorts of things in here
like return an object that says
number is d
and then now we're talking now we're
talking
yeah
right and then even like
double is d times
two
so you can construct objects
in this way
using dot map
so yeah dot map is it's just super
useful you know especially when you have
data
loaded from like a csv file or something
you can
uh parse dates for example
uh clean up the number of fields that
you have all using dot map
well for me a lot of my work is finding
an example of a visualization that's
pretty close to what i want and then i
have a data set that's slightly
different from that so most of the way
of like bridging that gap is just a dot
map where i make my data look like the
data that the example works on does that
make sense totally
yeah and dot map can be the bridge from
here to there
for sure for sure
let's see what else
reduce
reduce yes
yes yes yes
now reduce that's one of those ones that
is like kind of
tricky to wrap your head around and you
can get through life without using
reduce ever
however
i find that one of the most
useful things with reduce
is to
build up an object
where
the keys are derived from some array so
let me just uh
just try reduce
console.log myrange
reduce
accepts two arguments the first is a
function
that takes as input
two things
and i can never remember the order let
me just consult the documentation
reduce looks something like this you
define what's called a reducer it takes
as input the accumulator and the current
value
and here's one that just adds them
together you could use this for example
to sum all the numbers in the array
current value here is one of the
elements from the array
accumulator
is the returned value from this function
as it goes through
but the first time this this is invoked
accumulator gets the value that you pass
in as the second argument
to reduce
so let's put this into practice we can
say dot reduce
accumulator i do like that term and i
can use d
you know why not
so if we say accumulator plus d
we get
45.
which is the sum
of all those numbers
and uh you know i'm not sure what it
what it uses as the first value because
i didn't pass anything
but
if you pass in zero as the second
argument to reduce
that's what accumulator gets
for the first
entry
right
this is this may be kind of confusing so
let me just
open it up into a function
and say console.log accumulator
just to see what this is
um
looks like i have a syntax error
actually i didn't
so what this is doing here is it's
logging the value of accumulator
as the as it progresses through the
array
so here's what it's doing it's adding
which we passed in as the second
argument to reduce
and it's also adding zero the first
element of the array so the first time
through this returns zero plus zero
which is zero
that's why it's outputting zero twice
and then it's then it's returning zero
plus one one coming from the first
element of the array
and then the next time around
accumulator is three
because it added one
plus
two 2 being the next element
of the array so to be even more clear
here we can say
adding
accumulator
plus
d
so now we can see that it's adding
zero plus zero zero plus one one plus
two
so one plus two is three and then so the
output of adding one plus two
is the new the next version of the
accumulator then it has three plus three
which is six and then it adds four to
that which is 10 and then it adds 5 and
so on until it gets to 45.
so that's reduce
in a nutshell
and while we're here i do want to show
the most common use case that i
encounter for reduce
oh but first of all are there any
questions yet here about reduce
yes if if
you remove the second argument which is
zero
does the f
does it default to something
um
am i could it just default to the first
value of the element
in this case
that exactly appears like what it is
doing
yes
yeah it appears to be
adding zero plus one
in the first time around and it must be
getting that from the array
yeah yep that makes sense
and we can we can be totally sure but
just by saying like
you know two and three
it it does see yeah the first time
around it takes the first two elements
of the array
and adds those together meaning it it
takes the first element of the array the
the thing at index 0 treats that as
accumulator and then takes the thing at
index one treats that as d so that that
is what happens if you leave out the
second argument
and actually i wasn't sure of that until
i just did this just now so
i'm learning too
all right i think the last thing we're
going to do here with arrays is
construct an object
from an array
and let me show you what i mean
oops
i'm going to make a thing called entries
and in this thing there will be
objects
and
the key
will be
something
like
um
i don't know just a
all right and value
will be
um
fool
it's just random stuff that doesn't make
any sense
and then we have another one where the
key is b
and the value is
bar
um just to show the mechanics
of all this stuff
so now let's say what we want
is
an object
that actually has
the key of a
and the value of foo
like this
and then the key of b and the value of
bar
like this
this is our desired result
so the challenge is how do you write
code that gets from this to this
i encounter this all the time
and here's how you can do it you can do
it with reduce
entries
dot reduce
and the trick is that you start with an
empty object so you pass in an empty
object as the second argument to dot
reduce
and then this reducer function takes as
input the accumulator
and
i'll call it d
just by convention
and
in the body of this reducer
we ultimately
want to return
the accumulator
i mean so here's the approach i'm going
to i'm going to add a property to this
object
and then return the object
so we return
accumulator
but before we do that
we can say accumulator
at
d dot key
equals d dot value
and then we got that object that we were
trying to get
and and by the way i'm not sure i've
introduced this syntax
yet but if you have
an object
let's say you have an object you can say
object dot
a
equals
foo
like this
but the there's an equivalent syntax
where you could say object at
a
like this using these square brackets
and that's equivalent
so now object has a is full like that
but anyway yeah this is this is how you
can use reduce to accomplish that task
oh i see there's a question in the
youtube chat
here let me pull it over here so you can
see it
question i deal with
two dimensional arrays a lot
um is there a way to sort by columns
question question question question
sure let's do it why not i mean
so we've got this
entries array let's say we wanted to
sort by
the key
and let's say they're out of order
to begin with
i think the question is asking how would
you sort by a certain field
of these objects
so if you wanted to do that
you could say
entries dot sort
and pass in a comparator
or a compare function rather that takes
as input a and b these are objects
these are the objects in the array
and it can return
you know if a dot key
is less than b dot key
and this will be comparing strings so it
would be essentially a
is less than b which you can do
in javascript that works it sorts by
alphanumeric
values so you could say if a is less
than
if a dot key is less than b dot key
then return
one
otherwise return one
and
that works
it sorts by key now abc
and if we're using
d3
we can say entries.sort
ascending
a dot key and b dot key like this
and that
would do the same thing if we had d3
at our disposal
so thanks for that question
so i think what i'll do is actually pull
in d3 so that we can use this and it'll
work
um and then i'll take a short break like
a 5-10 minute break and then come back
and do something creative
with d3 selections
but are there any other questions at
this point
all right
so i'm going to go about
pulling in d3
in vishub
the most straightforward way
of doing this is to use the
package.json feature which is relatively
new
specified dependencies d3
at version
something let's see what's the latest
latest version of d3 is 6.6.2
so we use that
and now
now we can put some javascript in
index.js
so i'll move this
into
index.js
and now
we can say
import
ascending
from d3
and now it should run
there we go
so now
this code actually ran and this is how
you would
sort things by a value with d3
all right i think we'll dive in to
d3 selections
so here's what i'll do i'm going to fork
this viz and say
d3 selection
exploration fork it
and i'll add you all as collaborators
again
i want this to be kind of a jam session
all right i'm going to delete everything
here
and then we can import select
from d3
the select function lets you
[Music]
create
d3 selections
using what's called a selector string
where you can select elements that are
on the page already
for example we can say select body
and that is a d3 selection
that contains the body element so here's
what i've i think i'm going to do
i'll create an svg append it to the body
give it a width and height and then we
can create some array maybe using the
range function from d3
and then make a bunch of circles based
on that array and maybe make the circles
move around
in different ways
selections have a method called append
so we could say dot append
svg
like this
and it creates a new selection and
returns it and that is the selection of
that one svg element
at this point if we were to inspect the
dom
we can see that there is in fact an svg
element
there
in the dom
and i'm noticing there's an extra script
tag
yeah there's an empty script tag we'll
just get rid of that
we can see that in fact there is an svg
element
appended to the body right here
so
to work with svg
we need to give this svg element width
and height so we can say dot attr
to set the attribute of that dom element
of width
to be
width
which is a variable
that i'll create
and i'll derive that from
the actual width of the browser
so we can say window.enter width and
we're also going to want height
as window.inner height
so what's happening here is it's created
a selection of that svg element and then
when we call dot attr
oh
hey felipe has joined us hello
hello
happy birthday
thank you thank you very much
well i'm so glad you could make it this
time alive you i see you've always been
watching
first time i was able to i mean i was
not able to do the exercise from the
last class
but i was able to join at least amazing
amazing so look
i'm going to add you here as a
collaborator so if you want to jump in
you totally can
okay thank you
oh
yeah it's valid
oh there it is
yeah there it is nice
here you are
and i will drop you this link
in the hangout chat so you can see it
so yeah everybody here feel free to jump
into this thing
once we get rolling
all right so we give this svg a height
of height here
and we can assign this to a variable
because we're going to want to add stuff
into this svg
so const svg equals
this stuff
so now when we inspect dom
we see that it has width of 960 and
height of 500.
i also noticed that it's slightly offset
from the corner and there are scroll
bars
this is a very common thing
that we can address with a little bit of
css
so in the head i'm going to say
style not style
and add some css that says
for the body
make the margin zero
that gets rid of the margin but still
for some strange reason there are scroll
bars
we say overflow
is
hidden
to get rid of those
pesky scroll bars
now we're good to go
all right so here's where i want to have
some fun we can we can make a bunch of
circles and this is our first
four a into d3 data joins
and it looks something like this
svg.select
all
circle
this selects
it makes d3 selection that contains all
circles that exist
within that svg
and at this time there are none
but that's an important piece of
information for the internals of d3
because
once we say
data and we pass in
data
and i'll just define data to be range
of let's say 15 we're going to make 15
circles
and we can import range from d3
like this
now that we have
called
dot data
we have created
what's known as a d3 data join
and on this data join
there are three parts enter update and
exit and i have a slide about this
with a d3 data join
there is an array
and i'm calling that data here and then
there are dom elements
which i'm just putting dom calling dom
here on this diagram for example it's
all of those
circles that don't exist yet
in the case
that
there is a data element you know in that
array that does not correspond to any
existing dom element that's what's known
as the enter selection
we can tap into the enter selection to
append new circles
for all of the
data elements
for which there are no circles yet
so let's do that
to tap into the enter selection we can
say dot
enter
like this
that gives us the enter
selection and then on there we can say
dot append
circle
and what this whole expression does
is it creates a data join
it accesses the enter selection of that
data join and then on there it appends
a circle
so if we inspect the dom now
we can see that inside of this svg there
are many circles
to be precise
but they don't have any attributes so
let's let's work on setting setting up
the circle so that we can see them
we can call dot attr on this selection
that contains these newly appended
circles
and whatever we put in here will be
applied to all of the circles so we can
say attr r is where i'm going to start
specify the radius
to be maybe a hundred
and
now we get some circles to show up but
they're all on top of each other they're
all the same place so to spread them out
in the x direction
i'm going to say dot attr
cx which is the center x of the circle
and i could say like i don't know 400
it puts them all in the middle but
they're still all
overlapping
to make it so that they're not
overlapping we can pass a function here
as the second argument
that function takes as input what i'm
going to call d one of the entries of
this array and if we just return d
we can see that they're slightly spread
out
because it's setting the pixel
coordinate of the center of the circle
to be those integers
but they're only varying by one pixel so
they're not that spread out if we wanted
to make them
very more we could multiply them let's
say multiply by a hundred
now they spread out across the screen
because for each of these numbers
it's multiplying it by 100 and we're
getting this x coordinate that goes all
the way across the screen
i'm just going to tweak these
variables here
or not variables tweak these values so
that we can see some of these circles
better
and i kind of want to see where it ends
see there we now we can see
there are 15 circles here
and i don't really like how it it's
touching the corner so i'm just going to
add
some number like 20
or how about 50.
okay now they're nicely spread out in
the x direction
we can do something similar for the y
direction so c y
like this so now it's diagonal
if we just return
let's say
that puts them right in the middle
and
here's where i want to do something
fun
i'm going to use the sine function for
math
so we say math math.sin
this is a built-in function in the
browser
and it's the sine
function from trigonometry
so if we say sine of d
it's sort of
varies a tiny bit just because the
output of sine varies from negative one
to one if we want to see that variance
we have to multiply it
so if i multiply it by say
we can see that now they're all spread
out
which is you know not ideal it's sort of
the sine wave is going too fast and to
slow it down we can
multiply d by some value like 0.5
and now we actually see that it is in
fact
a sine wave here
and i'll just tweak these to
you know make it
a little bit more
uh if if i want to
to access the value of cx in the cy
how can i do it
access the value of cx in cy
well the way that i would do that is
extract this into a function
it's usually not advisable to actually
read the properties out of the dom
that were already set but what you could
do is recompute it
and so
i could do something like this say const
x equals this function and then we can
say
uh x of d to get that value
to c but it would be recomputing it
essentially
so yeah i was going to say i i
i'm tempted to um
ask you to turn
like when you make data like i would do
all of the cool stuff you're doing in a
map or like making a new object and then
just reference those values when i'm
rendering it right
love it
love it and this this is a great great
segue into the discussion about how do
you decouple
the lodge oh yeah i saw that someone in
the youtube chat was asking about like
how to separate your your concerns of
like processing data versus visualizing
it and all that
yeah exactly separate the concerns of
data from charting yeah another question
here from
lilac foonish can you please talk about
organizing the project top down how to
create modules for reusable yeah i'm
going to get to all that later but what
we can talk about now is this separation
of concern between
uh data manipulation
and
charting uh which is you know
essentially rendering or dom
manipulation
right because right now you're sort of
you're manipulating it and as you
visualize it you're changing it and then
rendering those values whereas you might
want to like do a
making a visualization data middle step
that sort of takes your source data and
makes it into a format that's ready for
visualization and then the visualization
side you just grab exactly what you need
exactly exactly right now it's tightly
coupled this rendering logic is
essentially too smart there's there's
all this
data processing logic
embedded in here with the rendering code
and this is exactly the pattern that
makes it really tough to port things
from d3 to other frameworks like react
or vue or angular well and also to get
the value of cx right so if it's
calculated on the visualization side
your other visualization parts can't
access that right like they have to
recompute it but if you do it in the in
the viz processing step then any step of
the way you can process all those cool
values and work with them
exactly yeah that's exactly right you
wouldn't have to recompute it you could
just compute it once and then access it
so let's do that
the way we would do that is to use dot
map right here
and so that can take as input d and it
can return
an object
and on that object
we can define properties
x and y
i think this is how i would like to do
it
and
x i can just move this logic over here
and say x is this
and it's going to work because d is the
same
and then i can take this logic here for
y
and move it over here
and so now we're constructing
the data elements that we can just
directly visualize no need to have any
complicated logic
down here with the d3 selections
we can just simply access
d dot x and d dot y like this
now felipe
to answer your question
we could just access it like this d dot
x
in the
in the function that computes c y
if we wanted to
for example if we just use it it would
be a diagonal
yeah i love it
you could do also cool stuff like you
could get the extent of your cx and see
why like if you wanted to make a light
to dark scale for how where they were in
the sine wave you know what i mean right
yeah for sure
for sure we could do something like um
yeah so
here's here's a place where i want to
get to i want to i want to get this
thing to move
and then we open it up for all sorts of
creative directions
and so
here's what i'm thinking
we we can use this construct called
request animation frame
um
well let me sort of ease into this
we want to animate it
and
one construct that's available to us in
javascript is set interval
and set interval takes as input a
function
and an interval in milliseconds so if i
say
1000 that's one second so every one
second
it would
re-recompute this stuff
and i think what i'll do is i'll just
move this entire logic
into here
and so now it's going to
append these circles every time
but i want to introduce the notion of
time
so let's say let t equal 0 t is going to
be our time
and every time we go through this we can
say t equals
t plus
let's say one
and then in our sine wave calculation we
can say plus t like this
so now
every second
it should
work
but it's not
i think you don't need to like call set
interval again or wrap it all in a
function or something like that
well i think what's happening here
is that
the enter selection is only triggering
on the first run
[Music]
back to our
back to our diagram here
the enter selection which we're using to
set all these properties only triggers
in the case where
there are no corresponding
dom elements for your data elements
but what's happening is
that is happening the first time that
that function runs but one second later
when that function runs again
actually what we need to work with is
the update
selection
and that's the case where
for each data element there already is a
dom element and all we want to do is
change it we don't need to end we don't
need to append new ones again
so let's try that let's work with update
okay here's what we can do
we can say const circles
equals
and we can define it to be this data
join here
right
so it will select all circle dot data
data this is the d3 data join
and then we can say circles
dot enter
dot append circle
and this is only going to happen the
first time through
right so all we want all we really want
to do is create the circles
um and i suppose we could set the radius
here as well because it's not going to
change over time
and then
circles
actually contains that update part
of the data join so we could say circles
dot attr cx and cy like this
but notice what happens
it actually works so now it's it's
animating
which is cool which is where i want it
to get to let me just tweak it so that
it animates in a smoother way
so now it's like every tenth of a second
and we can say um
t equals t plus 0.1 to make it move more
slowly
so now you can see really what it's
what it's doing here
however this is super fun right right
but there's like no now that you have
this there's so many ways that you could
just
add cool stuff to it exactly yeah there
is it's it's going to be so
so intense
but before we get into that what i want
to what i want to highlight
is that
check it out when this runs
let me set this delay to like
five seconds
then we can see the first time it runs
boom see all those little circles there
they're in the corner the circles are
just in the corner on the first run and
then on the second run they get
positioned
that's because the first time through
this whole thing
the update selection is empty there's
nothing there
there are no circles to update
enter only triggers so here the the
challenge here is that what we want to
do is we want to set all the coordinates
of all the circles
the first time
on the enter selection and also on
subsequent times using the update
selection
and
so how do we do that let's get back into
the code
one option here
is that we could duplicate this logic
right we could set the values for cx and
see why
on the enter selection
so it just appears
immediately correctly
and then the next time around it
increments just a little bit
however this is
duplicated logic i mean we want to avoid
duplicated logic at all costs because i
mean if you wanted to change in one
place you'd have to change it someplace
else
so as a best practice we should aim to
avoid this sort of duplicated logic
and this is where
merge
comes in
see ideally we could just
have this logic once
applied to
something that
that will be the enter selection the
first time and it will be the update
selection on subsequent times and here's
how we get to that thing
let me
assign enter to be
a variable
so now we have the enter selection
defined here as circles enter and we
have the update selection defined as
circles
so what we want to do is
merge those two together
so we can say circles dot merge
circles enter
like this and it creates a brand new
selection
that
merges those two together it's like
both of them
meaning the first time around that
selection resolves to the enter
selection with all the brand new circles
but on subsequent times
it
um
oh i'm just confused at what's happening
sorry i i hacked i was playing around
with some svg transitions i wasn't sure
if it would take effect right away it
did it did and i'm like why are those
circles moving a tiny little bit sorry
that's so cool
oh it's cool it's cool uh but you know
this is this is where i wanted to get to
just to explain this this pattern with
dot merge
which is one of the most confusing
aspects of d3 so if we use circles.merge
circlecenter the first time around it's
going to be the enter selection with all
the brand new circles and we're going to
apply cx and cy to those and on the
second and subsequent runs it's going to
resolve to the circles from the update
selection
and in recent times i believe it was d3
version 6.
there's a new
shorthand
that you can use
to do this exact same thing
which is dot join
so let me just i'll keep this as it is
comment it out just for reference
and with the new api
you can say
right here dot
join circle
and that actually gives you the merged
enter and update selection
and on there
is where we can set all of the
attributes
so this is sort of a simpler way
to do it
and it accomplishes the same thing
i mean it would it would actually be
equivalent to defining r on the merged
enter an update selection
so it's assigning r
unnecessarily but you know
maybe that's
fine all right
so now we can start really messing
around with this
uh making the animation go faster and
faster
ideally it would be 16
milliseconds which is uh at 60 frames a
second so like 1000 divided by 60
should give us animation at 60 frames a
second
and then we can slow down
this stuff
so yeah i mean we just we talked about a
lot of things any questions or
discussions at this point
oh i see
i see there's a question
what is the difference between merge and
join
join so
merge
is a method on a selection where you can
pass in another selection
and it will merge them together it's
essentially a set
union
you can think of it as a set union
that's what merge does and the most
common use case is to merge together the
enter and the update selection
uh
for rendering a bunch of things
that's what merge does
join on the other hand
is sort of a magical
shorthand
for this entire pattern
so it actually does a bunch of stuff
internally
what join does internally
is it creates
the enter selection
using this tag
um
so it's what it actually does is it's
equivalent to
this up here
we pass in the tag name to dot join and
internally it says okay
on this data join we will create the
enter selection and we will append
tags of this type it does that
internally it has this exact logic
internally
and it also
returns
the merged enter and update selection
so what we get as a return value out of
join
is
essentially the result from merge which
uses internally to merge together the
enter and update selections
and so then
once we have that
we can set all these attributes on it
and i believe join
also removes elements
that are in the exit selection
so it's a shorthand for the entire
pattern which is known as the general
update pattern
yeah and actually i would love to
to demonstrate that
so i think i'll i think i'll go for that
um we're defining a range of 15 every
time
but what if that number were different
so i'm trying to get get us to a case
where
where there are things exiting the scene
where at a certain point there are fewer
data elements than dom elements
so i'm going to go back to
this
the long form
using dot merge
and then
i'll define this number as n
like the number of circles
so if i set it to say 14
it's fixed but what i'm going to do here
is i'm going to set it to a value that
changes over time so let's say 10
oops
i'll say 10 plus math dot sine
of
time
times
5. so now it should vary
between
5 and 15
and notice the effect that it has on the
animation
over time
it is sort of disconnecting from those
circles
but it's leaving those circles there on
the page
this is where the exit selection comes
into play
the exit selection
is the case where
there are dom elements sort of hanging
out in the dom
from some past events that no longer
have any data elements associated to
them
and the most common thing to do with the
exit selection is just to remove those
things
so let's try that
to access the exit selection
from the data join we can say
circles.exit
dot remove
to remove all of those circles
so now you can see that the circles are
added and then as that number gets
decreased the circles are actually
removed
from the dom
and this
is also done sort of automatically for
you
when you use this dot join method
so as it decreases
boom see those circles are removed
so that's what dot join is all about
so i think i'll fork this just to sort
of save
the state of everything but then i'll go
back to this one where folks have been
added as collaborators and we can sort
of get a little creative here
and uh
make something cool but yeah what do you
all think
so far i mean i hope this is
hope this is a clear
explanation of d3 data joins
yes it's um so this uh it sounds like d3
is automatically
matching
every
data point with every
circle in this case it's it knows which
data point belongs to which circle
that's right
yep that's right
i believe internally d3 may actually
store
the data values on the dom elements
which are also javascript objects which
you can do which is kind of a
um
a tricky thing if you get into doing it
yourself but
yeah i believe what d3 does is when it
enters
i mean when it appends new elements as
part of the enter selection i believe it
actually associates
the data values
on those dom nodes for future use
i may be wrong you'd have to study the
d3 source code
but
yes essentially it does associate the
data elements to the dom elements
and so it knows
once you create the data join you select
all the circles that are there on the
page you tell it what data you want to
use
it computes that venn diagram internally
by sort of inspecting those two things
comparing them
somehow
that's how it works
yeah sounds that's fantastic
current what is this particular
programming pattern called where you
just join methods together like this
oh this is called method chaining
yeah method method
it's a very uh jquery like thing right
was jquery the first kind of language or
is this just a common programming
pattern
you may be right that jquery was the
first one i haven't used jquery in so
many years
i don't even know i don't even remember
what it looks like to use it
but yeah it does have
perhaps this the same method chaining
idea where you can say
dot something
and then that returns the same thing
that you invoked it on and so you could
chain more and more methods
and this still uh this still
separates the two concerns
one for
data processing and then
displaying it
this program yes i would say it does um
because
we're just using vanilla javascript to
produce this data
and then in the rendering logic it is
just accessing those properties it's not
computing anything from those properties
i mean if we if we wanted to go all out
we could we could associate the radius
to these values as well
and we could say
you know axis d dot r and we could
compute that as well
and now that we've done this we can
you know vary
vary the radius as well
which could be cool
to that question some part of me wants
to go like because you basically have
two functions here right you have your
like make data and you have your vis
data you could easily just make this set
interval call those two functions right
yes
yeah you totally could you could you
could abstract this
into a function
and you could abstract this into a
function
yeah that would make for really clean
readable code
we could do it shall we
yeah do you want to do you want to i'll
do you make data and you do this data
sounds good
then you just need the number it's like
you just use n i guess i suppose t is
what you would need
or no yes i like that yeah n
or n
t is is used inside of there yeah so you
would need it yeah exactly
all right
does that work did i break everything
let's take a look
probably huh
oh yes the return is critical it's
pretty important
nice it works
sweet
yeah now now this is a nice compact
little thing that says
we compute n we call make data with n
and t
pass that into viz data
yeah and we could even conceivably
make it even smaller
but i kind of like explicitly saying all
right this is our data we're gonna pass
it in
yeah totally totally this is a great way
to decouple
these two concerns
and these could even be refactored into
modules i mean that's something that
we could do as well
but i don't know if it's worth it
actually why not i don't think we've
discussed modules yet at all
right yeah i'd like to see that that
would be really cool
yeah let's do it
so i'm going to make a new file ej you
want to do it at the same time again you
want to do make data and all this data
yeah that sounds good
so i'll make a new file called
visdata.js
and then i'm just going to grab that
stuff inside that function
and paste it into that file
and in order to expose it to the outside
world we need to say export
like this
now we get what's called a named export
from this module
and then in index.js i could say import
this data from
dot slash
vis data that tells it to look for a
file
locally
so this is es6
modules
super super useful way to break down
code into multiple files and scale a
code base
super due super duper useful
so
you're all set with make data yeah yeah
while i'm here i'll i'll import that to
make data
from dot slash make data
and
let's see does it work oh range is not
defined and make data
nice so we just need to move that import
over i'll do it
we need to import range in that module
got it
and then
i don't believe we need range in index
dot js
svg is not defined it says
ah
yeah yeah yeah so this is my bed uh
i i didn't pass it into vis data so this
data should take as input the selection
svg
and the data so the x uh
svg can be the first argument
and now it's working all right
excellent so while we're here i just
want to say
once you abstract things into a function
like this it's sort of a best practice
to rename this to be like
selection or at least this is my
personal preference
and i'm realizing we're not using the
circles variable so we can just get rid
of it
and this still works as well the idea is
that if you wanted to you know call this
on a group element it would and the
variable name would still make sense
and last but not least i do love to use
selection.call when i can so we can say
svg.call
this data
and data like this this is the d3
invocation pattern on selections
it just takes whatever arguments you
pass
and
you know passes them as arguments to
this function these two lines are
equivalent
all right
so the uh the svg object is the
first argument being sent
to the
first of the argument to call
correct
is that how it works okay yeah that's
how it works when you when you when you
use selection.call it takes as input
the first argument which is a function
and that function should expect
the selection that is called on as the
as its first argument
and then whatever other arguments you
pass get sort of spread out as the
arguments
to that other function
right yeah
i mean this in this case it really
doesn't matter which which way we we do
it
but i just kind of like to use dot call
when we can
is dot call a d3 thing or oh yeah
something that
okay
yeah yeah it's a specific method on d3
selections only it's a d3 thing yep
it's useful for chaining because then
you could call
you know multiple things if you wanted
to
but we don't have that scenario here
all right i think i should wrap it up at
this point
um
oh where'd my slides go
okay i'd like to leave you all with uh
an exercise all of you who are viewing
follow me along this this whole series
four can modify what we created today
and just make something super duper cool
you know change the sine wave and like
maybe maybe set the fill color based on
sign of time or something like that
and just see
see what you can come up with
as an alternative exercise more specific
and targeted
see if you can add lines between these
circles
and to do that you could use line
elements
or you could use a path element
or you could use a polygon element
any of these things
and please once you do this
submit it in the hub forum
on this episode 5
topic here
welcome everyone to episode 6 of get it
right in black and white where we'll
discuss javascript modules
and build tools
i often get asked the question how do
you work outside
vishub
every time i've taught this course you
know people are happy generally using
vis-hub to learn how to code
it's great because you can start coding
right away
but um when folks start to export the
stuff out of his hub they're confronted
with this new universe of stuff like npm
package.json
roll up
building a bundle.js
and then including it in the page and
then having to serve the files locally
within http server
so all of this stuff is what i want to
get into today
today's episode is dedicated to
answering this question
thoroughly
what we'll cover today i will start with
reviewing last week's uh exercise
submissions as usual
and then we'll get into this uh content
starting from scratch really how you
know how to include javascript in html
various ways to do this
um we'll talk about es6 modules
we'll talk about rollup how to use
rollup how to configure rollup i think
i'll use a rollup starter project
webpack as well
and perhaps some other things around
webpack like
create react app
if you all could mute yourselves it'd be
great thanks
webpack and things around webpack
um and also
using github because if you're not using
vishub you need to you know store the
code somewhere store the revisions
and so i think i'll walk through also
using github creating a github
repository
putting the code into the github
and maybe even hosting it with github
pages
if we have time
so that's what we'll cover today that's
the plan
let me pull up next week's last week's
exercises here
all right here's
last week's
uh forum
post
let's see what we've got this is so cool
double harmonic look at this
it is a double pendulum
inspired by
sisyphus table
not sure what that is but
sounds cool
beautiful stuff very mesmerizing and it
creates something
most worthy of being
printed out
on a canvas or something
no there is a lightest version of it on
the home page of wheeze up oh yeah
yeah it's cool
oh wow he's got a lot of stuff going on
here oh my gosh look at this
black and white version
sweet
and yeah it looks like spears in there
this one oh look at that
that's pretty wild
wow very cool
very cool
yeah w gloss
nice work w gloss
let's see what else have we got
oh there was a question
actually like
oh i just cannot get this running
locally which is like okay yes now it's
time i have to talk about how to do that
so
we'll address all of this stuff today
for sure
oh some new stuff i haven't even seen
yet look at this one from nita
whoa
very cool
some nice transitions
very nice
you want to talk about this at all
yeah i will
oh it's using transitions i just use uh
transitions to create the basic
animation the one you created felt a
little difficult
very nice so yeah if you
if if you run this
it has a transition when you load it
and that's created by
so this the cx and cy are initialized i
guess at zero which is inferred
and then you use transition and duration
and change cx and cy very nice
very nice i think in a future episode
i'm going to get way deep into
transitions
and here's one from a deal look at this
oh nice you got the lines to work
fantastic
beautiful
wow very nice very nice ideal um would
you mind like walking through how you
did this here oh sure yeah uh it's um
it's
yeah so it's basically using um trying
to make use of the path element to
connect all the circles up
and
so that yeah d3 has this um
a line generator which will uh convert
all the data points into
the
string that gets passed to
the d attribute which is uh
which is part of the path element
um
so um
yeah this was really just an experiment
to see if i could get it to work
and uh so i i would be very keen to find
out whether there's a better way of
doing this but like for for example
combining uh everything in one
method chain
um
but uh my first pass was just to try and
think about it separately and then
use the
the join method um
to
handle all the uh
uh
yeah syncing up all the dom elements
with all the data
um
and uh yeah but that line generator is
is really awesome because it just
generates that complicated
d
string
right
um
you know what's happening here is it's
creating a path
for each and every
element of the array
and so for however many circles there
are
there are
an equal number of paths
that are all on top of each other
ah yes so if you inspect the dom you'll
you'll actually see a many many paths
and that's why the line appears somewhat
uh harsh like thick if the anti-aliasing
around it
is not quite right that's because
there's maybe you know ten or five
lines on top of each other
let me just quickly
fork this and and
you know
give you my take on on how to do this
so instead of using
data here
we can just use an element with a single
sorry we can we can just use an array
with a single element
and see now that line is not so thick as
it was
because now there's only one of them
and it doesn't matter what this thing is
you could have it be null or whatever
because you know none of these functions
access it
because d is always a line generator of
data it's not a it's not a function of
the this element in this array
so this is
um
actually something i was hoping to get
to in the last episode which is namely
the special case
the special case of a single element
and this is a perfect example of it you
know where there's just a path you only
want to have one of these path elements
but it's driven by data that could have
many elements but it's actually just one
path
if you wanted to have do it a different
way where you had maybe line elements
multiple line elements
then you would you know use
an array as data with many elements but
since it's just one path
this this
approach works perfectly well and i
would say this is sort of you know the
optimal way to do it
to use a path
and have that path
use these multiple lines
so
yeah great work i feel
that's really really good to know yeah i
that that's that that's uh it makes a
lot more sense now just to have the one
element in the
uh being passed to the data method that
that makes sense nice
thank you thank you very much yeah my
pleasure
all right that's it for the exercise
submissions
all right that's it for a review of last
week's exercises let's get into ways to
include javascript in
html
for this i will start
invis hub
i'll create a viz from the
hello html starter
i'll fork this one and call it
js in
html okay so this example
i'll just clear out the readme
this example already has
some javascript
and this is
the most straightforward
you know maybe simplest
way
to include javascript in an html page
you use a script tag and then inside of
that script tag
you can put arbitrary javascript
but as you see when we write a lot of
code
it ends up
uh
getting very large
and there may be more stuff in
index.html and then pretty soon you're
at like 100 lines 200 lines 500 lines
in my various work i've seen
i've seen you know html files that are a
thousand lines or 2 000 lines of code
which is just um
it's unwieldy
so
there becomes a need to split the files
up
so here's one way to split the files up
you can take the javascript
create a new file
let's i don't know i'll call it uh
script
dot js just as a
silly example name
and then we can remove
the stuff in that script tag there
but notice that it's not running
now this script is not doing anything
because it's not included into
the html of the page
to include it
into the page
we can use the src attribute of the
script tag so we can say src equals
script
dot js
and now it runs
it loads
and all this stuff works without any
build tools
the issue with this approach
which by the way used to be the approach
years ago
in sort of the early years of javascript
for a very long time
the status quo was you know this is how
you include a library
on your page and this is how you include
your script files on the page
but what would happen
is that over time
you would end up with
many
script files
on the page you know script one script
two
like this
and then
you would need to manually keep track of
which script depends on which other
script
so you know for example if in script one
you want you want to refer to a global
variable introduced by script 3
then you would need to rearrange these
such that they're in
the right order so everything has its
dependencies
and the algorithm to do such ordering is
called topological sorting
um
so i i think in like rails ruby on rails
you can specify
which script depends on which other
script and then there's some utility
that calculates the correct ordering and
automatically generates the script tags
but that all is sort of
um in the past
because in modern times there's this
thing called
es6
modules
anita says that's so deep
yeah feel free to speak with sound it's
fine
this is you know how one option
of a way to work
but let me let me show you how it looks
with es6 modules
in vishub
you can use a special name
called index.js
this is a special
name of a file that vishub specifically
looks for
and so if you
if you define an index.js
see vishub automatically created
this file that you you're not allowed to
edit called bundle.js
this is
a bundle
created by
rollup
internally within vis hub so inside of
the vis hub software it actually loads
in roll up
which is an amazing tool for for
generating
bundles
and what a bundle is
is
it's a it's a file that combines many
modules together
here's what es6 modules
look like you can say import
something
from
i'll say dot slash
um
something
dot js
and we can create this file called
something.js and in here we can export
something
equals i'll just define it as a string
a thing
so you can use export
before the the keyword const
to export a named
well it's called a named export
whatever variable you have locally you
can export it with a name
and then if you have named exports you
can import them with this syntax
let's use that by saying instead of
hello javascript hello plus
something
whatever something is
it should appear
and now it says hello
a thing
all right so that's generally
how you author es6 modules let's take a
look at bundle.js to see what it's done
here rollup
has actually combined
index.js and something.js together
into a single
file
here's the content of something and
here's the content of
index.js
so
bundle.js makes
basically index.js with everything
included
bundle.js is automatically generated
from
index.js
everything that index.js imports
is included in bundle.js and also
the things that are imported by the
things that are imported
by
index.js are also included in bundle.js
so something.js could also
you know import
um
thing
from
dot slash thing dot js just making stuff
up here
and then that could say
uh
plus
thing
and then we can make another file
thing.js
equals
thing
planet earth
sure
so that allows us to author this module
that defines this named export
called thing
which we we can import in something.js
and use
and something.js
in turn exports
the named export called something which
is imported in index.js which is used
there
and then
the cumulative output is hello uh
planet earth
and if we look at bundle.js
all of those various modules are
included
inside of bundle.js
so bundle.js is totally separate file
it is
yes
yep
yeah
and we if we name we have to name
index.js
as index.js expanding
correct
correct because um
the viz hub
roll up configuration that it uses
internally looks for a file called
index.js
yeah
so what role do the curly braces play
the ones that wrap
something in this case
oh that's a great question this is the
distinction between named exports and
default exports
with named exports you could
you could import multiple named exports
from an es6 module
and here's an example
let me just see this through
we can use both of these
and then in something.js we can say
export
const
something else
other
when you use this form of exporting
export const
you could also use export
function
this is valid syntax
you could also use let export let
something these are the various ways you
can use named exports and with named
exports the key thing is that you can
export multiple things that have names
so now we can see that the output
is hello uh planet earth
other
that's named exports
if you don't use
the curly braces
like this
right now we get an error that says
default is not exported
if you don't use the curly braces it
uses what's called the default export
this is
this is the case where you want a module
to export only one thing
so if we modify
some
this
if we modify something.js
we can
use the default export
like this i believe export default
something
this will expose
the variable in this file which is
called something
as the default export
and by the way you can have
a default export as well as
named exports
let me just show you what that would
look like
like this
so if we don't export something
we export something else
and then we export default
something
check this out in index.js we can import
something which is the default export
and
something else
as a named export
and we can use that here
like this
and it still works
and you'll often see this uh with react
if you end up using react
react
uppercase react is the default export of
react but then there's a lot of named
exports from react like use effect
stuff like that
that's an example
where you would see this sort of stuff
in the wild
does it have something like that what
default modules and sorry what was that
d3 does d3 have d3
well
i believe
it does not i believe it only uses named
exports
which is a really good segue
let's check it out
so in vishub
you can include a script tag so here's
here's
here's the d3 library hosted on
unpackage
which is a content delivery network
that hosts npm packages
all right and npm
is this
giant
database of
packages
with all of their different versions
um it's a package manager for javascript
and it's sort of the de facto package
manager so all this is to say
let's let's load in d3 onto our page
using unpackage
by going to unpackage.com d3
and if we just go to onpackage.com d3
and hit enter it automatically resolves
to the latest version of d3 which at the
time
happens to be 6.6.2
and this is the minified
build of d3 which contains all of the
different
modules
that are part of d3
so i'm going to copy this url
and then over in index.js
i'm going to
insert a script tag
and
set the source
equal to
that
url and this is how
cdns content delivery networks or
content distribution networks
are intended to be used
at this point
in our javascript
we can say console.log
d3
and it should work see
that script tag defines d3
as a global variable this is called a
browser global
and this is one way it's like sort of
the old school way of using libraries
insert a script tag that pulls it from a
cdn or you could pull down d3 to your
files and load it from your files either
way
and then access the global variable that
it defines
this is one way of doing things
this is not using es6 modules at all
not at all this is this is an older way
before there were es6 modules that's
called browser globals
so you could say d3.select
that resolves to a function
d3 dot
you know scale linear
all this stuff
so
[Music]
d3 is object
and each module
is property correct
yes
values of functions
yep
that's
correct that's great yeah using
the d3 browser global
you could say that yes d when you
include
this script tag here that defines d3
that
introduces a single global variable into
the you know global namespace
of javascript
that's called d3 so that's a variable
called d3
and the value of that variable is
an object
and on that object you can see all the
methods of d3
listed out here
and this is great because
when this program runs it just pulls in
javascript from that cdn
and it doesn't cost us anything meaning
i don't have to host d3
inside of this hub or anything like that
it's just when you load the page it
pulls that from that unpackaged server
which i have no control over it's you
know totally not my thing
this is why
this is sort of the preferred way of
using libraries invis hub in particular
and i want to say
the vishhub rollup configuration has a
mapping for d3
as a package
so
that's what lets us do import
select
from
d3 like this
and then we can say console.log
d3
whoops
there is no d3 dot anymore it's just
select because we've imported select a
named export
from d3
and it resolves to the right thing
this is slightly mysterious
right it's there's a little bit of black
magic going on here with the roll up
configuration
roll up has this
this feature
where you can tell it to resolve package
names to browser globals
so somewhere in the configuration
internally in viz hub that you don't see
right now
there's a mapping that says okay if you
try to import from
d3
without the dot slash so it's not
looking for a local file
it's looking for a package
called d3
if you do that then
look for the browser global called d3
and resolve all the named exports
to properties on that browser global
this is a really nice configuration of
rollup
that allows us
to use this really nice es6 import
syntax for packages
and at the same time
pull in the script tag from a cdn
now let's take a look at bundle.js
for this case
oops
bundle.js
is
wrapped up into this
this one expression
right so it doesn't create any global
variables it's very self-contained
it defines a function
and inside of that function is all of
our code from all of our modules that
we've authored
and that function is immediately invoked
with
d3
which is
not defined
anywhere in this file
because
there's an assumption that it will be
defined
as a browser global and that's why all
this works
uh let me show you
um
actually there's a little bit of magic
as well where
vishub is injecting a script tag at the
end of the body that includes bundle.js
script src equals
bundle.js and if we have it there then
it is not automatically injected
so i want us i want to show you that
if we include d3 after bundle.js
it doesn't work
i wanted to do this to cement this idea
that bundle.js when it runs it assumes
that there's a browser global called d3
and inside of
any html
when you have a script tag
that script tag is fully loaded
parsed and executed
before
the next script tag
in the list
so what's happening here
is
bundle.js is looking for d3
it's not there
and we get an error but if we reorder
this to include
the script before
bundle.js then
it all works
so it is a
hierarchical
i mean in a sense that bundle.js depends
on
d3
yes
but the data structure is not actually a
tree it's not a hierarchy it's actually
a graph it's actually a directed acyclic
graph if you want to get into the weeds
yes
knows which one comes first right right
yeah internally
roll up
i mean if you have this dependency graph
of modules
rollup knows internally that
the stuff in thing must come before the
stuff in something because something
imports from thing and also it knows
that this stuff in something must come
before the stuff in index.js
inside bundle.js so that's why it has
done this correct ordering using the
topological sort algorithm
internally
nice so in virtual world also the things
are hierarchical
sure
i see there was a question here from
sriram
is roll up
comparable to npm or yarn
what's the what's the difference between
a package manager and a module
bundler yeah i mean
they're at different levels
of this hierarchy
in a sense
npm
is
it's a company actually that makes money
and it's a bunch of servers that exist
out there in some cloud
somewhere
that's what npm is and it's a set of
scripts and tools that allow people to
publish modules into npm and also to get
modules out of
npm
and so what we're using here is npm
as well as unpackage which is another
another product in inside of the
ecosystem of npm
to pull this script down
and
npm
confusingly is also a command line
tool
where you can say npm install npm run
npm this npm that
and there's an alternative command line
tool to the npm command line tool that's
called yarn
and yarn is
arguably more efficient faster better
but it also pulls
the packages out of the npm
package manager database system
cloud thing so in a sense you know npm
and yarn are not that different they're
pretty much equivalent tools
and rollup
is a module bundler and rollup has peers
in this ecosystem like webpack
parcel
snowpack recently
but roll up is pretty nice
yeah so
the difference between a package manager
and a module bundler
is a package manager is a repository of
packages but a module bundler is just a
tool it's actually a package within npm
rollup is also a package inside of npm
um and then when you run rollup on your
stuff locally it pulls the packages that
are
that are installed locally using npm and
generates a bundle so it's all kind of
kind of this big hairball of stuff which
is why it's confusing
uh shariram says npm and unpackage are
sort of like cdns for code
in a way in a way i mean
the cdn
is
is essentially a wrapper around
npm
this unpackaged cdn and on package
itself
is more akin to a
a library like a physical library where
you go to get books like when you
publish an npm package it's like you're
putting a new book in the library
and when you're pulling it out it's like
you're
you're you're asking them to mail you a
copy of the book i don't know
maybe it's not the right metaphor but
yeah i hope that clarifies things
current uh going back to the
the default exports and the named
exports yeah is there um
uh are they
are they used in different situations uh
is is there a
a general
uh advantage to using
named exports over default and vice
versa
is something there's some general
guideline around that
that one could keep in mind
if you google named exports versus
default exports
there are a lot of people that have very
strong opinions
about this stuff
and like here why i've stopped exporting
defaults from my javascript
and this is actually the philosophy that
i adhere to
there's a lot of issues
with default exports
often i've seen
in the in the module that has a default
export
internal to that module that export is
named
something
or not not exactly
something but it's it has a particular
name and then in the in the module that
imports it
it's imported with a different name
which is super confusing
that's the that's the one big drawback i
see of of using default exports they
don't dictate what name you use so you
could actually say import
it
which is the default
and then we could use it
like this
and it still works
so um
yeah actually this cropped up in the
vis-hub code base
where
the names don't match and then when
you're navigating the code base it makes
it super confusing because you have to
remember okay it's called this inside
the module and it's called this outside
the module
and it's just it just makes things super
confusing so i personally
tend to always
only use named exports and imports in
the code that i author
uh but there's pros and cons
for sure i mean react has chosen to use
the default export of react
which makes sense for that case i think
um so there are cases where you know
using a default export makes sense
in a way
uh but yeah that's my personal take on
it and so all the code that i authored
today in my you know
work with clients and everything
i strictly just use named exports
and that's it
no default exports
yeah that makes sense to me i think i'll
follow that
nice
i see there's a bunch of chatter in the
youtube chat so let me get caught up
on that
guitar covers oh i think i addressed
this is bundle.js used there in index.js
yes um it's there now because i added it
if it's not there vis hub does some
magic and it inserts that exact thing
so that's that's what's happening there
and then
yeah you can give the default export of
a module any name when you're importing
it that's true that's true that's why
it's confusing
how is index.js included
since i don't see it in index.html oh
yeah it's the confusing blackmagic part
where vishub injects
exactly this thing
automatically if it's not there
you know the intention is to make it
easier to use but it's sort of cryptic
and strange
if you don't know that's happening
try out vite sometime as a bundler
yeah
vite
i heard about this like
last week for the first time i feel like
an old man i can't keep up with his
stuff
so fight is another one
um
yeah it looks cool
looks cool
see the thing with all of this stuff is
the intention of vite
webpack roll up
snowpack
parcel the intention of all that stuff
is to make it easy and straightforward
to author your code
so that you don't need to think about or
deal with all complexities of generating
a bundle including the bundle into your
html
and all that stuff
we've discussed how to use stuff in
vishub and es6 modules now i want to
talk about how to set a project up
locally
so
let's start by
exporting
out of this
there's this export feature
what it gives you is
a zip file
that has a bunch of files
so i'll open up a terminal
i'm on linux here
i'll go to my
my place where i put code called repos
short for repositories
uh
i'll just make a directory called
example
which is empty
um
and as you do this stuff
you know your setup your mileage may
vary i mean i'm very comfortable with
the command line and everything but you
may want to use gui you may be in
windows you may be in mac
so
the place where we're going
is fraught with peril because everybody
has a different setup a different system
different ide text editor that you use
vs code is most popular i think nowadays
but i like to use vim
doesn't matter
once we have this
zip file
we can hit extract
and i'm going to extract it to
repos
example
i'll hit extract
show the files
in here we have
index.html
index.js
bundle.js which was generated by vishub
we've got the readme markdown file
and these are all just text files
we have something.js and thing.js
and we have a few more things that are
not visible at all in vishub
we have a package.json
and a rollup.config.js
let's dig into these
i'm going to use vim you can use
whatever ide you prefer like vs code
to look at the files
package.json
is a file that defines your dependencies
and it's a whole
it's a whole thing
that has a lot of very well defined
aspects to it
the npm documentation for package.json
is the canonical
documentation
for everything that you could put in
package.json
this whole concept of package.json has
come out of
npm
essentially it's a way for npm to track
dependencies
and if you define a package that you
want to publish to npm you need a
package.json to specify
the name
the version
description keywords home page all this
stuff
but if
and the license you can specify in here
which open source license
all sorts of things but if you're not
publishing a package per se
the main thing that we use it for is for
dependencies
it just maps
package name to aversion range and this
is using semver semantic versioning
and this is
what you'd want to research if you get
interested in
you know how exactly these versions are
specified what the carrot means
all this stuff
here we have a very simple
small
package.json that says okay we have dev
dependencies
meaning
they're not dependencies of this package
if it were to be published but it's
dependencies that you need if you're
running a development environment
locally
what this means
is that
if you run
npm install
in this directory that has this
particular package.json
it will
use that package.json to figure out what
it needs to install and then after it
installs that stuff it appears in this
directory called
node underscore modules
node underscore modules let's see what
it contains it has all this stuff these
are
our direct dependencies
including rollup and
another package
called at roll up slash
plugin dash buble
and we can see those here it's got roll
up
and it has
at roll up
and i think the slash
um
there's stuff inside of there that we're
using
but what are all these other packages
right
these are the transitive dependencies of
our dependencies
a transitive dependency is
essentially a dependency of a dependency
if we look at rollup for example
and
we're still inside node modules
if we look at the package.json file of
the rollup package
it contains a bunch of dependencies
dev dependencies in particular so all
this stuff is pulled in
and each of these dependencies
has other dependencies
so all the dependencies of dependencies
of dependencies of dependencies are
pulled in
and what we end up in
node modules with is this list of all
the transitive dependencies
so this is how you set up a project
locally essentially you
you run npm install
that uses package.json to install these
dependencies
now
the dependency
that we're really using is a rollup
and we're also using buble
to support jsx
which we don't actually need here
we don't actually need it here but if we
want to author react code with jsx we
would need buble so i'm actually just
going to delete this i'm going to start
iterating this configuration
locally which i would i would suggest
you do
because the viz hub export is just
sort of a generic simple
export
that makes it so you can
generate bundle.js by yourself outside
of vishub
here's bundle.js
what i'm going to do is delete this file
so if i use rm
there is no longer any file called
bundle.js
and then
if we look again at package.json
it has a scripts field
and in that scripts field there's a key
called build
and the way that the scripts field works
with package.json is that you can say
npm run
followed by the name of a script in
which in this case the name is called
build
and there are sort of conventional names
like npm run build generates the bundle
across all various
tools there's also npm run start
which is equivalent to npm start which
is set up for a lot with a lot of these
templates but it's not set up here
there's no script here called start
because this is just a very minimal
simple
configuration that's aimed toward
the minimal possible thing that you need
to generate bundle.js
if we run npm run build
it invokes rollup
because that's what the script is
defined to do rollup dash c
and then
it creates
bundle.js from index.js
so this is how you can create bundle.js
locally
in your
own machine outside of vishhub
the dash c of rollup means use the
rollup configuration file found in
rollup.config.js
let's take a look at that
this is where
that mapping exists between the external
packages
and all of this stuff is sort of
pre-programmed
into vishub
we don't actually need
any of it except d3
so i'm going to delete all that junk we
don't need and here's the mapping from
the browser globals to the package names
or rather the other way around from
package name to browser global
again we just need d3 because that's the
only one we're using
i mean i would like to imp there's a lot
of things to improve with vishub like
ideally it shouldn't include any of this
stuff that you don't need but this is
the state of things at the moment
it also uses this buble plugin to
transpile jsx
but we don't actually need that so i'm
going to delete that
and yeah here is an interesting use of
default exports you could just say
export default
and boom put it put an object literal
right there it doesn't even have a name
this is this is an es6 module that
defines the role of config
so now if we if we run that build script
again it still works
it generates bundle.js
and there it is bundle.js
how would you run this locally
if you wanted to actually develop
well you need to use an http server
to serve the file locally
you could maybe get away with not doing
that
by just double clicking on index.html
yeah in this case it works
but
as soon as you introduce any code that
uses
xmlhttprequest
or fetch to fetch data
that fetching of data uses the http
protocol so
you need to be hosting it with a with an
http http server locally
let me just quickly show you how i would
do that
my go-to tool for that is
http dash server
which is an npm package so you can say
npm install
dash g to make it a global command
that's available to you http
dash server
and then you can run
http dash server just like that as a
command
and boom it's created this server that's
now running
so you can go to this url here
and it's serving your page
127.0.0.1
this is a special ip address that is
equivalent to
local
host
local host colon 8080 the 8080 is the
port number
that's a sort of conventional port
number that's used
that's how you can set up
things locally
and then
once you start developing you get into
this loop this development loop this
cycle
check it out our code is running um
there's something about a fav icon file
yeah the browser when it loads a page it
always looks for this thing called
favicon
favicon i don't know how to pronounce it
but that's the little icon that appears
in the tab
so that's what that error means it
doesn't it doesn't really it's not
important but that's what it means
if you wanted to customize the little
icon that appears in the tab
you would have to introduce a
favicon
file
but anyway
let's say we wanted to change
some of this code
and oh check it out here's the log from
http server
every time
we fetch the page it outputs something
to this log
let's say we wanted to change this text
from hello to greetings
if i change it
and then i save this file oh wait a
minute i'm editing bundle.js that's a
big no no we don't want to be editing
bundle.js because it's an automatically
generated file
so
um
here's what i typically do is
npm run build
that generates bundle.js
it's the same it was as it was before it
says hello because it was derived from
index.js which we should be authoring
and changing
let's say we wanted to change hello to
greetings
if i save this file
and then i refresh this page
it does not
get
our change
because
this page is using
bundle.js not index.js
in order to update bundle.js we need to
manually run this script
called npm run build
now if we go and refresh the page it
says
hello
uh planet earth uh oh
there's like something wrong here
this is called caching
if you hit shift and hit the refresh
button
now it says greetings
because it when you hit shift refresh it
disables the cache the browser cache the
browser cache is a thing
that
it uses an older version of the file
that you that you got and it's for you
know efficiency on the internet uh if
you loaded an image
yesterday
and then you go to the same page that
uses that same image and that image is
on your machine in the cache then the
browser will use it and not fetch the
image again it's it's a way to conserve
bandwidth
so this is another sort of thing that
you would run into with local
development
is the cache and in the network tab of
the chrome dev tools you can click a
little box that says disable cache
which is something i would recommend
doing
because then you won't have to use shift
clicking the refresh button it'll just
never use the cache
alright so
this is
how you can set up a local development
environment and it basically works
however
you don't get the automatic refresh
stuff
which is which is nice to have i mean in
invis hub if you make a change it
automatically generates bundle.js and
re-runs the program for you
instantly
this setup here does not does not do
that
if you want to do that that's where
you get into these project templates
and so roll up starter app
would let you do that
oh but before i get into that are there
any questions
so far
guess not
roll up starter app is a more fully
fledged
project template if we take a look at
the package.json here it has more
scripts besides build
it has
start
which does the serving for you the http
server stuff is built into this
it has
build which is our same thing we had
roll up dash c it also has watch
what watch will do is automatically
rebuild your bundle every time the
source changes
the source code changes
and then there's
dev as a script which is what we would
want to use during development we would
say npm run dev
and
what this does is it starts
these two scripts in in parallel using
this package called npm run all
parallel so it runs start
which serves
the stuff on an http server and it also
runs watch
and i believe this package called serv
which is a
dev dependency here
it i believe it does that automatic
refresh
but i don't know let's let's give it a
try let's give it a spin
so how do we use this
what i want to do
is
i think clone this repository using git
i'll call it example roll up starter
and then i can run get clone
oops
i should just copy this here it already
has the git clone
run this
this uses git
to
make a copy of all these files for me
locally
it's inside a directory called
rollupstarter app
which i guess is fine so in here i can
run npm
install
or just npm i which is
shorthand for npm install
that will install the dependencies
and then we can run
npm run
dev
and it gives us this nice little
output okay it's running on localhost
let's roll up starter app
excellent
and then the development
workflow
looks something like
we don't open up these files
and this is these are the files from the
starter app it's like
just
their version of hello world
we could
put our code in here
um that's probably that's the way to do
it if if you want to like
really start
a new project based on something
in
vishub probably the thing to do is just
copy your files into one of these
starter apps
notice how this roll-up config is
slightly different it looks for
src
main.js as the entry point instead of
index.js like ours does
yeah and it has a couple more plugins
to resolve
npm packages and this is something i
want to get into
all right
so i'm going to gut
these
files and put our own files in there
i'll remove this update.js
and then main.js
i will replace it with the code that we
wrote earlier
so here's our index.js i'm just going to
copy that over to here
and then we need
something.js
so i'll make a new file
called something.js
and then i'll just copy this
code into there
and then we also need
thing.js
so i'll make a new file called src slash
thing dot js
and then
copy our code
into there
save all these files
and let's see what happened
in our
window where we're we're running npm run
dev
we have a couple of warnings here it
says unresolved dependencies
oh no
d3 is imported by src
main.js
and yeah the bundle has not been updated
the problem here is that we don't have
d3 as a dependency here
now here comes the main difference
between what vis-hub does and what
people usually do
in projects
usually
instead of
pulling in libraries from a cdn with a
browser global usually people add it as
a dependency in their package.json and
then the bundle contains that entire
library
let's see how that plays out
what we want to do is add to this
dependencies
d3 at a specific version
but rather than hand edit this file
what we can do
is run a command
called npm
install
dash dash save this will update bundle
uh sorry
this will update package.json and it
will add that new dependencies
the new
this will update
package.json
and include
whatever we type here as a new
dependency at the latest version
so if i run npm install dash dash save
d3
it will figure out the latest version
and add it
to our dependencies section and it will
also install it in
node underscore modules
now if we look at package.json it has d3
version 6.6.2
all right
let me restart this i don't know if it
catches that if i change it like that
oh there's some warning about circular
dependencies with d3 yeah that's a
long-standing issue but it's just a
warning it's fine
it created a bundle.js
let's take a look at bundle.js i'm quite
curious to see
what it looks like now
it's in the public directory
public by the way is a conventional
directory name for the stuff that gets
served over http
that's where our index.js is and that's
where our bundle is
now
inside of this version of bundle.js
um
i forgot how to turn on line numbers in
vim
one moment
oh yes
okay
in this version of bundle.js
let's see how big it is how many lines
it's massive
it's huge
look we're only you know ten percent of
the way in 300 lines
so what three three thousand lines of
code
this is because
all of d3
is included now inside of our bundle.js
vishub does not do this
because it would be a huge waste of
storage
and
compute time and everything
but
as a standard practice nowadays you know
if you have for your own project this is
typically what folks do you know all the
dependencies
get included inside of bundle.js
which introduces the need for
minification
uh minification is when
this stuff is sort of compacted the
variable names are given nonsense names
that are just one character or two
um
and the idea with minification is to get
the size of the bundle down
i'm just curious what how big is this
bundle
if we take a look at these files we can
see that bundle.js here is
76 kilobytes
so that's
you know that's what happens when your
dependencies get in there and as you add
more and more dependencies this bundle
gets to be
you know 500 kilobytes
a megabyte two megabytes
um so you got to be careful when you
just you know
add dependencies willy-nilly
but
anyway
when we look at the web page now
it says roll up starter app
i'm not sure why
oh perhaps because
i did not in i didn't update index.html
yeah we're still using their
version of this
and notice
in the rollup starter app version of
this they also have script source equals
bundle.js
it's sort of a standard convention
as the last step
i'm going to replace that with our
version
of index.html
copy all this stuff that we had from
earlier
put it into index.html
however
we no longer need to pull in d3 from
unpackage because it's
installed
locally and it's included inside of
bundle.js so i'm going to delete that
now if we look at this page it says
hello html
and it has our greetings
here
and it also resolves the d3
stuff to the correct thing
all right this is how you can
essentially bootstrap a local project
for development
yep
that's it any any questions
and does this uh also
refresh the page every time you make a
change oh good question
let's see
if i change index.html
and save it
it does not
no so we need to manually refresh
but i wonder
is it set up so that when we edit the
code
it reruns
let's just change something
here
other thing
no it does not it automatically
generates the bundle but it does not
automatically
refresh the page
hmm
i don't think let me just try again
make a change save it
no
it automatically generates the bundle
but does not automatically
refresh the page
okay at this point if you wanted to add
that
we can start researching
about that sort of thing but it's a
whole
it's a whole can of worms really
there are other starters
um for example the webpack
dev server
um
i was hoping to go through this today
but we don't have time we're at time
here
webpack is a great alternative to rollup
and it has this thing called
the the webpack dev server which does
exactly this sort of re automatic
refreshing of the page
and automatic generating of the bundle
so i would encourage you if you're
interested to go through the docs
of webpack
they seem to have a very nice
getting started section
where was that
it's in here somewhere
but yeah it's it's a similar kind of
configuration to the rollup config where
there's an entry and then there's output
it's not exactly the same as rollup but
it's you know the same in spirit
webpack i think is uh
perhaps more widely used
than rollup
for projects
for you know
applications however rollup is very
popular for libraries because it has
this efficiency around
only including the code that you need
which is called tree shaking
but anyway
i would like to leave you all with an
exercise for this week
export something you made
in vishub
put it in a github repository
um
unfortunately i didn't cover that today
but you know try to figure it out
and then adopt a build tool roll up
maybe go through the same process i did
or try webpack
or try a newer tool like parcel or
snowpack or
what was that other one that was
suggested today
i don't even remember
what was that one
invite
invite yeah
yeah
yeah maybe try out invite
and uh
yeah i i hope this has clarified
the question of
how do i work outside of vis hub
all right i think we'll well i think
we're pretty much done any any any less
questions or discussion points
if i have to if i want to do the local
development then should i
start with roll up only
i would suggest it that's actually my go
to
tool
it seems to work extremely well
uh but
maybe webpack
is for you i mean
totally up to you and some of these new
ones
like snowpla snowpack or vite you know
they claim to be even better
than
whatever else is there web packet roll
up so it's um
it's wide open territory
it's average it's an ever-changing
landscape where things are coming and
going people things are hot things are
things are cold you know so it's
it's really a jungle out there and
i've sort of reached the end of what i
can
recommend because honestly i haven't
really kept up with this whole space
so it's an you know trial and error and
just try a bunch of things and see what
works
yeah i think i think what i'll do is
extend this to next week
well actually i should tell you all next
week is cancelled
the 17th is canceled but i'll resume
these streams on the 24th
24th i think that's a saturday
and i think it would be worth going
through setting up a github repository
and maybe walking through
using webpack to bootstrap a project
and as always i welcome any input
or suggestions for things to talk about
but then yeah after this we could get
into more of the visual stuff d3 making
different visualizations and so on
all right thanks everyone for joining
today
i'll uh
see you on the 24th and beyond
thank you
my pleasure
very useful thank you
testing
productizing a could base
this is
part of get it right in black and white
but it's a little different because it's
just me working on this stuff
and this is work i was going to do
anyway
so why not put it in the series this
work is about
exporting something that you built invis
hub out of vishub putting it into a
github repository which is where people
you know generally put code and
deploying it with github pages
also this particular work happens to do
some data processing in node js so we'll
touch upon that as well
this is the thing that i built it's a
stream graph of d3 activity for the past
10 years
i'm not going to talk at all about how
this works
but you know think of it as a black box
code base that we're going to get out of
this hub
and
sort of productize you know make it a a
real open source product
i'll start by exporting these files
and we get this zip file that has a
bunch of files in it
but where should we put this stuff we
should put it in a git repository let's
make one of those
in github i'm going to click on this
little plus and create new repository
i'll call it something like
get
history
stream graph
i'll make it public
add a readme
choose a license i'll make it mit
create repository
all right we've got this empty
repository i'm going to copy this text
so that in our terminal
we can go to where the repositories are
and use git clone
and paste that url
to clone that down
whoops the directory already exists
let me try that again
and now it's working
i'm in a linux terminal by the way this
is my typical working environment
git is installed you might have to stop
and install git on your machine
rm means remove
uh the dash f means force
and the dash r means recursive
and git clone is the command that you
use to make a copy of all the stuff in
the git repository on your machine
now that that's there we can cd into
that directory cd means change directory
and then ls meaning list
all the files there
and i like to use vim as my editor
with nerd tree
that lets you see all the files
so this is this license is a mit
template
and this readme is a blank readme
i think i'll start this work by just
referencing all the input sources in the
readme
this project aims to
visualize get history as stream graphs
it draws from the following
previous work
namely
and this is where i'll drop a link to
this thing here d3
get history stream graph
and i'll make that a link in markdown
that goes to that url
this one here i'll copy it and paste it
right in there
and this one refers to
this thing that's in github gist right
now which is a set of
node scripts that are forked from
original work by ian johnson he actually
figured out
how to do this how to get the data of
commits out of a git repository and into
a csv file
so i'll link to this one
as well
ian johnson's set of scripts to pull the
git history
and i'll make that a link to
this url right here
okay i'm going to write the file and
quit vim
and now i'm going to make the first
commit
git status dash s
is how you see
what the status is
git diff is how you can tell what
changed
git add
makes sure that all the
changes you made are sort of staged to
be added to a commit
and then git commit dash m
add links to readme
and then finally get push
get push
will push up the changes that you made
into the repository in github
so back in github if we refresh the page
we should see this new stuff
the language of the readme file by the
way is markdown it renders to html and
looks like this so now you see these are
links
but in the original
text
you know this this big heading is just a
hash
and
you can make the bulleted list
with these asterisks
all right now that we've got this far
i'm going to start by pulling in those
node scripts and then after that's done
we'll pull in the
the front end code that makes the
visualization
here's my fork of ian johnson's gist
which has been modified to remove bulky
commit message data
and to also publish the combined file
to adjust
and by the way that that stream graph
thing it pulls the data from
this gist
to add these files to the git repository
i'm going to start by cloning
this gist
i'm going to clone it
as a peer
directory
with git clone and then i'll paste that
url for the gist
okay it's already there on my machine
i'll just do a git pull to make sure i
have the latest and i do
okay so we have a bunch of files here
the main things i'm interested in are
these javascript files so i'm just going
to say
copy everything that ends with js over
to
our get history stream graph
directory
then i'll go back to that directory take
a look okay everything moved over
at this point i know we're going to have
a bunch of files eventually so i want to
start to organize them these files are
the data processing scripts
which will be i think in a different
directory than like the frontend code so
i'm going to make that directory now
i'm going to make a new directory called
data processing
scripts
and then i'll move over
all those javascript files
into that directory
now our directory looks something like
this
where we have
a bunch of javascript files and a readme
and a license at the top level
at this point i'll make another commit
oh before that i have to add
all these files
and then i'll make a commit that says
add
data processing
scripts
and get push
at this point the main focus is just to
get all the code into the repository so
i'm not even going to run these scripts
i'm going to refactor and massage that
stuff later but for now the goal is to
get the viz running and publish it with
github pages
to that end
i'm going to extract
the stuff from our zip file
our vishub export
into
this directory
by clicking on extract
scratch that
and navigating to that directory
and i think i'll make a new directory
actually
scratch that
and i think i'll make a new directory
called vishub export
just to keep everything totally separate
for now
i'll hit extract
show the files and there they are
okay great now we have our vishab export
i'll make a commit
but first i have to get ad
okay i'll push this up
okay the main thing that's missing at
this point is the data itself the data
is currently hosted in a gist and the
viz pulls it down from that gist
but as we're unifying things we'd like
to make
the visualization code pull the data
from this repository somewhere
scratch that whole segment
now that everything is there we should
just be able to turn on github pages and
get that whole hosting working
for that i can go back to the repository
which now contains
vishub export
and inside there there's an index.html
that should work if we just host it
with github pages which we can enable
in the settings
of the repository
we can just scroll down and find
pages
by default it's disabled but we can just
turn it on and say all right host the
main branch at the root and click save
now it says your site is ready to be
published at this url here
and now we just need to modify that path
to go to
slash vishub export slash
index.html i think
if i just paste that in it's going to
work
not quite yet
it says
it's the site is currently being built i
guess it might take some time
okay i just refreshed and boom there it
is
all right that's how you can export
something out of this hub and put it
into a github repository and then enable
hosting with github pages
from here on out i'm just gonna massage
this code base to be
coherent and clean
and also make it so that the viz pulls
the data from the repository
as it gets generated
in this repository
the first thing i'm going to focus on is
whipping these uh node scripts
into shape currently they're kind of a
mess they create github repository they
create git repositories
as peers of the source files which is
not quite right
so if i open up the editor
go into data processing scripts
there's a bunch of different scripts
that do different things this one clones
all the d3 repositories from
dependencies
and then you run this knife sv thing
that generates a bunch of files
json which converts those files to json
and then combine which combines all of
those together
into a single file
ideally we would just have one script
that we could run so let me start there
and see where it goes
i'll make a new file called index.js
under data processing scripts
and this will be the main
thing that runs so first we clone the
repositories
convert to knife
sv files
convert to json files
and combine
the output file
since this is node
i'm just going to use
require
rather than import
if we say require dot slash clone
that should pull in the stuff from this
clone
file over here
i'll call it clone when we import it
but the thing is this is currently a
script
that runs
so instead of just running a script
i'm going to define a function called
clone
which is a function that just goes
through each of the dependencies and
clones them
and then in node we can export it by
saying module dot exports
equals clone
now we can just proof that this is
working by saying console.log
clone it should output a function
and then i'll make a new
terminal
window here
navigate to the data processing scripts
directory and then run it node
index.js
okay it's looking for d3s
package.json
yeah those scripts assume that the d3
repositories is cloned
but that's not really the case
so i'm just going to take this
package.json and drop it
into our
repository
i'll call it d3package.json
create that file
paste the content
and then i believe it's this depends
thing that is pulling in that file
let's change this path to be d3
package.json
and see if it works now
okay worked we got a function great
now this clone function itself
just runs
get clone and so
um
you know i'm not even sure where
these would end up
let's run it and find out
in index.js we can actually run
that function
so when i run this
let's do a bunch of stuff i'm going to
stop it before it gets too far
and now see there are all these d3
repositories right here
in the same directories all the source
files which is kind of a mess
so i'm just going to delete
all those
remove everything that starts with d3
dash
because i want to keep d3 package jason
okay now those are all gone i think the
best approach might be
to have this clone script make
like a directory
we can run exec
outside of all that
and have the command be
make directory repositories
and we could handle errors here but
i don't think we really need to
and then we would a cd
into repositories and then run git clone
on all this stuff
we'll see if that works
i'll run node index again
and then again i'll stop it with ctrl c
huh it did not work
it did create the repositories directory
though
i guess the cd didn't work
yeah it looks like it doesn't work for
cd
it looks like we can pass something into
exect called
cwd
let's try that
so instead of cd repositories we just
pass
an object
with cwd
dot slash repositories
would that work
i'll get rid of those d3 things again
and then see what's in repositories okay
it worked look at that
all the stuff has been cloned into
repositories
excellent
okay at this point i'll make a commit
oh you've added another git repository
inside
yeah you know i think we just want to
totally ignore
that directory which we can do by
editing
dot git ignore
if i just put that in get ignore
okay it's still added them
but let me just remove that whole thing
okay now if i go and run that thing
again
it's going to clone all the repositories
now when i do git add
it doesn't catch them
but i think they are still there yep
okay so git ignore is working
now i'm going to make a commit that says
start iterating
data processing script
one thing i don't like about this is
when you run it it doesn't even tell you
what it's doing or how far along it is
so i'm just gonna add a little something
that says
console.log command
just so we know which command is running
also we may as well
output the error just so we know
if anything happens
or rather
if there's no error error is null
so let's say if
error then console.log error
okay now we get some
some stuff
git clone fails
when it already exists
okay yeah that makes sense
so let me remove that repositories
directory
and try again
okay
it's running all this stuff
and i finished amazing
so if we run that again
it's gonna give us all this um these
errors
but i think
i wanted to actually just
not tell us
if there's an error
because
i could imagine you know running this
this
index again and again
and if it's already cloned you know it's
already cloned
so now let's let's work on the knife
aspect
just copy that line
change all clone to knife
and then we just run knife
but over in knife
we need to again make
an exported function
so i'll make a function called knife
that runs this command
and then add it to module.exports
module.exports is knife
now if we run this whole thing
oh it's trying to cd into
the repositories
but it's looking at the wrong place
so instead of cd repo
it should be cd
repositories
slash repo
let's try that
cannot create dot dot slash data slash
d3
okay that makes sense because we don't
have a data directory
similar to clone
we might want to make a directory
make directory data
so now let's try it
okay that did not work i think we need
to be going dot dot slash dot dot slash
because here we go two levels down not
one
so let me try that dot dot slash dot dot
slash
okay it's working
and we're getting all these nulls
because
it's doing console.log error
i'm going to change it to only
console.log the error if there is
an error that's not null
okay now it runs fine
now let's run the json conversion
which we can get from that file
replace knife with
json
and in json we can say
const json equals a function
that runs all this stuff
and then export that
let's see if that works
it seems to have worked but i don't
really like
how we don't know what's what it's doing
so i'm going to add a little bit of
console.log
cloning dot dot
knifing
dot dot dot
converting to jason
that's a little more
user friendly i sort of know what's
happening
and lastly we need to combine
the output file
dot dot
so we can run combine
which we get from
combine
dot js
and here again
we need to make this a function
that runs all this code here
and then export it
like that
all right let's see if it works
okay
that looks good we've got this new file
all d3 commits
which looks something like that
and you know i'm always a bit hesitant
to add data to repositories because
the files are usually pretty big
and in the case of this one there is
actually further aggregation
that happens in the front end
it actually aggregates
by
weak
yeah with some stuff from d3 utc week
and then it applies some smoothing
to that data
but you know the smoothing i kind of
want to keep that on the front end so
that if we wanted to we could
vary
how the smoothing is done
but i think it would be advantageous to
do this data processing
in the node script so that
we don't have to fetch a 500 kilobyte
file we can fetch a much smaller file
that just has the weekly aggregations
and then we wouldn't need to add this
data file to the git repository at all
in our data processing script we can add
another step
aggregate by week
i'll call it aggregate
and we can get that from
aggregate
dot js
which is a totally new file
which will have a function called
aggregate
and that will be exported
this is where we get to do the fun
exercise of porting browser-based code
into node
this code here
expects
data
as
the output from the previous script in
this pipeline
namely this file here all d3 commits
so let's load that file here
with fs.read
file sync
all d3 commits
jason
and we can call that data
string
and then data would be json.parse
data string
and those console.log data just to see
if it worked
fs is not defined fair enough
i'll look at some of these other scripts
it just requires fs which is the
built-in node file system module
and it looks like we might need a dot to
string
on the
result from read file sync
but if we run it without that it
actually works
just fine so maybe we don't need that
after all
okay we've loaded in this data
now
we can
take the stuff out of his hub that
processes this data
i'm going to copy all this code up until
the place where it computes
layer data
and what we're calling layer data here i
think will be
the output it's the aggregated data
so i'll paste all that stuff in here
this code imports a bunch of stuff from
d3
but since we're in node
we can say
const d3 equals
require
d3
and
for that to work
in our data processing scripts we really
probably should have a package.json
to track our dependencies like d3
to create a package.json i'm going to
run npm init
and i'll just you know accept all the
defaults
and then we can run npm install
dash s meaning update package.json
d3
and if we take a look at package.json
this is how it looks
that's fine main thing is it has the
dependencies now
that means that
this line of code here will work
oh we also need
array blur no no we don't
we don't that'll be done on the client
side
that's the smoothing
we can reconcile this
es6 import syntax with our es5 you know
node
environment by saying const
all this stuff
equals d3
this is destructuring right here
and i might as well move that up
to where it's imported
okay so let's organize this code here
we've got parse date and layer which are
statically defined
so i'll pull those out
transform data equals data well we don't
need that because we're already inside
of a function that has data there
visible
all this stuff should run just fine
and then down here is where it sort of
trails off it's we gotta just wrap it up
here
and we we have layer data
which we somehow somehow need to get
into a file
so let's see what layer data looks like
here and see if the code runs
to this point
so if i run
index.js
apparently layer data
is a big array
probably the easiest thing to do would
just be
you know make a
an object
i'll call it aggregated data
and
layer here is the name
of the layer
so i'm just going to say
aggregated data at
layer
equals layered data
now we have something that we can output
to
a json file
let's see how did that other module do
it
there it is fs.write file sync
so i'll just drop that line and it calls
json.stringify
and i'll just pass in
aggregated data
to there
and the file name i think i'll just call
it
aggregated data
now if i run everything
we have a new file called
aggregateddata.json
it contains a bunch of zeros but i think
that's okay
each of these numbers corresponds to a
week
but
you wouldn't know that based on this
data
in our code the weeks are available here
as all weeks
so let me just make that available here
in aggregated data as all weeks
and then we can nest
the repository
data under
say repositories
now we can say
aggregateddata.repositories
add layer equals layer data
let's try this
oh
okay now we have all weeks
the format is a little verbose
i kind of want to just clean that up
we already have this parser so let's
just add a formatter
format date is time format
and we need to get that out of d3 as
well
now um
instead of all weeks i think i'll call
it
dates
because you know we might want to use
months or something in the future
and then we can say all weeks dot map
format date
now when we run this
oh we get an error
i'll just backtrack
okay now it works i don't know how i
what i broke or how i broke it
just introducing the formatter shouldn't
do anything
but it does what
that's odd
if i don't create the formatter
all by
myself yeah
mommy
i don't know twilight zone moment
okay let's try it again
you
okay this is super weird it says you
know d.date is undefined
if we do it like this
but if we do it like this
explicitly pass one thing into format
date
then it works
weird might be something about a second
argument to format date
or something but anyway now it's working
just fine
now if we take a look at the files
we can see that the aggregated data now
is only 31 kilobytes
instead of a whopping
we should just make sure that this data
doesn't end up in the repository
so i'm going to delete this file
and i'm going to tweak this script
to
generate this inside of data
inside of the data directory
data slash
all d3 commits
and then when we load that we need to
get it from
this light the same place data slash all
d3 commits
and then in our git ignore
we can also ignore the data directory so
that everything in there does not
end up
inside the git repository
so i'll run all that stuff one last time
okay it worked
if we do a git status we see
the stuff here
generally looks good but i see there are
swap files being tracked
and also node modules is being tracked
by git
we don't want that so let's go back to
our git ignore and say
any
swap file this is just a temporary thing
that vim generates that we don't need
and get
also node modules
okay great there we have it we have
aggregateddata.jsonvisible which is only
30 kilobytes
so i feel good about adding all this
stuff
and then i'll make a commit
add aggregated data
all right now that we've scratched that
all right
scratch that
now that we've got the data processing
scripts sorted out let's deal with the
front-end code
the front end code is currently in this
vis-hub export thing
which has
sort of a sketchy
dead simple
package.json and rollup config
the first thing i want to do here is
make sure that we have a proper setup
so i'm going to turn to
roll up starter app
we can pull things in from here
and i like to do it one at a time
so here's package.json
since the thrust of this project is the
front end i'm going to let the front end
code live
at the root of the repository
so i'll just drop that stuff
into package.json
but instead of
roll up starter app we should call this
git history stream graph
like so
everything else looks decent
i'm just not sure that it's at the
latest version oh and we don't need
date functions
that's something that's used by you know
the starter app
i'm just not sure all this stuff would
be at the latest version
so i'm going to run
ncu
which is
you can get it with node
sorry npm install
g
npm check updates
this is a little utility that goes
through your package.json and checks if
all the versions are the latest
we can run it with ncu
and it turns out there's some version
increments
and so i'm going to run
ncu-u to actually modify package.json to
use all the latest versions of things
and then i'll run npm install
while that runs we can pull in some
other stuff
from this starter app
such as the rollup config
this is more of a production oriented
configuration
for rollup
so i'll make a new file called
rollup.config.js
and i will drop this content
into there
now let's look at our files
and
take what we need from the vishub export
there are really only two main modules
here index.js and transform data
i'm inclined to make a new directory
called src the source directory
and put those files there
so i'll just move those into
the source directory
and notice that the rollup config looks
for
src slash
main.js i'll just change that to index
dot js
and index.js
imports a lot of stuff from d3
and also from
d3 area label
now this is a fork in the road where we
could choose
how we want to include our dependencies
we could either go the traditional route
of
pulling in the dependencies into our
bundle having a huge bundle with all of
the functions from d3 and these
libraries that we're using
or
we could opt to
pull our dependencies from a cdn like
unpackage and have our bundle only
contain our code and not any other
library code
that's what i'm inclined to do because
we're publishing this with github pages
and to publish this stuff with github
pages we need to include the bundle
in the git repository
and if we include a bundle in the git
repository that contains like d3 and and
libraries
it's going to bloat the git history
so that's why at this juncture i'm going
to opt toward using
libraries that come from a cdn
to do that we need to adopt some of the
stuff that's going on in the viz hub
config for rollup
namely marking things as external
i'm going to bring that line
into our rollup config
it says okay d3
is external
also globals
and we need that as well under output
so that d3 can be resolved
to the right thing at runtime
since we're using d3 area label as well
this
piece also needs to be pulled in
from our rollup config
it just says
anything that gets imported from the d3
area label package
looks to the d3 global
and that just happens to be how that
library is set up it adds more stuff
to the d3 global
okay and finally we have index.html
where should we put this
and this is a kind of ugly
indentation wise
let me just fix the formatting
okay we're pulling in these three
libraries from on package
and then we're running our
bundle.js
uh but is that where it ends up
in our new rollup config
no it ends up in public slash
bundle.js okay good to know that makes a
lot of sense
the directory name public is typically
where
index.html lives and also css maybe
images
or data files things that get loaded
by the client
so i'll go ahead and make a new
directory called public
and i'm going to move
index.html into
public
and you know that's where the data
should live as well so i'm going to move
aggregateddata.json
into
public
there's also styles.css which can go
in public as well
okay now public has our data our html
and our css
let's see if our rollup build works
see our index.html expects a file called
bundle.js
and our rollup config outputs a file
called bundle.js in public
however that's not there at the moment
to make that
exist
we can look at our scripts in
package.json see we have a build script
which will just run rollup to generate
that bundle
invoke that we can say npm run build
like so
and it says unresolved dependencies and
also missing global variable name
okay we just have to take some more
stuff over from our
other rollup config
from vishub
namely we need to add array blur and d3
area label
under the external
configuration
like that
also in globals we need to define
which global array blur
resolves to
it just so happens that that library is
also set up
to add stuff to the d3 global
so we can say array blur resolves to the
d3 global
let's try that again
okay no errors
and now bundle.js has been generated
in the public directory
and it looks something like this
it's pretty small
this has been minified
by the way because
in the rollup config
terser is used terser is a minifier
okay great now let's see
if everything
actually works
there is a script here called start
which just runs serve which is another
npm package and it serves the public
directory
let's try that npm
start
okay we have a local http server running
on port 5000
and if i run this boom it works
look at that
amazing
so the work is done
the final step here is to you know
commit whatever we've done
and make it work with github pages as
well
also i'm remembering that i manually
copied the data over into the public
directory
but ideally our scripts would output
there directly
from the aggregate step
so instead of writing
aggregateddata.json i'm going to change
this to dot
dot dot public
slash aggregated data
this way if we modify any of these
scripts we can just run it and then push
to github and it'll actually
automatically
deploy to github pages with the fresh
data
i'm just going to run that
processing script one last time to make
sure that the last step works
i think it worked but to be sure i'm
going to delete this file
now it's gone
i'll run this again
and i'm getting an error now
scratch that
okay that ran
and now in public that file exists boom
all done
get status to see what changed oh a lot
of stuff changed
i'll add everything to get
this change set looks good
make front end work is my commit message
push that up
now in the github pages config
since we have a public directory now
we can actually change this
configuration
so that instead of serving the root at
the root it should serve
slash
public
scratch that section
okay now we can go to
this github pages site
oh now shows the readme that's pretty
cool
but we can go to slash public
and we should get the visualization and
we do all right sweet
you
ideally we would not need this slash
public
but in the settings for github pages
we can only select between two options
the root and slash docs
so the thing to do might be rename
public to docs
that way
we could
you know
just use the root
of this url
and that would resolve to the working
visualization
so i'll go ahead and do that i'll move
public
to be called docs
and then i'll search for all mention of
public
which gives us these
three places that we need to change
public to docs
and by the way i'm using this a g
function which is a really nice thing
called the silver searcher it's like a
command line search
utility
okay so in roll up config
i'll change
public
to docs
yeah that's the one
same thing in package.json
public to docs
and lastly in our aggregate script
all right there we go
i'll add that to git make commit
migrate public to docs for github pages
push that up
now i can change this setting to use
slash docs
and now if i go to this url
it'll take a minute to change
but if i refresh
now
i'm in the middle of something
that i really need to have everything in
my head
we just sat down
you
it should eventually show up
if somebody can get
okay
um
oh i could
let me just finish what i'm doing
sweetie hold on
you
the last sort of loose end we need to
wrap up here
is the fact that our our client program
is still pulling in data from github
gist see check it out under source
index.js
we've got this data url
which is still pulling from github gist
this one needs to change to pull it from
dot slash
aggregated data
dot
json
and this is where you know we've moved a
bunch of stuff
from the front end to the back end or
the pre-processing step
so
we're gonna have to modify this
transform data function
so that it does not do
all the stuff
that it did before
rather it's going to expect
this new format for our aggregated data
which contains dates
and
what else
repositories
so we can destructure those from data
and let's take a look at our aggregate
step
it does a bunch of stuff in here so we
can delete that from the front end code
we don't need to do the grouping
we don't need to compute
all this stuff
we do however want to apply the
smoothing
layers here represents the list of
repositories
so we can derive that from repositories
by saying object
dot keys
repositories
and all weeks
is actually
dates
however we do need to parse those
strings into dates
using
parse date which we have defined there
so how about this instead of doing this
destructuring
we can say
data dot repositories and we can also
say
dates equals data dot dates dot map
a function that takes as input
one date and returns parse
date of that date
now dates should be defined correctly
and we should be able to
set everything up you know just let it
run like it did before
however there's this thing called data
by layer
what is that i think i clobbered its
instantiation
we can use git diff
to figure that out
yeah here it is i deleted it by accident
it's just a new map
so we can bring that back
scratch that
so we can bring that back right here
data by layer a new map
and now let's see if it works
so
npm start just serves
everything what we want to do now is
actually regenerate the bundle
so let's try this dev script
npm run dev
that will run
in parallel both the start script and
the watch script and the watch script
is essentially the same as the build
script but it watches meaning every time
you change a file it automatically
regenerates
bundle.js
so i'll shut down npm start and run
npm run dev
oh look at that we have some warnings
that's really nice unused external
imports utc week utc weeks
and group
are imported but never used
yeah that makes a lot of sense
so
we can just get rid of those
we don't need uct week you see two weeks
or group
great see i wrote that file and then it
updated bundle
immediately automatically
let's see if the front end works
i believe it was localhost to 5000
it appears broken it says grouped data
is not defined
okay let's see what
what is that
i think what used to be called grouped
data is now
called
something else but no that's actually
not the case
what we have is layer data
yeah i remember this stuff is actually
in
our
data processing script in the aggregate
step
yeah so what we're doing is we're saving
layer data to the file
so we can just get layer data out
of the file
by saying
data dot repositories
at layer
like that
okay let's see if that worked
all weeks is not defined
yeah i think we re we changed that to be
called dates
t is not an iterable hmm
i don't think i can do it sweetie i'm
sorry
you
okay it says t is not an iterable and if
we follow
the code it's it's when it tries to
compute extent of data
apparently data
is not an iterable
so let's see we just need to connect the
dots
data i believe was the original
data
so we actually need to
change the frame code
so that it doesn't need
data at all
all it really needs that for is to
compute
the domain of the x scale which is
the extent of the dates
and we have those dates available
so we can just expose these dates
instead of data
and then we can use that
to compute the extent
it's just going to be the extent of the
dates
and it sort of worked
got something kind of funky going on
i don't know why the dates go back to
1970.
it appears that we might have like an
invalid
date
yeah the dates are going back to like
1971.
why is that
okay well that's that's what's appearing
in our aggregated data
so why is that
looks like there's some bug in our
data processing scripts
oh here it is it's all weeks.map
that should be
well no that looks fine format date of
date let's just format all the dates
let's counsel.log all weeks at index 0
to see what is the first date here
it says 2013.
that seems right
so what are
what's going wrong here what if we pass
that into format
date
it says 1969
1227.
why
you
okay this is super weird if i just bring
back the code like this
it gets the correct date
and
the stream graph appears correctly
okay weird
but we seem to be missing a bunch of
commits on d3
uh
you
okay
okay the issue there was
it was calling exec
and this command was not finishing
before the next step in the pipeline ran
that's why we were missing some commits
so i just changed it to be exec sync
so this command actually totally
finishes before the next one runs
and that was the source of our strange
errors
so now if we run this
and we load the data into the viz it is
full and complete
and has all our stuff in it
all right that's how you can productize
a code base
all right welcome everyone to episode 8
of get it right in black and white
today
the goal is to build a d3 scatter plot
from scratch
so introductions for new folks if any i
see
oh someone joined the call and left but
you're all welcome to join
if any money if anybody does join i'll
come back and uh
we can do introductions
i'd like to begin by reviewing some of
the submissions from the last episode
which was two weeks ago now but let's
take a look at what folks did
that was the one on javascript modules
and build tools
and
here's a nice roll up example
by
floating purr
very nice very nice
and here's another one
that uses vite
this looks kind of interesting i've
never used devite but seems to uh it
seems to work
and here's another one
that seems to be just the straight
vishub export which works too
but yeah i'm really glad to see folks
are able to get their stuff out of his
hub into github
so that's
that's one of the most commonly asked
things like how do you get out get out
of this hub
so that's how and hopefully that's
satisfactory
and by the way i recorded um episode 7
by myself
a couple days ago i'm going to release
it as a video soon because i was doing
this work anyway of of getting a uh
you know makings like an open source
product out of something that's in vis
up and i just recorded it so
i'm going to post that
eventually it's not posted yet but
that's why we're on episode 8 now not
episode 7.
metal guitar covers hello everyone
hey feel free to join the audio if you'd
like
it'd be a lot of fun
today we'll build a scatter plot
and the goal here is to create a vanilla
html
implementation
of a d3 scatter plot that uses modern d3
conventions
and
implements this pattern of decoupling
rendering from data
processing the goal of that is to make
it easier down the line to swap out the
rendering logic
if you want to with another framework or
canvas
or what have you
and
i hope to get out of this
a forkable template
that can be sort of a go-to resource
uh if anybody asks like how do i make a
scatter plot with d3
you could just send them a link to this
template and like boom that's it and
it's like probably less than 100 lines
and it works and it's basic
and it's vanilla
and i mean truly vanilla so we're not
going to use es6 modules even because i
want to show
what that option looks like to not use
es6 modules
okay
i'm going to start
by
creating a viz invis hub from
this vanilla html starter
i'm going to fork this and say
d3 scatter plot
so what have we got here anyway it's a
basic
html template with some
space for javascript i'm just going to
gut this
delete everything
but i'll keep the places to put things
like the script and the style
because i know we're going to need to
use that stuff
okay step one let's load in d3
and um there's a number of ways to do
this but since we're doing vanilla html
let's just load it in from a cdn i'm
going to use unpackage as a script tag
at the end of the head
i'm going to make a new script tag
open script close script
and the source
will be
d3 somehow
and the way that we get that is i like
to go to unpackage.com d3 and it
resolves to this minified build of d3
so i'm going to paste that url here
now we have access to d3
which we can prove by saying console.log
d3
and taking a look in the console and we
get this object
that has all of the d3 methods
right the next step is to load in some
data
and since this is a you know going to be
a template i like to use the iris data
set
if you just do a google search for the
iris data set
there's even a wikipedia article about
it that helps to give some context it's
also known as
fisher's iris dataset it's a
multivariate data set from like 1936
about flowers about iris flowers
these are the iris flowers and it's got
like petal width
petal
length
and they're just measurements in
centimeters about these particular
flowers
so it's a classic data set
i'm going to use it because we end up
with nice scatter plots
but
part of the goal of this is to develop
something that's a template that you
could easily swap out the data to be
something else so in a sense it doesn't
really matter what data we use to start
anyway if you scroll down in the search
results i've got this gist
up in github
that contains the iris data set as a csv
file
publishing data in github gists like
this is a pretty common practice
for visualizations that are hosted
on the web and various platforms
it's great because github essentially
hosts the stuff for free
and lets you pull it down from
any program
so if we click this raw link right here
we get to see the content of this file
which is a csv
a csv file and csv stands for comma
separated value this is the header row
and these are all the rows that contain
the data
so it's got sepal length and the sepal
length of the first flower is 5.1 it's
got sepal width and the sepal width of
the first
flower is 3.5 centimeters it's got petal
length
and the petal length of the first flower
is 1.4
and it's got petal width
the petal width of the first flower is
and it's got species
and the species
are iris setosa
iris
versacolor
and
virginica these are different species of
iris
so
we can take this url right here copy it
and paste it into our program
i'd like to make a variable for this
so i'm going to call it csv url equals
and i'm just going to paste it
right there
and at this juncture
you know
for me i don't really like seeing these
long lines that wrap around in sort of
an unwieldy way so here's a little trick
that you can use to
to clean up the code around strings
i'm going to make it an array
of strings
so we can see the different components
of this url
yeah i'm just going to split it up here
close out the array and then we can say
dot join
which is a method
on javascript arrays
and then we can use prettier to format
that nicely
and now i feel this is a lot more
readable
we know that it's coming from github
gist this is the user
name
this part of the url
is the id of the gist
and this part is the commit
and then this part is the file name
so that's how you can
split a long string
into multiple lines in you know a
somewhat elegant and readable way in
javascript
and just to make sure we're getting the
right thing still we can console.log
csv
url
and we should see that url yeah there it
is
and we can even click on that and it
resolves to the right thing
okay now that we've got this csv url we
have to fetch this
csv file
to do that we can use d3 dot
csv
now at this juncture
we can make a decision do we want to
have d3 dot all over the place in our
code or
do we want to extract the d3
stuff into local variables
the latter would be my preference
because that's how it ends up when you
use imports es6 imports
so to make this vanilla javascript more
closely resemble the code that you would
write if you were to use es6 imports
i'm going to make a decision
to destructure
all this stuff out of the d3 global like
this we can say const csv equals
d3
and i'm going to do it at the top
because traditionally that's where the
imports go
so what this is doing is is exactly the
same as
this const csv equals d3.csv
it's exactly the same thing
but it uses es6 destructuring which is a
nice language feature
so now that we've got this
the csv
thing
we can we can use it we can say csv
and pass in
csv url
and
what this does is it makes a network
request using http
for that particular url
and the csv function returns a promise
which is
a construct in esx javascript to deal
with asynchronous control flow
so when you run this code it makes a
request
and then that request takes some time to
come back and then after it comes back
the promise resolves
and that's when we want to get the data
that comes back
to do that we can say dot then
dot then is a method on promises
and we could pass in a function that
takes as input data
and then we can say console.log data to
see if it worked
indeed it did see we get this array of
150 elements
that also has a property on it called
columns
see this is the result of
d3
dot csv doing its thing internally it
actually loads the file
and it also parses it it goes through
that big string of text
and it splits it into rows and it
constructs these objects
one object per row
so what we get here
it's an array of objects and each of
these objects has
a bunch of properties
like sepal length simple width
however these are strings
and ideally these would be numbers
so the next step here is to parse these
strings
into numbers
takes as input a second argument
i'm going to call it parse row
and this is a function
that takes as input a single row i'm
going to call it d
and it returns
some object that will replace that row
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to return d
but before doing that i'm going to
mutate d
and say d dot sepal
width
well actually
let me just copy
the set of columns out because i can't
remember all of them
and we only want to do this for the
things that are numbers so species is
not a number
so we don't need to parse the strings
into numbers
and by the way the reason why it's good
practice to parse strings into numbers
is because
you know when you do math on strings you
don't always get the right result
just as a brief detour
let me just show you
if you add like five
plus
5 as strings
you get 55
but
if you add 5 plus 5 as numbers
you get 10.
so how do we get from strings to numbers
we can use this operator called unary
plus
if you put plus right before the string
it
parses the string into a number
and so that's what we can do for for all
of these numeric fields here
going to paste that here
and
i'm going to use
the macros i think to just write this
code quicker
so we can say d dot
z length
equals plus
d dot
sepal length
and then set up for the next one
and with these macros i can automate
that
and then i'll use prettier to format the
code and there we go
we've got
numbers instead of strings and let's
just see if that worked
in the console we can see
indeed these are numbers now
we've got some questions in the youtube
chat
uh by the way anyone can join the live
audio be higher bandwidth
so
csv is converting the file to a json
structure
yeah you could think of it like that i
mean it's a it's converting it to a
javascript object in memory which is the
same structure as a json file but json
is is a serialization of javascript
object so it's not exactly json but it's
similar it's it's yeah it's an array of
objects
that's true doesn't d3 add columns
yep
yep totally does
yeah so d3 does all that magic
internally where it adds this columns
property
yep
okay what's next here
let's start using d3 to build up
this graphic using svg so the first step
of that is to
create an svg element on the page
we can do that
right here i suppose
const svg equals
d3 dot
select
body
dot append
svg
this will append a new svg element to
the body
however since we don't want to see d3
dot
sprinkled throughout our code i'm going
to also destructure select
from d3 up there
and for svgs to work we need to give
them a width
so i'm going to say attr width
and also we need to give them a height
so i'm going to give it width as
the value of a local variable called
width that i haven't created yet
and the same for height
height gets height
and let's define
width
to be window
dot inner width
this measures the size of the browser
at the time where
the program runs
i like doing it like this so it's
generic and it's not a hard-coded number
okay let's see did this work
we get these uh these undesirable scroll
bars which we can address with
some styling
in the css
we can say okay on the body element
set the margin
to be zero this is just a common trick
that you sort of need to do all the time
if you want to have full screen svgs
and overflow
is hidden
that will hide those
pesky scroll bars
okay that looks better
all right now that we've got this svg
what do we want to put in here um well a
scatter plot is made of circles
so
let's just
go at it that way you know let's add
some circles to this svg based on the
data
the thing is though that data is only
available inside of this callback here
and i don't know this dot then i don't
really like it because
because there is a more elegant
construct called async and await
my preference is to use that
and the way you can do this is introduce
a function i'm going to call it main
and this is going to be an async
function
and what that means is we can say const
data equals await
csv
all this stuff here
this um strike strikes me as a little
bit more
elegant you know i'd prefer to use it
like this
um and then we have to invoke main of
course
and let's just see if it still works
after this
console.log data
indeed there it is
okay so that's how you can you can use
async and await instead of the then
syntax for promises which is sort of a
more modern approach
now
we can add circles to our svg
with the
d3
general update pattern
svg.select all circle
dot data
data
dot join
circle
and now we can set our
attributes
on the circle
attr
cx
is going to be
now what is it going to be i mean this
is where we need to do a lot of work
actually to figure out what that x
position should be
and
it brings up the point that um i would
like to have
the concerns separated of the data
processing and the rendering
and so i feel like we're getting a bit
ahead of ourselves we're not quite ready
for the rendering because we haven't
done
the data processing and so by data
processing what i mean is
figuring out
which x and y coordinate each circle
needs to get based on the data and using
this construct called scales linear
scales in particular
so let's do the data processing first
and then circle back to this rendering
logic
all right i'm going to comment out this
and
to figure out where x should go
we need to use
a scale
and i'm going to just call it x
this is going to be the x scale
because this is a convention that i've
seen
in recent times
with d3 programs
this is going to be an instance of scale
linear
and it would be d3 dot scale linear
but we're also going to
destructure that up here out of d3
skill linear
but what does a scale linear i mean what
is this what is scale linear why do we
need it i've prepared a diagram to
explain this
scale linear
has a domain and a range the domain
is typically the values that you see in
the data
in our case this would be like the you
know the width of the sepal
or whatever
and
typically the domain goes from the
minimum to the maximum value that we see
in the data so let's just say we have
some data set where the minimum value
that we want to use for
say the x position
is 0
and the maximum value is 10.
and what the purpose
is for scale linear in this case is to
transform
data space into pixel space
and the range of the scale is the pixel
space and in the case of the x
coordinate
this is going to be
you know
the the lowest and the highest x pixel
coordinate that we want to see
whoops
hang on
so
when we have a data value and we want to
project it
onto the screen
we we give this scale a value from the
domain
and what the scale does is it gives us
as output a value in the range
for example
if we were to have the number five in
our data
we could say okay mr scale linear my
data value was five
where should that be on the screen
and then scale linear would say oh
i know that should be at 25
because think about it
5 is halfway between
0 and 10
and 25 is halfway between 0 and 50.
so that's the purpose of
skill linear
i see someone has joined
hey felipe is here hello
hello
hey
i'm late it's really difficult to me to
make it oh no worries i'm happy you
could join
yeah i'll meet you meet you i'm also
glad that i came good job
nice
um
i can't remember if you introduced
yourself last time you came on but maybe
just give a a brief intro to yourself
here
okay
i'm felipe
i'm an engineer
as a profession
i don't code
i just love to code but it's not my job
and uh
and then i'm i'm trying to learn as much
as i can
to to start
coding and make things
more
more easily
very nice i really i'm really enjoying
making making things
awesome yeah i've been very impressed
with your work you know i'm so happy
that you've been following the series
and and doing the the exercises you know
it's very
it's very great to see and i'm so happy
you could join me today so here's what
i'm going to do i'm going to share my
screen in the google meet
okay
so that
you can follow along there
and you can close the youtube stream
because there's a lag there but this is
great because you can we can have
discussions in real time if you have any
questions so feel free to interrupt me
if anything's not clear
okay we can dive deeper
but in the meantime please mute yourself
because there's a little bit of
background noise oh my gosh adil is here
too
hey hey adil how are you
you're muted
hello everyone hi karen how are you
hello so glad you could join today
sorry about the the last minute arrival
at some babysitting duties oh no worries
no worries
oh this is great two folks joined it
once and felipe just joined philippe
have you met um a deal
not not personally but nice to meet you
nice
hi filipe hi how are you
great well let me just
um
give a quick recap
because you're all just joining
this is what we've got so far it's not
that much
it loads d3
it uh fetches a csv
parses the rows from a csv
constructs an svg element
and constructs a scale linear
and the goal here is to make a scatter
plot
and i just went through this slide about
linear scales
and the purpose of linear scales is to
convert values from a domain to a range
domain is like the input the range is
like the output the domain is the data
space and the range is the screen space
so in our case
we
want to position these circles in the
scatter plot in the x direction
and
what should that be though we have to
pick one of these columns to use
and this is where i like to define
an accessor
that i call you know i like to call it x
value y value
color value size value whatever it's a
naming convention
that i like to use and it's a function
that takes as input one row and it gives
you back
some value from the data
that we should use
so here are our various options
um i don't think it really matters at
this point which one because i just want
to get something to show up so i'll pick
petal length
this is going to be our x value and the
same for y
let's try
simple
length
for y
so we're going to build a scatter plot
where
you know petal length determines the x
position of the circles and sepal length
determines the y position of the circles
now that we have that in hand
we can define
the domain
of rx scale and the way that you do this
is
firstly you construct an instance of
scale linear by invoking d3 dot scale
linear as a function
this gives you back
this object that has methods on it
such as domain and domain can be used to
set the domain
and the domain remember is just two
values a minimum and a maximum
and so we can this is going to be like
min
and max
min and max are actually functions from
d3 so we could say d3.min
give it the data
and give it the x value accessor
and this will actually iterate through
all of the different
values
and compute the minimum
from there
and we can do the same for max d3.max
data x value
and it will compute the maximum x value
let's just inspect
uh what happened there
x value is the same of x
x value is just this function okay yeah
it's just this function here that
returns the petal length
for each row
and we could tweak it here if we wanted
to change which row to use but yeah
that's all it is it's just a function
that returns the petal length
for each row
and so what what we're doing here we're
passing in that function to d3.min
which expects a function that takes as
input a single row and we're also
passing in the data and when we run this
d3.min call
it actually
checks each and every value
that gets returned from this function
for each and every row and it keeps
track of the minimum one that it saw
and then it returns
the the minimum
of all the values
and same thing for max but just for the
maximum
and we can check if this worked by
saying x dot domain
and the thing about this
scale dot domain
is if you pass it a value it acts as a
setter meaning it sets the value of the
domain
but if you don't pass it any value like
this it acts as a getter and it returns
the value that you set
previously i just use prettier there to
format and so if we look at the result
we can see an array of two values
and check it out it goes between 1
and 6.9
so d3.min and d3.max are great and all
but there's actually
a function that
does both of them for you at the same
time which is called extend
so instead of this
we can use d3.extent
and d3.extent actually returns an array
with two elements
so when this runs
we can see that it's actually the same
the same end
result and as a last piece of cleanup
instead of using d3 dot extent i'm going
to destructure
extent from d3
up here
okay
so now we've got the domain of our x
scale figured out
it's the minimum and maximum value for
that column in the data now we need to
figure out
what should be the range
for our x scale
we can set the range
in much the same way that we set the
domain with a function called dot range
and by the way note how
it's calling dot range on the return
value from dot domain
and the thing is uh with this with the
d3 api
it's using um this technique called
method chaining
and what this does is
if you use for example domain as a
setter like this
it returns
the instance of the scale which is the
same thing as x
so we could potentially say okay x is a
scale linear and then
x dot domain is this
x dot range is this other thing and this
all would work
but since it's developed
with this method chaining api
we can use this shorthand
and this works as well
so
let's figure out what should the range
be
well the range
it's going to be an array of two numbers
and i think to start let's just make it
go between zero and width
to fill up the screen
and we can see what that is by saying x
dot range
like this
and it's array of you know 0 to 960 that
seems right
okay
that's our x scale it's finished
now let's do the same for y i'm just
going to copy all that
change x to y
and then we want the range to go from
zero to height
but not actually
because
the y-coordinate is flipped in svg so so
zero is at the top not the bottom but we
want the lowest data value to be at the
bottom in the screen
so we actually need to flip
this
the range will go from height
to 0.
now we can do our data processing
i'm going to create this thing called
marks
and it's going to be data.map
where we invoke a function
for each and every row
of our data set
and we can return
an object
and this object
can have on it
the properties of
x and y
so x
will be
x
meaning this x scale
of
the
value from the domain
and by the way
these linear scales are functions and
you can pass in a value from the domain
and so the value from the domain will be
you know d dot
what is it
pedal length
oops
however
since i don't want to hard code these
values in here and we already have this
accessor function we can just say x
value
of d
that way it's nice and generic
and the same thing for y
just replace x with y
and there we go
now let's console.log marks
to see what we ended up with
oh i've got two console.logs here which
is confusing let me get rid of the other
one
i'll get rid of this console.log data
so now we're just going to see the marks
and we have objects that have x and y in
pixel coordinates
all right fantastic this is great now
we're ready to move on to the rendering
step and and because we did the data
processing separately the rendering step
is a very straightforward thing where
you just map
x and y from these objects directly onto
cx and cy of the circles
pixels pixels for me i have the
the impression that should be in tangent
numbers not
floating numbers
why is that
yeah that's an interesting point pixels
being integers versus uh floating point
numbers with decimals
yeah it's interesting um
svg because it is scalable
vector graphics
when you're looking at it on the screen
um
let's say you're looking at it on
a high dpi display like a retina display
on a really expensive like macbook
and um
[Music]
and you set a pixel value as like 100.5
on a high dpi display that has double or
quadruple rather the pixel density as a
regular display
that incrementing of the pixel
coordinate by 0.5 will actually
increment it by one physical pixel
and svg
within svg you could do transforms and
even with css you can do transforms of
scaling and so
svg actually does accept pixel
coordinates as floating point numbers
they don't need to be integers
and by the way interestingly this is
different
with canvas html5 canvas which is a
raster
based system
if you draw a line in canvas and you
give it a floating point number i i i'll
have to double check but i think
it like takes the floor of the number so
you can actually only
get down to a single pixel
in the canvas which is a raster image
because it's made up of pixels however
in svg
it's more
detailed than that so somewhat
surprisingly you can actually use
fractional values for pixels and also
for things like line width if you set
the line width to
0.5
it it makes it like slightly
lighter
when it gets anti-aliased onto the
display
uh but again if you were to view it on a
high dpi display it would actually be
one physical pixel
as opposed to like two physical pixels
because it depends on the what's it
called the device
device pixel ratio or something like
that but yeah long story short svg
accepts floating points as um
values
okay
thank you yeah my pleasure
yeah i remember it blew my mind when i
learned that actually um and it makes
sense in a way because
let's say you print an svg when you
print something it's like
300 dpi
so you can actually get to sub pixel
uh precision when you print it or when
you view it as a hana high-res display
um current yeah
when it comes to choosing a scale um
does that depend on what kind of
um
what kind of metric we're dealing with
so
we're chosen a linear scale in this case
and
does that is that because it it's
there's something about the original
metrics um
that that makes
a linear scale appropriate
yes it does
and um
i will be getting into this in the
future but yeah long story short
linear scales is just one type of scale
it's a particular type of
continuous
scale
and these continuous scales include
other ones like a power scale
which includes a square root scale a log
scale a time scale radial scale
so all of these continuous scales are
meant to deal with numbers
as input
so any time you have a column of data
that just has numbers in it you can use
this type of scale
however
there are other types of scales that
make sense to use for other types of
values
time scales for example work with dates
and it it's categorized as a continuous
scale because it
it acts like scale linear but for dates
it treats a date as a point in time
and also
there are ordinal scales
so in our data value for the iris stuff
we have one column which is species
right and it has three distinct values
that are strings that are not numbers
and so when you have strings in your
data you can use ordinal scales
either an ordinal scale directly which
is essentially a dictionary that maps an
input value to an output value
but within this space of ordinal scales
you have
band scales and point scales a band
scale
maps these
discrete input values to
discrete output values that are arranged
as
bands
on the screen so this is useful for bar
charts for example
and then you have
point scales
can be used to represent
data that has discrete
input values like different strings but
then project that onto a space so if you
wanted to have a scatter plot where for
example y is the species you could use
scale point to map species to a y value
but since we're just dealing with
numbers mapping numbers to the screen
that's why we're using linear scale
and we will start to use all these
different scales in the future for all
the various um
visualization techniques
yeah thanks that makes that makes sense
thank you
my pleasure
okay let's get these circles to show up
and make a a basic scatter plot
i'm going to bring back this rendering
logic that we started on earlier
by uncommenting it
and i'm going to change it to work with
marks instead of the original data
now if we want to set the cx attribute
we can just give it a function that
takes as input
one
entry in the marks array
and it can return d dot x
and the same thing for y
c y which is the center y coordinate of
the circle can return d dot y
and let's see if it worked
sorry
they are
missing they are yeah good call good
call yes yes yes that's it
if you don't give it r if you don't give
a circle a radius it doesn't have a
radius and it doesn't show up so let's
say
five
all right there we go
boom
got a basic scatter plot
okay so how do we add axes
to a scatter plot first of all we need
to make room
for the axes
using a margin
and in the d3 world there's this
this thing called the margin
convention
actually let me just show that one
because it's it's really good
if you just google d3 margin convention
mike bostock the author of d3
has this piece
in observable which is
the d3 margin convention
the idea
behind this is to make room for axes
on the left and on the bottom or on the
top and the right wherever you want to
put them
but
the whole idea is we define this margin
object that has top right bottom and
left
and our code will sort of use that
margin to
to know where to put things on the
screen so it impacts how we compute the
range of our skills
instead of going from zero to width for
example we would want to go from
margin.left
to
width minus margin.right
and that's what this example does here
back in our code let's define a margin
margin is going to be an object
that has top
i'll just set them all to 20 for now can
change it later
right
is 20
bottom
and left is 20.
and by the way this is an actual
convention to to go from top right
bottom left because it's clockwise
around the screen and i think that's how
css
sometimes in css you can
you can like specify things as a big
string
and
it goes from top right bottom and left
like that
so that's why i chose that ordering
but anyway now that we have this margin
we can tweak our scales
instead of going
from zero to width for our x scale
we can make it go from
margin
dot left
to
width
minus
margin dot right
and now we can see that there is
actually a margin being applied
let's do the same for our y scale
instead of going from height to zero
it's going to go from
height minus margin dot bottom
to
margin
dot top
like that
and everything else just sort of works
everything else flows
from the scales so it just works
we can verify that it's working by
testing each one of these one by one
like what if we set the top to 200.
see that it works we have a big gap on
the top
what if we set right to 200
it works we have a big gap on the right
how about bottom
yep
got a gap on the bottom and left
yes i have a gap on the left
that's how you can implement the margin
convention
now that we have space for axes let's
add some axes
when we destructor stuff out of d3 let's
also pull out axis
left
and axis bottom
and the way that we can use those
is
on our svg
we can append a group element
for each of our axes so this is going to
be
um
let's do the y-axis first
svg.call
and this is where we can construct
a new axis
axis left
and when we construct this axis
we can pass in
the scale namely uh y
like that
and we're not seeing anything because
it's sort of off to the side of the
screen
what we need to do is move this group
element
to the right a little bit
actually we need to move it to the right
by margin.left
we can do that by saying
dot
attr
and we can set the transform
to be
translated
and this is an es6 string template
literal
we want to translate by
margin
dot left
in the y direction and in the x
direction and 0
in the y direction
and now it shows up see
get some tick marks
the numbers seem to be cut off though so
let me just tweak the margin
i'm going to tweak the left margin to be
let's say 50.
and now we can see
this axis shows up
all right that's how you can add
an axis with d3
maybe let's do the same for the y axis
or
let's do the same for the x axis now
just going to copy this code
and modify it
to be for
the x-axis
which i would like to put at the bottom
so we can call x's
bottom
and pass an x
like this
but the transform
is not quite right anymore see we've got
all these numbers at the top we want
these to be at the bottom
so what we need to do is translate by
in the x direction
but in the y direction we want to
translate it to be all the way down at
the bottom
and so that's going to be
height
minus
margin
dot
bottom
yep
and that works
all right very good that's how we can
add x and y axes
to our scatter plot
one last little tweak i would like
yeah question uh
i'm sorry i i'm not sure how how do you
ensure that the
uh the mark in the
in the axis
is exactly
matching the the value of the data
because
since you can transpose the axis
you could be ending the number in the
different places
i don't know if i made myself clear oh
sure yeah yeah i mean
the shorter the short answer is
because they're derived from the same
scale
but yeah if you
if you wanted to
you know
you could translate it by let's say like
50 pixels in the x direction and make it
misaligned
like now it's not lined up
but if you don't do that
it is perfectly aligned
just because of how
the scales are set up
so because the axis takes as input the x
scale
the axis
actually uses
the range of the scale to position
itself
and since it's the same scale that
drives the x and y of the circles
it it ends up aligning perfectly
yeah and we're translating it by
notice how we're not translating the
x-axis in the x-direction at all we're
just translating the x-axis
in the y-direction to put it at the
bottom
and so all yeah so all the x positioning
is just strictly coming from the x-scale
okay
okay nice
nice and same with y by the way we're
translating y
in the x direction
just to align it with the x scale so
when all of the y positioning is just
strictly from
the y scale here so that's why that's
why they all align correctly and you can
sort of see
that they align because this the
the lowest x value which is the circle
here
the center of the circle is exactly on
that line of the axis
can i see something
yeah um we can check the value for each
circle by putting title on it and we
will see it matches with the axis
oh we totally could
yeah that's fairly easy to do let's just
do it that's a great idea
so there's this thing
called title
um
you know what
that might be a little more complicated
because we need to tap into the enter
selection
yeah i don't know that seems a little
bit out of scope for today
yeah we need to we need to change this
code around to access the enter
selection so i don't know i don't really
yeah but
it's no problem
my questions was wondering if we could
mess it up
but
as you said we we never transformed in
the axis that
we are actually
moving exactly
made sense completely
yeah
nice
yeah great great but but yes we could
potentially add tool tips that will show
the numbers
um
which which we could then verify that
could conceivably work but i don't think
i'd like to do that right now
because i want to keep this example um
nice and simple
i have a question um
if if we wanted to the the axes
to begin from zero
uh what would we need to do
oh yeah sure if you wanted the axes to
begin at zero
you could just use um
instead of using extent you could use
max d3.max
and
as the first value you could explicitly
just pass in zero
like this
now the x-axis starts at zero
very cool
yeah
thank you yeah that makes total sense
nice yeah my pleasure and i love how you
know d3 is
is designed
in such a way where it's like you can
fit things together like lego blocks
you know
so it's you can just plug in whatever
you want to
for the domain but it provides utilities
like this max
and extent
for the most common use cases which is
you know deriving
the domain from your data
and for a bar for a scatter plot it
makes sense to use extent but for other
visualization types um like a bar chart
it always makes sense to start at zero
so
you know if once we make bar charts
we'll always start the domain at zero
and then use d3.max
and same thing if you're assigning areas
to circles like the size of a circle
based on some numbers i mean we'll get
there in the future but i'm saying like
there are very concrete use cases where
it makes sense to start the domain at
zero and then go from zero to the max
of the data and that's how you would do
it
so yeah i think we're pretty much done
here i kind of want to just um you know
give this a once-over oh one thing i
wanted to do
was make the ticks the tick marks bigger
because um in my opinion the default
size is pretty
pretty small
and i want to give a f just a flavor of
how you might customize
some of the stuff on the axis which is a
rabbit hole there's a lot of different
things you could do there
but the simplest thing you can do
is just
use css
to say
for all text elements
which includes the tick marks
we can set the font
size
to be
i don't know 24
pixels
and that works
it's it's bigger
but as a best practice i like to scope
the changes because if there's you know
if there's other text this will apply to
all the text
which may be what you want
but
with d3 axes in the dom
there is actually
a structure that we can leverage
namely that each tick mark
is is composed of a group element that
has a class of tick
and then within that group element
there's a line element
and there's a text
element so we can select the text
elements inside of the ticks
by deleveraging the fact that this group
element has a class of tick
by saying dot tick
space
text
what this what this does is it
constructs a selector css selector
that selects the tick
elements and then the space signifies
okay within within that look for
children of that element that are
of the type text so this is how you can
set the font size
of the tick elements
and the labels are getting cut off so
i'm just going to tweak the margin again
i tweak the bottom margin to be
say 50.
maybe 40.
yeah and um
at this juncture i think the code is is
done
in a sense
but now just to close this out i want to
look through this code from the
perspective of
someone who wants to fork and modify
this
because that's what the assignment is to
fork this and modify it to show some
other data set
and so
you know in this direction what i want
to look for is
are all of the tweakable things in one
place and all the generic stuff in some
other place that's what i would aim for
if if the goal is to create a reusable
template
so let's just look through
and
i'm going to make a comment
here called tweakables
and all this stuff should be
data set specific
so we got the csv url
very much data set specific we got
parsero
very much data set specific
x value y value
very much tweakable and actually at this
point let me just show you how easy it
is to change the meaning
of of one of these
x or y instead of sepal length we can
change it to c pull
width
and boom our scatter plot
updates just like that
and so when you load in another data set
part of the process is just going to be
trying out different values for the
columns and see and see what pops out
the margin
very tweakable
something you'd want to probably tweak a
lot
and
the width and the height
yeah this part is sort of
something you might want to tweak like
if you have some downstream code that
where you want to position the svg
inside something else
so sure it's tweakable
now
this part is generic
so i'm going to go through this and see
is there anything that's
specific to this data set in this code
or not
so far it looks pretty generic you know
this cut this same exact code could run
on any data set oh there's one thing
that's tweakable the radius
so i'll pull that out into a tweakable
variable
i'll put it along with
x value y value and margin
radius is 5.
yeah that's an arbitrary thing
that uh you might want to tweak
but um i think that's about it that's
all i see
so that's how
that's how you can polish up a
a forkable
dataviz template
all right a great i feel like we've set
out the original goal to have something
that's just vanilla
html javascript it doesn't use any
bundler or anything
it approximates the feel of es6 modules
by
destructuring
the stuff out of the d3 global but it's
it's totally vanilla so anyone could you
know
export this and use it
all right i think that's it any um
any questions or things you want to
discuss
um
i have a question about the call
function you used for axis
sure let me just plug in my laptop
there's the batteries running out
yeah the question is about dot call
i guess you could phrase the question as
like
what is that what is it really doing
and it's it's really just a shorthand
for invoking functions and there's a way
that you could do this without using dot
call
let me show you what that looks like
um let's let's look at for for
axis left
we could potentially pull that out
like this into a variable
and then
pull out this group element as another
variable
so now we have
i'll get rid of that dot call
now we have
the axis as a standalone thing
and the group element as a standalone
thing
and we want to sort of inject that axis
into that dom element
and one way we could do it is
y axis g dot call
y-axis
which is the same as it was before but
now things are split into variables
the other way to do it
is like this y-axis
y-axis
g
like that
and it still works
so what's going on here
is
when you invoke dot call
on a selection
it expects that you pass in a function
and it will invoke that function
passing in the selection
on which you invoked.call
so it's exactly the same as this y-axis
is actually a function
that expects to be called
with a d3 selection of a group element
as the input
so these two are exactly the same
behavior-wise
um dot call is just
it's just sort of a shorthand a
convention it's convenient because you
can chain stuff onto it you could say
dot call that dot
you know select
um
you know domain
path or something
and remove it
as an example use case where you might
want to
use dot call
and see that removes the domain line
that path
the which is that vertical thing and
often i find myself wanting to remove
the domain
path because it's like i don't see
much value that it provides
but
anyway
yeah i hope that answers your question
these two are
equivalent dot call just invokes a
function and passes the selection
but i think i'll put it back to the way
it was
it's kind of confusing but it will work
yeah yeah there's always a trade-off
there's always a trade-off between
writing
concise
code that might be a little cryptic
versus verbose code that's like twice as
long but it's easier to read yeah it's
gonna try to strike a balance
so it's the first argument
to the
uh yes the first argument of the first
argument
[Music]
yeah maybe i should just keep all that
around as a reference yeah just
commenting will be nice
so the
you know it's like the argument of axis
left function
is the selection svg selection
is that right
yeah the argument that y-axis expects
is a group element well rather it's a d3
selection of a group element that's
empty and the y-axis function is going
to be like okay you give me an empty
group element i'm going to put an axis
into it and if there's an axis already
there i'm going to
i'm going to you know update it to be to
be accurate
and it has to be group element
it expects a group element yeah i mean
you could
conceivably pass in like the top level
svg element but
yeah i'd expect a group element
but yeah it's a good question could you
could you pass in something else i don't
know um i've only ever seen it
used with a group element
oh i
i broke it
there we go
so so yeah i mean it's it's good to
study this um because it is a lot of
stuff sort of wrapped into one
so what it does here is says okay i'm
constructing an instance of an axis
and i'm passing in the y scale
so the return value from this
constructor
is a function
that we could call y axis if we wanted
to
that expects as input a d3 selection of
a group element
as its
argument when it gets invoked
and that's exactly what gets passed in
when you when you use dot call
and the dot call is
is called on this group element
that's been transformed
but um
yeah yeah that's how it all works it
does take some time to to wrap your head
around it
um but oh in time i've come to prefer
like this
this sort of construct
rather than
making a bunch of variables
but again it's just
just personal preference either way
works
you know that another thing
another while we're at it another way
that you could potentially do this
which might be even
more confusing
is that you can construct the axis and
then
pass in
this selection here
that works as well
i i don't understand this
to me it seems like uh could be because
i'm more used to fighting but seems that
you're pressing like
the svg thing like a argument to the
function that's left
yeah it's not clear
yeah that's right that's right so
when you call axis left from d3
you give it the scale
it returns an instance of a d3 axis
but that instance of d3 axis is in fact
a function
that expects
to be invoked with a single argument
namely a d3 selection of a group element
and so
this statement here
returns a function
and that's why
we can invoke
that function
like this so this part here
we are invoking that function that gets
returned from the axis left constructor
and we're passing in
a d3 selection of this group element
because as soon as we call svg.append
g
it creates a brand new
d3 selection of a brand new dom element
which is a group element
and then it calls dot attr on that group
element and because
it uses this method chaining api the
return value from dot attr is the same
as the return value from dot append g
it's a d3 selection of the group element
and so this whole expression here
yields you know it returns
a d3 selection of this group element
and that's what gets passed into this
axis left function
okay when when you inspect the
inspect the element uh the result is
exactly the same right correct
yeah all of these different um
all of these different ways of
of invoking the axes
result in the exact same behavior
they're just different ways of
formulating it
but yeah when you when you when you see
it visually it's the same and yeah when
you inspect the dom it's going to be
exactly the same
and from the perspective of the dom
this thing here is the parent group
element that we created
with this code here svg.peng said the
transform to be translate this is that
group element here
and then
when we pass that into the d3 axis
the axis implementation adds all this
stuff as children
to it so there's a path
which is the domain line
and then there's
group elements for each and every tick
and within each tick you have a line
and a text element
so yeah no matter how you invoke it
it ends up to be the exact same dom
structure
it's quite confusing yeah
it looks like you can pass
axis function in the svg selection and
vice versa
well you can that's exactly what dot
call does it sort of inverts
everything
you know i think
probably the clearest one
to read
is this variant here
where we don't even use dot call
we construct a variable
called y-axis which is that return value
from axis left and then we construct a
group element by appending a group
element this is a d3 selection of a
group element
and you can see the relationship very
clearly right here
y axis is a function that expects
as input a d3 selection of an empty
group element
and this is
this is
i guess shows the border between them
very clearly
but yeah i get it that it's totally
confusing that you can invert the order
of those
in the code with dot call
yeah it takes a while to wrap your head
around
okay let me ask you one thing it's not
quite related i i think i got my my head
around this
it's regarding the the arrow function
uh i don't need to use
uh the return ever in the arrow function
it's always the last line that's
returned
right
there it's only one line so it doesn't
make sense my question but if i have um
an
object
and it has more than one line
do i have to use return or not
that's a good question
yeah
let me show a variant of this one
so with the arrow function
if
it immediately goes to an expression
that could be an object literal could be
a string could be a number
it it sort of activates this thing
called implicit return
it's it implicitly
adds or exec it implicitly executes a
return statement or the equivalent of a
return statement
and that's sort of one of the magical
features of these arrow functions
however
if
you start the arrow function with a
curly brace
like this
then it opens up into a function
body
where you need to explicitly return
so you you could like
you know
run some code blah blah blah but then
at the end of it
if you just define an object
like this
it's not going to be returned you need
to explicitly return it
like this
and so
this function here
is exactly equivalent to this function
here
but the one on the top uses that
syntactic sugar of the implicit return
that comes with arrow functions and
that's by the way why it needs to be
wrapped
in these parentheses
because the parentheses signify okay we
are defining a literal object
and and that's why it gets returned if
you leave out these parentheses
uh
it's not valid javascript and it breaks
so like if if we try to run
that
it's going to say
it's not valid it's
unexpected token
because
when the parser goes in it it interprets
it okay like we're starting a function
body now and then this is like garbage
doesn't make any sense
so
yeah that's why you need those uh
parentheses
okay
i i got this therefore a lot so it's
good to know that
this could be a reason
nice the
unexpected two columns
yep
yeah that's one of the most common areas
you got a syntax error then you need to
track it down figure out where it is
um and by the way you know a lot of
folks who have been maybe programming in
javascript years ago
you're used to this other syntax where
it's like a function
like this
and this is like i like to call it the
old school function
notation
this works too but the arrow function
syntax is just
it's a lot more
concise
and
that's what folks would use probably
nowadays
all right very good a lot of fun we've
explored some ins and outs of um
of the details here and we've ended up
with this
forkable template
oops hold on
so i'd like to wrap up
and leave you all with an exercise
the exercise for this week is fork the
scatter plot that we made and i'll share
the link
and change it around to visualize a
different data set
and i've provided this link here to
uh this data repository that i have
where i've just been accumulating
over the years um
various public data sets of interest and
you don't have to necessarily derive any
data from here you could just find you
know do a search for
data that's interesting to you
and plug it in to the scatter plot
and i've got this other video on youtube
called
preparing data for visualization and
this walks through
how you can create a gist
and put a csv file
in there
and then once that's there you can
follow the same steps that i did today
to pull it into your code and visualize
it
and this is all there
in the vishub forum
so please
submit your uh
your work here
looking forward to it
okay
thank you
all right yeah my pleasure and uh thanks
everyone for joining today
it's a pleasure as always
today i'd like to talk about reusable
charts
this has been a fascination of mine
for years because every time you figure
out how to make a certain visualization
um it becomes sort of a telescope that
you can point in different directions
right at different data sets
and encapsulating the reusable elements
has always been somewhat of a challenge
hey felipe how are you
hey i'm fine thank you what about you
good
good good we got a full house today we
got sriram nita adil and felipe this is
amazing
very cool
so yeah today i'm going to talk about
reusable charts and what i'm going to do
today the idea is
to take what we did last time
refactor it a little bit start to use
es6 modules
and then adopt this
reusable
charts
pattern which is sort of the the module
pattern that
is is commonly found with pure d3
implementations
but first let me review
the submissions from last week
yeah we got some really good stuff
this week
uh here's philippe's work
title to the dot
um nice so there's little tool tips that
you get when you hover um you want to
talk about this a little bit
well that's that's not much but this is
just uh the title i didn't
and knew how to use the invert function
so i add p x and p y
in the marks
uh but what p x and v y is doing it's
pretty much
the invert function if you can scroll a
little bit up
yeah
there you go right
nice
but maybe
there is some kind of invert function
that i could use in the text
i i think andrea i guess let's
talk about this in one lock post
right this is just just to have the
title
and i i got this from your cheat
uh oh yeah cheap tricks for interaction
yeah
nice
let me just provide a little bit of
feedback
on this
so
this step here
creating marks as a derivative you know
array of data
this is where all of the transformation
can happen that you need in the
visualization including logic like
putting together strings
see doing it this way it actually puts a
bunch of intelligence into
the rendering logic meaning this this
string of the tooltip is derived
in the rendering logic rather than
in the pre-processing step so here's
one thing that you could do
is just move this logic
out of here
and use something like d.title
instead
and then you could just say the title of
each mark is
and then you can get rid of these
intermediate values
p x and p y
so it's it's a very small change but
this is more in the spirit of like
then
uh here do do i have to put d dot x v
yeah okay no yeah a good catch yeah i
just overlooked that yep because x value
and d
is visible here so this should still be
working
yep it's still there
nice
but yeah great work great work adding
that that's something that we had talked
about during the last
uh you know last week session and i
never
added it but i'm great i'm happy to see
that uh it was added here
yes this was just after the class the
last class
and then my my exercises
it's
in the end of the posts
okay
it's a little tricky though because just
to just so you realize um
whenever this runs it's going to append
another title every time that's not a
problem here because it only runs once
but just something to be aware of
and yeah in the future we'll dig into
the patterns that you need to to make it
work properly
but yeah nice work very nice
let's see oh this one's beautiful
this is awesome
this is um
well let's read what it says daily new
cases of covet in italy
from andrea this is awesome awesome
nice yes x-axis uses scale time
excellent
and
there's some
interactivity here let's check it out
toggle path
whoa it turns the path on and off
that's super nice
oh my gosh
beautiful let's take a look at the code
real quick
i see that there's different sizes in
use as well
ah so when the when the path is toggled
it just changes the display attribute on
the path brilliant
very nice very nice
yeah so it parses the date
a pretty generic way of parsing the
numbers
and let's check out the rendering
r nice so the radius here changes along
with x and y
beautiful way of doing it
but i have to say that
uh with radius
here let me just
fork this and
suggest a tweak
with radius
um it's it's a good practice to have it
so that the the area of the circle
corresponds with
the data values so one filled in pixel
would correspond with one you know
um unit of of the data and this
method here doesn't accomplish that
because it uses a linear scale
but the area is a function of the square
root so we can change this to scale
square root
sqrt
which we can also get from d3
like that
and then
it really the range really should start
at zero
and the domain really should go from
zero to the max of the data
and yeah max we need to import from d3
so yeah now
now that the domain starts at zero and
the range starts at zero and we're using
a square root scale
now the area of the circles is actually
proportionate
to the value
you see as it goes down it's gets down
to nothing which is what you'd expect
and the higher values are are you know
bigger circles
and i think
well actually what is the
what is the radius value
terrapia intensiva
nice
yeah i don't know what it means
but this is beautiful work
beautiful work
let's see what else we've got
it means intensive treatment
ah
intensive treatment
yeah interesting
so the number of
cases
yeah it's it's an interesting uh pattern
here i'm not quite sure how to
what to make of it
but as the case numbers were going up it
was not
that number was not that high but
later on that number was higher
oh someone's joining
hello
all right we got someone new
hello uh
how do you say mex maximiliano you want
to introduce yourself a little bit
um hello
kuran how are you good good how are you
yes i'm i'm max you can call me max it's
okay
um
i'm from chile an interest i haven't
been able to
to see the course uh like it's
online last the same day so yeah i i
managed to do it today so it's great to
be
nice welcome welcome i'm glad you could
join us
so yeah we got a full house today a
bunch of people sri ram adil anita and
felipe is here
so
yeah as i dig in feel free to interrupt
me and ask questions to clarify as we go
awesome thanks awesome
so yeah this week
there was just a lot of activity in this
forum like a lot of back and forth and
i'm really happy
to see that
uh oh here's here's something that adil
made dinosaur
d3 scatter plot
wow ideally you want to just talk
briefly about this one
uh sure yeah this was um based on a
data set from the natural history museum
in london
they have about 300 plus
dinosaurs in that data set and
i
just wanted to try
uh playing with it a bit using this and
so i uh thought
try plotting the
length of the
dinosaur uh on the x on the x axis with
the weight of the dinosaur on the y axis
and
i then also stole the
the tip from felipe and yourself about
implementing these little
uh tooltips
um
and
yeah so it was just really uh
just just uh getting familiar with the
data set and um
it's a it's a bit patchy and the the
data so i had to do a bit of extra
processing because not all of the
dinosaurs
had a weight um
and
so
from 300 plus dinosaurs i could only get
about 49 i think
which had both length and weight and
then i uh yeah just just uh
just try to
create a label um early on that combined
some interesting uh bits about each
dinosaur
nice
that's beautiful
beautiful stuff
the uh the one in the corner i thought
might have been a typo uh
far corner but it turns out it's
actually uh um
the biggest land animal that's ever been
discovered wow that's incredible
70 000 kilograms argentinosaurus
35 meters
70 000 kilograms you got to be kidding
me
yeah i looked on wikipedia apparently 70
000 was kind of average for that
dinosaur yeah not that
it's just sort of average
wow um one really small thing that i
would suggest um
so when you have numbers like 70 000
i don't think we've touched upon number
formatters but it's a really quick
change that
i would like to just do right now just
to show
how it could be done so the idea is to
oh it looks like you used it here
um i think that was already built into
your fork i think
i see
oh maybe the axis does it automatically
format
but if you so one like the first thing i
noticed was in the tool tip 70 000 kg
um ideally would have a comma after the
and we can add it pretty easily
by importing format from d3
and then making something called uh
i'll call it comma format
and we can just call format with a comma
and format accepts this you know very
specific string that you can do all
sorts of things with but a very simple
version of it is just to
specify to to add a comma separator
and then
in your code that generates the label
we can just pass that through that
function
like so
so whatever the v the y value is we
format it with a comma
and
voila
there it is 70
comma thousand
it's very nice oh that's that's really
nice yeah thank you yeah
nice
great work very fascinating data set
and i think that's it
if you can just go a little bit up uh
previous to this one yeah this one
um
oh yeah
sorry
yeah just just it's a little bit
different uh it's it's the same data set
but i use colors oh wow the name of the
the class but
um
my goal here was to have all the
information that we had in the data set
of the flowers
uh
here
so i put also the
a few miles over
the color means that the specimen yep
right the species very nice the species
yep and
the elliptical
radius
is the sepal but
that's my question because if i change
the the order of the data
the petal and the sepal
the radius becomes very small so it
almost
vanished
so
how can i
like normalize the radios
right
yeah that's a good question i mean
let me dig in a little bit
it it depends on how you use the scales
like which scales you use
for the radius
so
oh you had a question how can i easily
change shapes according to the data
um yeah this this questions like because
i didn't want to use ellipses in the
beginning right i thought okay i can use
different
marks but then i said okay i don't know
how to do this so i will just use
ellipses and
then i can use the
the radio different radius different
right
right i mean
it's um
you it's it's creative to use an ellipse
that has you know different width and
height for the different values here
but it may be a bit hard to read
and so
you know
maybe
maybe the best we could do is just show
three variables
i mean color is color color is a great
choice for the species because it
represents a you know
a column that has three distinct values
a quantity
yeah qualitative
uh categorical attribute
but when it comes to the radius
um
i would say
again it might make sense to use circles
and then
set the radius
using
a square root scale
so i'm going to set r
to be
r of
r value
of d is the way i would set it up
and then
r
again could be a square root scale
and then the domain can go from 0
to the max
of r value
and then the range
would go from 0 to max radius
and i think there's a lot of things that
we don't have defined
i can pull in this and this from d3
and then our value
okay you've got our x value in our y
value it may be sort of too tricky to
show both of those at the same time
and so we can just pick one of these
and
oh let's use this as max
radius i'll set it to be i don't know
15.
that should work maybe i missed
something
oh yeah data
the max over the data of the r value
yeah and so
because the the data values are
like they don't even get close to zero
they're in centimeters
and so
it works pretty well
with um
with a square root scale to set the
radius like this and we can set the max
radius to maybe 10 so we don't get so
much overlap
but now
radius is showing the the variability in
sepal length
and it doesn't it doesn't vary that much
actually
but yeah this is how i would suggest to
do it is to use the square root scale
where the domain and range both start at
zero yeah i i see but um
if i if i have a kind of data that i
won't like uh make a normalization
of
of the range
of the data how how can i do it
how do you mean well i'm not sure what
you mean
um
i mean
imagine that i have a range of data but
i want to restrict it from zero to one
and
have the average
um i'm not quite understanding so let's
take for example this data set
yeah if you if you see like a petal with
it's it's has 0.2
if i
if i use this it's too small so i want
to make it from a range from let's say
one two
two
uh the size of the the radius
then it would be a linear scale right
yeah
i mean you could do that
that's totally
you know something doable
so i'm just going to comment out this
one
and put this other one back where
like you said we we could
make it so that
the lowest value corresponds with some
like min radius
and the max value corresponds with some
max radius
and we could define
min radius to be like
i don't know five
and this would work it would make it so
that you have like it would make it so
that it's guaranteed that the smallest
circle has a radius of 5
and the biggest circle has a radius of
max radius which is 10.
so this is how you would do that i think
this is what you were
asking about
yes yes that's that's right for for this
case it doesn't make sense but it's just
something that i was thinking about
yeah i mean technically it's possible
and and you could use a sk a linear
scale and do it like this
however
the main
problem
with doing it this way is that the area
of the circle does not
correspond to the data values
which could be
problematic um
it's it's not easy to read this in a
sense i said that it's not it's not like
um
i don't know what the word what the best
word is like
like it's it's almost like not really
honestly
yes misleading yeah
exactly exactly it can be
misleading uh because you know you could
pick up a min radius of one
and it would make some of the dots
really tiny but it would you know
it's it doesn't really express the true
uh like variability within that
particular value of the data and so you
know this is an area
of
debate
within the community of people who make
visualizations some people are very
lacks on how they use radius
and so you know it could be a linear
scale it could be a square root scale
could be a log scale you know whatever
it takes to make a pretty picture
but i i my sort of philosophy is on the
opposite end of the spectrum where like
i firmly believe that if you use size
to encode
some value from the data
then
you should
make it so that the area of the circle
corresponds exactly with the values
from the data
so if the value in the data is zero
it should be a zero size circle that you
can't even see
you know
and uh but that's sort of an edge case
i've seen people use one as the min
value so that you could at least see
something on the screen
but
besides that you know i i would pretty
pretty firmly stick to that
philosophy that if you do use
radius
then
the best thing to do
is to use a square root scale
because
the area of a circle varies with the
square root of the radius
um what's that uh
what's that that formula yeah area is pi
r squared
so this is this is why it makes sense to
use a square root scale
and so the radius of a circle um
is calculated
with respect to that same formula
so that's why
if you if you want to make it so that
the area of the circle corresponds with
the values
from the data
then you have to use a square root scale
and make sure that the domain and the
range both start at zero
and so the domain could go from zero to
the max
value
oh whoops i'm editing why my mistake
yeah so it would be this version here
of setting up the scale
oh whoops
that has to be defined above
so it would be this version here
and
you know sometimes it doesn't
turn out
the way you expect
yeah in this case it doesn't doesn't
mean
anything
right yes
exactly exactly
and so this is you know part of the
process of making data visualizations is
just trying different things and seeing
what works
you know spreading the value across the
screen from left to right
between the min and the max like you
know the x-axis or the y-axis of a
scatter plot
that's hugely effective at looking at
you know things that fall
in in like a small range
but there's a lot of variability within
that small range
but radius isn't is not good for that
sort of thing you know the because these
values i mean look they value they vary
between like
i don't know two and four or something
and so it's not really that great of a
variation so it doesn't really
it doesn't really pop out when you use
radius
but it's worth a try for sure
all right cool cool
so um
yeah great work everybody
very nice
all right let's dig into this um idea of
a reusable chart
we will build
a reusable chart based on the scatter
plot we made last time
on the way i'm going to refactor the
code into modules
and then
the whole point
of this
reusable chart thing is to strictly
decouple the specific
and the generic meaning the stuff that's
specific to the data set and the
visualization that we're making and then
the generic stuff that
you know implements
reusable
logic for a specific type
of visualization
and we're going to use this tried and
true pattern
from mike bostock in 2012 can you
imagine towards reusable charts is what
it's called
and
i'm going to make it dynamically update
it's going to dynamically change
x and y
and i want to talk a little bit about
why
i'm
doing this
today
from the structure of the course
perspective
i i want to go in this direction so that
we have a very solid
basis
for
starting on different visualization
types so rather than go wide in the
beginning like we only made one
visualization type so far a scatter plot
so rather than
you know making a bar chart and a line
chart from there what i want to do is
make a reusable chart
version of the scatter plot
and then use that as a basis
for
future episodes where we branch out into
all sorts of different visualization
types that way
by the end of the course we'll have like
a library of
reusable chart components that are sort
of usable off the shelf
and we'll be working within this this
pattern which is very useful
to know and it's one of the trickiest
aspects of d3
so let's dig in
i'm going to start by forking this
scatter plot that we made last time and
i'll call it reusable
d3 scatter plot
right now it's just um
this
index.html
single file sort of thing
before we do anything
i want to change some stuff around so
that it it reflects like the structure
of
a javascript project that you might see
so i'll split out this the styles
into a separate file
oh someone is joining hello
hello someone has joined us uh larry
how are you you wanna hi
nice you wanna introduce yourself a
little bit
uh yeah uh my name is uh larry rancho
i'm from the philippines
nice i work with uh with the university
as a faculty and i also work as a
developer for data visualization
for a company in australia so
yeah i've been using your resources
since i started working with d3 thank
you so much i really appreciate that
oh fantastic
fantastic well i'm happy you could join
um
i think this is the most people that
have ever been on the live call
and this is great so we'll see how it
goes um
all right thank you welcome welcome
okay so the first thing i'm going to do
is split out
the css into a different file
um just because i personally prefer to
have a bunch of small well-defined files
that that way you know the complexity
can scale over time
so i'll call it styles.css
and i'll take this css and move it into
that file
and then
get rid of that style tag and then we
can use a link
tag and i can never remember the syntax
so i'm just going to google it
um
yeah the html link tag
there we go
link rel equals stylesheet which is i
guess the type of thing it is and it
points to styles.css
there we go
i'm also going to
create a package.json
and this is going to have inside of it
dependencies
d3
at a specific version
which i'm going to find from
on package i'm just trying to figure out
what's the latest version of d3
okay it's 6.7.0
so that's what i'll put there
that way
um
we can get rid of this script
tag here
and then i'm going to put
all of this javascript
into a separate file
called index.js
and the way that vishub is set up
it automatically
loads in that file and it also
automatically loads in
our dependencies which includes d3
this is how most modern-day
javascript build systems work so like it
mirrors the experience of webpack or
roll-up locally
so now we're at sort of
a a comfortable starting point where we
can start to refactor this stuff
at this point i would like to introduce
the concept of towards reusable charts
this is a great great piece from
mikebossdog the author of d3
from 2012 and it's one of those unique
things that has actually stood the test
of time
so rather than trying to invent my own
pattern
which i did for the 2018 version of this
course
and rather than use a library that has
components built in like react does
which i used for last year's version of
the course
this time i want to use the pure d3 way
of making so-called components
once you make a component with this
pattern you can easily wrap it with
whatever other framework you're using
like vue or react or angular
or whatever
but
this is a way of making components that
is just purely dependent on d3 and
nothing else so here's how it works
it's going to be a function
so as i go through
i'm going to implement these ideas
so i'll make a new file called
scatterplot
dot js
this will be our scatterplot component
i'll start by saying export const
scatter plot equals
a function
and
it's going to be used in much the same
way as
a d3 axis
this towards reusable charts pattern is
actually used
or a variant of it you know is used
within d3 itself
where you have a constructor for
something
and then you have these chainable
methods
that you can add onto it
so let's keep reading
in this towards reusable charts
one way of configuring the thing would
be to pass arguments
but
um you know he mike boss dog here goes
through the various ways of
of configuring something
and the pros and cons of each
you know it's cumbersome for the caller
to remember for example the order of
arguments so maybe make it a config
object
but that's also cumbersome for the
caller because the calling code must
then manage
both the chart function and the
configuration object over time
so rather than do it like that
we can use
this method chaining pattern
that looks something like this
you create the instance of the chart
and then you call for example dot width
passing in the width that that then
returns the instance of the chart and
then you can call dot height to set the
height
and that state
of width and height is stored inside of
that instance
of the chart
so let's work toward this
in our code
um
in this scatterblock component
we can have a thing that i'm going to
call my
which is going to be the instance of the
chart and this name
pays homage to the original
article
which also uses my
so in this chart constructor it returns
a function called my
this is going to be a function
and this is what will be returned
from this constructor
so
let's create
some of these
accessors or getter setters
this here is a kind of verbose way of of
doing it but let me just walk through
what this means
my is a function
and in javascript functions can have
properties so we can set my.width to be
this function
that accepts as input a value which will
be the new
width
or not
and if it's if it's invoked with no
arguments that's what this is checking
here arguments.length
so if there are no arguments then the
function acts as a getter it returns
the width which is stored in this
variable here
otherwise
it sets width to be the passed in value
and crucially it returns my this this
returning of my is what enables
method chaining
to happen
and height is just the same pattern
but this is kind of verbose
and
when i do this sort of thing i like to
look at the source code of d3 axis
as a reference
because
it has much the same
pattern
to it
but the implementation is is pretty um
pretty concise
and this is part of d3 itself so
i think it's a good
reference to use it's a it's a much
smaller way
of implementing
these getter setter functions
and since we'll have a bunch of these i
would prefer this one
the way it works is
you know it it uses underscore for the
name of the thing that gets passed in
and it says okay return
if there is an argument
set the
value of the thing internally
comma
axis an axis in our case is going to be
my
and this is a weird little javascript
expression that you can do you can
actually have an expression that is just
two
things separated by a comma
and it implicitly returns the second
thing
and so in this case axis gets returned
to enable the method chaining
but if there
if there's no argument then it just
returns
uh offset this internal variable here
so i'm just gonna copy this template
and use it over here and adapt it
to to our code here so instead of axis
it's going to be my
instead of offset i'm going to start
with width and height because width and
height does need to be configured
so my dot width
equals
a function where if a value is specified
it just sets that value
to be
width
right here
and it returns
my
otherwise it will just return
with
but width is not defined in this scope
yet
so i need to say let with
like this
and we can't use
const because we reassign to width here
so that's why
this needs to be let
and this is the general pattern
of
these chainable getter setter functions
now i i realized this might have been a
lot
are there any questions
so far
yeah the
the plus that came before the underscore
um
was that to
ensure that it was a number because i
think that worked that this came up in
the previous lesson
exactly yep that's exactly what it is
so in in d3 axis i think it was the
offset which
is expected to be a number
and so yeah if you pass in a string like
you know it gets to be that value but if
you
if you preface it with this unary plus
operator it parses the string into a
number
and so that um we actually could add it
there
this is this is called um
defensive
programming
where you sort of expect the worst case
you know you expect people might abuse
the api and pass in a string where
they're really supposed to pass in a
number
so
that's why the plus is there it's just
to guarantee that before it gets to this
variable inside that it's
the right type of thing
um
so hey why not let's let's leave it
there
it'll make our api more robust so we
could pass in a string if you you know
if we
accidentally
had a string that's our width and
everything would work out just fine
yeah
and the um
the my after the comma that that is i
don't think i've seen that before um
yeah yeah this one threw me for a loop
the first time i saw it too let me
unpack it a little bit
yeah i'm glad you're asking because
it's a lot to process
so in javascript
there is this um
this construct that's not very widely
used which is just parentheses
and stuff separated by commas
and when you execute that
it returns the last
thing um and those things in the middle
could potentially have side effects so
let's say let x equals
zero
we can have something like x
equals five
comma
as a a piece of javascript and like it's
yeah it's cryptic it's kind of weird but
to understand what it does it just you
know it just executes this
and
it returns the last thing
and so this is a miniature version of
what's happening in the code here
it says width equals this thing
and so now if we inspect the value of x
it it's actually five
because it was assigned here
and this you know
in all likelihood this violates some
kind of like
you know if you were to use eslint this
might not pass eslint because it's too
it's cryptic
um
but this is what mike bostock uses in d3
axis so
it's good enough for me
that's sort of how i look at it and i
think these these parentheses inside may
have been added by prettier if i run
prettier
it adds those parentheses i guess just
for clarity
um but yeah that's what's going on here
if you just have
parentheses
with commas
it executes all of those things and it
returns the last
entry in the list
yep that makes sense thank you yeah
um and another another thing that may
not be obvious is that
we can't use
the arrow function
here because with
with the arrow function
arguments is not defined
um
check this out
if we make an arrow function that just
logs out arguments
arguments is a special keyword in
javascript
if we execute f
we get arguments is not defined
that's one of those little changes that
was introduced with the fat arrow
function
but instead if we say f equals function
you know the long form where we write
out function
then we can access
arguments
and it gets undefined but if we pass in
like one two three as the arguments
that's what arguments resolves to the is
the arguments that you pass into the
function
so um
we could you know instead check like
is the value defined but then that would
like break in the case of zero you know
which
so as a general reusable pattern for
these getter setter things
um this is the safest way to check
if there were any arguments passed in or
not
and that's why
we use this keyword function so so that
we get arguments defined
inside of here
all right so we can move on and and we
could do the same thing for
height
we can set height and return height
and define height up here
and now we can begin to move our
visualization logic into this component
here
the way it's going to look
is
in our main
we're going to load in the data
and then
all this logic is going to be go inside
of this scatter plot function
which we're calling my right here
so i'm just going to paste it it's not
going to work
and this is how
we can invoke
this component we can say
well first of all we need to import it
import
scatter plot
from dot slash
and now we can use it in much the same
way as we use
a d3 axis we can say scatter plot
dot width
is width which we have here as our
you know window.inner width
and same thing for dot height
we can call dot height which invokes our
setter and we can pass in the local
variable here
height
and then we can
call this
with our
svg element
and that's another aspect of this
towards reusable charts pattern
is that it accepts as input a d3
selection
and it's going to put stuff inside of
that selection so
um
similarly to axes like d3 axis it
expects a d3 selection of a group
element
and then it puts the axis stuff inside
of there
our scatter plot can do the same you
know it could accept maybe
a whole svg element or or an svg group
element either way could work
and this is how you would invoke it you
know pass in the selection
to the chart
which is equivalent to saying selection
dot call
my chart and we got into this last time
with the axes
and so
the way that i would love to see it
is svg.call
scatterplot
width and height like this
so this is the the overall pattern
i'm just going to keep going until it
works
another point of contention with this
pattern is how to deal with the data i
think we should deal with the data as
just another thing that we can set you
know so let's set dot data
we pass in the data
and then in our scatter plot
implementation
we can have another one of these local
variables called data
and then we can have another one of
these
accessors
for data
and in this case we
we must not have this little plus
because uh it's expected to be an array
not not a string that's going to be
coerced into a number so i'm going to
get rid of that it's just going to set
data internally to whatever was passed
in here
and
it's it's going to remain broken for a
while so i'm just going to keep going
like this adding the things that we need
for example x value y value
margin and radius
these are all
you know configurable things so let's go
ahead and add
add these as
as configurable things on our plot
the way it would look to invoke this
stuff is that we could say
dot
x value
and pass in this function
dot y value
dot margin
and pass in
this margin
and then dot
radius
passing in
like that and then when we use prettier
it all formats nicely
and this is what it looks like to
configure
our scatter plot
now we need to go and implement all of
those
as you know local variables with getter
setters
so
we've got what was it x value
y value
margin
radius
and then i'm just going to copy the same
template
four
times
change data to x value which is going to
be a function
change data to y value
which is also going to be a function
change data to margin
which will be an object
and then change data to radius
which
will be a number so we can actually
bring back that little plus
to be defensive
about how we implement this
okay now we have getter setters for x
value y value margin and radius
[Music]
when i see the the more verbose version
of that function
um the one that you showed before
a
the function evaluates the absence of
argument when with an exclamation mark
right
in this more concise version how is the
absence of length is being evaluated in
this in this version oh i see what
you're asking
yeah yeah let me explain it's it's a um
oh there's all our errors
it's a behavior of javascript where
so
let's say let's um
bool equals
true bool is going to be some boolean
value
and so if we have something like
bull question mark
yes or no
it evaluates to yes
if bool
is
false
it evaluates to no
and here's the tricky bit in javascript
there's this notion of truthy
things are truthy or falsey
you know when they're coerced to
booleans
strings for example numbers
when you pass them in when you treat
them like booleans they're they're
coerced to be truthy or falsy and so the
way that that plays out in the case of
arguments.length
is going to be a number because
arguments is an array
and so if arguments.length is 0
then the value of 0 will be put into
this ternary operator and it turns out
that 0 is falsy in javascript so that's
why
it would evaluate to no
but if the length of arguments is let's
say 1
that evaluates to something that is
truthy in javascript it's kind of true
it's it's like true
if it's treated as a boolean and so that
would evaluate to yes
so that's why
arguments.length works in this case like
it does
great okay it makes sense thanks nice
nice happy to hear it
and this is so great i'm so glad that
that you're asking these questions
because
sometimes i don't know what to stop and
explain and what what not to you know so
thanks for your question
all right let's keep going here
um
looking at this file
it seems like everything is right we're
pulling in the data we're defining our
svg
um
one thing that we're not doing yet is
in our scatter plot
this function here needs to take as
input a selection
i can call it svg
but honestly i would rather not because
it could be an svg it could be a group
element
and so i'm just going to replace
svg with selection
so i just replaced all instances of svg
with selection
and now it should work we might be
missing some imports yeah that that's
one thing that's
outstanding
um oh i never changed this around
to use the es6 import syntax
this is something i should have done as
soon as i moved it to index.js
so we can import all this stuff that we
need from d3
and in scatter plot
dot js we're going to need scale linear
extent axis left and axis bottom but not
csv and not select and in index.js i
don't think we're going to need any of
that other stuff
so we could just use
csv and select
over there
so let's see is it working
um
oh we get a nice error
unexpected token
okay
there's an unexpected token somewhere
in index.js
line 46.
it's missing the column in line 45.
um
in line 40
no no you're
chaining no you cannot have that
it almost feels like it has like a like
an older version of
my file
ah scale yeah it was some some sort of
glitch
now it says scale linear is not defined
okay fair enough
scale linear we should be getting that
from
d3
that's odd
let me try console.log scale linear
to see if it
is even like loading to that point
it is
it's there
so now what
what
what it's working
the total um
total 20 magic yeah total twilight zone
moment with errors that resolve
themselves
yeah like magic
all right
sweet
we've done it it works
this is amazing
so yeah just just to quickly review
everything
index.js
has all the logic that we had
from earlier where it loads in the data
it sets up the svg
but now our main function
is a lot more concise it just
invokes our scatter plot
and configures it with all this stuff
and here's something that's kind of
mind-blowing you can take this
expression
and and we can skip that local variable
we could just pass that straight into
data like that
that works too
yeah to me that's a mind-blowing thing
because a weight it's like this
asynchronous control flow and it it has
to like
wait until that's done before it invokes
this whole thing but that's the magic of
um async await right there and i kind of
prefer it like this it's it's more
uniform all the configuration happens
right here
awesome awesome um yeah and in our
scatter plot we have a bunch of local
variables in this closure
um
a closure is this the scope of the
variables inside of this function so
when you invoke the scatter plot
constructor it creates this closure
and that's where these variables live
and we use let here not const because
they can change
over time
and then we've got this my function that
gets invoked with a selection and this
is where it sets up all the scales and
does all the
you know transformations
right here
and it references these variables that
are defined above
and it resolves to the things that we
passed in
to these these getter setter functions
and we just use them as setters
not getters
and
yeah all the logic is the same as same
as it was before for the scatter plot
and it works
so with this template and
one
would be able to change the data set and
the and the name of the variable the new
variables if you change the data set and
it will update like automatically now
exactly
yes that's right and and the key thing
is that
nothing at all
inside scatterplot.js
will need to change
nothing at all if you change the data
set that's what i meant earlier by
separating the specific from the generic
like this is a totally generic scatter
plot implementation if you were to
change the data set
the only file you would need to change
is index.js you can change the csv url
change how the rows are parsed
and change the configuration of the plot
and all that
yeah this is like the whole point of
this reusable pattern is that all of
this configuration happens
outside of that reusable component
so yeah you can just tweak it right here
if you want it to be um
you know pedal width you could just
change it right here
and boom it updates
if if i want you
to have like the specie
as a different marker
as a classification marker
how could i add this to this code
that's a great question
and let me just clarify what you mean by
marker i think you might mean
like a different shape
like these yep
yes that's right that's right yeah
you know this would be um
this would be a great thing to try to do
as an exercise this week
and and i can outline how to do it i
don't think we have time today to
actually do it but i can outline yeah
but
but should i use like a case switch
uh inside and where in the logic this uh
switch case
uh how algorithm
would be
or should i use
something completely different
well let me walk through how how you
would how you might do it um
the switch case meaning
the logic that determines which shape it
is is that what you mean
yes yes
so d3 dot symbol
does that
um with symbol.type
yeah yeah this would be actually a great
thing to work through
but what you would do is create an
instance of d3 symbol
and then
set up an ordinal scale
that maps
the the three values for the species to
these
symbols you know maybe three particular
symbols
and yeah it's exposed as like symbol
circle symbol cross
symbol diamond
so it would be something like you know
create an ordinal scale
and then set the range to be
d3 symbol circle d3 symbol cross d3
symbol diamond
and that scale
you can pass in a value from the species
column and it will give you back out one
of these
one of these symbol types
and then
in the rendering logic of the scatter
plot
instead of
rendering circles these would be paths
and then
when you set the the d attribute of the
path
you would want to
change the type of the symbol
and then invoke the symbol
and that's how you could make a scatter
plot with different shapes
i don't know i kind of want to just go
ahead and do it right now
what do you think should i
yes do it do it do it right
yeah let's do it let's do it why not
i'm gonna keep this as it is because
it's nice and clean but i'm gonna fork
this and say
reusable d3 scatter plot with cymbals
oh i love this it's gonna be so much fun
okay now we need to import uh these
things oh actually symbols check it out
symbols is an array containing the set
of built-in symbol types so we could
just use that okay so i'm going to
import symbols
from d3
and then
i'm going to build out something very
similar to x and y i'm going to call it
um
symbol i guess
symbol value
and then i'll set up
another one of these accessors
for symbol value
it's going to be a function
and then in index.js this is where we
would want to say okay our symbol value
is the species
i think it's
d dot species
um let's take a look yes yes it is it is
nice
yeah species nice
okay so this is how we would invoke it
and configure it now let's implement the
rendering
so instead of circles these would be
paths
select all path
and
instead of cx and cy
oh yeah we would still need to position
these oh how would we do that
you know what we would want to do is um
probably use
group l yeah okay okay it's getting a
little tricky here
but let's just get a bunch of different
shapes to show up and then we can
um
we can worry about
positioning them
looking for the okay there's a
constructor
so let's import symbol
from d3
and then we're gonna need a symbol scale
i'm gonna call it symbol scale because
symbol the word the the name symbol is
already taken because it's imported
and this will be an ordinal scale
we need to import that as well from d3
and the range
this is the key thing the range is going
to be symbols
and the domain
you know we don't actually need to set
the domain
uh because it sort of fills in
automatically
but just for completeness sake we could
say data.map
symbol value
and that will just get all of the
different species values
and that will contain duplicates but
that's okay because when you pass an
array with duplicates to scale ordinal
dot domain
it automatically you know deduplicates
it
so we can just say
just to inspect how that ended up
symbol scale.domain let's just
console.log that it should just give us
those three values
oh there's some problem oh i forgot a
comma
there we go see
so that's correct
satoshi versus color virginica
and then if we take a look at the range
it's a bunch of these
d3 symbol implementations which are
actually objects that have a draw
function
but we don't really strictly need to
know
what that is
okay now we need to create a symbol
generator
simple generator is
new
symbol
using the constructor from d3
and let me see
um
size defaults to 64. that should be fine
i mean we could we could use it to
change the size but let's just use the
default for now see how it turns out
and this is the thing we can say symbol
dot type
so this is what we need to do
we need to make these paths
and
we don't need cy cx or r
but we need
d
which is this domain specific language
for svg paths
that's what the symbol generator will
output
so we can call symbol generator
so this will be a function that takes as
input d and then we can call simple
generator of
symbol
value of d
those these are different right the
the string one and the the other one
they don't mean the same thing
right they are totally distinct and
different yeah it's confusing that they
have the same name
um d is the attribute of an svg path
which has a very specific meaning
so if you look at the documentation for
svg paths it expects a d attribute
that is going to be a string
that is a
it's an expression in a domain specific
language that defines svg paths
okay
so
yeah so this d
is the attribute d
and this d is
it's called
it's just one of the rows
okay not a column but a row in it's it's
an element in the data array or rather
the marks array
and you know oh my gosh
i i sort of forgot that we have this
transformation step
so this is actually where we can compute
d which makes it even more
confusing in a way because we d dot d
um but this is where it makes sense to
pass in
yeah to do the transformation to the
marks
to for clarity i'm going to call it path
path d
because it's there's too many d's
okay and this should
work
i think but
looks like broken let's see what's going
on
cannot access symbol generator before
initialization okay yeah that makes
sense
i have to move it to be
before we compute the marks
okay i think it's
sort of working see that we have some
stuff in the
but it's in the corner that's the
problem
and they're pretty tiny they're pretty
tiny
so i kind of want to make it
bigger
but the the main problem is they're all
in one place they're all in the corner
and i wonder
can we have a transform
if you just uh set attribute x and y
it does not work
i don't believe x and y works on paths i
mean we can try it
that would be ideal if it did
but it doesn't
okay
we may be able to specify a transform
on the
path so we can translate
by
d
dot x
and d dot y
but i don't know if that's going to work
oh sorry i forgot to make it a function
of
d oh well look at that it's sort of
worked
but but they're all circles
they're all circles that's indicative of
a problem yeah yeah i forgot to um
i forgot
to
set the type
so here's what we need to do this is not
right we need to
we need to call simple generator dot
type
and then invoke it
this is what we need to do
uh looks like there's some problem
maybe that's not quite right
why this empty parenthesis in the end
yeah i think we need to invoke it
or
you know maybe i should consult the
documentation
assemble that type
yeah but it seems that you're invoking
two times
there
again
see this is what i want to do i want to
i want to create an instance
of d3 symbol we'll call it simple
generator
and then for each mark i want to say
symbol generator dot type
is
oh oh i forgot to pass it through the
scale that's
so silly so symbol
scale
of symbol value of d
okay so symbol value of d will give us
the species value
we need to pass that through the scale
symbol scale in order to get at the
particular symbol and remember symbol
scale
it just maps the
the symbol
the
species to the various symbols that we
imported from d3
so we need to call simplegenerator.type
to set the type and then these empty
parentheses on the end are to invoke the
symbol generator
as a function to generate this path
string so now we can see that it's
actually
giving us different types of shapes
yeah it's kind of tricky business
it is
but i think what we need to do
to move these around
um oh wait a minute
it should be missing the clothes
like this that's what it needs to be
there we go
there we go so it's translating by x and
y
correctly now
yeah
this is what you were trying to do isn't
it yes very cool amazing
amazing great great yeah that only take
like 10 minutes amazing
okay now i can make a scatter plot
kuhn's face
yeah
you totally could yeah yeah you could
even put different people's faces
yeah
nice
wow pretty satisfying um one thing
that's just not quite linked up yet i
just want to wrap this up nicely radius
is here but it's not being used so what
i want to do is use it so that we can
configure
the size
of the symbols
but radius doesn't make sense we can use
size instead
and the default was 164. so let me say
size is 50
and then in in our scatter plot
i'm just going to do a search and
replace
across the whole thing
replacing radius
with how do you do a search and replace
in views
oh i'm using
i'm using vim mode
and then once you enter vim mode you can
use the vim command
for the search and replace which is this
okay so the
the percent
means
global
search and replace um
s means
search i guess it's it's one of those
sort of obscure vim things
um it works with uh some other command
line tools too in linux
but yeah this is how you trigger it you
you hit colon to enter this little space
which is you know derived from vim the
editor
and then radius is the thing you find
size is the thing it gets replaced with
g means global means um
it means to replace
every instance
on a line
and so this is just sort of the the
incantation to make it happen
so once i run that
we have size
and once we have size
defined here
then what we can do is
we can pass it into our simple generator
dot size size like that
and it it could we could make it vary
for each mark
but for now i'm just going to make it
all the same size
and just to confirm that it's working
i'm going to change the size here to
like 500
okay and it gets bigger
and yeah size it's the behavior of size
with d3 symbols can be a little
counter-intuitive because it actually
was really well thought out so that the
area of each of the symbols
is the same
i'm pretty sure
um and and when you change the size
you're actually changing the area
so
it's not a linear scale in at play here
it's it's more like a square root scale
internally so if i change it to like a
thousand
that means there's going to be a
black pixels
for each shape
but if i change it to a hundred that
means there's going to be a hundred
filled in black pixels
for each shape
and while i'm talking about symbols
i would be remiss to not show this
really nice piece
um oh that's not the one
hang on hang on
mike bostock has this really nice
thing that illustrates that they're all
the same
area
it'll be worth the wait
there it is
yeah this is a really nice little piece
by mike bostock that he developed um
looks like in 2017 i think when he was
working on building out d3 shape
and so notice here how the radius
of each of these circles is different
but it says here each of these shapes
has a configurable area
here 2 500 square pixels
and so this is the
this is the like deep thought
that that you get for free when you use
d3 symbol
it turns out that each of these shapes
has exactly the same number of filled in
pixels and that's what gets configured
when you call dot size
all right well that's how we do it
that's how we make a scatter plot with
symbols
within the confines of this reusable
chart pattern and this is just playing
out so well i mean i would much prefer
to do things this way to have a reusable
chart pattern in place and then branch
out to all sorts of different
visualization types rather than
you know get it basically working in one
huge file
and fork that a a bunch of times
so
yeah thanks thanks everyone for for you
know sticking with me through this
refactoring effort
and i hope it was useful
thanks quran it was really insightful
all this class
nice happy to hear it happy to hear it
i'd like to leave you all with some
exercise options
fork and modify
what we made
and
maybe add axis labels one of the things
that it's missing is the labels the text
labels on the axes
and i think we have now enough
knowledge of d3 to be able to do that
another option would be you know fork
this scatter plot and change the data
set to get that experience
of
just changing the index file and leaving
leaving the scatter plot implementation
as it is as a generic thing
or
fork this and change the chart type i
mean you would probably need to change
the data set too
in order to do that but that would be a
great exercise if you could fork this
and maybe change it to be a line chart
component or an area chart or a bar
chart
uh we're going to be doing that in
subsequent episodes
but if you you know feel inspired by all
means take stab at it now
um and if
if you can't get it done you know at
least take a stab at it share your work
and maybe maybe you could use that as a
jumping off point for a future
episode
so all of this is in the forum the viz
hub forum
i made one for
episode nine
uh where did it go
i may have lost it or something
but i'm going to make one now for
episode nine
uh so you can post there
welcome everyone to episode 10 of get it
right in black and white dynamic charts
so first i'd like to start with some
introductions
um we have some we have a new person
today
welcome maxine
uh you want to introduce yourself
briefly
yeah so i'm maxine or max and i worked a
bit on
um viz hub with curran and that was
really fun because i think it's a great
product
and now i'm a data visualization
engineer for mural and in my free time i
just try to learn as much as i can about
d3
nice i love mural by the way i've
started using it it's a really neat tool
and ideal is here hey adil
hi karen hi maxine
all right so
let's start by reviewing the submissions
from last time
we go reusable charts
so here's one from
felipe
hilarious
um
i think it's it's like the data of how
many viz hub users there are but with my
face in there
so nice work felipe
um yeah very cool very cool
i want to take a just quick look at the
code it's still the same scatter plot
like template with the
you know the methods and everything
and it's just been modified internally
to show these
svg paths
pretty cool
all right what else have we got
something from
ej dasbach
this is pretty neat
i was actually pretty impressed with
this one
it's a nice actual visualization
of
covet 19 deaths over time
and uh yeah great work adding the title
adding the labels for the axes
vaccination at 30
that's like some additional information
pretty cool and great job linking to the
source too in the viz itself
very cool very cool and this easily
could be converted to a line chart just
by modifying some of the internals i
think a line chart might make more sense
for this particular data although it's
kind of cool with the dots because you
can see the gaps
yeah good stuff
all right yeah there was some confusion
about last week i had to cancel but um
all right i think that's it
that's all there is
so all right great to see some
participation
[Music]
yeah before i dig into
stuff for today
i'm just wondering are there any
questions from last week's content adil
or maxine
uh that was unclear
not from my end i thought it was pretty
clear nice
yeah it was it was really
very clear um i think
returning
the method chaining in particular was
quite um
it was it was just yeah really
eye-opening really
oh great i'm glad to hear it
yeah yeah that the pattern still blows
my mind because it's just javascript
essentially
but you can make these components and
you're not tied to any particular
framework like react or view or anything
i was wondering
when um
doing the core dot call
and
all the method chaining that follows
whether there is a
uh whether there's a convention uh at
all or um
a preferred i guess it's a
personal approach but um
when uh
when when doing this uh svg.call scatter
plot um
then
all the methods that uh
follow um are they is it recommended to
do them in any particular order for
example to do the data manipulation
first followed by the
dom
anything that touches the dom or is it
um
is that
is i just just it's up to the
uh personal preference um
yeah that's a great question does the
order matter is there any particular
patterns no i would say no it's it's
like lego blocks you know you can
assemble these things in any way that
you want and as long as their
relationships are correct between like
the inputs and the outputs
and um
the order of like the
the dependencies
uh is correct like first you need to set
up the svg then you need to call it but
beyond that
um no it doesn't really matter it's
totally personal preference you know
which order you call these things um
and even
i've seen it quite often where you you
construct the
the element like
right here instead of even having a
variable and like that works too it's
totally personal preference yeah
stylistic
yeah that makes sense thank you
all right we've got another guest
um
[Music]
hello there you want to um here let me
just pull up the introduction slide
are you here
yes i'm here eric dosbach here can you
hear me yes i can hear you great to meet
you
yeah nice to meet you um finally got
this down figuring out between um
youtube and
um
google meetup so
yeah yeah it's kind of a kind of a
quirky setup but it works
yep
so just a little about myself uh data
scientists outside philadelphia trying
to upskill uh my data visualization so i
uh
filed the
first nine
and uh now
uh
looking forward to participating live
amazing amazing welcome and i i think i
just um presented your work but yep but
i would like to welcome you to present
it yourself here we go let me find it
sure
here it is
yep
yeah so a little bit
yeah so thank you yeah so the um so
appreciate the opportunity the
uh
part of what i do and so i work in
healthcare and and part of what i do is
visualizations of
these sorts of dynamics and so forth and
so i really enjoyed the notion that we
had a reusable scatter plot and i think
the assignment was to switch out to
another data set one and then to start
adding axes and so forth and you know i
found that framework
uh
really useful from which to do it i
think probably one of the most
challenging things i found was just
the date scale and figuring that out and
just you know
trying to get that to line up right and
i still haven't figured out how to
manipulate uh the months and years and
so forth quite right
but um because
bizhub is so nice and interactive it
allowed me to just keep trial and
erroring to get it to this point
which is really helpful for uh learning
nice
that's fantastic
yeah well so yeah and i guess the other
part of the assignment
sorry i lost you there
you there
i lost your sound there eric are you
still there
yeah i'm still here yeah oh you were
saying
oh yeah i was just saying so
i think his sound is down yeah i lost
your sound
um
oh you muted yourself
can you hear me now yes
okay
uh
yeah so i was just saying that i guess
the other aspect of this was trying to
um figure out how to make things item
potent
oh well yeah that's what i was going to
get into today that's what i plan to
really touch on today
and so um so i'm starting to go back to
some of your work and react
um
ah yep
yeah i mean i would like to address some
of your questions around the the day
formatting and stuff because it's
actually quite simple what you can do
to make adjustments to the formatting
um
so it's a little bit off topic but i'll
spend like five minutes on it just to to
move that forward because if because you
were struggling with that
so when you oh i gotta fork this to make
some edits
to have a little more control over the
the dates
and the formatting there
so we've got a scale time here
and one thing you can do is control the
number of ticks by saying
dot ticks
and you pass in like five or something
that gives you
oh it's not loading
what happened
oh sorry not on the scale not on the
scale on the axis
yeah that's something that trips me up
so when we when we create the axis oh
you did that already it takes six
so if we up it till like 16
we get more
ticks
and so if you want to change the
formatting is that what you wanted to do
change that formatting
yeah i was trying to figure out so
implicitly there was
it dropped the years in and then um the
months and so forth and i was trying to
figure out how how to actually
manipulate those sorts of things
totally totally so you can use this
thing called
d3 time format and this old example on
blocks.org from zen armstrong
is a tried and true
way of of figuring out how to format
dates with d3
so the way you use it is uh now it's
called time format camel case it used to
be time dot format
but the api is pretty much the same so
you can pass in this weird looking
string like you know percent y dash
percent m and each of these little codes
has a specific meaning like this is the
full year this is the the month as zero
one
but let's see
what kind of
ticks might be appropriate maybe just
the month
right like uh
yep i think i actually found this site
too
nice i was
i was um
not getting it
somewhere in there i had the month uh
aspect
oh nice and time format is even there i
see yeah
nice nice
and so when you call axis bottom you can
just call dot format
oh okay
or maybe it's
i think it's actually tick
format
yeah and then you can just pass in
a time format
of
this string
which
i can't remember i have to look at the
example dollar sign b
for like jan feb like that yeah
then i'll use prettier to format the
code
and now we get
huh that did not seem to do the trick
actually
yeah then you have to i think manipulate
the text to
well that should work
that should work let me see if i get any
errors no
hmm
so if i search for d3 axis tick format i
hope i get the um
the name right
yeah axis.tick format
i should do the trick
[Music]
i wonder if it was set somewhere else as
well
i think you're right i i i know i said
it somewhere else i'm trying to remember
where
yeah cause i think if you
if you set it on the axis
or the scale
it might like take precedence or
something
oh wait a minute there's two
oh there there's two axes on the bottom
yeah i forgot to clean that out this is
when i was going to item potent
oh nice let me see
so that might be just not visible and
then let's try putting it on this other
one
let's see
we need one more parent yep
there we go
yep there got it boom
yeah so that's how it works
very nice very nice
thank you yeah my pleasure thanks for
doing the assignment i'm really happy to
see this sort of uh
engagement and participation
yeah appreciate it thanks
all right we've got a bunch more people
coming
let's see what's going on here
we've got
um
maximiliano
hello
i think you came last time
and we've got ken penn
hey ken welcome
and we've got uh
maribel
welcome maribel
would anyone like to introduce
themselves
am i muted oh there you go i can hear
you now
this is weird um
yeah no i'm still i'm new to to
um to d3 and um
still learning a lot so i have questions
i shall listen okay
cool well feel free to interrupt me as i
go and
and ask the questions along the way
thank you
hey kuran and everyone
yes i was here last week how are you
everything's fine thanks good good
so great to be here again
welcome and i see ken joined us ken you
want to introduce yourself one a little
bit
uh there was a bit of an echo there so i
was kind of holding back uh ken pan um
currently who run on everyone
yes i was here yeah you gotta close the
youtube sorry it's a little a little
funky of a setup good good but if you
close out the youtube uh window
shouldn't work
there we go uh
yeah so uh ken pan um have been using v3
for a bunch of years um
currently um unemployed and um
just uh doing this to stay in practice
and get tuned up on uh incorporating
d3 with uh modern javascript
nice
well i'm glad you could join us ken um
ken and i go way back from the d3
meetups in san francisco
many fond memories of attending events
there
meeting people learning things so
great
you should provide a link to your uh d3
parade entry yesterday that was quite
good oh yeah
yeah that was fun yeah i hope to
actually build something like that as
part of this series as we get further
along
um
but yeah yeah it was fun that was fun
i i think it was very instructive too
and it might be for um
for other people where you showed all
the the
wrong steps broken made art that she had
oh yeah
persisting to the right kind of like you
just helped with the dates just now i
thought that you know learning to use it
instead of uh
just getting frustrated and quit is uh
you know how to persist through that is
really important i think
nice for sure and that's why i'm having
this whole thing um
you know live with q and a so
because i know people get stuck and i
want to teach people how to go from
stuck to unstuck because that's the key
thing
yeah
all right we've got some other folks
joining us um
hello felipe how are you
and we've also got matt oliver
hello matt welcome
howdy uh thanks for doing this queren
i'm in texas
and i'm uh in my day job i'm a product
manager and i love building with d3 and
um
love learning new stuff so happy to be
here and um haven't been able to make
the last few but um
whenever there's time and whenever i can
i wanna i wanna participate so thanks
again
nice this is amazing wow welcome well
this is a full house we've got so many
people so let me just dig into this
what i wanted to do today
was to make our chart that we made last
time
dynamic
meaning
what i was thinking of doing is cycling
through x and y columns
we saw last time that if you change
the code
to change the function that accesses the
data for x
then the meaning of the x column changes
to be that column
and
what i want to really touch upon today
is like
if you want to make such a change
interactively without having to go and
change the code how do you do that
that gets into this concept of
idempotent rendering
where
you have this function that you invoke
namely the scatter plot
and
what you want is that the scatter plot
knows how it's supposed to look it has
all this configuration set up
and what you want to have happen is when
you call that function again
for the second time or the third time or
the fourth time
it should just
sort of whip the dom into shape and and
be like all right dom like you need to
now
change
to represent the new setup the new
configuration
and with d3 there's all these foot guns
um things
that you can use to shoot yourself in
the foot
like
dot append
which doesn't really work well if you
invoke the function again and again
because it's going to append more and
more elements again and again which is
not what we want and there's a couple
telltale signs of when this is happening
that i think i'll get into today
and then if there's time after we get
the idempotent rendering down
if there's time i would like to dig into
animated transitions but we may not we
may or may not get that far we'll see
all right
so
here is the reusable scatter plot
from last time
after last week's session
i i had like a realization that like oh
no it's not actually done
because it's not idem potent
which which sort of defeats the whole
purpose of making it
reusable and this is a word that you
don't usually come across
unless you're in like
computer science
so i just wanted to read the definition
of the word um i think i think the
wikipedia article does it justice
idempotence
is the property of certain operations in
mathematics and computer science
whereby they can be applied multiple
times
without changing the results beyond the
initial application
so the the key here is that
the result that you get after invoking
the function
should be exactly the same
regardless of
the state of affairs before
you invoke that function
and so that let's let's apply this to
our to our code here
all right so first of all we need to
have some change be
happening
and so i propose
that instead of just calling the scatter
plot one time like we're doing here we
can call it
multiple times
in a loop of sorts so let's say every
every second or every two seconds
we change the value
that gets returned from this x value
accessor function and that would have
the effect of you know changing it
from let's say petal width to sepal
with
boom see that change
that's the kind of that's the change
that i want to see
without re-running the program
so how would we do that
there is a a construct in
javascript
called
set interval
and what set interval does
is it accepts
a function as the first argument and as
the second argument it accepts a number
of milliseconds
so if i put a thousand here that means
every second it's going to run this
function
whatever it may be
so let's just
you know console.log here
to make sure that this
the setup is working
then i'll open the console and we can
see
it's printing out here
again and again and again
every second
and those little numbers mean
like that's the number of times that the
same thing was printed out again and
again
and we see it's incrementing every
second but if we change this to
100 it's going to increment every
um tenth of a second so we'll see the
number going a lot faster
so what i want to do here is let's say
every two seconds
we're going to change the meaning of x
but how do we do that
and and this comes back to your question
from earlier a deal of like does the
order that you do this stuff matter
well the order depends on
the use case like the scenario where you
need to invoke this right now we have to
do a little bit of refactoring because
there's a bunch of stuff happening
in one call
but now the task at hand is to tease out
what needs to happen once
at the beginning
versus
what needs to happen
every time we change
x
for example
we're calling await
csv here which will fetch the data
and we don't want to fetch the data
again
every time we
we set it up
and also this scatter plot is being
invoked i mean the constructor of the
scatter plot is being invoked within
this svg call
so we have no way of accessing
the instance of that plot to change its
configuration so i'm going to have to
move this around a little bit
what i'm going to do is
pull this out into a
variable
i guess i'll call it
plot
equals
and then we invoke the scatter plot
now we have
we sort of have a handle on this thing
so we can change it after the fact
now we can do svg call plot right here
to initialize it
and
we can use the same construct inside of
our set interval
console.log plot like that
so now
it is invoking our plot function
every two seconds and we're already
starting to see some of those telltale
signs
that that the thing is not item potent
namely
notice how
around these labels
it's not quite smooth
it's a little um
pixelated or like harsh when you look at
it
i mean and what's happening is the
anti-aliasing is getting messed up
because
what it is there actually is a bunch of
layers of the axis again and again and
again and we can see this if we inspect
the dom
we can see if we zoom out to the right
level
there are multiple copies
of both the x and y axis
being added
and if we scroll down to the bottom
we can see that every two seconds
there's another
copy of both axes being added
so this is the problem that we have to
set out to fix and this is a very common
type of bug
when you're working with d3
because the way d3 is
structured like
you can get something working
when you invoke it once and that's
pretty straightforward you can use the
dot append construct
however when you
when you have a situation where
you need the thing to change over time
you have to actually do different stuff
you need to make sure that you use the
general update pattern of d3
which handles the enter the update and
the exit of all of these dom nodes
and the problem here is that the parent
group
for the axes
is being just appended over and over
so that's what we need to change
so let me go back to our
scatter plot although you know let me
let me just finish this
this thought first what we want to do is
change the value of x and we're ready to
do that so let's do that first let's
change x
and then let's go and make our our
reusable component idempotent
we can just say plot
dot x value
and instead of d dot petal width
we're going to want to cycle through
so we can say d at
column
and we can say column equals
petal width
to start
and
how do we cycle through
the various columns i propose we have
something called columns
which is going to be an array
and petal width will be one of the
options
another of the options is
sepal width
and then
we can copy those options
and add
height
or no length what was it
let me figure out what that was actually
from the data
yeah it does length
oh yeah length length it was indeed
so we can change width to length
now we've got these options to choose
from for our columns
and
what we want to do is say column is
columns
at index
let's say i
and i
is something that i would like to
increment
every two seconds but once it gets to
the top we should it should like cycle
back it should circle back
so instead of using const i'm going to
define this outside of set interval and
use let
i'll initialize i to 0
and say i
plus plus
and then console.log i
let's see what this does
so
far it says
one
two
three
four five and this is where it's getting
buggy
because um
once it gets beyond
three
it should go back to zero
and the way that we can do this
is
i equals
i plus one
modulo
columns
dot length
-1
and just for
well let's see if it runs
zero zero
oh it's not working
just for some context if you haven't
seen the modulo operator
four modulo
two is zero
but five modulo two is one
a modular 2 is is a way that you can
check if it's even or odd
and so
what we want to do
is
make i go from zero to like three and
then go back to zero
so you know what we could do actually is
just
we could simply say i plus plus
let it increment
and then let's console.log i modulo
column stat length
minus one
you know it could have been a
parenthesis issue
let's try like this
so we see one
two
zero
one
two
zero
but we have four options
um maybe it's just a not off by one kind
of a thing
let's just modulo by columns.length
i think this should give us the right
thing now
one
two
three
zero
all right so we just need to use this
when we access
from columns
like this
so we can just sort of um compress this
like so
and i kind of want it to start at zero
so let me just increment i after
we do this this stuff here
all right now it should be behaving
as we expect
so this is a dynamic scatter plot
um the circles are idempotent
they're behaving correctly
so what it's doing is it's cycling
through
each of these for x
and notice that at a certain point we
see a diagonal that's that's when x and
y are the same column
here's the problem now
the axes are getting messed up see the
x-axis it's just a bunch of copies now
let's address that problem
of
multiple axes
uh but at this point are there any
questions about what i've done so far
um i
i
[Music]
i wanted to ask
how this
concept of item potent relates with the
the update pattern in the tree because i
i i don't know if it's related but but
it's like
the same principle i guess because the
points
are dynamically changing but i haven't
seen this concept before when we see the
update pattern the enter update exit
pattern so i'm not sure if how they are
related
right right
and
by the way people don't really talk
about it they don't use this term very
often
and the term idimpotent rendering i
think was used back in the days of
jquery
when it became like a thing
um
so maybe that's why
like it's not a commonly used term it's
like a sort of a nerdy computer science
term but i think it's the right term to
apply here
but the relationship between the concept
of idempotent rendering and d3's general
update pattern is
it's the same
thing
d3's general update pattern makes the
rendering item potent
and so
um
let's let's take a look at our code for
the circles
what this does is it uses the new dot
join api
which does a bunch of stuff internally
it creates an enter selection
and an update selection and it merges
them together and it returns the
resulting selection and then we can set
the circle the the attributes on
the resulting thing so that is an
idempotent rendering pattern
let me show you a variant of this that
is not
idempotent
if we call
dot enter
dot append
circle
and then we set the attributes on those
circles
what we're going to get is a bunch of
overlapping
circles oh no i'm that's not right
that's not right because
it is actually
only
so when it's when it says select all
circle it's picking up the circles that
it rendered last time
but this is not idempotent because it's
not updating it's not updating it's not
working right
so to make it item potent we use enter
dot append circle
um
well we could use the dot merge
thing
check it out um
circles dot merge
um
sorry this should be circles
which is the update selection
and then we merge it with the enter
selection
like this
this should be the idepotent version of
it
see now it's updating properly
and this is like super confusing
it's sort of a deprecated api to use
merge like this it's very low level it
helps you out
but what this is doing is exactly the
same thing as this
simplified api where you just call dot
join
and it and join also
handles the exit case so if there were
fewer circles
oops i must have deleted something
data we need
yeah so so this this does item important
rendering
does that answer your question
yes yes definitely that now i i get a
how that concept like
is part of the of the of all this
structure yeah
nice
and so the problem is
are our axes are not idempotent
i mean the axis itself is coded in such
a way that it does correctly do item
potent rendering however
we are appending a group element on the
outside
which is the part of this stuff that's
not item potent it just appends a new
group element on each render which is
not right
this is the special case of the general
update pattern that deals with just a
single element
and so it's sort of a non
it's not the most common form that you
see usually
we call data and we pass an array of
things that actually represents data
however if you want to use d3 selections
for just a single element we need to
just make up some data that has a single
element
so let's do it
selection dot select all
um
we could try dot g
oh we could try g here just to select
all group elements however i could tell
you right now this is not going to fly
because we have multiple group elements
one for each axis and we need to
disambiguate between them so at this
point before i go any further
i'm going to i'm going to use a class to
disambiguate these
select alt dot
i'll call it y axis y dash axis
because this it's the y axis
dot data
and this is where we need to pass in an
array that has a single element so i
could just put the number one or
whatever i'm going to use null
because i've seen this around in in the
d3 source code actually for
i think d3 axis uses this
so it's it's an array of data
that doesn't really have data it's just
null it's but the the thing is it's a
single element
so it doesn't really matter what that
element is it just matters that it's an
array that has a single element
because when you use the dot join
construct
like i think i could say join
g
dot attr
i have to give it the class
of y-axis
so that it picks up
the one that was added previously
this i believe should work
and i think we could say g dot
y axis just to make it really clear i
think that's a valid selector means it
means that the the tag name is g and the
class
is y axis
so the y-axis actually looks good
on the side see it's not getting that
thick
quality to it which indicates to me that
it's just rendering
once
um so what happens is every time
the function gets executed
it's taking a look at what was there
from the last time and just whipping it
into shape to match what it should be
this time
and because we're not changing y
it doesn't change
uh which is the right thing
so now let's apply the same pattern to x
this is where we'll actually see it
um
we'll see it work
more clearly because the axis won't be
totally messed up
so i'm just going to copy paste
that whole pattern
and then change
y-axis to x-axis
and let's see let's see if that does the
trick
yeah see that
now it's correct
yep
the axis is not getting
all messed up
so just to run through what's happening
again here
we're using
this dot join api of d3 which is the
modern day you know general update
pattern of d3 that handles enter update
and exit
and we're passing it a data set that
just has a single thing a single element
which is null but it could be anything
doesn't it really doesn't matter what it
is
but just the fact that there's one of
them
is what matters because the the
internals of dot join will take that
data and say okay
i just need to make a single group
element so
if there's already a group element there
that matches this selection then i'm
going to use it i'm going to use the old
one that was there before i'm not going
to make a new one
and so that's the beauty of this the
first time it runs it will create an a
brand new a mint brand new
group element but the second time the
third time the fourth time it's just
going to use the grip element that was
there before and then it's going to
call
this axis function which itself
implements idempotent rendering properly
internally
so that makes the whole thing
item potent and and working
correctly
so this is it this is this is the
the complete
version of the reusable chart
now you can use this you know swap out
things in in real time and it'll work
correctly
any questions
great i think it's great so so if i
understand correctly the
with the
null
like a
array that you create
it's like a a a unique id
for the for the group and that way it
recognizes
as the same thing when it updates
well
it's not really an id it's not actually
used
at all the thing that's serving as an id
to differentiate between the different
groups
is actually the class
so let me show you what happens if we
get rid of this
class
if we just say select all g
and then select all g for both of these
axes
let's see what happens
see it's only getting one of them
the y axis is not showing up at all
and so in terms of the concept of unique
id
to disambiguate between them the class
is really what plays that role the data
that array of null is just to signify
that there's one thing that we want
not two not zero but there's
just one thing that's the significance
of the
of that right
right right thank you
and just to deconstruct why
there's no um y-axis here
when this code runs
it builds up the y-axis
first
because select all g
the first time there's no group element
it'll create one
and then after that runs
the code that is for the x-axis says
select all g
boom it's going to select that group
element that was used for the y-axis
that's what happens
that's what happens when you don't use
classes it selects whatever group
element is there on
the page like as a child of the
selection
and so
that's why
um it's clobbering
the y-axis and it's it's using the same
group element and it's building it into
the x-axis
so let's bring back our
our selection that uses class
yeah so
now it says select all elements that
have the class y axis
if it's the first time there's going to
be none so it's going to make a new one
give it the class but if it's the second
time around it's going to find the one
that
that this code put there before and use
it
yeah
okay so i'm going to leave this
reusable scatter plot
here
as it is because now i feel like it's
finished
i'm going to fork this
because the animated transitions do add
quite a bit of complexity
so i'll call it
animated
reusable
d3 scatter plot
all right in our scatter plot
i'm thinking we can focus on the circles
as the thing to add animation to
and maybe
we could potentially animate the axes
as well
d3 axes are implemented in such a way
that you can animate them which is
really cool
but first let's get grounded in some
documentation or
examples
so i'm going to search for d3
transitions
yeah d3 transition here it is
looking for some example code
yeah
so with transitions like there's a
million and one ways you can invoke them
um you could even just say dot
transition
actually let me do that first to see
what happens because but i don't think
it's
the right
behavior but
just just as an experiment
if we just put
dot transition
right here what happens
okay
it worked now they're animating
see that
so that's the simplest
way of invoking
d3 transitions
we just add dot transition
and it creates this
thing called a d3 transition that
kind of looks and feels like a d3
selection it so when you call dot
transition it creates a new thing
which is an instance of a transition and
returns it and so these dot attrs
they're being invoked on the transition
not the original selection
and you can also say dot duration
like this
and pass in a number of milliseconds
like let's say two thousand
now the transitions are slower
two seconds
and you can really see the stuff dance
around
pretty neat
however
this is sort of
the
the lazy
approach that ends up in
semi-buggy stuff because
watch this
uh when this program runs
notice how the circles
sort of fly in from the corner
zoom
this is on to me this i mean it's maybe
acceptable
but like to me this is
not right like this is this is kind of
buggy
you know
so i think we need to do the more proper
implementation of of um
of transitions
which we can get into now from the docs
so the thing to do really is to create
a transition
object
that you can use in multiple places
because what what this does if you call
dot transition it creates a new
transition
and if we wanted to say
transition the axis too it would it
would like create a new different
transition that has like slightly
different timing or something like that
and so like if you want everything to be
synchronized
the best way to do it is to create an
instance of d3.transition so that's what
i'm going to do now
i'll just create it right above our
circles
i'll use const instead of var
and instead of d3 dot transition i will
import
transition from d3 at the top
and i'll get rid of this stuff
down here
ease linear um oh yeah you can specify
all sorts of easing functions which is
like the
the different way that they animate but
i think we can just we can just use the
defaults for now
and i'll we'll keep the duration of two
seconds so we can see it clearly
now
let me find
some more examples
so we can call dot transition
on a selection and pass in
the transition that we created so this
is
the same behavior as before
but what i want to focus on now
is
when
the the plot gets initialized for the
first time
i want to have like some nuanced
animated transitions where
here's what i want to have happen the
circles should appear
in their correct locations
but they should grow
from nothing to something so i would
like to to animate the radius of it
right i think that that feels to me like
the proper way to start off
a scatter plot that has animations is to
you know do something sensible
rather than like the default behavior
which is they fly in from the upper left
corner which is sort of nonsensical i
mean it makes sense in a way technically
but like i wouldn't want to wouldn't
want to see that you know
so for this
we have to
we have to use dot join in in a
different way
let me see if i can find i know there's
a good example
of this
somewhere
let me see if i can just find it i know
it's probably here in observable
here it is here it is
yeah this is the canonical example by
mike bostock author of d3
where it's the general update pattern
with animated transitions and these
animated transitions are totally
um controlled like like the code
controls exactly
all the cases of of these animations
and so when when things enter they're
green they fall from the sky when
they're exit they transition down
they become red and transition down
and when they update they're black here
and they just move from where they were
to where they are
or where they should be
this is the example i would like to
follow
so here is
here's
here's what it looks like to do this
properly
we call dot join and instead of just
passing a string
the selector
we pass in three functions
the first function is what to do on
enter
the second function is what to do on
update
meaning when there's something there
from the last time around and we just
need to update it
and what to do on exit when something
disappears
exit we don't need to handle in our case
because we don't have a case where
things exit i mean that would be the
case where like uh when we invoke the
scatter plot we change the data so that
there's one fewer
uh entry so this case we might not touch
upon but we want to touch upon these two
for sure
let me i'm just going to copy all this
stuff because it serves as a decent
template
for reference
uh kern just a question uh you went to
uh you went to observable rather than
the documentation
right
and uh is that is that the way to look
stuff up now i mean go to observable
first rather than the documentation
well
here's the thing like the documentation
of d3 and observable
are becoming quite
um
interconnected
so for for example if we look at um
d3 selection
i often do start with the docs in the
readme of the github stuff here
but the thing is all of this stuff links
into
observable well notebooks okay
yeah and so joining data for example
see the selection.join notebook so
this stuff in observable is essentially
an extension of
the d3 documentation
okay i'm just planning on spending a lot
of time in the documentation
to learn how to do stuff in version six
yep
yeah the documentation is great but
i don't think it contains a
complete example i mean this is this is
pretty close
so this is a place we could start as
well
but i don't think it contains a full
example with the animated transitions so
for that we do need to go into
observable
but yeah my my my general approach is to
use the docs
as much as i can and then if there's
something that i can't find in the docs
then i'll click through the observable
links
and import it
essentially port the stuff to vanilla
javascript
by copy pasting little chunks
yep
thank you
yeah my pleasure thanks for the question
here it is so yeah i mean if i had my
druthers this
code snippet should be in the readme but
it's not
because this deals with
how transitions and selections
intermingle and work together
so instead of using this approach i'm
going to delete
what we had earlier
for the dot join and then i'll paste
all this crazy looking stuff
but you know really what i want to do is
i want to use this as a reference
and then code it
ourselves so i'll leave that
it out
current uh one practical question how
what's the shortcut for
multiple commenting out in bishop
oh it's well if you're not in vim mode
it's control
slash
control slash
yeah and i've been meaning to add
something like a list of keyboard
shortcuts that would be useful wouldn't
it
right here in the editor
yes
it's it's
it's on the to-do list yeah
but um
yeah control
slash
comments the line multiple lines
super useful
thank you
the general structure that we need here
is
a function that takes as input the enter
selection
and does something with it
a function that takes as input the
update selection and does something with
it
and lastly a function that takes as
input the exit selection and does
something with it
enter what we're going to generally do
is append something
in this case we are appending
a circle
and on update
is where we want to you know change the
position and on exit is where we
generally want to remove
the stuff
um
i'm just going to keep it there as a
good practice
but we don't have like a test harness
that tests that case
yet
but anyway
what i think we should do
on enter
is initialize the circles to where they
should be
so that's where i'm going to take these
lines
move them up to here
so we are pending a circle a brand new
circle
the first time it gets invoked and we're
setting
x and y
and what we're left with is now circles
that don't move around because we
haven't
addressed the update selection
so let's do the same thing on update
i'm just going to paste that logic there
so we're setting cx and cy on update as
well
now we're seeing that the circles change
like they should
okay
so now what i want to do is adopt the
transitions
the way that we can do this
well let's think about first what we
want to happen
on the enter case when the circles get
created what i want to do is transition
them from being zero radius to having
the radius that they're going to have
for the rest of their lives
and that is r
set to radius here
i'm going to move this logic
over to here
but what i really want to do is
initialize r to be zero and that's what
we can do here i'll just set r to be
zero
like this
and
i wanna i wanna have a transition
to
the next radius
however there are some subtle
things to consider here
namely
this function needs to return the enter
selection
that's just how this api works it
expects the enter selection to be
returned
so that's why we can't just call dot
transition
like this
because
it's going to sort of mess things up
internally
but
then the the last line
should be the
the radius right i cannot move the
radius
up and do the transition right
or the transition also return the uh
returns the enter selection
yeah it can be a little confusing so i'm
just going to comment out that for now
and this is where we need to look to
this pattern from from the example from
observable
it uses dot call
and the reason why it uses dot call
is that what gets returned from dot call
is the enter selection and the enter
selection needs to be returned from this
function not the transition
but this is how we can create a
transition
derived from the enter selection
and then use it to actually do our
animations
and it takes as input the enter
selection
and it derives a transition from that
and the existence of this
this transition is just strictly inside
of this callback
it doesn't get returned from this this
outer function
what gets returned is the enter
selection because dot call returns the
selection that it was called on
so this is why you need to use dot call
to get at
what the transition should do
and in here is where we can say dot attr
radius
r and radius and all this stuff
and i might have like a mismatched paren
or something
i'm missing comma there it is
yeah
so
check this out
if i run this
i'm going to make a code change to
trigger a run make it full screen so you
can see
this is the transition that we want
yeah i'll run that again so you can see
it starts out as little dots that don't
really exist to they grow
into their final form
and actually just to make it super
visible
let me set the duration to like
five seconds check this out they're
gonna start at nothing get bigger and
bigger and bigger
and now they're big
and if you want to make it smaller after
shows then it's you're going to exit
right
yes
okay
yeah we could apply the same pattern on
exit
um yeah exit is um tricky i think i'll
leave that to another day um
sure
because we don't really have a use case
for it at the moment
but yes you can control what happens on
exit
and in the example
is good like make it turn brown
[Music]
and then have it transition
to go down and then remove it
and the trick with exit and transitions
is that
you need to call dot remove on the
transition
because what we want to do is have it
wait for the transition to finish and
then remove the dom element
but anyway let's finish
the desired update transition
again this this should return the
update selection so we need to use the
same pattern of using dot call
update.call
update
and then update.transition
passing in the same transition object
that we created earlier
and this is where we want to set the
cx and cy
attributes
so now when this runs
it should
slowly move
there we go
yeah so now we're having with this kind
of a funny
a funny effect that's going on because
the transition is longer than
the time that we're giving it to finish
the transition is five seconds but we're
changing stuff every two seconds so let
me just align on those values
two seconds
okay
this is correct
all right and so let's i just want to
put a little icing on the cake here
um there is a magical thing that you can
do with transitions i'm going to make it
one second
and then do this magical
trick
which is
we can set a dot
delay
on the transition
to be a function that takes as input one
row and also the index
and we can return the index
times let's say 10
or 100
so you can see what the effect of this
is
oh you can't really see it
i don't know if it actually worked
what this should do is make it so that
there's a sort of a staggering effect
where not all the dots move at the same
time
i thought this would work
gohan um
i was doing a few tests
another day and i noticed that sometimes
the
index indexer and the d gets swapped
depends of
oh really
yes i'm not sure why that happened i can
check later and let you know but try try
to change the ind
okay
somehow i i i have my doubts but i'll
try it
yeah nope
nope okay um yeah i don't know maybe
maybe we need to call this
not here but
over here
after we call dot transition
what if we pass it in over there
yeah now it's working
this is
very cool very cool
although
it's
it's set way too high but if if i set it
to like a hundred
we can see
well let's see what happens
yeah they all kind of move
in a staggered manner
let me tweak things
a little bit more
i'm going to have just a slightly larger
delay
so instead of two seconds let's make it
three seconds
and then in the delay let's set this
delay to i don't know 50 50 milliseconds
to get the desired effect
that's still too high let's say like
10 10 milliseconds
we can get a really beautiful
sort of eye-popping
effect there it is that's the effect i
was going for
so the whole thing finishes between
uh the intervals where it changes
but it's this beautiful beautiful effect
that i love with d3 transitions and
setting the delay like this
it's got this like voom like this this
really almost like a choreographed
effect to it
it's really cool very cool nice
thank you yeah this is
fun so yeah i try to you know spice it
up
with client work like if you add this to
work that you do for other people
they're gonna just freak out and love it
so it's nice icing on the cake that you
can add
all right and so lastly i think
we can
we can transition on the axes as well
so let me get rid of this
reference code
and just to wrap this up
i'm sort of winging it here
but
if i just say dot transition t
before we call the axis
all right let me do it on the x so we
can see if it works
let's see if that works
yeah it works boom see that
brilliant
yeah the way the d3 access is
implemented it does it handles
transitions correctly which i just it's
just fine so i find it so beautiful
you can pass in transition and
it updates the axis in an animated
fashion
brilliant all right i think our
animation work is complete
any uh
any questions or thoughts about this
um
yeah it's actually it's another task
the last class uh
exercise was to put the
title in the axis
i did it but i'm not sure i did the
right way
so i would like to see how you do it
sure um
because in this case you have to update
also the the title right
exactly or is this the exercise for this
class
actually
it is
actually it is this is the perfect
exercise
okay
and the timing is perfect we're getting
to the end of the time here
add axis labels
that are idempotent
yeah
yes this is a very good
exercise
that i will leave you all
to do
and just as a as a little hint
you're going to have to use that dot
data and pass in an array of of no of
one item
null or whatever
and um
so instead of just
selection dot append text
it would be
selection dot select all
text
dot
y axis label you're gonna have to use a
class to disambiguate between the two
things
just like we did with the axes
and
yeah essentially apply the same pattern
that we did for the group element that
contains our our axes for the text
labels
and i think this is a great exercise
because it it it actually paves the way
to a lot of other things like if you try
to add
labels to this
you're going to quickly find
that
we don't have enough information
we need to add another
another um
accessor to this component which is
going to be the x label
we're going to have to pass that in too
because this passes in a function and
from this function we can't tell what
the name is of the column so we're going
to have to add one additional
thing to get it to work so that's why i
think it's a good
exercise yeah
um current yeah
i was just curious about the arguments
that are passed to join
and i noticed that there are a couple of
lines that are duplicated namely the cx
and cy
and i uh
i recall that you you've brought up
merge in the past to help uh
remove that duplication and i was just
wondering whether there was something
equivalent uh for inside the
uh yeah before for inside the arguments
um
yeah i'm i'm thrilled that you brought
this up because
duplicated logic is is one of those
things that i just hate
i just hate to see it
and so
i would like to address it i'd say it's
a great call to address that we've got
duplicated logic for cx and cy
and it's not so bad i mean it's only two
lines that are pretty simple
but still it's duplicated logic and you
may find yourself with complex logic you
know ten lines of complicated stuff that
you copy paste
between these two places which is not
ideal
and so
the problem is
this logic really needs to be executed
at these two different places
um
in the past like if you if we don't have
animated transitions
you know like we did before i started
adding this stuff
it could just go once at the at the end
because it
when you put it here it acts on the
merged enter and update selections
but if you do it like that you lose the
animated transitions
like it's not
it's not actually correct anymore
so let me go back to the way it was
is it possible to me like create a
function an external function that
updates cx and cy
then i call this function in the enter
and
inside the update
is that possible yes exactly you hit the
nail on the head that's exactly what i
was going to do cool
and so let's do it
i'll call it um
what's it going to do it's going to be
positioning the circles so i'm just
going to call it position
circles
and this is going to take as input
a selection that contains the circles
so i'll just i'll call it circles
we could call it anything
but it'll take that as input
and
what it will do is just gonna have this
side effect
of calling
dot httr on
that selection
and
it could actually return
circles but doesn't really need to
um
and then to invoke this
doesn't need because uh
later you will change the r attribute
right
so it should return the circle or not
well it all depends on how we invoke it
um if we use dot call
then it does not matter what this
function returns because dot call
is going to return the selection
of the circles anyway so it really
doesn't matter what this function
returns
and this is how we can do it we can just
say dot call position circles
and then in the other place where we
have the same logic we can put the same
thing dot call position circles
like that
and it seems to work
and on the creation step yeah it seems
to work okay
yep
so yes indeed this is how you can do it
this is how you can
reduce the duplicated logic
across these two places
and i think this is the best way to do
it because
this this logic needs to be executed in
both of these places it needs to be the
circles need to be positioned before
the radius transition happens and they
also need to be positioned
every time things update and so yeah
refactoring it into a common function
that's invoked in these two places i
think is a good move
yeah that's perfect thank you very much
for for walking through that
nice yeah my pleasure and i'm glad you
caught that because um when i was
planning for this episode
that i had this in mind like oh yeah at
the end i'm gonna refactor it but i
totally forgot so thank you for
reminding me
also uh do you have a you i think you
mentioned in a previous lesson request
animation frame
um yeah
versus uh set into a interval do you
have a preference for one over the other
is is one more um
does one have benefits of the other
well they have different
properties request animation frame is
actually used internally by d3
transitions
and when you invoke request animation
frame and pass a callback
that callback will be invoked
as soon as the next
render cycle happens
and it depends on your system setup for
example if your if your monitor is 60
frames a second which is most common or
30 frames a second which might happen if
you have like a 4k monitor on a computer
that's not very powerful
and
regardless of of your actual hardware
request animation frame invokes that
function on the next animation frame
it's called an anime they call it an
animation frame that means when the
display updates
so let's assume you have a like a
standard setup where your refresh rate
on your monitor is 60 frames a second
that means and that's that's standard
like when you move your mouse around on
the screen
if if you just sit there and up move
your mouse around you're going to see
that it's not a continuous
thing like it actually just appears at
different places really fast
and every time it appears that's 1 60 of
a second which is approximately 16
milliseconds
and so the benefit of using request
animation frame
for things like animation
is that it it synchronizes correctly
with your display
whereas if you use request if you use
set interval
for animation like if you if you were to
use set interval and past 16
milliseconds
it would give you
[Music]
it would call your function roughly
every animation frame but it might call
it twice between animation frames
sometimes or it might call it once
across two
animation frames which would result in a
slight
almost undetectable visual glitch
in the animation
and so if you're if you're doing
animations then request animation frame
is the best
thing to do hands down
uh and and that's why d3 transitions use
it internally for a time it wasn't
supported by all browsers
and so
for a couple years there you had to
you had to implement a fallback that
used um
set timeout or set yeah set timeout
is the is the like a variant of set
interval that just calls the function
once
um so i remember back in the day i had
to do like detection like if request
animation frame is there then use it
otherwise use
set
timeout and pass 16 milliseconds
or whatever
1000 divided by 60 is
and so that would be an approximation
however
if you have other use cases that are not
animation like what we have here
um
like
where you you want to wait for one
second or three seconds
then set interval is the thing to use
actually
um
yeah set interval is more appropriate
when you have longer time
scales that you're considering but if
you're doing animation then request
animation frame is is the thing to use
yeah that makes total sense thank you
nice
my other question yeah
um so
go back to scatterplot.jf
um and so
uh
where you or i guess the
where did you have the abstraction out
for position circles okay yeah there um
the question i had in terms of and just
sort of style and
uh readability i really like the notion
of putting position circles there
it just reflects what's actually
happening
it from a uh sort of a
coding style would someone do the same
thing with the dot call enter that
comes a little later right after it
um it just seems
at least to me a little strange
but that's probably how javascript works
and so forth but could you actually name
that as a function that is
you know uh more reflective of what's
happening just like you did position
circles does that make sense
yeah um i'm gonna select some text do
you mean this block here yeah yeah that
dot call enter um
or this inner one here yeah yeah that
inner one yeah just
could you name that uh create a function
just like you did call position circles
in a way that um it reflects what it's
actually doing there in other words
making the um
uh
radius bigger or transitioning yeah grow
radius exactly for sure
yeah i mean it's just a function
okay
so for sure i mean um
you can you can do all sorts of
refactorings like this and organize the
code and i like doing things like this
because
in a way it's
documentation like variable name
is in a sense documentation for what it
does exactly that's where i was going
with this yeah um
okay
for sure and so i love you know when i
can i like to structure code like almost
like a book
exactly where you learn about okay this
grow radius what is that it's some
cryptic code that sets the radius but it
says grow so that therefore it must be
like growing from zero to something and
so
for sure i would encourage doing this
sort of uh slight refactoring to make
the code more readable and clear
yeah right and it's thank you you're
welcome you're welcome but yeah it's
totally a stylistic thing like i
personally probably wouldn't do that
just because it's setting the radius on
the line before
uh but how you know it's totally
personal preference like this may be
more readable for somebody coming at
this code for the first time
for sure so yeah
up to you okay thanks that helps yeah my
pleasure
but what's going on that the the radios
oh the radius just
right it's in in the intersects just
begin and yeah okay i got it
it's just in there
it's not when it moves okay
see if we if we wanted to take this to
the extreme we could say initialize
radius
and pair these together
and so instead of saying right here attr
zero we could say dot call
initialize radius
and that's what this would do right here
and this actually implicitly returns it
which we don't need to do so that's why
i'm going to add these curly braces
and actually same same with this we
don't need to return it
so this is like the final form if you
were if you were to want to
you know factor out things and name them
this works as well so it's super clear
now that like okay first we're going to
position the circles
then we're going to initialize the
radius
and if you read it you realize
it's initialized to zero
and then we're going to grow the radius
from zero to something else using a
transition
so yeah yeah this code
it's
definitely more organized more readable
in a certain sense
but it's also more code so it's always a
balance between how verbose and clear do
you want to be versus how
minimal and concise and arguably cryptic
you want to be
yeah there's trade-offs for sure
all right maybe i'll take one more if
there is another and then we'll call it
wrap it up for the day
anyway well karen i have one that's uh
on
not on this chart but on a
forced layout so i don't know if anybody
has any other questions on this
you know i'll be i'll be working on
forced layout in the future so like my
inclination is to
is to hold off on that until we're
dealing with it
uh but i'm happy happy to feel the
question about it actually
it's it's mostly i see some places where
um you the
links are set up as an empty array
and then how do you get that data to do
that so that instead of me having to
do source target for you know a thousand
different data points
i just do the auto magic
javascript and it does it for me
yeah there's some there's some magic
stuff that happens with d3 force
to be sure
um i need the force to be with me on
this yeah i get it
yeah yeah well
yeah when you and i think when you call
for
i don't remember exactly but when you
pass data in there's some kind of magic
initialization that happens
um
but i i will be doing forced layouts in
in future episodes so
maybe hold that idea how long
i'm not sure
i'm not sure i haven't planned out the
full series but
i think from here on out
i'm debating to go deeper into this
to add menus to this so you can
interactively select
so that's one direction to go another
direction to go would be
to
do a bunch of things where we start from
scratch and just implement different
visualization techniques like a bar
chart
a line chart an area chart a pie chart
from scratch
with just enter and not this general
update pattern stuff um so those are
some of the things that i'm going to be
doing in the future um
any any preferences for for which
direction to take it
i
i would say i would say uh menus are a
really good idea if you're uh
designing this for a user having them
have the power of choice over what what
shows on the screen is powerful exactly
that's what i was thinking too so like
now that we've got it to this point
it's a cool technical demonstration but
you know we're gonna have to add the
axis labels and if you were to develop
this for an actual use case of someone
needing to visualize the data the
logical next step would be to make it so
that you can choose like you said which
yes i will also appreciate that
functionality you know yeah
right on right on i like it
sweet yeah
i agree with ken and everyone yeah
sweet yeah yeah let's do it so probably
next week i'll
add menus to this one
and uh yeah that'll uncover some
complexities along the way
all right i think i'll wrap it up for
today
so
thanks everyone for joining me so much
thanks karen
thank you thank you
yeah this was a lot of fun
this was a lot of fun with a lot of
people here i love it so um yeah i hope
you all can join next week as well and
beyond
so have a good weekend take care all
right bye
take care thanks bye bye
welcome everyone to episode 11 of get it
right in black and white charts with
menus
we've got a full house today we've got
felipe adil nita and eric dasbach i
think i'm saying that right is that
right
das bach great
so yeah let's start by reviewing
the submissions from last week
this forum from last week
all right so the exercise was
add labels to this reusable scatter plot
let's see what folks did
wow this is pretty nice
the labels are animated
very cool
nice work
it's kind of surprising
the arrow that's a good question
let's check it out
i guess it would be in here somewhere
it's an actual character
see that
yeah
yeah pretty neat there's actually a lot
of um
surprising characters that you can use i
think it's from unicode
but there's arrows there's little old
dots
emojis of course you could put emojis in
here and it should work
nice okay so the the axes
the labels are
animated as well
with the same pattern
very nice
cool let's take a look at what some
other folks did
this is pretty cool
so the animation pattern is it just
disappears
and then comes up from the bottom
hello
welcome
perfect timing i'm not sure how to
pronounce your name but uh
but you just joined the call welcome
i think this is the first time you're
here you want to uh introduce yourself a
bit
uh
kostav i'm not sure how to say your name
but welcome kyle stuff you want to
introduce yourself
you're muted i'm not can't hear you
welcome
kathy hello i think this is the first
time you're here you want to introduce
yourself a little
oh yes
got it yeah i'm i'm experimenting with
opening up the the live chat the live
audio chat to everyone watching
because um yeah i think there's a lot of
value in people you know stopping me
asking questions
we can have a lively discussion
all right glad you could join we have a
full house today
yeah no i i would suggest you close the
youtube window it's a little tricky of a
setup
yeah because there's delayed audio
coming from the youtube window and and
there's the google meet window so if
you're in the google me you have to
close the youtube window
sorry it's a little it's a little
confusing
oh good welcome kostov i'm so glad you
could join us um i've i've seen your
work recently and it's really great you
want to introduce yourself a little bit
excellent
oh this one
nice yeah this is really beautiful work
yeah i've been i've been really happy to
see see you working here and i'm
thrilled you could join us today this is
amazing this is amazing
so yeah this is this is sort of a dream
come true for me with this series i was
hoping to
collect sort of a core group of people
who are following along intensely with
this stuff
and this is actually what happened so
just thank you so much for
for joining me on this journey this is
amazing
so i was just showing your work uh
costume how do you say your name again
i'm sorry
kostov
gostiv nice do you want to present this
work a little bit see and and explain
how you did it
very nice
right
yep oh there it is
oh that's actually pretty nice
that's a pretty nice technique you're
actually checking the value to see if
it's a number or not
nice work
yeah so if folks if folks haven't seen
this type of operator this is a really
nice operator you can you can say type
of something and that operator returns a
string and it could be number
like the string number
or the string s-t-r-i-n-g or object or
anything and this tells you what type of
thing it is so this is checking
the first row
at the certain column what type of thing
is it
nice
so it's filtering just by
the numeric columns great work
i see yeah continue has to be
an expression on its own
and so if you wanted to do that let me
just show you real quick how you could
do that
so this is using the four in
construct which is slightly different
from four of
uh
but this is this is working fine so the
thing is
the ternary operator
it creates an expression that has some
return value and so
you know if this value is true then it
returns
the first thing right after the question
mark if it's false it returns the thing
after the colon
however continue
continue needs to be its own separate
statement so if you wanted to use
continue
you would need to do it like this
you would need to use an if statement
and an if block right here
and and this use of the ternary operator
is a bit confusing but because it has a
side effect
it's typically not recommended to to
have a side effect meaning pushing a new
thing onto the array
uh inside of a ternary operator it's
just a little bit confusing so this is
how i would suggest to do it
use an if and inside of that if block
do this do the thing with the side
effect so it's really clear that okay
this is this deserves its own line it's
doing something it has a side effect
it's changing this array
and then in the else block
then you could use
uh continue
but
yeah i was about to say like but you
don't really need that because it's
gonna just continue and do nothing
anyway
so
nice
nice yeah i'm glad i'm glad this came up
yeah continue
it's a control flow thing that you only
need to use if you're inside of some
like deeply nested thing
and then you you know inside of some
deeply like if you have four
like three like i don't know two or
three nested if statements and you come
to some case where you need to continue
that's where you would want to use
um continue and i can't think of an
example offhand but if it's just a case
like this you don't actually need to use
continue
at all
so this is another way of doing it
yeah so with the for in construct
this actually works because it's block
scoped
so this block
here
so const it declares this variable
called col column
and you could also use let here that
would work too uh you could even use var
if you're old school
but const works
yeah yeah my pleasure and um
what this what this block of code is
actually doing is it's filtering the
columns
to have only the numeric columns
and so i can't help but just also
suggest
alternate way of doing it
as well
which is
like this
const
numeric columns
equals
um
there is no list comprehension but there
are many useful
methods on arrays
that you can use
and so
this for in construct actually uses the
keys
of this object
so
you could say object
dot keys
of the first row
this gives you an array of all of these
columns
and then you can say dot filter which is
an array method and a lot of this stuff
you could do in python with list
comprehensions but there is no list
comprehension in javascript it would be
cool if there were
but we can just use these constructs
like filter
and so
we can pass in a function to filter
and
this function can just return this
boolean
you know if the type of
the first row at this part particular
column is number then return true
otherwise it returns
false and i'll just use prettier to
format this code and this actually does
the exact same thing as
all of this
it's just a more concise way of doing it
understood yeah excellent excellent and
i can see that like i can see that
you're
you're learning and trying new things
and this is this is a very good way of
um
like this
i can yeah it's great i could see your
learning process which is amazing and so
this is a good
first working version and then you can
simplify it with the addition of these
different constructs like filter
this hub does not do linting i tried to
get it to work with linting
but
it was causing all sorts of
instabilities it started crashing
uh that's something on the road map for
vishub it would be amazing to do linting
and vis up that's something i really
would like to see but unfortunately not
right now
but the closest thing we have is
prettier this little p which which
formats the code for you i find it super
useful
and along these go ahead
sure
it's an array of strings
and it just for some example if we were
to test against
string
it should return just species and it
does yeah
species is actually a
something that uh sort of throws throws
a wrench in the works of how our scatter
plot works and this is uh
this is going to be related to the
exercise for today
and we'll get more into it later
but yeah
this is an alternate way to do that
filtering
and let's see what time is it it's 11
21.
let's just see a couple more
exercise submissions
here's another one from cost of
um i don't know which one i clicked
actually hold on
this is the one i wanted to click
data source dozen d3 scatter plot
oh this is amazing the data source
so good so good
nice so this
excellent
yeah great work this this is awesome the
data source data set by the way it's
it's got a lot of history to it
um
i can go into it at another time but
it's a great data set because it
it has this picture of a dinosaur that
you can see here
and
the point of it is that
if you take all sorts of statistical
summaries of this data set
they're all like
the same for all the different columns
but if you visualize it you get totally
different things like that data source
and dots and the star and the point of
it and the circle here and the point of
this data set is to show that
statistical summaries lose a lot of
information
and when you visualize the data you can
see these patterns and information that
you cannot see with just the statistical
summaries
very nice
and here's another one
with labels this one blew my mind when i
saw it
it actually does the
animated general update pattern example
within the label
isn't that cool
really a lot of attention to detail on
this one it's
i was happy to see this one it made me
laugh i'm like oh my god this is
this is so funny
yeah so really nice work really nice
work here
by andrea nice
oh here's one from eric dusbach
nice you want to talk about this a
little bit oh cool animation
alright
right nice
well this is very nice
this is very nice
however
however i do see some telltale signs
that the labels are not
adhering to the general update pattern
see if you could see around the edges
they're like very sharp
and crisp
that indicates to me that there's
actually a bunch of labels on top of one
another
so let me just go in here and see
what's happening with that and how we
might fix it
so the y-axis label
looks fine actually this one is behaving
correctly
nice work with the data null
oh nice
oh nice that's great
that's great i'm happy to see this like
cross communication
happening
but here's where there's still a problem
see
with this one it's just appending a new
group element every time for for axis
bottom year
but it's very close to what it needs to
be i mean all you need to do here is
selection dot select all
a dot
axis bottom year
dot join
g
and now
oh sorry sorry sorry i forgot the data
null
here
now if you see the animation play out
this 2020
is is looking correct it's not getting
that crisp
thing happening to it so yeah this is
the pattern right here that you can
apply to all the different text labels
like this one united states
and this other one here
nice
so yeah you're well on your way nice
yeah my pleasure
great work great work
and while i'm in here i just kind of
kind of want to see
if we make this
delay
i times like 20
i kind of want to see it play out in its
full slow
beauty
see this is
this is really cool oh my gosh oh it's
look what's happening here
nice yeah that's what you got to do you
just got to dial it in
dial it in or alternatively you could
make this a function of the
um number of
rows in the data that's actually
something i wanted to do earlier
but yeah it's it's gets a little
detailed
but yeah excellent work excellent work
all right
last one from andre
take it out
oh is it broken
oh this is this is just a bug this is a
bug invis up i don't know what this is
coming from i've been meaning to
investigate this i think just the data
set was taken a long time to load
that's working now
nice
very cool so it's just plugging in a
different data set to that one
with the
with the transitions on the labels
nice very nice work
oh let's check it out
oh you can only hear me oh my god
seriously this is a disaster
oh my gosh
it's been just my audio coming through
this whole time can one of you say
something just to check the levels
uh
yeah i think so yeah it's a
yeah sorry i i had my youtube close
said something um
yeah it's it's my problem on the obs
config hold on just let me try to figure
this one out
all right can you can one of you say
something
testing nice there it is
what is usually
okay now it's coming through
oh this is a disaster
so all the audio so far was was lost
from everybody else but now it's coming
through
sorry about that
oh so sorry
yeah
you saw it
before the class start but uh the
question is in the
uh it's in the meat uh chat oh the meat
chat okay this is too much for me to
monitor it's too many chats yeah
that's why i said because it's
too much places
yeah i think you need to take break
every half hour and check around
yeah totally
all right now let's get into today's
episode
so i'm gonna try to
i'm gonna try to keep this to a half
hour
what we're going to try to do today is
add menus to our animated scatter plot
so that instead of just cycling through
different columns it's going to be
driven by the choice of the user you
know what do i want to see right now and
so you can click a menu and select which
column to use for both x and y
oops
so i'm going to start from
what we did last week
this animated reusable scatter plot and
i'll drop the link here
in the chat
if you'd like to follow along
so i'll start by forking this one
and i'll say um
animated reusable d3 scatter plot or
just i'll say scatter plot
with menus
or reusable
how about animated
animated scatter plot with menus
okay
so what i'd like to do here
is add menus how do you add menus
it turns out this is thing called
the select
tag in html and it looks something like
this
here's an example from w3schools
this is the sort of basic built-in menu
that you get from
html
and this is this is good for us we can
use this
so i'm going to copy this code as a
reference example
and
i'm thinking we can use the same pattern
that we used for our scatter plot
for the menu
so we're going to want to be able to say
import
menu
from
dot slash menu
and we can use the same reusable chart
pattern for this menu component
so i'll create a new file called menu.js
and in here i'm just going to paste this
as a reference and comment it out
and then
i'm going to copy all of this
scatterplot stuff
paste it in here
and change scatter plot to menu
and
and then just remove
everything inside of here except the
core skeleton
of what we need
and i'll keep one example of an accessor
because we're going to want to have a
bunch of these
all right so this is the basic skeleton
of what we want to do
and then let's let's um invoke this from
index.h index.js to get to a starting
point
for development
i'm gonna get rid of this set interval
stuff
because it's going to be replaced by
uh in the interaction of selection and
we have this columns thing here which
can drive the menus
so we want to call
dot call
menu
on something
but we don't have that thing yet
and i think what that thing should be is
a div
that we append to the body
so maybe up here
i'm going to make another block called
menu
container
where we select the body and we can
append a div
a div is just a container
element
in html and maybe let's give it a class
of menu container
just so that we can style it with css
and then we can use this
to invoke our menu
component
so what this is i have a question yeah
go ahead
so this
um h table elements uh it doesn't make
sense to
uh attach them to svg because they are
basically html elements so they go to
body element only correct
yes
um
within the svg element you can only use
certain
certain tags that make sense within an
svg like circle and line and all that
stuff
if you want to use a div inside of an
svg there is actually a construct you
can use to do this it's called foreign
element svg foreign element
but i don't use that very much because i
find it confusing to have divs inside of
your svg and it has some weird behavior
so what i generally do is
keep the svg graphics totally separate
from
the ui elements the regular old dom
elements
and so this is why
i'm setting up a div giving it a class
of menu container
and then we can put stuff into there
so we can instantiate our menu
pass it into dot call and then inside of
menu
when it gets invoked the selection is
this div it's the parent div
so let's just try something
selection.txt
just as an
example of something
notice how it doesn't actually show up
anywhere because i think it's showing up
below
the svg like beyond the boundary of the
page
so
what we want to do is style it so that
it appears at the top of this page
so we've got this class menu dash
container
in our styles.css we can
access that
and i'm going to just position these
menus on top of this svg
to do that we can say position
fixed
top
and left
zero this will put it at the top left
corner
so now we can see there it is foo at the
top left corner
i would like to ultimately center all of
this stuff and i think i'll do that now
just while i'm in the css
to do that i like to use flexbox
which you can
set up with display flex
and this is a whole thing
that you know i could spend a bunch of
time talking about but suffice it to say
that when you use display flex
it opens up this whole
landscape of options for you
which is extremely well documented in
this thing called a complete guide to
flexbox which has been a really great
reference for me
whenever using flexbox
so what i want to do is center it so we
can use justify content
um
i think space around is what i'd like to
use so that we have one menu on one side
and another menu on the other side
so justify content
space
around
it's still in the corner uh i think we
need uh right
zero as well which will make this div
span the whole the whole space from left
to right now we can see that little foo
is in the middle
here
which is what we want
all right
we're going to actually want
two menus one for x and one for y so
let's scaffold that out now
while we're here
i will put these as children of menu
containers so i'll call it
maybe x menu
container
or how about i'll just call it
x menu
and we can do the same we can append a
div
give it a class of
x
menu container
but you know
i don't think we actually need different
classes for this so i'll just append a
div the simpler the better
so we've got x menu and y menu
and down here we can say xmenu.call
and then ymenu
dot call
and see now
we have two different labels
one on the left and one on the right
this is looking good this is what i
wanted to ultimately ultimately end up
as one menu on the left one menu on the
right
now that we have our positioning down
let's develop this menu component
using this this example code as a
reference
so i think the menu should be comprised
of roughly this structure where there's
a label
and then there's a select element that
has a bunch of options inside of it
let's begin by creating this
label
we can say
selection
dot select all
label
dot data
null
i'm just gonna start by using this this
item potent pattern from the beginning
so we don't end up with any bugs
later if we invoke it multiple times
dot join
label
like this
and the label
is for
this select
and that has some implications for the
ui like if you i think if you click on
the label
it gives focus to the select or
something like this
um i'm just using this as a
as a template because i think it's all
correct
so let's begin by
setting this four
attribute
i can say dot attr
for
and i'll use something called
id
which is something that should be
configurable
so let id
equals nothing to start and we can we
can set up an accessor for id
like this
oh what is where is label
what do you mean where is label
is this variable
this is just an element here select all
label
yeah
the idea is we're going to create this
structure is inside the dom
and so there's no variable called label
it's just the tag
name label
and it's going to appear as some text
next to the menu that says what the menu
is about
yeah but in this case you okay i got it
you're selecting all the labels but
there is none label
right right now correct
and then you will create but what what
if we have a label
in our
in our page right if there's already a
label there as a child of this selection
then it will it will select that and use
it instead of creating a new one this is
what this
this whole pattern is all about this
idempotent rendering pattern the first
time it's invoked it'll create a new
label but subsequent times it's going to
use the existing label
and then change the change its
attributes
okay
so we are using this fake data for now
so what is the real label in our
that
iris data set well that's where we're
gonna have to configure it
so i'm beginning by
by by setting up this id and in this
dummy example the id would be cars
so four equals cars here name equals
cars and id equals cars over here
but we have not set it up yet
and what i'm doing is i'm working on
[Music]
i'm working on the
the accessor so that we can set this up
so i'm creating an accessor called id
and over in index.js
when we set up the menu for x
we can we can call dot id and pass in
the particular id
i'll call it x dash
menu
for example
and the key is that the id for the y
menu needs to be different
so now this will work because we just
set up this
accessor so we can call dot id pass in
the id
that invokes this function here which
sets
the variable called id to the value
oh we need to get rid of this plus
because that will that will parse the
string to a number which we don't want
here
and then once that is set
uh when it gets invoked it'll set for
that id
now we need to put the
the text of the label
which i think i'll call label
or how about
label text
just so it's not confusing
we want the text inside of this
label to be label text
so in our in our rendering code here we
can say dot text
which sets the inner text
of the element
to be label text
and again we need to set up an accessor
where we just change id to label text
like this
and then over in index.js
we can call dot label
text
for these two different menus and pass
in different things so for x it would be
x colon i think is what i want it to be
and then for y it would be
y colon
all right and then it shows up like that
x is here and y is here
excellent so far so good
now
let's begin
working on this
this the actual menu part of it
which is sort of what all of this has
been building up to
the general update pattern here
or
yeah this item potent rendering pattern
will be the same but instead of a label
element it's going to be a select
element
and here we want to set name
and id to be
id which is very similar to this line
here where we we're setting four on the
label
so i'm going to use that same
pattern
but instead of four
it's going to be name
and id
like this
now
notice that we have sort of a stub
of a menu that doesn't have anything in
it
so we're getting there
now we need to populate these options
question sure
uh so when we're doing this select tag
uh we are passing
two attributes name and id
and in the example as well they are both
set to the same value so
is this intentional or is this just
specific to this particular example
yeah this is intentional
and to be honest
i haven't dug too deep into
each of those things
i just sort of blindly copied it from
the example that i found
but here's another example of an html
select element from mdn
where they do the same thing where the
label is for
and that has to match up with the
id
but i see here that name is different
and i do i do not actually fully
understand the role of the name
attribute on a select
so let's see if we can find that name
it's used to specify the name of the
control
i mean
this is one of those things where
i'm just going to sort of blindly follow
the example
what about id
yeah i'm not really sure
but the thing is when you when you click
on
when you click on the label
it gives that menu focus
that's why i think it's important that
these
match but apparently okay only the id
needs to match and not the name
so could it be like the id is its name
is sort of like a class
to apply say css styling or something
like that
could be
could be but then i mean if you want to
use css you may as well just give it a
class and be sort of standard about it
right
i mean maybe it would work to just leave
out the name
honestly
i'm not sure
okay
yeah but that four should match the id
that's the main thing correct yeah four
should match id
um i think i think the id should be
unique to the whole html document
right yeah generally id needs to be
unique in the whole document
and to get to the bottom of this we can
do some experiments like if i click on x
see how the menu gets focus
and i'm curious if i if i leave out both
of these
name and id
and i click on that label
it does not get focus
so we know that one of these is
important
let me try just setting name
and see what happens
if i just set name and i click on it
it does not get focus
it does not get focused at all
however if i leave out name and i just
set id
and then i click on the label it does
get focus this is the behavior that i'm
after this is why this is the whole
reason why i'm setting this up
so you know maybe i'll just be a little
cowboy about it and leave out name
because like
i like to have this philosophy of like
if i don't understand why it's there i'm
not going to put it there you know if it
doesn't do anything for me there's no
need to put it
so thanks for asking that question i
have always wondered about this actually
and now with this little experiment
we got to the bottom of it
so i'm just going to set id and be done
with it
yeah
but id generally yeah it does need to be
unique on the whole page that's why it's
important that the id is different for x
and y
all right great let's continue let's add
these options
to our menu
inside the select we want a bunch of
options
which is where we can
continue this
expression here
so we're inside of the select net in
here we can say dot select all
option
dot data
options which we have not defined yet
i'm going to define that
dot join
option
and then
each of these options needs to have a
value
attribute and also some text and the
text inside the option
element is what you see on the screen
the value is more like an internal id
that the code uses
so let us
let us assume that each element of this
options array which we're going to
define in a minute
we'll have
a couple things
namely
a value
property
which we can use here to set the value
attribute
like this
and also a
text
attribute
so i'm going to say dot text
and here we can also pass in a function
that takes as input one row
and we can return text like that
yeah this should be the complete code
required to render our set of options
now we just need to define options
and options is something we want to
define from the outside so i'm going to
set up
an accessor
for options so we define the variable at
the top
i'll use this this template here
to create a new accessor for
options
i'll just replace id with options
everywhere here
all right and then in index.js
we need to pass in
our options to both of these
and columns is pretty close to options
however it only has
the actual columns it doesn't have the
labels that we want to use i mean we
could use the same for both
but my preference
would be to set up
objects for each of these that have
labels as well
so value
will be the original
value here
and then
from here
we can say text
will be
some string and
for petal width that should be
uppercase petal space
width
i'll just type these out
these are the labels that we're going to
see on the screen so they should be nice
human readable stuff not this lowercase
underscored limited thing which is
kind of like
uh
nerdy you know it's not really
not really presentable
so petal length and sepal
length
all right
these are actually our options
so i'll just rename that
variable to options
which we can pass into the options
accessor for both of these different
menus
all right now we have
options in our menu look at that it
worked
amazing
all right now is the fun part where we
get to wire it up and make it all work
make it all happen
this is where things get a little a
little tricky
what we want to do
i want to be able to call dot on
on this thing here
which is generally how we add event
listeners
to things
typically the first argument is the the
name of the event
on change
and then the second argument is some
callback
where it accepts a value
and it does something
so for now i'll just say
console.log
value
and later on we'll have that actually
interact with the scatterplot to change
to change x and y but for now let's just
put it like this to see if it works
and this is where
it's kind of a challenging thing to
to iterate on this pattern this reusable
charts pattern to handle events
luckily
there are a couple d3
packages that do this one of them is d3
brush
and i like to study the source code of
d3 itself
to see how to do some of this stuff
you'll see that
the implementation of d3 brush uses this
other package for events called d3
dispatch
which is what we can use as well this is
this is part of d3
this is how you can set up components
with event listeners
so the way that brush does it is first
it imports dispatch from d3 dispatch
which we're gonna have to do as well
so i'll just do that now import dispatch
from
in our case d3
um
and let's see where it's used
listeners equals dispatch
passing in various types
of events that could potentially happen
let's do that as well
i'll say
const listeners equals dispatch we're
only going to want one type of event
which is change
so i'm going to put that like that here
this is the
conduit by which we can emit events and
we can event we can listen to these
events externally
and
let's see
where is listeners used
ah to emit an event we need to use dot
call
but first we need to expose
dot on
to the external world
and this is the pattern
that d3 brush uses
it calls listeners.on
dot apply
listeners and the arguments to this
function
and if that value
is the same as listeners then it returns
the
the brush
otherwise it returns
the thing that was returned by those
listeners
now i'm going to be honest with you i
have not fully dissected and grocked
everything that's happening here i just
know that it works
and mike bostock the author of this
module must have really thought this
through
so i'm gonna do something a little
uncharacteristic and just copy paste
this whole thing
without fully understanding it
and of course all we have to change
brush
to my
and this effectively exposes the dot on
method so that you can add an event
listener
to this menu
so now our code should work
it's going to add the event listener
the next thing we need to do is actually
emit that event
from our event listener
every time that the menu changes
this is where we need to iterate our
rendering logic to add an event listener
to the select element itself
which we can do with dot on
change i'm pretty sure
and this will take
as input
an event which is the dom event that
that's provided to you from from the dom
environment
now let's console.log event here just to
see if this is working at all
i'll open up the console
and then if i select
something from this menu
we get this event
it worked
alright
i just know from experience that you can
use event dot target
and then unpack
the value
from this
dot value is in here somewhere among all
this stuff
so event dot target
dot value
is how you extract
the actual thing that you clicked on
from this
so now if i click on pedal width
oops sepal width rather it's it prints
out
the name of the column
simple underscore width like this
and if i click uh
sepal length it outputs sepal length
this is the value that we want to
dispatch to our outer
event listeners
and let me again refer to
d3 dispatch
there is a method here called
um dot call
this is the method that you need to use
to dispatch events
to tell all the event listeners like hey
this event actually happened
so what we need to do is call type
and then
the the context object which will
resolve to dot this
i'm not really a big fan of using this
like we don't need to use this
necessarily
but the third argument is important it's
the arguments that get passed
so let's see how to how to actually set
this up
our instance of dispatch is called
listeners here
so in here we can say listeners.call
the first argument will be
the type which is the name of the event
in our case it's going to be change
the second argument
is going to be
the the context that resolves to this
and i'm not i'm not a fan of using that
so i'm just going to pass in null
to say like this is not this is not a
thing that we're doing it's not a thing
that we're using
but the third argument is important
which is going to be event.target.value
this will make it so that
the na the column that you click on is
passed to the outer
event listener that we've defined in
index.js
now let's just say console.log
in
index.js to be sure this is where we are
now
let's see did it work
if i click on this thing
it worked
boom
so i clicked on it the event
sort of got forwarded through this
component to the outer
index.html
and now in index.html we get notified
when we when we change this
so this is
this is the pattern that you can use to
introduce events to your components and
let me just give another
overview of how this is working
we import dispatch from d3 which gives
us this
event emitter construct from d3
we instantiate it
once
when we instantiate the menu it's an
instance of dispatch that only has one
type of event which i'm calling change
we could call it anything but i'm
calling it change because that's sort of
a standard
name for menus
we're calling that listeners in here
when we render our select
element we're adding a
change event listener to that element
which is a it's a standard um
thing that emits events from the dom
when we get that event we are extracting
the value that was clicked on
and then we're using
listeners.call to essentially forward
that event through our
d3 dispatch
construct
so what this is doing it's essentially
emitting a change event
and it's it's
just passing in
uh
the value which is the the name of the
column that was clicked on
so you know we could just pass in the
event
but i my preference is to
to eliminate all that complexity for the
external listener
so that all you need to do is
is use the value that was passed in to
this callback here
right
so i i realize this is a lot
this was actually pretty difficult to
figure out how to do but i think it's
the right pattern i want to pause now
and ask you know are there any questions
so far
yeah the the the null that you did there
that's supposed to be this and that
what what's that
yeah we can dig into that because i it's
it's a little sort of a mysterious thing
i'll pass in
foo
here just to demonstrate
what this is
in our index.js
if we use the old school function syntax
not the fat arrow notation
to define this function
then we can say
console.log
this
and
i'll get rid of all that other stuff so
we can just isolate that
i think there's a typo in function
oh whoops
function
now if i select something from that menu
foo gets output to the console
it's um
it goes to like the history of
javascript and object-oriented
programming
you know there's a bunch of patterns
throughout history of javascript where
people try to make it object oriented
and use
the keyword this
extensively
but i think like to me that's sort of a
thing of the past like there's no need
to use this at all
and it's just it's essentially another
way of passing another thing into this
callback in addition to the value
but i personally just don't see i just
don't see the
the usefulness in it
but if if you wanted to do it if you
wanted to use this
then you could um
but it is like uh
we have like two combo boxes
um does
does it
somehow
chew
i don't know identify which
combo box are you using
could be use it like this or not
i mean
one thing i could imagine is
passing in my
here
so that it would resolve to the instance
of our menu component
in the external listener so you could
say like i don't know
so you could manipulate the menu or
or something like that
but like i said i don't really get it i
don't really get the point of it it's
just sort of an inherited thing from
from patterns of the past that we've
sort of moved away from in minor times
um
so that's why i don't really like to use
it it's just a confusing thing
um
like in d3 a lot of the time
this
is referred is is the is the dom node
but it just goes to show you in
javascript the keyword this could
resolve to literally anything it depends
on how you invoke the function that's
why i just find it confusing to use the
keyword this when you're developing
software
but this is it
this is how it's how it could be used
you could pass something in as the
second argument could be anything and
then in the callback
if you use the old school function
notation then you can use the this
keyword and it will resolve to whatever
you pass in as the second argument here
okay
um
i'm not familiar with this i'm familiar
with that you would listen to an event
using the on and natasha
a function that will
that will be operated on when that event
is fired and i think i missed the point
why we're doing all this while we're
using the d3 dispatch
oh we're using d3 dispatch
so that
we can
essentially define our own set of events
in this component
so we can call dot on change and pass a
callback which is sort of the ideal api
that i would envision for for adding an
event listener
and it's it's a way of decoupling
the dom like what we're doing when we
actually render the thing from the
component itself it means
we can add this event listener to our
menu component
and then internally that menu component
can choose to fire that event anytime
inside so i mean we could we could fire
this event any time it just so happens
that we're listening to the change event
on our select element and then
essentially forwarding that event
i see so for example suppose you're
changing one of the selects but you want
to change both of the axes you will be
able to fire two events based on
a selection and one of your selects
if you need to well i mean if you wanted
to do that then you could just change
what the body of the listener does
you could like set
one axis
and then set
another
you don't need necessarily two different
events for that
but let me revert this change because
using this is confusing
and i prefer the
the arrow
the fat arrow syntax for functions
and then in our menu dot js we just pass
null
as the second argument
so so yeah this is this is just
generally the pattern that you you can
use
if you want to introduce events
into your reusable components that you
generate with this with this towards
reusable charts pattern
and the reason why we're using d3
dispatch
is so that we can control the set of
events it's a generalized pattern
to be clear
where you can you can set it up like
this
you can set up dot on
like this
and then
you could add any sort of interaction
like let's say for example you wanted to
make it so that your scatter plot could
listen to events when you click on the
circles you could use the same pattern
to accomplish that
so the pattern
can be the same
it's just that
the things
that trigger those events could be
different depending on whatever your
component is
i wanted to introduce this general
pattern because it's useful in a number
of different contexts whenever you want
to add interaction to your to your
components
this just so happens to be a menu
component where
to know when to trigger the event
we need to attach an event listener to
the select dom element
and then unpack it like this and then we
pass it into our our change
listeners like this
all right
now
let's make it so that when we select
something it actually changes the
scatter plot this is the moment we've
all been waiting for right we've got all
this wiring set up that it
you know it dispatches the event and
everything
this is the this is the moment of truth
where we sort of connect these two
things together
let's look at this code that we had
earlier
it uses
plot.x value to set the accessor
and then it uses svg.callplot
value in this case is actually
the column so i'm going to rename it to
column
just because that makes more sense
and then in this event listener we can
say svg.call
plot
this will cause our scatter plot to
re-render
but
just before we render that i'm going to
call
dot x value
and set that x value accessor to be a
brand new function that takes as input
one of these rows
and it returns d
at
column
column being whatever column we just
selected from the menu
now
if i select something
it actually changes
yeah this is the
this is the moment where it all comes
together
and we can actually use a menu to select
what is being displayed on the x-axis
and it ends up pretty small and concise
but we're getting the column from
the event dispatcher
and we're setting the x value accessor
of our plot
to be a function that accesses that
particular column for x
and then we're
invoking our plot with svg.call
and to complete this
we can do the same for y
but instead of saying
x value we set the y value
and this is it
it's done
we can set x
and we can say y
so now we can explore the data
and one beautiful thing about the s the
the select elements is you can actually
use the arrow keys
to quickly navigate between the
different options
so any questions
does
the event
change on the select element files when
you first render the page to make sure
that you've got the first selections
correct it does not that's actually a
really good point
when we set up our scatter plot it's
defaulting to this
x value is
petal width and y value is sepal length
but when we initialize the menus
they're just getting
i think the first
the first option is what they're
defaulting to
so that's a good call out that when it
loads it's actually not correct
it says
pedal width and it says pedal width for
both x and y
yep yep so that's a bug
that's a bug ideally we would have
something like uh
initial option
or what have you
but just to fix the bug
i'm going to initialize x value and y
value both to be
pedal width
now at least it's it's correct and
accurate when it loads
but yeah good catch
good catch
there are a number of things we could do
here to
to like make it so that initially
there is some
some selection
of the menus and the accessors that's
initialized correctly
but i think i'll i'll leave that as an
exercise for the reader
but actually here here's what i want to
leave you with as an exercise for today
handle
species
this is going to be kind of challenging
the value here would be species
and the text here would be species
this would be the ideal
situation where you could select species
and it would work but right now it does
not work
because we're using linear scales
we're using linear scales with with a
thing that is is not numbers it's
different strings
and so
if you wanted to visualize
species
you would need to use
scale point
instead and have the domain be
data.map
x value like this
and so the challenge is
set up x and y scales conditionally
based on the type
of attribute you've selected
and and the overall goal here would be
to make it so that if you select species
for x
the x scale would change to be
a point scale not a linear scale and the
axis should render correctly
so that's the challenge
for this week
all right i think we'll wrap it up any
other last questions
just say thank you this is great
my pleasure
yeah this was um
i was i was a little nervous going into
this because i know it's a lot of stuff
to digest um but thank you all for
asking questions along the way
when when things were not clear
and uh it's
yeah it's not clear to me
what
we should see
if it's
if i get this passive because
i i can imagine like uh using different
icons
for different
species oh if i
if i get like the x's as a specie um
especially i i don't get it because i
would have like two species two or three
something like this
let me just show you real quick
it should be scale point
which will distribute those three values
across
x and then the domain
would be
data.map x value like this so it just
gets all the unique values
and now if i
oh scale point we need to import that
from d3
if it runs now
and if i set x to species
it looks like this
this is what it should look like
okay i got it
um oh but yeah actually let's add a
little bit of padding
because it's all up against the edge
there
we can say
dot padding of like 0.2 maybe
and now if we select species
it looks like this so this is what it
should look like when you select species
as x
because we're using scale point all the
time if we go back to one of these
numeric columns it's using a point scale
what it's doing is it's it's taking all
the unique values that it sees
and giving them a location along x which
is totally not right it's totally
incorrect a point scale should only be
used if you have a bunch of discrete
values for example three species
not if you have quantities
so what i envision could be the solution
uh is like
you have some ternary operator here
like if x type
is
a categoric is
if x type is categorical
and you can create an accessor for x
type
then use scale point
otherwise use
scale linear
so there's sort of a sketch
of what the solution should be and i'll
leave it to you to implement it
and i might even implement it uh next
episode
if yeah the
other way
could be implemented is a third menu
which is then a stratification variable
which is says overall and then by
the species i think
then you would see subgroups
for each of those xy plots oh yeah
you mean like you'd you'd see like three
scatter plots side by side
you could do that or if someone wants to
dive in and you'd have a menu which
would be let's say z it says overall and
then each of the species
and so then you could select each of
each species or overall so right now
we're looking at overall
yep um and so that would be another way
that way you're not confounding that
categorical variable with um
the actual intent of the scatter plot
true
yeah good call you could do it a number
of ways you could use color
or you could fast it into like three
different plots that have the different
subsets highlighted or filtered to just
show them
yeah yeah totally there's a number of
ways to do it
yep good call
and we'll be getting into those i hope
to add color to the scatter plot in the
future
and also do all sorts of different like
aggregations like you could you could do
a box plot all sorts of options many
things many things to do
is there time for a very quick question
on selections and join sure yeah
thank you if you go back please to uh
where you select for the label for
example
this one
yes thank you there seems to be a
pattern where you select all for a
special
uh uh
value and then you join the same value
is there a case where you would do it
two different things or is it always the
same you would select all for one thing
and then you're showing for exact that
same thing
that's a great question
this is the case where
we're selecting on the tag name
that appears here label and this string
is a selector you could select by class
as well if you want to but this case is
simple they're the same because we know
for sure that inside of any one of these
given
divs this is our parent that we're just
going to have one
label
element
if we know that there's only going to be
one label element in here
then then we can use the tag name in the
select all
however
if there's going to be different
instances of the same tag name
as children of the same parent
then we want to have something different
which we have here in our scatter plot
because
we have one group element as a container
for the y-axis
and we have another group element as the
container for the x-axis
in this case
then we need to somehow differentiate
between the two
and
i think the best way to do that is with
classes
and this is the case where
what we pass into select all will be
different than what we pass into dot
join
what we pass into select all
is a selector string that uses dot at
the beginning to signify that it's going
to look for an element that has that
class
attribute
y-axis
so if if there's no y-axis
then it's going to create a new group
element and the thing you need to pass
into dot join
is always going to be a tag name not a
class you're not allowed to pass a class
into dot join
so this is a case where they could be
different
yeah and you need to do this like if you
pass g into here
and into here then
this block is going to res it's going to
find the group element that was left
over for
the y-axis and it's going to use it for
the x-axis and you're going to get rid
of your y-axis it's going to be a bug
and so that this is the case where you
need to differentiate
between two
things that are the same tag name namely
a group element in for in this case
with classes
perfect thank you very much my pleasure
welcome everyone to episode 11 of get it
right in black and white
quantitative and categorical
we've got a full house today uh we've
got kostov here adil is here eric is
here
anita
and myself
welcome everybody
how are things
going all right
right great thank you
all as well
all is well
um
yeah
the submissions for this week were quite
cool
um looking forward to step through them
and maybe we can bring up some any
questions that that have arisen
through trying to do this exercise
so here we go
here's the forum submissions from last
week
um
oh there was a typo in there make
the menus work
with species
that was the goal
so let's see what happened
um
let's see
oh can you all see my screen
actually
i can't see your screen there we go
sorry
now you should be able to see it
oh great yep all right
so kostov uh
had some had some great um
discussion and i was so impressed uh
that you were able to use the little
snippet embed feature of this hub that's
so cool so we can talk about the
specific line numbers
yeah this was really helpful to have the
snippet in the chat as well thanks for
the tip on how to do that
nice yeah my pleasure i'm happy to see
the feature being used it's a feature
that's been there for a while we haven't
really used it much but it's supe it
comes
in handy when we're you know asking
questions about the code
so the question was
um
you were trying to add the click event
listener to the option element
yeah
see
this is actually what i did too the
first time i tried to get the menu
working
and i was also confused as to why it
wasn't working
but it turns out that
what you need to do
it turns out that what you need to do is
actually add the event on the select
element
not the inner option elements and once
you do that it seems to work
but yes yeah did that work out for you
custom
yes yes that worked out so i was instead
of use applying the listener on the
options element and applying on the
select element
yup
excellent
so yeah i think
event.target.value works
um and this is a great lead-in to some
of the stuff we're going to do today but
the follow-on question was okay now that
i have you know the column name back
from the menu how do you get the text of
it like the the label text
and it's a great question um
there are a couple of different
approaches but my preference is to keep
uh sort of metadata about the columns in
a data structure that you define
yourself
and this is also something i'd like to
do in today's
live coding
this way you can associate the value the
label and the type for each of the
columns
which lets you then distinguish okay
species is categorical
and you could do this by introspecting
on the data like checking the type
but i like to you know type it out
explicitly
so that we have this data structure and
to be clear you can generate this data
structure by looking at the first row of
the data
so it's a nice way to decouple those two
different activities to have an
intermediate data structure like this
and then
to answer the question you could look up
the text by constructing a map which is
a data structure that's essentially a
dictionary looking up key value pairs
so yeah
um yeah this was really nice i
really like the way you structured your
metadata as a separate variable
and looking into it has also found a
subtle difference like when you said map
i think previously we also used
the map function which had a lowercase m
right while
this map this had this uppercase m
for sure
so this uppercase m map that's the
dictionary and the lowercase one is like
uh a functional functional programming
construct is that right exactly that's
exactly right and i can see how it's
confusing because they have the same
name
but yeah map
is a data structure built in from es6
from i think it's from the introduction
of es6 so it's a fairly new data
structure
if i want to know about it i just typed
up javascript map mdn which is the best
place to look for documentation so this
page here tells you all about uppercase
m map what it does how to use it
so it's
it's different from regular objects
in a number of ways
but essentially it's the same and it has
some nice methods on it
hey felipe is here welcome felipe
but yeah map you can create a new thing
you can set
keys and values for that thing
and then you can check does it have a
certain key all of this stuff is
available on maps
whereas
javascript
array map
is a method
on arrays
which you can find out more about here
it's it's indeed a functional
programming construct where on an array
there's a method called map you can pass
in a function that takes as input one of
the elements of the array and returns
something and then you get a new array
of just the returned values
so yeah that's the distinction between
lowercase m map
and uppercase m
map here
and i think we'll we'll end up using
this data structure in today's live
coding as well
great thanks this was really helpful
nice
so yeah here's the uh the submission oh
i like the styling on the menus very
nice
and it works
fantastic
beautiful beautiful
very nice work
awesome let me just take a quick look
how it's done
nice see here's the trigger
nice work
so it says
if x name
is not species
so for any others column except for
species we use scale in here just like
we did before
but otherwise
use a point scale and set the domain to
data.map x value which isolates all the
unique values and then
point scale spreads them across
the visible space
so that's why this works
nice job
let's see what else do we have
well assad
also took a stab at this
and
went a little bit beyond
as well
this is quite impressive
so we got sepal length petal width using
linear scales
species works using the point scale and
nice job adding the padding see it's not
all the way down to the bottom
and then also
added an option to use a square
root scale
this is amazing
or a power scale what is this
so yeah different types of scales
in use here it's brilliant
so if we want to see what the scale does
we can say okay pedal width linear and
then petal width
square
you can see it's a square root
relationship
if i remember my high school math is
this a parabola
or maybe not
i don't know
but yeah very nice work
i have question about this one sure
are there circles on top of
like many circles in one place
it looks like that yeah it looks like
there is
yep
you could see this the edge on this one
is is sort of soft i don't know if it
comes through in the stream
but the edge on this one is really rough
which indicates that there's a bunch of
circles in the exact same spot
yeah and this makes sense because
there may be
a bunch of data points
that share the same
value
what's the point of square skill
ah
great question i think here is just an
experiment so there's not really any any
point per se except to figure out how to
do it however
the the place where square root scales
come in handy is defining the radius of
circles based on data
such that the area of the circle is
equal to
the quantity in the data
yeah i think we'll get that we'll get to
using it like that some in some future
stream where we use size but that's i
think the main use case for a square
root scale
yeah and then there's a log scale
which is not here but that's useful when
the data follows a power law
distribution
and i think we'll use we'll get into
that again also in the future
but yeah great work here from uh
whale assad let's see how he did this
just adding a type
property to the various columns
very nice
band squale square power
and then in the scatter plot
hook into that value
and he even made a separate function
called get scale which is very nice very
nice
refactoring so if it's
the code is very readable if it's linear
then use scale linear
if it's log then use log
if it's square then use square root
otherwise use power scales
or band scales
so yeah great work
let's see what else
yeah there was some interesting
discussion
using the options array approach works
oh eric has one look at this eric's here
with us right now
let's see what is going on here
oh my gosh they're blue
that's awesome
and it does filtering
look at that oh this is brilliant
brilliant so it filters by the species
you know each particular species
eric you want to talk a little bit about
um
your experience with this
sure yeah i uh
i guess misinterpreted the assignment so
i was just wanting to look at
all the data
stratified by species
this is awesome
oh nice
yep
oh yeah flexbox can be um
kind of tricky and the way i did it last
time was sort of a
shortcut in a way to just overlay them
on the top but yeah when you need more
complex layout you need different
different tools css grid is an amazing
tool to use
nice
that's awesome
and i see that the colors change as well
now that they're now they're all blue
but if you go to one of these
it's it's red
nice nice
yeah this is awesome
um
so yeah let's just take a look at
how it was done
options
so we've got all
setosa versus color and virginica which
is this menu here
and then that's passed in
to the scatter plot
and then
here's where the filtering happens
nice
so this is yeah this is great it uses
the dot filter method on arrays and if
if species equals
the z value of d
which is passed in through these
accessors
then include it
very cool very cool
and i like how you split it out into
functions with dot call that's a nice
approach
very nice
yeah it is kind of crazy yeah that's the
crazy thing about javascript
um and one of the reasons why i love it
because it's
it's got elements of functional
programming and it's got elements of
object-oriented programming
and you can make it yeah you just showed
that map
yep slower and uppercase and like what
yep it's it's a great playground to be
in there's tons of um
tools in the toolbox
so to speak
yep
yeah it's getting complicated yeah it is
it is it's a journey it's a journey of
learning new things using them
and this functional and object oriented
programming is kind of confusing really
and you don't know where which one
starts and which one is
right
yeah and the other thing that's also
interesting is how i don't know if this
is a style
right
yeah it does get confusing
when a variable has the same name as a
function or property has the same name
as a function somewhere else
yeah
yeah it's totally a trade-off
picking variable names
but um
the one piece of feedback
i would i would have for this
in terms of like visualization design
is that when you when you switch between
setosa and versacolor
the dots animate
and that's a cool effect
however it communicates to the viewer
that
each dot
is
like the same
in a sense
you know what i mean it's like when a
dot
when a dot moves across the screen it
makes sense if it's the same exact the
same iris flower as it was before like
this kind of animation makes perfect
sense because when the circle moves
its identity remains unchanged it's the
same flower that it was however when
when this animation happens
it's actually
kind of misleading because the flower
is a different flower that's represented
by the same circle as it moves across
the screen you know what i mean
well
i think it's just a matter of
you know noticing that that's an issue
and we can go in and fix it and here's
how
i'll fork this so i can play around
and
i don't think i ever even talked about
this but because we didn't need it but
there's a second argument that you can
pass into dot data
which is a function that defines the
identity
of the thing
and d3's internals will use that
to distinguish between
um
you know things that are the same and
things that are different
so here's here's what we can do we need
some some kind of identity
across the different iris flowers
first actually before we do anything
else
so here's here's what i propose when we
load in the data
there is no
column that is a unique identifier for
each individual flower
it's just not there
but we can easily make one
by saying d dot id equals
uh you know the simplest way to do it is
just to have an id counter
so like id counter
plus plus
and oftentimes there is something in the
data
that is a unique id but since there's
not here we can just use the index in
the table
as the
id and so
just to see what this does
it gives us
oh sorry d dot id i had a typo
wait why is that not working
somehow it's broken did i break it
i didn't really do anything
huh
i don't know
i'm having um what i like to call a
twilight zone moment or i have no idea
what's going on
so i think i'm just going to delete this
and try again
i'm getting a little
sidetracked
here it is
the original one is not loading now
which is weird
huh
i don't know maybe there's some outage
or oh there it comes there it is
maybe the data was just taking forever
to load or something
i don't know
let me try again i want to do this
because it's a very useful thing to know
okay now it's working it must have been
like a data
latency issue or network problem
so
id counter is zero
d dot id
is id counter
plus plus
console.log d just to see what we're
dealing with here
it should be integers
see this one id 3133
id 134 the point is that it's unique to
each of these different iris flowers
so now that we have that
um and also we might actually get past i
as a second argument to parse rho
i don't remember but if we do then we
don't need to do the id counter oh we do
check that out
that's nice
that's even easier we don't need to do
the incrementing ourselves
so d dot id equals i
done we're just going to have integers
as the ids now in the scatter plot
when we do the data binding we can pass
as a second argument a function that
takes as input one row and returns d dot
id
and hopefully with that one single
change it should actually solve the
visualization design issue that we were
talking about
okay it sort of does there's there's one
there's one that's not behaving
correctly
but it's getting close
and this is this is more
accurate in a sense more honest in terms
of what's happening
although there's
well i mean i've seen this sort of thing
so many times that like oh it's sort of
muscle memory
at this point i don't know why that one
is misbehaving though
i'm getting not a number from somewhere
is it
huh
let's try console.log
d dot id just to see what it is
yeah so these are coming from our
index.js there's not a number coming
from some other console.log somewhere
else
but i think the ids are good
maybe
maybe they need to be strings or
something
so if we do empty string plus i they're
going to be strings now
maybe 0 is coming back falsey and that's
causing problems no
that doesn't do it
the problem is that there's a little
there's one of these red ones
yeah good idea
you know this is buggy too because now
it they should animate
they should animate smoothly
yeah it sure does it looks like they're
they're exiting and then entering again
which is not supposed to happen
good idea
ah
it does not
yeah see we're doing this
i think i know what's going on
we are missing the id in this
transformation here
so good idea to look at this place
we can just solve it by adding the id
to the resulting objects and this makes
sense i mean it decouples the
the data transformation from the
rendering which is good but it adds a
place where we can forget something
let's see if it works now
it still exits all the time
which is not
what we would want oh there's something
else marks overall
oh
there's different paths that it takes
so let me add it there too
now this is working as i would expect
so when you do it like that
the right thing happens now
the right thing happens as well see
okay
great this gets to the bottom of it and
i think this is like the you know
correct
quote in quotes correct design
where if you change these columns it
makes sense that because the identity of
the dot correlates to that iris flower
but then when you do the filtering
they don't animate anymore they sort of
disappear and then reappear
and if you wanted to be complete about
it
you would um
make it so that the exit
mirrors the enter in terms of the
animation so instead of animating in it
would animate back to zero radius and
then disappear that i think would be the
ultimate best solution
but this is
this is pretty awesome as it stands
so i think i'll leave that as an
exercise for you eric if you want to
take that out yeah yeah this this is
great learning so thank you awesome
awesome yeah my pleasure
and the way to do it just a little
teaser would be to
um
put put the transition
on the exit
okay and have something like grow radius
but
oh here's actually how you would do it
dot transition
t
dot call
shrink radius
something like that
oh cool
yeah can i have a quick question here
sure
when you have things entering and
exiting at the same time which runs
first in terms of animation
well they that's the elegance of using
the same transition they run at the
exact same time
i see
and what would you do if you want
things to exit first and then enter
again
well you would have to
invoke the entire code multiple times
with different data
that's the only way to trigger things
that happen at different times or now
that i think of it i mean
you could add a delay
to the whole thing so so that the
transition is delayed by a fixed amount
of time if you wanted to yes i see so if
i want them to exit first i would add a
delay to the enter so they would exit
and that would that would be enough time
for them to exit and then enter will
will be involved oh i see what you're
trying to do yeah yeah
and it almost pains me not to do it
right now because we're so close
and we're discussing this let me just
let me just do it real quick
thank you
so on exit
we use exit.call so that we can use the
transitions
and then
we can call
shrink
radius and then
dot remove
calling the dot remove on the transition
will remove the dom elements only after
the transition finishes
which is something that only d3 does
really well if you try to do transitions
with other libraries like react it's
such a pain to do this sort of thing
but d3 does it very well now we just
need to implement shrink radius
which should be pretty easy
just copy grow radius and make it
transition
r to zero
like this
let's see if it works
it does but the delay is problematic
the delay is like too much
i don't think we need any delay at all
as a matter of fact
the delay is the fancy thing for moving
x and y but for exiting and entering i
don't think we need any delay at all
hmm not sure what's happening here
is shrink radius taking the enter
selection
as an input
shrink radius is just taking
well it's it's called enter here
but the name doesn't matter
oh wait a minute
it's adding the transition here
oh well if it's if it's adding the
transition there we don't need to add
the transition here as well
and we don't even need this call
so
here's what we can do just exit dot call
shrink radius
easy peasy
let's see if that works
oh i think i think we're not making the
radius um
we're not growing the radius
on update
and shrink radius really should remove
the elements as well
let's see if that works
yeah there we go
that's how it should be
yeah this is exactly what i was hoping
for
okay cool
problem solved
and it was a interesting journey to get
there
great
so
i think now what i'd like to do is
you know present my take
on how we would
implement this
just so that every all the pieces are
very clear
i was just noticing that
the problem we were just working on is
not fully done i'm not going to solve it
now
but just just to show you
if you
wait for the transition to finish
before you change the menu
everything works perfectly
however
if you change the menu twice
before
the transition ends or rather if you
change it three times
before the transition ends
you can end up in a state like this
that's not correct
and i think what's happening here
is that the exit transition is starting
and then
you
change the selection which causes the
filtering to change and everything to
update but that exit transition is still
going on and when it finishes
it removes those dom elements
and so to really solve this um eric if
you wanted to take this on as a
challenge because this started from your
work
if you really wanted to solve this the
thing to do would be to cancel
the exit transition
whenever
you render the data
again which may be a little tricky to
figure out but that would be the
ultimate solution okay
give it a go yeah give it a go
see if you can uh
make it happen because this is i'm glad
we got to this point though because this
this reveals some of the trickiest
aspects
of working with d3
and this would be a good solution a good
uh
a good little puzzle to solve to really
solidify the knowledge of everything
great thanks yeah so good luck good luck
with that
okay let's dig into today's
live coding
by handling species using scale point
and manually adding metadata about the
columns
like type for example so column name and
type that's what i'm thinking of as
metadata
before we dig in though
i want to talk about these terms
quantitative
and categorical
these are terms that
i got from tamara munsner's book tamar
munsner's textbook called visualization
analysis and design
which is a great book really great book
highly recommend
and it's used
in a lot of
classrooms you know people teaching
about data visualization use this as the
textbook i use it for example when i
teach
every fall
and
that book defines
terminology
that can be used across
you know discussions of visualization
design
so on and so forth i mean there's a lot
of different terms that have been used
over the years
and she sort of defines it like okay
these are the terms i'm going to use so
i'm going with her set of terms to
define
different types of
attributes in the data
and the term attribute that's another
term that means column some people refer
to them as columns i often refer to
columns as columns because that's what
they are to me
but in a data table sense columns can
also be called as attributes
and attributes have types
much like variables have types
and the types of attributes that we're
dealing with here
when we come up against this problem of
handling species in our drop down menu
is categorical
categorical attributes have different
type things
in them meaning not numbers
they are not numbers they're strings or
identifiers
for for things that have identity so the
identity of
the values in a categorical column
categorical attribute are different
and in the case of this iris data set
we've got a bunch of quantitative
columns that are numbers that you see
here on the left
but then we've got one column that is
special and needs to be treated
differently than all of those other
columns that are numbers namely species
and the reason why it's fundamentally
different is because it's not numbers
it's strings it's a different species of
a virus
setosa is one species versus color is
another
and there's one more
but the point is that there are strings
they're different things they need to be
mapped to the visual
space
in a fundamentally different way
and so that's what we'll
get into here
any questions so far
about this
all right i think i'll move on
okay
so now we'll actually handle species
and we're going to use scale point which
is kind of like scale linear
but it deals with
categorical attributes you can give it
different strings and it will it will
spread the unique values across the
space
which is how we want to do it
all right so let's dig in
the place where i'm going to start from
is
animated scatter plot with menus this is
what we created last week
and just to give a quick recap of what
we did we added these menus
with these animated transitions so you
can change x and y to be
the various
quantitative attributes of the iris data
set but when you select species
it just breaks it crashes
and the way we did this is we introduced
a menu component which is
using the d3 reusable charts pattern but
for a menu
added event
you know event infrastructure
to that thing
and then in index.js
we add a a listener for the change event
on these menus
which will
change the x value accessor of the
scatter plot instance and re-render it
with svg.col
and in scatterplot whenever it gets
rendered it redefines these
these scales x and y scale
and it's here
in the definition of the scale
that we're going to have to make some
adjustments
so to start i'm going to fork this one
i'll call it scatter plot
with menus
that handles
uh um
let me come up with a nice title
including species
thank you
that's perfect
perfect thank you
okay
so
what we want to have happen is that when
you select species here in this menu
and for y for example it should spread
out across
the y
coordinates the different values
but it doesn't do that right now
let's see
where we can jump in to solve this issue
to me it makes sense just to start
scratch that
to me it makes the most sense to start
here at the definition of these options
for the menus
and what this does here is
it defines the entries of our menu
essentially
that's the id for the thing this is the
text
the label the display name that appears
in the menu
i think the the most sensible approach
would be to introduce
another
property
on these objects called type
and the type of the species column
i would say using tomorrow munzener's
terminology is
categorical
and the type for all the others
is quantitative
so just for completeness sake
i'm gonna fill all those out
run prettier
yeah unfortunately because it gets to be
long
i think that's okay it's explicit
so now
we know
when we select a given option what type
it is
which is information that we need in
order to change the type of the scale
that we use
so now that we've got this in hand
we need to tell the scatter plot
you know
what type of column it's dealing with
we could do that in a number of ways but
i think this the most straightforward
way
would be to add another
accessor you know at one of these getter
setter
functions on the plot
called x type
because we already have x value it's
working perfectly fine we don't want to
over complicate that
um
but i think we can add another one
called x type and the invocation would
be something like
dot x type
and then we need to figure out what the
type is
for the column
so we have column which is you know the
name of the column
and we can use it to construct the
accessor like this
but we also need to use it to get
the type
somehow
i'm not sure how
and because i'm not sure how you know
this is a perfect place to introduce a
level of indirection i'm going to i'm
going to call a function called get type
just just one question i was trying to
do this
uh at home but
i was not able what i tried uh uh first
i
rewrote the get data
i put outside in a model
and and then i try to get the json
that's inside your
[Music]
your github
together with the data
there is in the site where i got the
data there is a json there
that has all these options already
the type
[Music]
really
yeah so the gist in here
yes and i try to use
the json
uh but i'm not able to
get the data out of the scope
when i try to
to put this in a in an array or in a
dictionary uh i lose i lose the data
inside the loop i have the data
right when i get outside of the loop the
they don't vanish so huh
how could we use this
so we don't have to hard code like uh
the type string or the type number right
from from this
right and it's so funny i actually
forgot that i put this here
um
let's see when did i make this
this was like
years ago that i put this up here
and at that time as well
i was thinking about metadata for
columns because it makes sense to be
able to
manipulate the metadata along with the
data set
which is totally possible so i mean we
can use the raw url here
and we could potentially use
d3.json to fetch this file
and use it
but uh for simplicity's sake i'm just
gonna you know paste it into the code
but
because we have this data structure you
know uh we could potentially do it like
that
and years ago i was thinking about like
oh i'm going to develop a data
publishing format where it's supposed to
be a csv file and a little json file
like this that describes each of the
columns
don't give up on that right
[Laughter]
it's not a bad idea i mean it would be
super useful
to be able to have like a standard that
you could just plug in
um so i'll keep that in mind but yeah
the way to do it would be
d3.json to fetch this file
and then use promise.all
to fetch the csv and the json at the
same time and then run some code after
both of them have loaded but no matter
where this information comes from
we're going to have to
implement
this function
get type
for the column
oh just yes yep sure
and
so let me just put that right here
get type is a function that takes as
input the column
and returns
the type
of
the column
now
the name column might be confusing
because conceptually a column is
described by one of these objects
but what this really is is the column
value
meaning like the name
the name of the column
so it's just a string it's it's not the
entire object if it were that'd be
simpler but it's just the string sepal
length
so you know honestly to make that more
clear i'm going to call it
column
name
or column value
i like to think of it as column name
that way
column a keyword
column attribute i don't know
in a way i wanna i wanna i want this to
be name
like this
but it's a refactoring that would mean
we'd need to update the code elsewhere
i don't know maybe i'll just leave it
like the way it was
but we just have to understand here
here's what i'll do i'll add a comment
say
column is a string
corresponding to
the
value property
on metadata objects
can i
can i ask a question about the problem
we're trying to solve here sure
thank you so
am i right to understand that we have an
array
of objects
and we have a value
a unique value for one of the properties
of those objects somewhere in that array
and we want to reach
the other
property of that same object within the
array
that's exactly right
yeah we have this
as in
we have
the string corresponding to the value
properties in these objects that exist
in this array and what we want to get
is the type
which is
a strain that comes from a different
property
of those objects
but we have a array of objects right
correct
and we we need to get
the value of the object inside the array
okay
yeah
we have to given
the column name for example species this
function should return the type namely
categorical
yeah
and so one one way we could do this
is
you know
iterate through each of these entries
and then
when it matches when the value matches
will have access to the entire object
and then we can just access the type of
it
and that would look something like
options.find which is another method on
arrays
d.value equals
column
this would give us the object and then
we could just access dot type
that should work
yeah cool
yes
and
and that will enable us to get to jump
from any property to any other property
within the same object exactly
in an array of objects correct
perfect
however
the dot find method on arrays
will check
you know the way it works dot fine the
way it works is it checks each and every
one it says okay let's take a look at
this one
and it passes that object into this
thing
and then this function runs it returns
true or false so it says is d dot value
equal to column it checks the first one
it says okay d dot value is battle width
is that equal to
column
which is you know whatever column we
selected
if it is then it returns true and then
array.find returns that one that matched
but if it returns false
array.fine goes on to the next one and
it passes in the next one and says okay
is that one the same
no it's not the same go on to the next
one
check it again if
if it is the same
then
the define method returns that object so
if it matches species for example it
would return this entire object
from this expression here that's why we
can say dot type
we could we could just as easily say
text
to access the text
so
because it iterates through each and
every one
i generally don't like to do it this way
because it's
big o of n
algorithm wise that means the algorithm
takes n steps where n is the number of
columns
in this case it's it's not that bad
there's only like five
so it's not really
it's not really an issue
so this would work perfectly well
but i kind of do want to show the way i
would do it
which is to create a lookup table using
the map data structure
but any questions so far
i just had a quick question around this
find method yes so
if like it's not present in this current
table lookup example but say we had
multiple
columns or multiple columns with the
same name so species was appearing twice
so what find like return
both those objects or will it just
return the first
uh occurrence of
the
of the selection selected column or the
column that we're trying to find
that's correct it would just return the
first one
okay okay
that's what fine does it just returns
the first match that it encounters so if
you did have species
as the value for multiple of these which
you wouldn't want to that would be a bug
but if you did
uh it would just return the first one
and not the second one
wait thanks
is there a
find all
method
um not the case here but uh just
yeah this is what i would do
i don't
think there is but there is
a filter which is essentially does the
same thing yeah okay yeah
exactly yeah so if you wanted to do that
you would say options.filter
and
you wouldn't want to say that type
because the result would be an array
this would find all of the matches
it would so filter is essentially find
all that match
perfect okay clear
now i just want to before moving on to
the implementation with map i just want
to make sure that this is actually
working
change the filter for find
oh thanks
so to just check if it's working i'm
going to say console.log get type of
column
this will let us
just check if it's working
and this is on the
um
the x menu so when i change x
it works
it says quantitative
excellent
yeah so if i if i use species it outputs
categorical
perfect
so it works quantitative quantitative
quantitative
quantitative categorical if it's species
so that part works that's great
x dot type is not a function but yeah
we'll deal with that later
but first because we're on this topic
and this is such a common thing to have
to do
i just want to say this is not how i
would actually implement this
how i would actually implement this is
to create a map
i'll call it um
column
two
type
is a new map
data structure
and this is built in to the browser you
don't have to import any libraries or
anything
it's an es6 feature
and
map
has a number of methods like set and get
so column two type meaning
the way i named it like that because
it's a lookup table from column to type
you know from column which you use as
the keys
to type which are going to be used as
the values
and so what we can do
is loop through
all of these
options
maybe something like
dot 4 each
is a way to iterate through these
and we could say for each of these
options
we can say
we want to set the value
and the key will be
option.value
and the value that the key maps to which
is confusing because the value you know
that we're using the word value here but
the the value that the
key maps to will be type
option.type so how do we put these
together this is where we can say column
to type which is an instance of the map
data structure
dot set
and set takes as input two arguments the
key
and the value
okay i think this uh solves the problem
that i was having
when i imported from the
from the website the json ah because
when i tried to to set the uh what i did
i create a external array
like before the column to type
and try to push the value inside
this array but outside this scope when i
try to get back
the array it's empty
inside the four each if i if i create a
array outside and try to push the values
inside this array when it's outside it's
empty
so i think this set may solve this
yeah and it's important to connect the
dots between the the data structures
because what you need to implement this
get type is a a dictionary essentially a
map a key value mapping where you give
it the key gives it gives you the value
but if you're starting from an array
you have to do something else like dot
find which traverses each element of the
array which you don't want and you can't
you can't say like options at index
column
which is you know you could use an
object
as a map as well
but um
but yeah i think this does solve the
problem and once we have built up this
map
we can access it uh but first just to
really comprehend what's happening let
me say console.log
column to type so we can see what this
map ended up looking like
it's a map instance
that has a bunch of entries and this is
just how chrome
presents it to you
in the console
it means the key
is pedal width and the value is
quantitative
and this double arrow here means like it
maps to you know
if you give
pedal width
to the function dot get
it will return quantitative
and it'll do so efficiently it doesn't
have to check each one internally it
implements probably like a hash table
kind of a lookup scheme where it's big o
of one instead of big o of n in
algorithmic terms it doesn't have to
check all of those it just gives you
back instantly the one you that you want
so
if we say
column
to type
dot get
column
inside of get type
this should work
as well
and to test it
we can change the column
and observe that yeah okay it still
prints out the right thing quantitative
and if i switch to species it outputs
categorical
okay this is working
this is working
however
this is not the
best way
it's not the simplest way
to do it
the simplest way to do it
is to take advantage of
a way of calling the map constructor
where you can actually pass in
an array
of arrays
and each of those
inner arrays
has only two elements the key and the
value
that way of doing it is much more
concise
and all you know
although it is a bit more cryptic
and the way that we would do that is is
we can pass in options.map
again the functional programming
construct that lets you give it a
function that function accepts each
element
and the return values end up as a new
array
we can return an array
that has just two elements
option.value
and option.type
and this should work as well let me see
if i got it right
yeah
seems to work just fine
so just to review
what i did there
options.map
maps over all the options and it returns
an array that has the value and the type
the first thing being the key of the map
the second thing being the
value in the map
and this is just an alternative syntax
for doing the exact same thing as this
other thing does namely looping through
all of the entries and calling.set
and to simplify this even further we
could use es6 destructuring
to destructure value and type
from
the argument
and then we don't have to say option dot
and option dot
so all of this is a roundabout way of
you know
exploring the ins and outs of
constructing maps
um but since it comes up so often i
wanted to dig into this this level of
detail because you know i think it's
it's really important to fundamentally
understand how to use maps
in today's javascript world
i see there are some questions
let me see
what is this and is it live
yeah
it is
it's live
why are you not using typescript
well i'm not using typescript because
typescript is a pain to use in my
experience
then you don't have to write comments
yeah i know
yeah it's just it's just a pain
is this microsoft monaco no it's not
it's a viz hub
this thing that i made
and you can use it too anyone can use it
you can fork this stuff and get a link
to it
what are we doing here i love these
questions
these are great
um
it's a new visualization tool people can
use yeah i mean
this being vishub yeah i created about
two years ago
d3 has been around a while as larry
points out thank you larry
yeah d3 has been around a while but the
apis have changed so that's why i'm
doing this tutorial now to like use the
most modern way
of doing it
okay thanks for those questions
okay um now we can move on to the next
phase
namely implementing
x type but before we do that i just want
to make sure are there any questions so
far about what we've done here so far
please go ahead
that song oh she just said it's so
complicated
yeah i know there's a lot of details
there are a lot of details to remember
but um
and the first time you see stuff like
this i realize it can be overwhelming
that's why i wanted to like
yeah this happens all the time first
time i see something it's like
wow i'm not understanding it and once i
get into it it's like oh it wasn't that
bad
yeah and console.log is your friend i
mean if you were on your own you can say
console.log options.map value type
and see what it is
and and use use console.log to
interrogate what you see here anything
that's confusing to unpack it and
understand what's
what's happening in that intermediate
stage see it's an array of arrays
and i realized when i described it it's
a bit abstract but when you console.log
it and you see it
you can understand oh it's an array of
arrays with the keys and the values
and also if you're on your own and find
the stuff confusing
it's good to consult mdn
which is the de facto standard
documentation for the built-in stuff in
javascript such as map
and it says right here
it describes
the map constructor
creates a new map object
and it says right here
that you can pass an iterable
into the constructor which is what we're
doing
and it just it documents that right here
it says what is this iterable it's an
array
whose elements are key value pairs in
the form of arrays so here's an example
that maps numbers to strings
so yeah if you if you're ever looking at
this stuff on your own and feel oh my
gosh this is so confusing
use console.log and
and and just do google searches for the
data structures that we use like map
because the documentation is great and
also the same goes for d3
the d3 documentation is really good so
if you see a d3 method that you don't
know like just google it find the
documentation
um
i do it all the time but it takes such a
long time it does it does there are a
number of um
there are a lot of rabbit holes that you
could go down and get distracted
really time consuming and
just takes a lot of time
[Music]
yeah i would say it's well worth it it's
an investment in your future
yeah i agree
that's why you and you have every other
week
yeah i changed and that makes it
difficult because
for example i'm so behind i am supposed
to catch up yeah
i wish it was every other day well
actually i was going to announce it at
the end but since you brought it up i
did change it to be every other week not
every week so going forward is going to
be every other week
thank god i updated the meetup page why
because yeah it's for me too it's a bit
hectic to do this every week
anyway are there any other questions
i just wanted to ask
what what would happen if you have
two entries with the same keys so you'd
be like while you were trying to iterate
you're passing two keys
two exact keys to
in your map object
that's a fantastic idea
well if we if we go back to this other
variant that i did here
with this variant it's easy to
understand
what the answer to that question would
be
if you understand
the semantics of dot set
if you call dot set
multiple times
with the same key
it will change
the value
and so in this
case
let's say we had two of these where
species was the same
what this algorithm would do
is
call dot set
passing the key species
and it would
set the value to be this one here
however
the next time around
you know in the for each when it gets
evaluated with the last option it's
going to call dot set again
and so
when it calls set the second time with
the same key
the way that maps work it's going to
overwrite
the first version of it and so
we're going to end up with a map
that
only has one value for species and it's
going to be the last one encountered in
this array
so that's a complete opposite of find in
a way exactly it's the opposite of find
yes
yes that's a great insight the way find
works is it checks each one and it
returns the first match the way this
works is it sets up entries in the map
for each of these entry entries in the
options array one at a time
and if it does encounter the key
multiple times
it overwrites it so essentially it's
putting the last occurrence of the match
in the original array as the the value
in the map that you get
thank you yeah my pleasure
and
i'm not so certain what the behavior is
when you use the constructor like this
but it may well be the same
yeah it may well take the last
match
although i'm not 100 sure
so you know we can do we can actually
test it out
and this is the beautiful thing about
coding too you can use the code to ask
questions about the code
for example
um oh there's a breakage
column to type is not defined
i'm sorry forgot to uncomment
uh sorry i'm just a little disoriented
but yeah let's do this little experiment
to figure out
what the answer is
all right so when we use this variant
that uses for each goes through all of
them i would expect it's going to give
us the last one
and if we select species
it outputs
categorical
which is the last one see the first one
was quantitative
and we actually have the same key here
multiple times
now
let's answer the other question of what
if we use the map constructor
like this
is it the same
so if i select species
it outputs categorical so the answer is
yes it is the same
that takes the last one
great question great question i love how
it digs in a little deeper
yeah thank you
okay
now
let's go ahead and solve the next piece
of this puzzle
now that we know what the type should be
when we select it
we need to pass it into x type
and you know while we're at it let's
pass it into y type
as well
why type is get type of column
oh there's some error
there's a syntax error
i don't know what that was about
so i'm going to also call
why
type here
okay it's fine nothing was
there was no problem
so now from the outer sort of view of
things
we're invoking it where we want to be
invoking it we're setting y type when we
change the y menu and we're setting x
type when we change the x menu
now the task at hand is to implement
that method in our scatter plot
so let's go into our scatter plot code
in scatter plot
dot js we've got a bunch of these
getter setter
accessors
and let's just make a few more
we've got x value and y value
i'm just going to copy paste these
and change
value to type
so x type is going to be x type
change y value to
y type
and we're referring to the variable y
type and x type those don't exist yet so
let's make those
at the top of the file
like this
now
these are available to us
when we render our scatter plot
let's just make sure because this is
where we're going to want to use those
let's make sure it's available with
console.log
x type
here
so we get undefined initially which
makes sense because we're only passing
it in when we change the menu
but when we do change the menu we get
quantitative
for these and if we type if we select
species we get categorical which is
exactly what we want
okay
this is great
and i think what we can do is say
if x type
is
categorical
using this
ternary syntax
we create a linear scale
otherwise
now this is where we can use uh
category
exactly
yeah yeah the good call so i got the
order reversed
it's going to be scale linear if it's
not categorical
but if it is categorical
then it's going to use
scale point
just use prettier to format that
and if it is a scale point
we can set
the domain
to be
data.map
x value
and what this what this does is it
returns an array of all the different x
values
including duplicates so it's going to
return like versa color versus color
versus color setosa satosa setosa but
then when you when you pass that array
into dot domain
the scale will
internally figure out that there are
duplicates and it will deduplicate it so
the domain will only end up having three
entries
the unique values
of the species column
and then dot range
um
actually should be the same
because we want it to span across the
same space
in pixels
so this should work
let's see if it does
if i change x
to species
there's some breakage let's see what it
is
oh scale point is not defined yeah i
forgot to import it
we just need to import that from d3
along with this other stuff
now it should work
okay great
check it out
it works
hooray we solve the problem
yep everything's working
the quantitative stuff is working and
when we hit species
it transitions to this
which is the behavior of a point scale
by the way it just takes the values that
it sees in the order it receives them
and identifies the unique ones and
spreads those across the space across
the screen
it's exactly what we want
and i must say i am impressed by
the way that d3 axis handles the
transition
see how it fades
d3 axis is brilliantly implemented
because
if it is given
another
a linear scale see how it animates the
numbers it animates the ticks
but if you pass into d3 axis with the
transition
a different type of scale it does this
nice fade
animation which is just brilliant
brilliant
but anyway
there's a little bit of cleanup work to
do here
but um any questions so far
yeah just um one question
here is eric
um
just curious uh
how
hard would it be
to actually um show
um
all the data that are
in each of those categories as dot plots
so in other words in other words some of
those as you mentioned earlier are on
top of each other but you would really
have sort of a
frequency
is this what you mean by dot plot yep
yep
so so
so what you're trying to show is uh
almost the distribution across those
categories
so that you can see where the peaks are
so that's hidden right now yep but it's
a sort of a natural transition but
um as i'm thinking about it
just trying to get a sense from your
expertise
how deep one would have to go and
actually do that
not that we do it here but i'm just
curious yeah it's a great question go
ahead
i
i just want to suggest an idea for doing
that and and let you see whether it
works or not
so
we
yes
that's right
to implement that
what you described eric
the first thing i would do
is
just look at it from from a bird's eye
view and say like what should the
architecture of this be
should it be one visualization or should
it be
a parent visualization and a child
visualization where the child
is
one of these reusable components like
the scatter plot but for a single dot
plot
got it you know what i mean and then i
would i would get it to work that's
probably how i would do it i would get
it to work for a single dot plot and
like you said costa
that requires
a step of binning where you take these
um
well in this case you can just use the
the different values that are present
here
i think it increments by 0.1
that's the resolution of the data so for
each one of these unique values you
would want to bin them
and count how many occurrences there are
for each of these unique values and that
there's a feature in d3 called d3 bin i
think or d3 histogram if you google
search d3 histogram
you can see this in action so that's a
data processing step so first you need
to do that binning
so that for each of these numbers you
know how many
occurrences there are and then based on
that after that binning happens
you can visualize
that
as a dot plot
got it and that would be one of these
components and then
what you're doing essentially is called
small multiples dot plots where you
would want to actually have three dot
plots one for each species
and so then you would need to change
this scatter plot code completely
so that
for each of the values
across the x-axis here
it would iterate through those and for
each one invoke that reusable dot plot
instance
so you'd have three instances of a
reusable dot plot that's one way to do
it
okay that's was
that that's sort of just curious how
you'd approach it so um not that
obviously we tackle it
but it's it yeah so that's how you would
do that but there's a uh
if you step back a little there's
another question what is the best
visualization design
to show this type of data
and small multiples dot plots is one
option
but there are a number of different
options there's actually one option
that's very low hanging fruit for us
that we could do right now
and i love doing this
because it's so simple
on the circles
we could set the fill
opacity
to 0.2 in the css
um
i don't think that actually worked
maybe it's just opacity
yeah there we go that worked
so if we set the opacity on the circles
and we subdivide them by species
you can see
it's doing it right there you see what
i'm saying
yeah yeah
i love it
so this is a simple modification we can
do to make the visualization communicate
the information of density like how many
overlapping dots there are which is the
same thing that would be communicated by
the dot plots
yep
yes so this is a bird's eye view yep
okay
so the bird's-eye view meaning
what i meant by a bird's-eye view is you
step back and look at the design space
of the visualization this is one other
option there are so many other options i
mean you could have small multiples box
plots for example
you could have small multiples
histograms
like bar
style histograms you could have small
multiples of violin plots
so many different ways i mean once you
get this
data structure and you want to visualize
it there are so many options but you can
frame it as small multiples
meaning
you want to implement one instance of it
and then just multiply it across the
different values
that's really cool
nice yeah and r by the way ggplot in r
does all this stuff
okay it's brilliant the way it does it
so yeah stuff to look into
thank you
yeah my pleasure
all right let's finish this up here it's
almost done but we've only done it for x
and not y
and this code itself can be cleaned up
whenever i see
duplicated logic
like this dot range dot range copy
pasted its exact same thing
i asked myself how can we get rid of
this duplicated logic
in this case it's fairly simple because
this expression if you put parentheses
around it
returns a scale
it could be a point scale it could be a
linear scale
but it returns the scale
and so we can essentially factor out
the call to dot range
so that it gets applied to the returned
scale whatever
type of scale it happens to be
then i just run prettier on that and
and this is what we get
yeah i would prefer this just because it
has less duplication
so to be clear this
set of parentheses
creates
the scale you know a different type of
scale depending on whether x type is
categorical or not it sets the domain
but it does not set the range
but whatever scale comes back from this
expression
we call dot range on that scale whatever
it is so it's just a simpler way to do
it
now that we've got that
we can just do the exact same thing
for y i'm just going to copy paste it
change x to y
all over the place
so instead of x value it's going to be y
value
but with the y scale we need to be
careful about the range because
it's different it's height minus
margin dot bottom and margin top top
so i'm going to take this
definition of the range and use it here
and get rid of our original
y scale definition
and this should do the trick
for both x and y
let's see if it does
x species works
y species
works
excellent
and one last little thing
that i don't like about this is that
there's no padding it goes all the way
up to the edge
maybe it's just personal preference or
stylistic but
i like always to put a little
padding
and the way where we can put that is
right here scale point.domain.padding
that's a function on these scales
i'll say
0.2
yeah so if we look at it now
we get this nice padding it doesn't go
all the way up to the edge
which i just find kind of
i don't know
distasteful
it has space to breathe the labels you
can read all the labels now so virginica
used to be off the screen
and just as the final step i'm going to
call dot padding
in the case of y
as well
so now it works
for both x and y
and the the labels get cut
off yeah
let me just
change the margin
to address that problem because what i
want to do is finish today with a
complete product that works
for all the cases that you select
but where's my margin
margin oh it's right here
margin left let me set it to 150 pixels
and see if that's enough for species
okay that's a little too much
maybe 120.
all right
there we have it
any questions
so one question i had was with those
drop downs there um i couldn't find
where one
does this or if it's even possible to
change the font and the size of those
drop downs oh
is that a css thing
that's a great question you know the
html
select element and the options
it's notoriously difficult to style
with css
so if you're working on a product
where you need styled menus the best
approach might to go might be to go
seeking out some third-party library
that implements
a drop-down widget that you could style
with css
okay
yeah explains the hunt
yeah they're right it's it's a hunt yeah
and like you just it's very difficult
to style these the way you want
um
but again it's a whole other level of
complexity to like evaluate the
different libraries and pick one and
figure out how to use it
um however
with this d3 reusable chart pattern
you could implement a menu component
just like this having the same api you
know having the same methods and
everything
but internally it could use that
third-party menu library that would be
the approach that i would suggest
okay
thank you but that said
i was actually surprised to see that in
one of the submissions
the menus were styled let me see if i
can find which was that you cost up yes
kostov how did you do this i think
i
normal css to do this
see this is beautiful it has that custom
font that's awesome yeah i just wanted
to make the phone consistent with maxis
menu so i just use this select
uh html and apply this property here
brilliant so you know
there you go all right i was trying to
figure that out
yeah there you go so it looks like it
looks like you had to style the select
the label and option
to get it to work
yep so i think the labels were for these
axis
labels and the option and select work
for the drop down right
yep
so there's your answer eric should work
thank you and i was actually quite
surprised to see this working
because
i've struggled in the past to try to do
this
but it looks like this works
yeah i was just playing around with it i
totally forgot that it worked for my
case that's awesome
and i wonder if it would behave
correctly if you try more advanced css
like setting the the background color or
the
you know the roundedness of the edges
i think you might run into a wall beyond
which you can't customize but
worth exploring for sure
right but yeah this is very nice and i i
have to say it's really nice how these
animate
or how your labels animate
really nice work
all right well
i think that's all for today
i
thank you so much
yeah my pleasure
thank you all thank you very much
thank you
yeah thank you very much
and uh yeah like i said it's i changed
it to every other week so just mark your
calendars it's not going to be every
week
and i will leave you all with an
exercise for this next two weeks
i want you to find a compelling data set
look around online
for different data sets
and uh yeah try to find a compelling
public data set
and just search around
you know
i would suggest coming up with some idea
of like data that you want to see
visualized
that you've maybe seen in the past or
thought about deeply like some sort of
existential like
question about society or
i don't know climate change the keeling
curve if you the killing curve would be
a good one
um but yeah find a compelling data set
that interests you
and the way to do it is just search for
the topic see if you can find any
visualizations that pertain to the topic
track down their data source
uh you know follow links until you can
get to a downloadable data file like an
excel file
and then export it as csv or just try to
find a csv or a json file
load that up
you know fork the scatter plot we made
with the menus load in that data
update the data parsing logic and i want
you to actually explore the data
using this scatter plot with menus
because now that now that the scatter
plot has the transparency
uh we can see the density of things
and now that we made it handle species
it can handle any column that's
categorical
and i want you to write up the key
insights that you discover
in the readme
of the viz
so fork this
modify the readme.md file to write up
like bullet points of like this is cool
this other thing is cool
you know interesting
insights that you find about the data
not about the vids or the coding
but i want you to like actually
explore some data
and uh yeah share your results in the
forum i've made an entry for
for today
episode 12. here it is
viz hub has been my passion project
since
and um
i've rewritten it twice
and i'm i'm embarking on rewriting it
again
okay because
i went in the other day to try to
redeploy and like
upgrade the dependencies and it's like
it was just so heavy feeling you know a
code base that i've been working on for
two years and so i really want to like
do a deep dive and like make vidshop as
good as it could possibly be
and uh focus on things like
you know
hot reloading of the code
is is what i've really been intrigued by
and also having some state associated
with the visuals so the if you want to
tweak something you don't have to change
the code but you'd have like a knob or a
dial that you could just touch
and tweak and see the feedback
instantaneously
so i was just very um
inspired to start working on
the next the next iteration of vishub so
that's that's what i'm going to do
but but this has been a really great
experience this series because it's
developed this little following
which i think is
it's amazing it's it's it's a golden
little
um
group of folks and and i just want to
say i really appreciate all of you who
have participated it's been really fun
and i've it's been really great to see
you all learn and grow
and do new things that you've never done
before so thanks for that
now thanks you for all of your
being so kind to to share your knowledge
you know
it's my
pleasure yeah and it's it's you know
it's proved it sort of proved the one of
the original vision
goals of of this hub and my teaching to
to reach a wider audience of folks who
might not
otherwise be able to learn this stuff
you know may not have access to
you know a university
so and it worked it's it's working i
mean i've i've seen people from all
sorts of different countries um if i
look at the google analytics of his hub
it's not just the us it's global the
audience is global particularly in
like developing countries which
which i'm so thrilled by i just that's
so happy to see yeah i'm for example i'm
from chile and you know last year
i it was really a struggle or maybe
2019 it was really a struggle to find
here
uh a curse on d3 a like a leap course
uh
and well in the internet there's a lot
of tutorials uh but
but i you know
the the ones that you produce are
are the ones that really made me
understand the tree and this one that
was synchronous it was really also
i i've learned a lot thanks to this
oh great
great i'm happy to hear that
yeah
yeah i remember being on and seeing
someone from new zealand i think was on
yep
so
we had new zealand india
us exactly it folks from india i think
kostov you're located in india right
yeah yeah i'm from india
quite a diverse set that we have here oh
i'm curious where do you live in india
uh so i live near delhi
ah
nice up north
you know i lived um i lived outside of
nagpur for four and a half years
oh well i didn't know that and actually
i developed visa when i was living in
india i was riding my scooter my honda
activa
to my little rented office
and uh coding this hub
all day
nice
yeah i also like would be definitely
interested in like you know
seeing this grow and
i found it really nice that feature that
you just write your code and you
automatically see the changes you don't
have to press any button or build right
right exactly
activity
yep and and that's that's one of the
things that i love about this hub too
but the way that it works right now is
that every time you make a a change it
tote it reruns the entire
page and i want to move away from that
i want to share with you all
brett victor
inventing on principle this talk was
hugely hugely inspiring to me so in this
case the the value
because he's got this idea
that
yeah check this out
he's got this
we are not seeing the anything oh i'm
sorry i have to share my screen in this
in this system too i forgot to do that
it's live on youtube but not in the
google meet but now you should be able
to see it
okay
yeah this is the thing i just want to
play this because it really resonates
with me spent working in the code
working in a text editor blindly
without an immediate connection to this
thing which is what i'm actually trying
to make
so i feel this goes against this
principle i have that creators need an
immediate connection
they're making
so i try to come up with a coding
environment that i thought might be more
in line with this principle i have
so what i have here
is i've got this picture on the side
and the code on this side
and
this this part draws the sky and this
draws the mountains
this draws the tree
and when i make any change the code
the picture changes immediately that's
what i want to have so the code and the
picture are always in sync
who did this
just
change things in the code oh brett
victor yeah
i see things changing the picture but
check this out he's about to do the
craziest thing
and now that we have this immediate
connection between the code and the
picture we can start thinking about ways
of changing the code other than typing
so for example this number here is
the length of the branches if i want to
control that number i just point my
mouse to it hold down the control key
and i can dial it up and down that's
what i want
oh wow i can see what it looks like for
big bridges or small branches and i can
kind of converge on what feels right to
me artistically
and this works really well with some of
the stuff in the past it's amazing
so this video by ve it's from 2012 this
video by brett
he's a
visionary yes
and what strikes me about this is it the
way this environment this little
environment that he custom built for
just this one talk
it it seems to not reload the entire
page it just reruns the code in the page
without having to reload the entire html
and so i think you know this is the
direction i want to take vishub i want
to make it so that you can author your
code and
and updates to the code should take on
the order of milliseconds to execute
without having to re run rerun the
entire html and then from there i want
to add like the ability to extract
different variables into like little
widgets
on the side like in the editor of this
hub there should be a visual editor with
colors and numbers and strings and as
you change those it should update
instantly
so yeah i just wanted to share some some
context for why i'm why i'm ending this
this series right now
so
yeah
that's it
have you been in contact with him on how
he's done that no okay i mean he's he's
a towering figure i mean brett victor
he's yeah
so i don't know if he's the kind of
person i could just get in touch with
you know
he's like this
this like celebrity figure yeah you know
i worked at apple for years and years i
think he developed
a lot of the
the early ui for like the ipads and
stuff
but hey that's not a bad idea maybe i
should just send them an email yeah
do it worth a try i guess
and yeah someone asked how to support
viz hub
yeah
the best way to support it right now is
just to sign up for the
the paid plan which is four dollars a
month
there's current there are currently not
that many customers and it's not
making money it's not even paying for
the servers
but um
and this is another direction i'm going
to take it i want to add more features
that people would be willing to pay for
so if anybody has ideas i mean i have a
lot of ideas like
pay for storage
pay for
collaborator seats
white label embedding where you could
embed a viz onto a website
without the vis hub logo in it
custom domains for visits i mean imagine
if you could create something at visshub
and create it set up a domain name to
point to that and so this help could be
your website hosting
provider so i've got a lot of ideas if
anybody else has more ideas let me know
and i'd also i also want to make it the
best tool out there for professors and
teachers to use for teaching web any any
courses to do with web technology
so what's the best way to get to get in
touch with you
oh just just email me okay uh at gmail
yeah current.kelliher gmail.com all
right
yep
yeah and um i'm on twitter
so you know after i end this series
i'll still be active on twitter and i
will definitely announce um
so it's yeah curran what is it
current keller on twitter this is where
i'll announce um
any new
developments or activities
um
okay
and i i am thinking of doing like a a
beta program
where where i invite people to test out
the new version of vis hub that i'm
developing
and so if anybody would be interested in
that let me know
um i don't have any
any onboarding form set up or anything
like that you know but let me know i'd
be happy to
great yeah i'll keep you in mind
all right so let's let's dig into this i
i want to just wrap up the series
by reviewing
all the last
uh the work that everyone's done for the
last assignment and uh responding to
whatever questions that come up i don't
have any prepared material that i'm
going to go through today so it's really
just more of an informal
discussion
sort of a thing
so let's see
oh kostov is here with us um
custom you want to walk us through what
um what you've what you've done
yeah sure so
like i took a copy of the scatter plot
templates template that we
prepared last thing and plugged in
a data set which comes from
this tidy tuesday project which also
runs on twitter so this is run by the r
for data science online learning
community and they release like new data
sets every week
and this was a data set that i hadn't
explored before and just wanted to try
out like
explore it a bit further and thought
like using d3 and the
and all the things that you've learned
over the past
past weeks to
create this wiz
it shows the
i think the median income
median household income over time
and varies by
the different communities
so as you can see that there's a
significant difference between
like
whites and blacks and hispanics so this
sort of brings out
the income inequality which is still
prevalent
wow this is amazing and what where is
this localized is it for the us or
globally or yes
so this is just in the u.s
so it's the entire us
yes yes
wow i think the original data comes from
the us census
right oh great
urban institute that's a great group
great great work good stuff
uh
i i have a question for current about
this beast yeah it's okay
sure um
is there a way because i really
love the idea but but i think that maybe
if the labels of the years are exactly
a correspond exactly to the to the point
it could be more
easy to to read is there a way for the
x-axis the scale x-axis come on process
that or
or do that
let's take a look
yeah i think that would be a very nice
edition
but before we dig into that i just want
to say that this is exactly the kind of
work that i was hoping for where it
actually
looks at a an issue in the world and i
just want to take a second and i will i
will get into that that question but i
just want to take a second and think
about what it means
that
white people in the u.s
are earning
it looks like on the order of you know
160 k
up and down
whereas black people in the u.s are
earning
on the order of
less than 40 000 a year
i mean that's profound that's that's a
profound piece of information
also yeah
i was also surprised when i looked at
sad to revisit the raw data just to
confirm like i hadn't read it
incorrectly or right like is that
correct like oh my gosh
that's what i was wondering there's such
income inequality
like this is
the median what's the the metric
yeah this this is the median median
household earnings
adjusted for inflation i think yeah it's
adjusted for inflation
what is shocking to me as well that that
that this difference is not improving in
time
right
it's not improving at all it's it's you
know it seems to almost have been
getting worse
and if you if you if you inspect the
median of the white group again you
would see that they have increased in
time
right rising up compared to the other
ethnic minorities and this big gap this
big gap here must have been the 2008
um
financial yeah
financial crisis recession whatever they
call it
so that seems to have impacted everyone
but
it is it is shocking and like disturbing
like why is it that white people earn so
much more than black people
i think that's
that's ridiculous and just i you know
thank you costa for selecting this
particular data set and servicing this
particular issue i think it's a very
important thing to look at
and can i say as well you brought last
time you brought an important point that
animation need to serve a purpose
and it's nice seeing it's not it's not
very nice but it's it's very telling
seeing those
points drop when you start
yes i agree it's a very great use of
animation
yep
and i would be curious to to do a
similar analysis for different countries
across the world
and see if the gap is so high in other
countries as well or if it's something
that's unique to the us
i don't know i haven't looked at the
data but
that would be an interesting analysis
or maybe have this broken down in males
and females as well right that would be
another
good analysis
yes for sure for sure and then once you
do that the possibilities of different
ways of visualizing that increase
dramatically because you can show
multiple things at once
and yeah that's one thing i wanted to
get to with this course of like the
variety of visualization types
but we didn't we just essentially worked
on scatter plots but i think that's okay
because
because you can build things that are
interactive and scatter plots actually
cover a huge range of data and so the
first first thing you can do with any
data set is make a scatter plot
so yeah amazing word costume
now
um who asked that question about
aligning
i did
great great let's dig into that because
i agree i agree this this apparently
uses the built-in axis of you know from
d3
which is not the same as the data points
and so makes you wonder you know for a
given dot
what year is that
right and i agree that that's a that's a
good that's a good issue
that i want to see fixed
i'm just scrolling through to see
what is actually going on
here's the x-axis
so if we just comment out that
oh i forgot the dot call line
if we just comment that out
it renders without the axis
which is fine
although i kind of like i kind of want
to keep
the visual elements of the axis
um so i'm just thinking how could we do
this
we could
do some
other rendering logic
where we we render these tick tick marks
ourselves
or
we may be able to configure d3 axis with
a set number of points
i believe we can do that
let me just consult the d3 documentation
yeah i think so
ticks
so
yeah the nature of the tix
method
is
not just one
format
see this is the format that we're using
like 10.
and then oh
put something in the chat
oh which jet
google me
nice
so i'll copy it from the chat and take a
look
this is i'm pasting from the chat
c dot tx6 i still don't think this will
do what we need
because what i'm thinking is
we may be able to pass an array of
specific values
into ticks
that's what i'm trying to figure out
see this this one here
you it this passes in an array to ticks
which leads me to believe that i think
we can pass in an array of of dates
so let's just try it
instead of passing in ticks
what if i pass in
an array that has
just a single date
where it's like uh the year 2000
does that show up no
if i get rid of the formatter
no
do i huh
i'm pretty sure there's a way to specify
oh look here it is sorry to set the tick
values explicitly use access dot take
values
yeah yeah yeah this is what we need this
is what we need
all right let's try that
so i'll just undo to where it was before
and then
what if we say dot tick values
and here we pass in a new date
year 2000
boom that works
see
right it says 2000.
and so now what we need to do to
implement your idea is to just isolate
the
unique dates that appear in the data
which should be relatively
straightforward
let me see what is the structure of the
data
well we already have x value
which is perfect and i think this is the
function that we need right here
data.map a function that just returns
all the x values all the dates
or for that matter
for that matter we can um um
wait a minute wait a minute i was just
thinking could we use x scale domain no
we can't because that's the extent of it
which we don't want
so i'll just try this if i copy that
down into the place where we put
new date
that does the trick
awesome that was success that's
impressive
great
beautiful yeah this is exactly
what you were describing and i think it
is a very nice improvement
to the viz because now you know exactly
what year
each of these are and it's kind of
surprising
which years they selected i mean it
doesn't seem to make any sense
there's not really any
pattern to it
is there
i mean
i think it's every three years since
1999 every three years
yeah yeah
with one listen
in 1988
interesting
i wonder why they chose every three
years
well i guess that's the census every
three years
interesting
oh i see there's a message in the chat
from
people's feelings you want to describe
that
oh yeah this is i was working on a
similar thing i don't know if this is
directly pertinent but just in case you
wanted to look at it
nice it's
the same as the earlier approach you
looked at
what is the
approach
because it's a scatter plot and it
references a cell this is from
observable hq so tornado years is an
array
but this
this i mean this will create an axis
that just has the ticks that are defined
by
the like default tick generator
setup so i don't think it actually
addresses the issue that we were having
oh sorry where because yeah we the issue
that we wanted to do is is make it so
that it's not just
like every year or every 10 years or
every five years but it's actually just
the ticks from the years that are
present in the data
but yeah thank you thanks for that
can you have as well default labels
default labels how do you mean
so
i was i was experimenting with something
and i felt completely
um say for example you have a a
categorical variable you want to you
want to show but one way of showing that
is assigning
numerical values
for those say zero and one
and by and by adding jitter you allow
the points not to
position themselves over each other but
then i got stuck with the actual label
on the axis because then they display
zeros and ones and and i want them to
display back those categorical
strings
is this something invis hub that we
could look at
i've
i failed completely to put it into his
home
oh it's not there
okay it's not it's not i apologize it's
just an idea in my head
i see but you tried it you tried
something
i
for for the exercise i wanted to
represent
data from the titanic and i wanted to
show
those uh say different
deck levels but i want to show them as
numerical values with a little bit of
random jitter so the points don't
position
but i wanted to add the labels in and i
kept turning in my head and i felt
completely i didn't know where to to
start from really reading
that is basis of my question
like a label over each point of the
scatter plot
uh like the current scatter plot we have
but instead of saying 2005 you you you
want to say say for example the
financial collapse year you you may want
to label that financial collapse instead
of 2008.
so i think what you're describing it's a
lot like
species
right
where you have discrete values and you
want to map them to some x y
like this
yes
so suppose in your data set those
species were represented by three
different numbers
one two and three right but when you
want to display the access label you
want that they you want that access to
display the actual species strings
oh oh i see what you're saying well in
that case you could do a data
pre-processing step
where
before you pass the data into the
visualization code
you can just replace those numbers with
the strings
in the data
but then i would lose that bit of jitter
i would have on those values
so they say
i i
i
encountered the same challenge and you
know um
and
i was able to i don't know if that's the
correct approach but i was able to add
jitter to a scale point
even though it was a discrete variable
um
it it's it a current if you want to to
show my example it's in in in the
in the forum and i think it addressed i
i believe it addresses this this issue
oh great is it in here in this thread
yes
that's the one oh this one
ah let's take a look
very so
if you put the the continent in the
y-axis
and the date inscribed in the x-axis
there's a little bit of jitter big and
that way it's not
like a like in the in the setosa example
in the in the flower example it's not
like on the same exactly exact line
this is brilliant
exactly exactly
so how did you do it
uh look the the
y scale i believe i i added some at
random there
at some point so it's not in it's not in
the scale definition it could be in the
is it in the y value accessor perhaps
i don't know i i you know i i look for
examples yeah it took me a time a while
to figure out you know
i uh i borrow it from somewhere so i
don't remember exactly where i put it so
it's not there it must be it must be in
the rendering
yes
wow let me just search for a random
there it is yeah it's right in the
rendering logic see that makes it that
makes perfect sense and that's how i
would have done it as well
yeah i see now i see
yeah so right before you render it to
the point
add the jitter
which is just a random number times 10.
however
math.random you have to understand it
varies between 0 and 1.
and so
this code here
will jitter the points
only in one specific direction
meaning it's it's gonna it's going to be
the original x
or greater
so it's going to be some place between
the original x and the original x plus
10.
normally jitter
would um
would move it in both directions
and the way that
you can do that
oh it's i have to fork this to edit it
and another just another side point i
want this hub to show the previous
authors too because it looks like i made
this but it's not my work so that's one
thing i want to address
but
the way that you could do that
is something like -5
so then it would
it would be x plus or minus five
randomly
and in general that would be like
if you could you could if you wanted a
variable
for jitter
you could make it like that and say
random times jitter minus
jitter divided by two
yeah jitter is an interesting technique
just adding adding random variation
and
this one actually if you were to put a
bunch of points and jitter them like
this
what you would see is a square
not a circle
because it varies them in x and y in a
square
i've seen other people do jitter
with
such that when you generate you would
see a circle and so then
what you want to do is compute
a random angle and a random distance
from that angle
and do the jitter like that
that sounds difficult
it's it's not that bad
i mean you just need some sine and
cosine
it's easier to just create a function
for for this right
yeah
actually that's not a bad idea
yeah because there's duplicated logic
which is unfortunate
so we can call this jitter
magnitude
and we can make a function
it's just a number
and then we
just do the jittering of that number
and so that way we can say
d is
jitter of d dot x
and then jitter of d dot y that would be
one way to
do it
um
uh you're defining jitter for the jitter
it's a recursive i whoops this one
i forgot to change the name
ah there we go
yeah jitter is an interesting technique
but
there's another technique that i like
which is the force layout
and in certain cases the force layout
could be better than the jitter and this
comes back to
this notion that you mentioned
here it is
yeah
so in the original question
it was like how do we how do we split up
how do we split the points
jitter is one option but with jitter
there's still a high probability that
they're going to overlap each other
however if you use d3 force with the
collision constraint
um
it has a similar effect to jitter but it
guarantees that there's not going to be
any overlap
and this this could be
a really nice option as well
yes especially because my purpose was to
like visualize each else that you were
able to visualize each element each
retouch element so i think that this
solution is more proper to accomplish
that goal
yeah i think it's it's more
accurate in a sense
as well i'm trying to find a good
example
it gives a better sense where points
cluster at specific places as opposed to
jitter
yes
yes because for example in my in my in
my case i i wanted to show how in europe
there's a disproportionately amount of
heritage elements and and you can't
really see that in this version because
because as as current says there's a lot
of overplotting in in europe
right
yeah yes if you did the b swarm on this
layout
or maybe this one
that would be a very that if yeah i
would suggest to try that to try the
force layout the force directed layout
with the collision constraint for this
exact view without the jitter
that way
you would see that like with this this
really dense area here in europe it
would actually
spread up and down
it would give you a a visual up and down
spread so you could really see the the
quantity like the density of the points
much more clearly than in this view
yeah that would be
similar to sort of a quasi quasi-dot
plot
yes
and and also almost reminiscent of um
like a violin plot
but yeah this is really nice work so i'm
curious did you see any insights from
the data
in here that surprised you
well that's the main insight
that i put because i i read the that
before the 90s
there was a
like
a really disproportionate amount of a
cultural and natural heritage sites
in europe and there was less of a
presence in latin america
africa
and other parts of the world but
but you can't really see see that with
these visualizations you know
and it was surprising maybe it's because
of this visualization doesn't show it
but
but i didn't really see that
that a temp temporal trend
with this visualization but but indeed
europe has like them the most every
touch size sites declare
by unesco
so that's the main insight you know
i see
i want to try i guess that
other thing i thought that i really
loved about this plot just from an
artistic standpoint was
that
how it showed the world map
oh yeah indirectly
yes yes
indeed in the readme section i i said
that it's really a map but but i like i
don't
i haven't learned yet how to make it
but
but because i use latitude and longitude
it really it's it resembles the
the geographical points
yep
totally
yeah i i can talk a little bit about
about how to actually make it a map
but first
i kind of want to try tweaking
some of the things that we have
available to us to tweak
to to show more clearly the things that
you're describing
one thing is if we pull the opacity way
down
that helps to show density in europe see
that
right yes definitely
and then
if we do it
by continent and date
i want to try
making the radius more
so instead of a radius of 5 let's say a
radius of 20.
oh see
ah this is
this is one thing where like the next
version of this hub i want to be able to
tweak the radius but have it remember
which things i selected
you know what i mean
now
maybe that's a little too big let's say
but then i want to bring down the
opacity even more like .05
now we can see a little more clearly
how dis disproportionate the density is
in europe
and if that's the thing you want to
highlight it's it's currently confounded
with the colors
it's hard to tell
based on the colors
so
just to tease out that one thing
if i just make them all black
oh whoops that should be date continent
now you can see it more clearly see
yes definitely
right
man i'm it's impressive how it gets
almost completely black
it's a heritage x-ray
is there a way you could also
filter on the counts and then
switch up the color once it hits a
threshold so that it pops
so you could have it red
yeah that's a great idea
to do that
you yeah and hey if you wanted to show
that europe has more
or less the message with this
probably that that's that's the thing to
do is to aggregate it by binning it by
the years
and then maybe applying some smoothing
even
and then you would have um
an aggregated view where you could apply
a threshold of say if it's more than 100
per year make it red or something so it
really pops
yeah that could totally work and to do
the binning you could leverage d3
histogram i think it might have been
renamed to d3 bin
or is it banned
no it's not banned
it's
ah it's bin this is the one so this this
example
is a normal distribution of like a
thousand points oh sorry i lost it
and then what it's doing is it's
it's calculating the number of points
that fall into each
bin
each bucket and in this case each bin is
like
0.5 or 0.05
or
here's 0.4 0.5
so 0.05 is the the width of the buckets
but you could
bin by the years
and so yeah that's that's one thing i
would suggest to try is binning by year
and another thing that now that i'm
looking at the visualization i i think
that that it it doesn't reflect the
message
uh so clearly
uh because it
i mean the main message is that for
example asia that's a continent with a
a bigger population than europe
has significantly
lower heritage sites so their culture is
not being like highlighted by unesco
as much as europe and and because
the population for example it's not
being considered in this vist you don't
really see that disproportionate a
reality you know
yes
this is so maybe i i i should i should i
should have done that data a
transformation before to to highlight
that disparity
but those are the kind of things that
i'm thinking now when when i hear about
you guys
yeah taking the population into account
would be quite interesting
as well
why africa was doing much better in the
60s compared to later years
that's a great question i don't know
but that's a great question
so 1980 there's a lot more heritage
sites defined in the 80s
and by the way this this number
formatting is not right that's something
we could fix
see
in the um
see why type
what is y type for the so i'm i'm
looking at the problem of the number
formatting and i'm thinking to myself
those should actually be just
represented as years without the comma
right and this actually is i'm glad you
did this because
it highlights the fact that we need
another type which is which is right i
just put it quantitative like date as
quantitative not as date exactly
oh i'm so happy that that this happened
yeah so now we can actually do that next
step which is the the complete the
completion of this generic scatter plot
make it handle quantitative categorical
and
time
or dates
uh what is the type of that i'll just
call it
time
and if it's time we need to have
a time
format
which is how we parse it
zan armstrong has this really great
time formatting example
so the specifier for the time parsing
would be
if it's just year it would be this one
percent y
and i'm pretty sure that's what it is in
the data
if it's showing up like that
and so now let's actually do this work
of making it work with time
so
let me get more space for the code
so we're looking at just x
if x type is categorical
then do this
otherwise
this is where
i want to introduce another
another case
where if x type is
time
then
do their switch and case for
javascript
oh yeah we could do that
we could do that yeah as we add more of
these it's getting a little cumbersome
to use this
this ternary operator
yeah that could work
but i feel like this is pretty close i
mean we're pretty close
to having just one type it doesn't make
sense to
create another logic for this yeah but
at this juncture i mean it's a good
thought and and what i would do is
get it working
first with the minimal effort
and then after we run prettier on that
then we make the call like is this ugly
enough to merit a refactoring where we
use the case switch
and then we would we could write it with
the k switch and see how it looks and
that might turn out to be more more code
more complicated
so yeah it's a good thought it's a good
thought but let's try to get this to
work
so it would be exactly the same as
scale linear except
that
it would be scale time
which we need to import from d3
and now that i think about it we may not
need to
specify the time formatter
if the data is already parsed into dates
which i'm not sure if it is
let's see where's the data loaded
where is the data
await oh parse row parser where's that
here it is
yeah yeah yeah
so this is where we can say
instead of just parsing the string into
a number like this
we can use time parse
or
yeah
we need to come up with a parse date
function that we can pass in
that string
and the way we can use um
d3 time format
or no i'm sorry time parse
and then we can use that
percent y
to parse those into dates
and we need to import time parse from d3
and let me just see if it's working by
logging these out
okay they appear to be dates that's good
and
yeah i think i implemented all the all
the logic let's see if it works
it does see that
awesome
this is great yeah this so now we have a
truly generic
scatter plot
that can handle dates as well but we're
not quite done yet
because
the code is kind of a mess i'm going to
run prettier on it
yeah i mean
it's okay
but it is a little cumbersome
with with two levels
of this
um you were asking about the switch
statement
let me see what time it is oh it's noon
yeah let's try the switch statement
i always like to look at mdn for
examples
this is what the switch statement looks
like in javascript
so let me copy this and try it out
okay so if we use a switch statement
we're going to have to use
let
so i'll comment this out for now
and let's just see how this plays out if
we do use the switch statement
let x
and then we are switching on
x type
and if the case is
categorical
then we say x equals
this one here
and then
if x type is time
then we use
this one here
x equals that
break
we need to put these break statements
otherwise it continues down to the next
one
and then
finally
if it's
quantitative
uh which we're not even explicitly
stating here we're assuming that if it's
not categorical and if it's not time
it's going to be quantitative
i think that's fine the yeah
yeah we could so we can use the default
here
okay
yeah and then
to the last case is this one
x equals
scale linear
and i'll try prettier on this
this is what we get
and let's see if it still works
oh there's something
we didn't
we didn't assign it back to the x-axis
we didn't assign the new x
back to the i think we also need to
assign that range
which we did oh i missed the range i
missed the range ah that's what it is
good catch
so yeah the way that this works is
the return value from this expression
is you know it's the value of x and then
we say dot range so what we can do is
just say
x dot range like this
okay
that works
yeah
great and so now
it's up to us to decide
which version
is more
aesthetically pleasing
yeah in this case maybe the
if and else makes sense but maybe if we
increase the number of
of options then
switch would be better
i i guess i don't know
yeah i like the case
i i was wondering just from uh
i don't know this style
um works in javascript but
could
when
type is passed in could that
automatically call a function
that would
render
uh
that logic
for the x assignment
oh yeah i know in other line
other languages where you just so so
that you don't have anything there
and that each of those would be a
function of itself
oh yeah i think
i think it may be complicated by the
fact we have different types of domains
depending on
those different scales
and actually i like the idea of
abstracting it out into a function that
way we could call the same function for
x and y
and we can we don't need to put x and y
in our in our stuff so we can just have
it a function of type
and
data
value
which is going to be the accessor
and in this case
we can just move this
into the function
and then instead of instead of x we can
call it scale
and then we can switch on type
and then instead of x value we can use
value
all these places
oh type is not a reserved word here
i don't think it is no in javascript i
don't believe
i don't believe type is a reserved
keyword
okay
and then we can return it at the end
and then
all we have to do is say x equals
compute scale
x type
data
and x value
and that still
seems to work
and then once we've done that
we can use it for for y as well
so we actually get rid of a bunch of
code which is great
but the question remains when we
implement that function
should we use switch
or this other thing i mean it doesn't
really matter but this is the process
that you that you go through and this is
what i wanted to
also convey in this in this course is
like what is the process of writing code
you have to make so many decisions
evaluate things based on efficiency but
also
you know aesthetics
and you could do the same thing with if
else
if
you know
you could go on and on trying different
ways and i actually do that when i write
code i spend time evaluating all
possible ways of doing one thing
and then getting them all to work
and then looking at the code from a
number of angles you know how easy is it
to read if i give it to somebody else in
the future how easy is it going to be be
able
to be understood
by someone else and also how efficient
is it does it create additional new
objects that you don't need to does it
need to be optimized
anyway these are all considerations um
yeah
so
in your
switch
scale is assigned once
yet you still have to declare it as let
because it's going to go past
one of these cases only and it's going
to be assigned once but we still have to
declare it as lead
not const
i believe so yes if you have the
um
well actually let's do some experiments
with that
if we don't declare it there and we
declare it here
i'm not sure
if that would work
i'm not sure what the scoping rules are
for for the switch statement
but it says it gives us an error that
says the identifier has been already
declared in the same scope
so this approach would not work
i see and thank you
if you
if you use const here that's also not
going to work oops
that's also not going to work because
oh well you need to assign a const uh
when it's declared
but here's here's another approach that
could work if you don't define any
variables
you could just
return them
like this actually this this simplifies
the code quite a bit
then we don't need the breaks because
when we return it's implicitly breaking
out of the whole function
however we need to pull out the setting
of the range to be outside this function
which is again duplicated logic down
here
we'd have to do it twice
so that's sort of a dead end i would
rather not do it like that
ah
so let's see is it still working
there seems to be some problem
oh i set the range or what happened
sorry
somehow it got messed up
that's odd it was working a second ago
is it because we missed the brakes again
no
the brakes are there
is it because like the range takes this
width thing like but for my skin you
would need like
yeah that's it oh good catch
good catch
so in that case
maybe we do want to use the return
approach and then set the range
separately that's what it is that's
exactly what it is
so the range for the y scale is going to
be
well let me just see what it was in the
one that i forked it from
i
accidentally assumed that the range
would be the same across each but it's
not
that's the right range
yeah that's right
and then
now we can just use return
but let me keep this around as a
reference
so this is option three
this is
option two
and i was just thinking to myself
if we're going to use a return
we may as well just use if statements
which might be even more clear to read
if
type equals
categorical
then
return
this kind of a scale
and since we return it we don't need to
use elf
we know if we don't need to use
else
we could just have another if
so if it's time then we can return
this one
and then
if it's nothing else then we can fall
through to the default of the linear
scale
so
this also works
as an alternate way of doing it
so yeah it's up to you it's a stylistic
choice
um i personally kind of like this just
because it's only
a couple lines
one two three four five six
however it could be cryptic for others
to read if you hand it off to somebody
else
so maybe maybe this is the best choice
or maybe this is good i don't know it's
it it's a it's a very subjective choice
but yeah this this has been fun really
nice work
and i like how how all of these
i mean this visualization as well as the
one that kostov worked on it highlights
social inequality issues which i think
is a very important
topic area to address with data
visualization in particular because it
really makes clear
things that are
in the data they're clear in the data if
you look at the data in the right way
and so yeah i think this is a valid
point like why is why are there so many
world heritage sites in europe does your
is europe really the like center of
civilization or is it just you know is
this unesco neglecting
you know other countries out of some
kind of
i don't know racist underpinnings i
don't have no idea i have no idea about
it but
but just to start investing these
investigating these angles is uh
it's great
it's really interesting seeing how
removing colors have brought this much
clearer
right because color itself has a
brightness
value to it it's called there's hue
saturation and luminance in colors and
luminance
is the luminance means how how much
between white and black it is but if you
have hue
um
it confounds the the brightness
i mean
yes and i think it's full circle that
this is get it right in black and white
right and we and we turn the the
visualizations into black and white
exactly finally
exactly
yep
yeah i'm happy it ended up in black and
white turns out black and white is clear
it's more clear and it's the same with
3d by the way if you see 3d pie charts
3d scatter plots
it's it's the same kind of thing as
adding color where you just make it like
more flashy but it doesn't really add
any value
most of the time
so yeah as a next step for this i would
suggest trying to do the binning
and the smoothing
and i wanted to show you all this thing
that i built
fairly recently
that that does
exactly that it's a stream graph of d3
contributions
over time
and what it what i did is i took um
d commits commit data from git from
github
um on all the various d3 packages and i
i've been to them by i think weak and
then i applied smoothing and i wanted to
show you the effect
of of changing the smoothing parameter
see if there's no smoothing
it looks
something like this
this is just the raw aggregated values
per week
and i think if you were to aggregate the
data that you have
per year
you would get something kind of similar
to this
but with you know with a different
layout
and you can apply smoothing though to
get a more broad
picture
of
of generally when things increased or
decreased it's a smoothed out
view of it and for this particular
analysis the smoothed out view was much
more useful than the detailed view you
can see clearly okay d3 was developed
monolithically
from 2011 to 2014 and then it was split
into a bunch of packages and then some
new packages were created after that
the the other thing is it gave you
an opportunity to annotate
which she just couldn't
exactly
exactly there's no room for the labels
in the version that's not smooth
exactly yeah
yeah
and even if you hovered over you
wouldn't get the insight
yeah it's tricky to
to hover over each and every one to try
to figure out what it is
yeah
so i forgot what it was originally
15 maybe
that's cool
so yeah this this one was a lot of fun
to make i had hoped to continue this
series and get to making something like
this
but uh
you know in the future
i'll do it in the future
all right well
i think i'm gonna wrap up
but um
let me see
yeah i'm gonna wrap up thank you all for
joining me for this this ongoing saga
of uh get it right in black and white
with vishub as our
as our tool
and uh
yeah i'll see you
[Music]
in the future sometime
and
yeah feel free to reach out to me
um
if you want to get involved with
upcoming versions of his hub maybe be a
beta tester
and just and let me know if you have any
feedback on viz hub in general or the
way i'm doing the courses ways that
things could be improved
what you've gotten out of it
what things that have been frustrating
i i want to hear it all
um
all right so thank you all fantastic and
he finally thank you so much
yeah my pleasure
thank you queen
thank you
i'll be in touch
all right great and if you want to
support me in the meantime sign up for
this measly four dollars a month and
it'll go a long way
yep done all right thanks everyone
thank you thank you ryan take care thank
you
bye bye
bye